Heat. Heat.
Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
I know you
feel
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
Whatever.
Heat. Heat.
Bye-bye.
Heat.
Heat. Hey, Heat.
Yeah.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
Things are only now heating up here at
the Atlanta Regional Qualifier. Eight
rounds of rigorous play have concluded
and we've moved on to day two.
28 legends started the tournament and
only three of them have locked in the
best of prize. 25 legends remain. Even
the Ahri is still in contention.
But what about the players? Out of the
past four regional qualifiers, three of
your champions are in the room right
now, fighting for a chance at maybe
taking home a second crown. But maybe
players like Prismaticism and Colin
Kaiser might finally take home a prize
of their own.
So many questions to still be answered
here in Atlanta. And we're going to find
out who your new champion will be today.
Good morning everyone and welcome to the
Riftbound regional qualifiers here in
Atlanta, Georgia. I've got my good
friend here with me, Kangis, and I am
Miss Chimcham and we're going to be your
casters for today. But I want to welcome
y'all in. Thank y'all so much for being
here. We've got a great show. Well,
we're here on day two. So, day one has
already been done. We've got a couple of
undefeated people here today. Do you
want to
>> We got a lot of undefeated still also.
Yeah, day one was fantastic. We made it
through our first day one cast. That was
both of our first time here uh at a riff
regional. So, that was awesome.
Actually, you went to Vegas, but more as
a content creator. Yeah, you had a lot
of cool stuff there. But, uh this is my
first experience. So, that was a great
day one for me. Yeah. A lot of uh
successful players so far and a lot of
folks that have now also qualified for
day two. There's a lot of prizing on the
line, a lot of reason to keep playing,
and also a lot of folks just hanging
out, still playing on all the side
events. Um, the energy in the room is
kind of electric. I still love just how
much people have passion for this game.
And even though like I was talking to
people that kind of scrubbed out early
on in the tournament, they're like, "Oh,
no, it's fine." Like, I didn't expect to
do well. Like, I'm just still here to
have fun with my friends. And I feel
like that's the energy that I would have
coming into an event like this. Some
people have expectations for how well
they're going to do, but I think it's
good to come into these and be like, I'm
just going to have a good time.
>> 100%. And I also just want to say like
being in the room here, yes, the energy
is absolutely magnetic. It's it's
electrifying, but as you said, some
people who got out early, they're so
eager to go ahead and make it to the
next uh qualifier uh in the uh in the
season. Let's go ahead and actually look
at that schedule if we can uh to see
what we have coming up for the rest of
the the day.
>> Yeah. So, we have five rounds of Swiss.
We did a full eight rounds yesterday uh
and now five rounds ahead of us today.
At the end of that, we will have a top
eight. A lot of players still in
contention for that. And uh that
moment's always pretty stressful at any
time. You're you're these big
tournaments when you're on the bubble
and you're like, "Okay, I'm X1, but I
have a really good match wins." Uh and
you know, even my loss like did really
well, so like maybe I'm able to bubble
in. Uh the XO's are the ones that really
feel confident though in that top eight
to be like, "Yep, I'm going to make it."
I believe Le um I don't think we had any
X1's. I I I'll have to check that to
make sure, but it's really tough like
when with this big of a tournament and
only a top eight cut. Really hard to
actually break into that top eight. You
have to have a great run.
>> Absolutely. And uh I mean it was a long
day yesterday, but here we are on
Sunday. We've got five more rounds of
Swiss to to reach that top A and it will
be single elimination.
So it's going to be it's going to be
fun. I feel like we're going to get into
like some really powerful matchups later
in the day.
>> I'm expecting a lot of Dravens in that
top eight based on what we've seen so
far. Um, but let's take a look at what
the players are also competing for cuz
it's not only top eight that walk away
with stuff, Ragan. There's a lot of
prizing on the line.
>> Absolutely. As you can see, we do have
that bone shiver. So, everybody got that
when they walked in the door, but we do
also have those cash prizes for second
place, 3rd through fourth, fifth through
eighth. But as you can see, the top
eight promo is a Blade of the Ruin King.
But if you come in first place, baby,
you not only walking away with $6,000,
your own champion playmat that you will
only have and a different Blade of the
Ruin King champion promo card.
>> That is a slick game at Look at that
thing. That is awesome. If if I had that
game at, I don't think I'm ever using
another game at for the rest of my life.
>> No, truly. That's all you need.
>> We need Viego. We need VGO as a legend
to to make this work.
>> All right.
>> Can you imagine playing Azir on that
one?
>> No, that would be fine.
>> Azir aren't really on Blade King anyway,
but you know, it's maybe the Ranada
players out there. There's been some
tech. Um, but I speaking of actually, we
have our tops and Ranata did not do
great.
>> No, no, she didn't. But we do have a
couple of people who actually have
already secured their best ofves. Okay,
so we're looking at Garen has already
been secured. Ranatada and what was that
last one?
>> I'm trying to remember. I It's not
coming to me out of the top of my head.
Leona, there we go. Leona,
>> thank you Production for saving us
there.
>> Yes. So, we've got those three. We've
got two girly pops and we got Garen. So,
I think that's absolutely fantastic
coming into here already like you
already got your win, but you got to go
for more.
>> But also, I think my stocks are a little
down cuz I was like, Ranata's slept on.
Ranata is actually better. Uh the
players representing Ranata were not
backing up my claims. Leona is
surprising to me though. That's the one
that I actually want to talk about
because we we saw some Leonas have some
pretty good uh performances in in
tournaments like Vegas uh making a
little bit deeper pushes than they were
able to here. Um and specifically things
like the baited hook. Uh I was actually
I got a chance to uh play a game with
pastry time and he um I'm going to say
borrowed I'm not going to say stole.
Well, I'm going to say borrowed a deck
list from one of the players from Vegas
that was on like a baited hook Leona
with like green or orange cuz then you
can like baited hook into that and then
like just look at the top five and get
another baited hook and like really cool
stuff you can do. Um but it looks like
yeah, Leona just didn't have that same
type of success here.
>> No, unfortunately. But we like I said,
we do have a lot of undefeated still
here. Shout out to everybody who still
got those bests like it's so cool to
make like the the best run on a certain
legend.
>> Absolutely. No, I think that's awesome.
You get your you get your card uh for
the best of. So they're walking away
with something. I think I think that's
nice.
>> Those metal cards are so nice.
>> It's so nice. Uh we actually have the
ones on the prize wall and somebody let
me hold there. Okay. Can I actually
>> Well, the prize wall ones are slightly
different than the best of ones. The
best of have like the the foiling,
>> a different foiling, but it's still so
heavy. Like it's so dope to hold. Like
it's actually so cool in it's it's
crazy, y'all. Uh, so we have a couple of
Dravens obviously so far who are 8. Um,
I think we also saw a
Azir a set.
>> Yeah, we've seen a couple Azir there.
There is a set that's undefeated right
now. Um, there's a Kai'Sa that's
undefeated. I actually chatted with the
Kai'Sa 8 uh right now and that was like
kind of my prediction as like a dark
horse for this event. I think Kaisa is a
little slept on as well. Uh, but here we
actually have the rankings. We don't
have the legends that they're playing
currently, but there are uh a a number
of 8 O's still and some names that you
might recognize. Players like
Prismaticism.
>> The second one's important. I was
>> The second one is very important. You
can't forget.
>> Your boy Colin's on there.
>> I y'all Colin is so sweet. And y'all
will see an interview from him later
today. But I am truly rooting for Colin
through and through.
>> And of course, Boulevard up in number
one.
>> Yes, I do believe we on Draven. But yes,
it's going to be so much fun seeing
these people battle it out and I can't
wait to see who takes the win.
>> Yeah, also two members from the same
team, CTCG, so that's cool. Allen's EQ
was technically undefeated 701, so a tie
there, but a lot of names that have been
like kind of building reputations,
building their stories in Riftbound
because there haven't been that many
regionals through which you can actually
kind of build up your brand and like
what you're able to do. But those
players have been consistently
performing. It's awesome to see that a
lot of them are still consistently
performing. Uh, and the the race for the
top is pretty tight here in Atlanta.
>> It is. And the pressure is on. I hope
nobody's shaking in their boots because
we're going to get started here shortly.
But
>> I'm not shaking. Mine mine are pretty
secure.
>> No. Okay. Okay.
>> I don't have boots on though. Does that
count?
>> Uh, shaking in their shoes. How about
that? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But
>> my loafers.
>> These aren loafers. These are These are
dress shoes.
>> I would show them on broadcast, but I
don't know. We got other things to talk
about.
>> We We do. We do. Um, so let's talk about
the uh road map for uh Riftbound real
quick.
>> The full year we started off in Houston
in December, the first regional there
and then Spirit Forge released and we
have been backto back to backto back
shows Bolognia Las Vegas as we switch
over. We got Leil last weekend into
Atlanta this weekend. four full
regionals for the set of Spear Forge and
they've all been really interesting to
watch because we've had different decks
taking each one. Um, not having like a
single repeat is is kind of uh
fascinating to me, especially when you
considered how strong Draven was for
most of it. Obviously, these last two
regionals or postb list and there is
still a chance if Azir can win or if
Draven Draven's kind of like the the
favorite right now to to take it in
terms of number of uh you know XO's
X1's. Um, but yeah, and then Unleash
comes out right around the corner.
Reagan,
>> let's go. I am so excited for Unleash.
I've had so much fun with Spirit Forge,
but I am ready to get into that
Unleashed on May 8th and then we're
going to Sydney uh midway through May
and then Vancouver for another regional
qualifier. We've we've
>> I want to I want to hear you say the
next one.
>> See, did is that why you passed this to
me?
>> I was curious.
>> Do should I go? Cuz I
>> Utret Utre Ut.
and then we're going to Hartford. So,
we're kind of going around the world in
80 days. But after that, Vendetta is
finally dropping. We've seen the
assassins that are coming. We've got
that set or not the set, the Zed, the
Shin. I think uh Jace is also coming
out.
>> You know more than I There's a lot of I
>> I like to live in the present rate. I'm
I'm still in spirit forged brain and I'm
just starting to be like
>> unleash
>> going to unleash brain ahead of the
pre-releases cuz I got to learn the
kits. I got to learn like what to draft
in the pre-release events. But um
>> you you dive real in I'm looking at the
pretty artwork. That's what I've been
analyzing and Vendetta has got that. But
after Vendetta releases, we'll also be
going to Barcelona, Singapore, and then
Los Angeles. And after Los Angeles, we
will be getting into Radiance. Now, I
only
>> Teemo is blocking Radiance's spot on the
on the
>> Yeah, we had to get Teemo in there. He
had to He had to show some face real
quick.
>> Also important to note that Vendetta is
the merge of China and English releases.
So, that's going to be really
>> We'll be catching up there.
>> But, I'm hearing that we're ready for
our first round feature match. So, let's
take a look at some of the deck lists
here to break them down. It's a Victor
up first. And uh we haven't I I don't
think we've seen a Victor on stream yet.
>> No, we haven't seen a Victor. We did
analyze a Victor deck, but we did not
get to see an actual Victor. Now, we
were talking about how Victor, a lot of
people fear him because there's a lot
that he can do. He makes those recruits,
but I'm glad that we finally get to see
him out and about today.
>> Yeah. So, I'm going to take a look at
this list. It seems pretty standard
outside of two notable things. Um, the
uh three faithful manufacturers. I
haven't seen every Victor list on this
many. Uh, a lot of victors have kind of
moved on to be more spell focused or um
I I guess like more effective units. I I
don't know how to say that in a in a
better way, but like this is more of an
Origins card from from my understanding
of how Victors have been playing. So I I
like that we're still seeing it cuz it's
a very efficient card. It gives you two
bodies for essentially three might for
the the three energy cost, but you can
split it across two. So things like
wages of pain then get more interesting
and your recruit can go in a blade, all
the shenanigans, right? But still, three
of that is a little notable. And also
three, wages of pain, the spell there.
Um, I I think it's a really good meta
read because we've seen a lot of like
overzealous fans, a lot of tide turners.
So, a lot of units that this can hit
across the board, but wages of pain is
the type of card that often you will see
come out of the main deck depending on
the matchup because it doesn't actually
get that much use against some of the
higher range decks, especially like the
Aurora decks. Um, so I think it's good
across a lot of the field, but uh maybe
we'll see it come out. But this is like
a pretty honest list. Three of across
the board. Everything's a three of here.
>> Exactly. Uh I'm super excited to see how
uh Victor plays today. He's going to be
able to deal with some bigger units if
he needs to with the coal of the week,
the hidden blade. So I'm really excited
to see how Victor is going to put it
down versus his opponent. I see we've
also got the singularity which will be
able to kind of deal with um a lot of
units here. Um and these units don't
have to be at a battlefield because it
can deal that six to each
two units. So if you think you're going
to play in your base, no babes, bring
that here.
>> At this point, a lot of people also know
the combos of Victor. Things like
Thousand Tale Watcher make the numbers
really easy for cards like Bellow's
Breath to then spread cuz this will
decrease the might of every unit on your
opponent's field by three. And then if
we take a look at Bellow's Breath, you
can spread one or two damage if you
repeat cost it across three units at the
same location. So like Thousand Tail
Bellow's Breath is like the big combo or
Bellow's Breath plus uh Imperial Decree
is the other combo which is even cheaper
cuz it's only um five uh energy cost for
the spell. You just don't get the body
on top of it. But like these are the
type of things that Victor's going to
do. It's just all kill kill. And this is
what it's up against, Reagan.
>> Oh my gosh, y'all. I'm so excited.
Finally, we're seeing a Fiona. Oh my
gosh, y'all. I love Fiora. So, I'm kind
of looking at this deck list here, and
it does look pretty standard. Um, one
thing that I have to point out is the
Karma. I have not ran a Karma in my
Fiona decks. I do call her Fiona. I
>> was wondering about that. I was like,
sorry, is this a Shrek reference or
>> She is that girl. Another thing that I
want to point out is the uh Fiora
victorious being the chosen champion
here. Yeah. Rather than the one that
readies a unit once they become mighty.
Now this victorious unit is very strong
because once you do get that additional
buff to give her the five might, she not
only is now mighty, but she can uh
deflect, she has ganking, and she has
shield. So, this is perfect because you
can tap that legend, get those uh runes
exhausted, but also you just become that
much bigger.
>> And I'm hearing from production that
this is the only deck in the entire
tournament that is running Karma.
>> Wo,
>> that is fascinating. So, this is not
like a Oh, this is a new meta like
shift. This is a new meta tech read from
this specific player. Vest VVS.
>> Oh, no. It's happening again. Uh, we'll
get confirmation hopefully of how to say
their name, but this is clearly that
this player just thinks that this card
is worth running. So, I I I had to
remind myself what it did. It's six
energy, one power cost for six might
vision, as you see on your screen, which
just means that when you play it, you
can look at the top card of your deck
and recycle it or keep it. But the key
thing is when you recycle one or more
cards, buff a friendly unit. Now, that
says cards, not just runes. So, like if
you recycle any cards from your main
deck as well, um, you're able to do
that. Now, I don't think there's really
anything that actually recycles from the
main deck now that I'm looking at it.
Um,
>> but yeah, I think that that's a really
interesting option here.
>> I agree. And uh I was trying to see
Well, first let me say it is Yees is the
name of this player. Yees. Yes. But I
was like, okay, well, you do a lot of
recycling with runes with Fiora
sometimes, but at the end of that card,
it does say runes are not cards. So, I
am kind of curious here how we are going
to trigger this buff. Um, I'm really
interested. I'm intrigued. I can't wait
to see it. I can't wait to see this deck
in action. But another thing I want to
point out is this set. Okay, set. He's a
Formite coming into the board, but he
can get that much bigger because when
you play him, you can buff him. When you
conquer with him, you can buff him. So,
there's this special uh interaction
where you play him, you spin the buff.
Sometimes you can um ready him with your
first mate here, and then you can move
in, conquer a battlefield, you get
another buff.
>> You can then spend that buff if you need
to. You can uh do we have challenge? We
do. And then you can challenge someone
in the back of a base if you need to
because he has then gotten that much
bigger. Love this set card. Love the
artwork. He kind of fine. Anyways,
>> very funny. Oh, okay. Okay. Now, now
we're get it. There was a set cosplayer
actually out there. I keep hearing these
sounds production throws into our ears
and I don't know if I heard a whistle
>> and I don't know if the stream heard it
and and now I don't know how to act. All
right. They're going to stream. I'm
hearing that's confirmed. All right.
Well, uh I'm hearing that we're ready to
to hop into game though here. So, let's
see the players in action. Very fun deck
lists. I think again it's a very honest
victory. three of across the board, but
Atlanta uh or rather um uh the the Fiora
match a little different. Um so let's
look at this. Victor versus Fiora match
up win rate. So this is probably
Victor's win rate, I'm assuming then.
>> Yeah,
>> so 66% win rate in Le and so far in
Atlanta a 67%.
That is a massive win rate.
>> I'm not excited to see those numbers.
I'm not going to lie to you. I am
rooting for this Fiora yees. You got to
hold it down one time for the one time.
But I will say a lot of people do fear
Victor and this is obviously why that is
a ridiculously high win rate. So I'm
going to assume a lot of Oh, also
interesting. Victor starting with
Arena's greatest as they're going first
Battlefield. That's also notable right
there. Okay, we got some fun players on
stage right now. Victor's going to be
going first. If I had to posture a guess
as to why the Fiora's win rate so low is
because you only have the three repos
for three spell negates and Victor's got
so many spells like you're never really
going to have enough negates to stop all
the kill spells and you don't have as
many units as the Fiora in some lists.
So maybe that's why the the win rate's
so skewed.
>> Absolutely. And we already have a
twocost the plundering porro has been uh
brought out for Victor and a first mate
has been brought out already for Fiora.
Uh it looks like we're going to get a
lecturing Yortle next with uh three
runes exhausted to bring that in. We're
going to draw for turn. Both uh players,
I want to notate, have collected their
first point from the uh arena's
greatest.
>> Yep. It's important to remember that you
have to actually trigger it at the start
of your beginning phase. Um and I'm just
going back to that karma like did I miss
something? I must have missed something.
>> I can't wait to see it. I cannot wait to
see that be uh brought out and how it
>> I can't imagine you're just using it as
a six energy, one recycle, six might
with vision. That that doesn't feel like
an a very efficient card. Maybe they
just love karma.
>> Maybe
phenomenal. I can't even lie.
>> We'll have to chat with them afterwards.
>> Absolutely. So, we've got three units on
the board because that recruit was
brought in from the victor. But, uh
we're looking to see what Ees is going
to do with his only lonely first mate.
Uh it looks like did we pass?
>> Yeah, it's interesting. The Plundering
Porro did not move in. Uh the runes have
ready on Eve's turn. So uh it they've
started their turn. Plundering Por could
have gotten a point in a gold gear, but
Rip Plus instead opting to save the
unit, save the resource.
>> All right, it looks like we're moving
into Arena's
greatest and we're going to see if
anything is to be done.
>> Yeah, this makes sense. You don't want
to go into Monastery of Herana until you
have something buffed. So, yep. Send it
into Arena's greatest. Just get the
point. Save the draw for Monastery for
potentially your next turn cuz Yeah. And
here it is. So, we're going to play the
set.
>> And boom. Just like that, set is coming
out. So, he's going to get that buff
immediately because he is played. Going
to tap that legend and draw one rune.
Exhausted.
>> Such an efficient card for Fiora. Um I I
actually tried to practice in Fiora, but
I only had two sets. The the three feels
really good. Yes. Uh, and I
unfortunately in all my testing I never
drew it. When you only have two, you
just don't see it as much. But man, that
card in Fiora plus your grand duelist
legend means that you just don't even
pay the power cost for it. And it's such
a good unit on its own. It feels like
yes, it set has its own legend, but it
almost feels like it was designed for
the Fiora Legend.
>> It really does. Uh, a lot of those four
mites, especially like obviously the
Fiora feels like it was designed for
Fiora. But yeah, there's a lot of those
four mites that when they get buffed,
uh, Aon is another one.
>> You know, I have a theory actually.
Maybe the Fiora Legend was designed for
the units. M
>> All right, Wages of Pain. And these are
the type of matchups that you actually
do get some value out of Wages of Pain
cuz first mate is in a lot of orange
decks.
>> Yes. And we're going to go ahead and
spin that set buff via Call to Glory.
So, he does not have to exhaust any
runes because there was a buff on the
board. you can spend that buff and
immediately give a three uh might to a
unit. It doesn't matter where the buff
is coming from or where the might is
going. Yeah. Uh you can just spend it
and give it.
>> This is another one of those ones from
Origins that I kind of overlooked at
first cuz you look at it, you're like,
ah, not that many decks like make buffs.
It's three energy. But the way people
have realized, oh, it's just such an
efficient tool in decks like Fiora, in
decks like like set themselves, any deck
that just makes buffs, this a free spell
essentially, and it's reaction speed,
which is the key part because you can
react to spells whereas a lot of the
other things specifically in orange are
action speed. So they they're not able
to do the same stuff that Call of Glory
can in these uh yellow orange decks.
>> Yeah. Uh, and when you're kind of caught
in a pickle and you got your runes down,
it's so efficient to just go ahead and
pull that out and not have to spend
anything. The lecturing Yortle is going
to come out. We're fully exhausted on
the side of Victor. So, we're going to
go ahead and pass our turn here.
>> Really?
>> Oh, didn't pass our turn. I I I don't
think we're going to I You got We got to
score points.
>> Cards. I I I I'm like, okay, there we're
we're passive, but
>> he hasn't writing anything. So, we have
not reached the a awaken phase in the
>> I'm just so excited for this Fiora men.
I just want to see more games.
>> But if you're riffing on plus, I mean,
you at least have a a recruit. So, you
got to start scoring points at some
point. I still think the porro, you like
the gold gear, and it's only one might
more. It's basically a recruit. Um, so
usually in this instance, I'm happy to
send the porro, but he didn't even send
the porro last turn. So, um, we'll see
what Rift Plus's game plan is here.
Important to note, I did not see the
Grand Strategium in the the main deck,
unless I I missed it. I don't I don't
think it was in there. Um, so that means
that you're not playing the Victor
that's like, "Oh, I'm going to make a
gigantic army and then just make it
huge." Uh, you are opting to instead
kind of use these snipe spells to do
damage and then like Imperial Decree as
the the use for the army. So, yeah, we
do send the Porro.
>> Yes. So, the Porro goes ahead and
collects that point, but also collects a
gold gear for uh conquering. and then
we're going to pass our turn. Um I'm
curious to see did we pick up another
set? I think we picked up another set in
hand. So we're going to have some good
might on the board here shortly, I'm
sure.
>> Eves holds for one and we'll get another
point cuz with Riftbound Plus tapped out
and nothing hidden, there's no hidden
blade or anything. And yeah, this is
pretty good.
>> Boom. The pit rookie is going to come in
and whenever that uh pit rookie drops
down, you get to buff another unit. So,
we're going to go ahead and give that
buff to set because then we can tap our
legend and bring in another rune
exhausted. We're going to go in and try
to start a showdown, but that resolves
fairly quickly. So, we're going to go
ahead and collect another point with
Set.
>> And here we're going through the motions
of Set spending the buff at the
Monastery of Herana to draw the card.
And when Set conquers, he gets another
buff. And he's actually picked up a
different buff.
>> He put that one buff on the left and
puffing up from the right. So that
buff's still on the left there.
>> So we're also going to go ahead and
bring out a Doran's Blade and equip that
to the pit rookie. So now he's mighty
now. Our legend is already exhausted, so
we won't be tapping again. But we get a
little bit mightier.
>> Yeah. And we're trying to hold against
the Victor. Kind of a bold move. Um but
also you're forcing the Victor to use
resources. This is a game plan that I
actually really like and I haven't seen
as many of the the players so far on
stream utilize is like just use your
cards against me. I'm going to It's not
like the most efficient thing cuz this
um I imagine it's not going to live
long. Actually, the set is probably the
more juicy target to go for. But either
way, it's like if you want to get
through the five might, you're going to
have to use a spell and that means you
won't have that spell. The Fiora only
gets three counter spells, which we do
have enough runes for a repost, so Ees
might even be able to do that. But in
these types of match ups, especially
when the win rate is so skewed, don't
let your opponent ramp. Make them use
their resources and then try and score
points as fast as you can. And that's
exactly what Ease is doing right now is
he's already at four points. You have
another body back in the base. So you
can assume you're going to get a fifth
point on the next turn. Um and you're
going to force Rift Plus to use some of
those powerful Victor spells in order to
get onto these battlefields.
>> Absolutely. And it looks like uh
Riftbound Plus is really just going
through the motions here, making sure
that he has the resources to deal with
these units on the board cuz they have
gotten to a point where they're going to
be a little costly. It is going to be a
little costly. Uh we have a two might, a
one might, and a two might. So
>> that that would crash with either side
of Battlefield right now.
>> Exactly. So uh let's see.
>> Have you spotted anything in their hand?
I I know that you're pretty. is a sing
singularity in Rift Plus's uh hand, but
it looks like we're going to save that.
Instead, we're going to imperial decree.
>> Yeah, I think the reason to do something
like this instead of going for the
singularity is that singularity is a
bigger spell that you know they could uh
use repost uh that there's enough runes
on Fiora's side that that's always an
option. So, you're going for the cheaper
spell so that way you have more runes to
work with if this doesn't go through.
Cuz at this point against Fiora, just
statistically, they've seen enough
cards. I'm assuming they have at least
one reposted. And if you're if you're
looking at the math like drawing one of
your three of you have two mulligans,
that means you've seen seven cards and
it's what been three more turns since
then. So that's 10 cards. 10 out of 40
you want your uh your three of um but it
it was not negated. So Eves is not going
to answer that. And that means that
these recruits, these bodies can be used
as resources. But even so, you have to
use the bodies as resources. So again,
Eve is losing his units, but that's a
power spell used by Rift Plus. And two
of the bodies are going to be gone. Now,
Victor makes a lot of bodies, so I think
it's probably fine, but Oh, this might
change things.
>> The Bellow's breath. Interesting. So,
we're gonna go ahead and uh recycle two
here for Bellow's Breath repeated so
that we can
>> So, so we're going to do one damage to
each. They'll still die. So, that death
grip was just for the draw cuz you're
still taking damage. The Imperial Decree
is still going to kill you cuz anytime a
unit takes damage, they die. So Eves has
a reaction speed spell, but it's just to
dig. This is actually now disastrous for
I was just kind of laying out like,
okay, I think the Fior's in a decent
spot, but Riftbound Plus showed us one
of those strong Victor combos. It's the
Imperial Decree into the Bellow's
Breath. Now, if it had just been the
Imperial Decree, I think Eve is still in
a good spot. But the fact that Rift Plus
had both with the correct uh curve for
it and even enough to use your Victor uh
passive um you get a recruit back in
base that means Eaves is now heavily
behind. You're not going to score a
point this turn you have to imagine and
you maybe only one unit like you you
need to get a second unit cuz now cold a
week is insane value for Rift Plus and
Victor has not played one of those yet
>> 100%. Now I will say the Fiora the
chosen champion has come out into the
board. Now, I do know Eves 100% has
other units in hand. It's just going to
take us a little bit to get those onto
the board, but like you said, yeah,
there are some cards from Victor that
might just make it a little scary.
>> I'd say first mate is the ideal one cuz
you can ready the Fiora, go in and get a
point. Um, and then also just have
another unit cuz the thing about cold a
week, uh, is both players select the
unit that they kill. If you ever have a
deck, especially for the Aelia players
out there, PSA, never leave your one uh
big unit alone against any Victor
matchup. Even like a lot of Azir
matchups. I know like the winning deck
list and Leil didn't have it. That's
scary too cuz this is a bigger unit. So
like that cold a week will come down and
kill something of pretty high value. Um
and it's not it's going to get through
the deflect cost cuz you're not
targeting a unit. Your opponent is
selecting the unit. So,
>> this is not ideal for EES.
>> And it looks like we're going to pass
turn. Riftbound Plus is going to collect
those two points here and we're going to
go ahead and ready all of our runes and
draw for turn. Um, I saw that Eves was
looking at his trash pile. Uh, one thing
that Fiora plays is Spectral, which
allows you to bring back a unit from
your graveyard
>> spectral maiden matron. Sorry.
>> I'm excited to see maybe we've got that
in hand. I wasn't able to peek at his
hand honestly. So,
>> but we did get a peek at Rift Men Plus's
hand earlier. You had noted that there
was a singularity and Eve is all tapped
out. So, or exhausted on the the rune,
so you can't repost this. You just lose
two units. This is even worse than the
goal the week. Um, and it looks like
we're just going to to game two. Yeah,
Eves is a is a nononsense type gamer.
You understand when you've lost, and I
think from that position, it's just
impossible to come back.
>> It is just a little a little rough, a
little tough, but that's okay. We're
going to uh reset and go into game two
here shortly. For Battlefields, it looks
like we've got Treasure Horde for Victor
and we've got Trifarian War Camp for
Fiora. Love the smile.
>> Yeah, Ees is in his own head like,
"Okay, how do I handle this? Man, that
was oppressive." And we see why the
matchup is so strong for Victor. You
have so many answers for so few units if
Fiora is putting out. Victor's weak
against like decks that go wide that get
a lot of units out there because you
know your cult of week's not as good.
Your singularity can hit two things, but
if they're smaller in in size, you don't
feel as good about it. Bellow's breath
still gets a lot of value, but like you
know, you're not as teched out for those
specific matchups, and you're also not
as teched out for like the green match
ups that have these counter spells.
Fiora is like none of those. You have
the the three counter spells and the
rap, but they're kind of expensive
counter spells. Yes. Uh, and then you
don't have you you don't have the same
ability to go like super wide. Um, you
have some units like even here the
unsung hero coming out, but in general
you you have like a couple of medium to
big stat units as opposed to a bunch of
little guys.
>> All right, so uh a couple call outs here
as we tap our legends and bring in a
recruit and pass our turn. Unsung hero
has been brought in by yees. Now that is
going to uh win mighty draw two. So, if
we are able to equip it with something
or give it some buffs, this that and the
other, we might be able to draw two off
of it. But, we're going ahead and we're
bringing in the Fiora to make sure that
we can conquer and hold.
>> Interesting call here. He did not use
Rift Plus did not use cold a weak. I
think that we're going to see a wages of
pain on the unsung hero into a cold a
week. I imagine that could be the play
cuz you can just deal with the fuel
right away and then there's no units.
Yeah. Yeah. He's got the runes for it.
And just like that, the wages of pain
does come down, but I do know there is a
repost in uh Eve's hand, but it looks
like they're going to let that go
through.
>> There's no there's no runes.
>> There's no runes cuz it's only turn two.
Like,
>> y
>> you feel good against a cold a week.
Again, I keep saying cold a week cuz
that's like every time you play Victor,
it's just always in your mind cuz
everyone's been punished by it. So,
we're traumatized. Once you're
traumatized from a cold week, you're
like, "Oh, just get another unit out
there." But then Riftbound Plus still
has enough. Now, will they use the cold
a week? because they didn't do a turn
one, which also would have been a pretty
optimal play cuz you denied the point
from Ees. I feel like it's the obvious
choice right now.
>> We're shuffling through. We're thinking,
oh, it looks like we might just go in
and conquer a battlefield for a point
real quick and then we're going to pass.
>> So, yeah, I guess the argument for this
uh line instead is that you are he's
passing priority. Uh I I believe I don't
think it's use's turn yet. Um, but the
reason for not using cold awak
because we do see Vanguard's armory in
Rift Plus's hand, which means that Yeah.
Okay. So, we're actually making the gold
gear. So, so Rift Plus is playing a more
patient line where it's okay, I'm not
going to deal with the immediate
threats. I'm going to let Eve score a
couple of points, establish a little bit
of a board because that's not going to
DM me. We haven't used either gold
token, and now we have two that are
going to be ready on our next turn.
Plus, we'll have the ramp for the
Vanguard's Armory or the ability to
pivot. And this means that we don't uh
you know lose out as much. Um
>> alrighty. So
>> does Fior just have ganking?
>> She does not have ganking until she is
mighty, but thearian war camp does give
her that plus one buff
>> to give her that. So she can't gank
back,
>> uh but she can gank over because she is
mighty at that one point.
>> Yeah, that's that's actually really fun.
I I like that a lot. One of Fiora's
greatest battlefields for sure.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Um
yeah, Fiora is also just one of those
legends that the longer people had to
cook on it, the better it got.
>> Absolutely. And the first mate is going
to come in with three runes exhausted to
move that Fiora back to base and then we
are going to pass turn.
>> Scary. So there are now enough runes up
for the repost.
>> Yes. So uh I did spot that in hand. So
just know once once it does come out, we
do have an answer for it. So we're
probably going to be seeing those two
runes kept up every turn from now on.
>> And because Eves has the resources, this
is the danger of Rift Plus not using
that cold a week at the opportunity it
was presented is that now Robost is a
defensive tool and Fiora can just go
back in Tfaren War camp, trigger the
Fior legend again, get more runes. The
Fior is kind of getting off the ground,
but I also said the same thing about Ees
in game one and we saw that the wheels
were like they they fell off fully and
like Earth plus could also play a slower
game. It's not like the game's going to
end in two turns even. It's going to
take three turns. So, you could just
play your um Vanguard's Armory and just
make a bunch of recruits, score a point
here, pass, you know, and then next turn
you get three more recruits. Turn after
that, you get three more recruits. You
know that you're going to have the time
to do that.
>> It looks like we're thinking about it. I
saw it in hand, but we're just going to
move that recruit in to uh score a point
and we're passing priority. Yep.
>> And then boom.
>> Okay. So, Ripon Plus, again, there's
always a decision tree. Anytime I say
like, "Oh, this is what I think they
could do." And then they do something
else. It's because you never like once
you make one decision, you're kind of
locked into one line and you can't go
back. And especially if it's a line that
dramps your runes. You really can't go
back when you have the Vanguard's armor
in hand. So, Rift Found Plus is showing
that as an experienced Victor player,
no, I'm just going to make sure I
continue to ramp my runes. Now, at this
point, that it's already established.
Now, we can start to decelerate our
runes, but
a lot of information.
>> Let's look into this uh hand real quick.
I want to see what we got.
>> I like how we just put the cold a week
there. He's like, "You're going to
probably take this." But
>> he knows.
>> Uh actually, Singularity is pretty
juicy, too.
>> As we uh spread them out, we've got
Bellow's Breath, we got a Stupify, we've
got a cold the week, a Hidden Blade,
which is also good, and Singularity,
which is also good. There's there that's
a good hand. A lot of answers for a lot
of units. This is a fantastic hand for a
Victor, but this is also kind of what
you expect. It's just going to be a lot
of spells. And now that I see the full
hand, it actually does make more sense
that you went for the Vanguard's Armory.
You want bodies. You want the ability to
score points. And once you have that,
then you can start dealing with the
board. Um, so the key things to note
here is Bellow's Breath. We saw the
combo with Imperial Decree. We don't see
an Imperial Decree yet, but we do have
like a hidden blade that we can use on
our own unit to draw more cards. Um, and
then combo with Bellow's Breath. So
that's probably on ease's mind as well.
The cold weak or the singularity are the
immediate like bigger hits now, but the
strength of the combo means that there's
also an argument maybe it's the bellow's
breath cuz then you put your own
opponent needing two cards in the combo
as opposed to just finding one more.
>> Right. Exactly. So it looks like we took
note of the cards that are shown face up
right here and we're kind of thinking
through what do we actually want to get
rid of. Uh it looks like we're coming to
a decision.
Blade is going to be the one instead of
cold the weight.
>> This kind of hits both that I was
talking about. It's like do you deal
with the card that's a threat right now
or the card that's a threat once you
have the combo. This is kind of part of
the way to dig for the combo and it's a
threat right now because you can use it
offensively or on your own recruit to
draw cards. So, um yeah, don't hate the
call from Ees there. It's a tough call
to make. Like I I I honestly don't know
offhand. I don't play enough Fior to
know like what the the correct threat is
here, but um I see the reason why you
would do that.
>> Yeah, I like the insight. And then
immediately we're going to move that
readied Fiora into the Trifarian war
camp to go ahead and take care of that
recruit and score another point. Um and
we might be about to yes score another
point with the first mate on Treasure
Horde.
>> Okay, now do we make the gold gear?
Fiora does have a decent amount of uh um
you know power costs. It does not look
like we're doing it though. We're just
going to play the set.
>> And this is if I remember correctly the
third set that we've seen. So it's the
third and last if I remember correctly.
>> Uh we game one.
>> Oh that is Dude, the games are coming
together.
>> The worst part is I also have a memory
of a gold. So like I I'm not confident
in that call. Um, but I believe that
Eves has already used the Fiora Legend
when he sent Fior into the Trafarian
War. I think I did see that. So, I I
believe that's what the that hang up
there was. E was saying, "Wait, did I
already use that cuz it was already
exhausted? Did I forget to unexhaust
it?" Um,
>> and the the beauty of moments like this,
I always like think in my head is like
somebody in chat right now was paying
full attention and it's like, "Ah,
obviously it was this."
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, I
truly am just so uh immersed in the fact
that Fior is on my screen right now.
Like I just you're living it right now.
>> Um
>> how do you feel about the Victor match
up? Have you played against this
matchup?
>> I haven't played against the Victor, but
I have played against Azir and that
matchup is normally uh for me in favor
of Fiora, but I haven't played against
many Victors. Okay.
>> Um I find them rare rare at the Nexus
Knights right now. Yeah, they've fallen
off somewhat in popularity. Um they're
they're not one of like the top
>> actually they might be in the top 10
represented. I think they like just uh
just edged in, but um
uh they were I'd say more popular in the
origin format as kind of like this ah
like the the rogue darkhorse threat of
the tournament. Um, but we're seeing why
they're still pretty solid right now is
the play style is very spellheavy and
just little little guys, little
recruits. Um, so I I don't really
gravitate towards the play style, but I
think it's it is a cool play style
nonetheless.
>> Oh my gosh. And the singularity is going
to come out for that six damage to each
unit of first mate and set. Are we going
to respond? We are.
And we have the rapas in hand for Eve.
So that will be counterpelled. But
again, reminder, this isn't always bad.
I know that it's like, oh, you can read
that he's got it, but you got to get
through them at some point. Like the the
threat of the repost will always be
there. Maybe you can try and bait it out
with a smaller spell, but like I don't
think that cold a week's going to bait
that out at this point. Um, so you just
accept that, yep, now there's one less
repost to worry about. Statistically,
now it's less likely that EES has a
second one in hand. I I don't know the
exact math numbers here, but I would
assume that Eves shouldn't. It would be
a slight statistical outlier for Ees to
to have another one already.
>> And the the second thing to note here is
that when you counter a spell, you get
that might
>> Yeah.
>> on a unit. So, uh even though the legend
is exhausted, you can't channel another
rune, you still get to make one of your
units a lot bigger. I imagine you go
first mate here just so that you the
three recruits can't crash into it cuz
first mate's kind of the nice cold a
weak protection uh currently like you
don't really care if this unit dies as
the fewer. I know it's like a three
might but still for fewer that's like
one of the smallest units that you're
going to have. Um so probably there but
we we'll see where Ees decides to put it
because there's not like a lot Yeah.
Yeah. There's not a lot in Victor that
will like increase the the strength.
Maybe Stupify and actually Ees does know
that Stupify is there. So you could
stupify the fior but then you pay the
deflect cost and it gets like a little
little scary. So
>> exactly she's sitting on that uh
trifarian war camp right now. So she
does have that field all of that.
>> But als
that that I I totally forgot about the
trif war camp. That's a five might. This
is going to be six might attacking in
the side.
>> Okay. Actually now you know what going
to walk that one back.
>> Well a little little reverse. Maybe
reposing the Fior did make more sense at
that point. I always forget about
Drifarian War camp. It's one of those
ones that just doesn't exist in my
brain. Uh, and there should still be one
recruit alive there. Did that get
flipped around to that buff that I see
on screen? I I I was I was busy doing my
little funny like rewind animation.
>> It was plus one plus one plus one.
>> So that' be six might attacking on five,
>> right?
But it looks like we're going to call
the weak and so we are going to let go
of that first mate still.
>> Well, did we score the point from Rift
Plus? Cuz you're going to lose a unit
from the cold of the week anyway. But
it's important to have the point. I I I
didn't again. I was looking at you doing
a rewind animation. I probably should
have been paying attention to the game
state. I'll do better.
>> No, I will I will also do better to not
be so animated here. Um, and it looks
like, huh, we're going to possibly
do something with all of these runes
that we have up now.
Okay. Yeah, there's uh no runes on
Victor's side. Eaves has five points to
two. You're not going to win this turn,
but you can set yourself up to win the
following turn. The scary thing is you
don't have a lot of units, only one on
the board. So, it's not a developed
board for Fior, even if it is a
developed and ramped rune setup. You got
to find a way to get more bodies out
there because um you Victor's never
going to run out of spells. Like, we
already know that there's a stupify in
hand, which will at the very least get
you another draw on top of making the
set vulnerable to the four recruits that
are already visible. So, at the very
least, Victor can crash uh with what
Eves has currently. That's just the
known information. Then there's two
cards unknown plus the one card that
Stupify draws which will be unknowns.
Um, and was there anything else? I know
that it was the we we got rid of the
hidden blade. There was a cold awake
singularity stupify.
>> I don't think we've seen the bellow's
breath.
>> Bellow's breath. Yeah, there's a
bellow's breath as well. Yeah,
>> I don't think we've seen that quite yet.
So, that is still there for possibility,
but uh it looks like Eves has been
checking his notes to try and make sure
he's accounting for everything that
could be in hand right now for Riftbound
Plus.
>> Yeah, this is a pivotal turn. You you
you want to take your time on moments
like this because you're already down
one game in the series and even though
you're ahead in points, that can easily
slip away against the Victor matchup as
Fiora. Again, it was a 66% win rate in
Le for Victor. That means uh Fioras only
won 34% of their games versus Victors.
>> Wow.
>> And it's even worse uh in Atlanta this
weekend at 67%. It's only 1% increase
and the event's not over yet, but not
great is is kind of the point of the
story when it's consistent across two
events like that.
>> Absolutely. So, we're going to go ahead
and move the set in real quick. Uh and
get that additional point here. And then
we're going to get the buff back because
we spent it. And we're going to uh get
that conquer buff back. Uh it looks like
we're exhausting
uh the five and recycling one so that we
can bring in that second set and we're
going to give a buff to him because when
we play him, we get a buff and we're
going to go ahead and pass our turn. So
this time I don't think the Fiora was
exhausted, but uh either way it's just
two sets on the board. Not the strongest
position, but with two runes up, maybe
Eaves has another repost. I don't again
I don't know the exact numbers, but it's
got to be under 50% odds to have a
second repost at this point, I would
have to imagine. So, Rift Plus can
probably play with a relative amount of
confidence that uh if you get like a
singularity uh or an Imperial decree or
something like that that it's going to
go through and if not again I mean like
sure you still can assume EES won't win
the next turn. It would be hard for the
Fior to get two points with only one set
on the back. But this is what a really
strong card here that Victors have
started adding the Zenhao.
>> Wow. Oh, and the Zenhao does come out to
play with the uh three runes exhausted,
one recycled, and we're going to see
Zenhao go ahead and enter ready by the
way. So, he can immediately do something
with this uh unit uh straight out the
bat.
>> Formite, which means it would crash with
the set currently cuz the stupify
lowered the might, which basically
cancels out the buff. So, it's just
formite on the set. Now, there's a
potential of like punch first. uh even
like the triumph that we saw in game
number one at reaction speed. So it's
not like guaranteed if you just throw
Zinga in there. Um let's see what
Riftbound Plus wants to do. Rift Plus is
doing the thing where you tap all of
your runes, exhaust all your runes
before going for the play. If you know
you're going to attack, I'm always a fan
of reversing that order. If if you plan
on attacking anyway, just attack because
then your opponent has to guess like ah
there's untapped runes, unexhausted
runes, like what what could they have in
combat? There's not a lot that Victor
would have to be like hidden blade
maybe, but it still makes them guess.
Whereas now Eves has much more
information in this combat of like,
okay, there's not enough runes for a
hidden blade. I know that that's not an
option for the Victor. So, you can play
with much more confidence like use the
uh the punch first and save the unit. I
like how Eaves has uh targeted this
treasure horde here instead of the
Trifarian War camp because he knows he
only has one unit on the board and
Riftbound Plus has a lot of those little
recruits. So, they're going to get that
much mightier just trying to swing into
that uh battlefield. So, we're trying to
decide
>> what who we want to send in right now
and where we want to send them. We also
brought in the Victor, the champion unit
here cuz when another non-recruit unit
uh you control dies, aka this Zenhao
that we have on the board now. We can
get a recruit in his honor.
>> And that that's why Riftbound Plus would
do this move cuz you get at least a
recruit. But in my mind, I'm like, you
have the Vanguard's armor. I don't think
that one recruit is doing that much work
when you don't have the um Grand
Strategium uh in the deck. Uh if you
were instead going for like the Imperial
Decree line, like one extra one might
isn't that much. But again, obviously
I'm going to defer to the player that
has way more experience on the Victor
than myself. Um, but now again, the the
cost of doing this type of play is EES
knows there's really nothing that they
can do. Maybe you know like another
stupify or the bellow's breath is an
action speed spell, but a punch first
would go through and would save this
set.
>> And so, uh, with the six might of the
two recruits in the four from the
Zenhiao, it looks like we might have a
response here. And we're going to spend
a buff
>> instead of uh
>> uh No, this is death grip, not triumph.
So this
>> Oh, we're gonna kill the set to give
that uh might. Yes, that one's a little
bit more costly. And we're going to give
that might to the set to try and protect
him.
>> I saw a um a hidden blade drawn as well
from Ees there cuz the the death grip
lets you draw afterwards.
>> And I love that. I love to see that. So
we've got um an additional five might
for the rest of this turn. and instead
riffound plus is just going to go to the
trifarian war camp and get that
additional point.
>> Mhm.
>> So that's a point for Rift Plus, but
Eaves is on the precipice of a victory
in game two here. You're going to hold
for a point and then we also can um
maybe have like a a first mate. We can
bring the set back, play the first mate,
ready the set. Again, we are completely
exhausted except for one rune I think I
see there. Uh, I'm assuming that that's
actually in play from Riftbound Plus,
but that's the Bellow's Breath or
Stupify. Like that that's really the
only things that a Victor could have
unless they like hide a hidden blade.
>> All right, it looks for reinforcement.
So, we're going to have a total of four
might there on the side. Uh, and we're
going to bring that up to six with the
additional recruit from uh Victor's
legend being uh exhausted.
>> I think you put one more out there at
least.
>> What if we do
>> two safe? Yeah. So, so I think Rip Plus
realized the similar line of like, yeah,
set can move back to base, spend the
buff to uh jump up to eight might and
then like a first mate would ready it
and send it in. That makes nine might.
So, currently with five one might
recruits, that's 10 defending, EES would
need to have like a first mate plus a
punch first or a first mate plus a
triumph, something else uh in the tank
to actually pull this off.
>> Yeah, something is going to have to give
if we want to get this eighth point. So
we are going to move the set back and oh
it looks like it's happening. So the
buff does get spent. Maybe there is a
pit rookie in hand that could give
another buff to set so that he can get
that additional form might. I'm not
sure.
>> Yeah, you can spend multiple in one turn
as ooh
>> and the digging through that graveyard
all y'all. So we're going to bring back
a first mate. So it's ready. The BF
sword. We're getting that equipped. It's
happening. We're moving in. We've got so
much might here.
>> It is eight plus the three from BF sword
is 11 plus the one from War Camp is 12.
Uh and uh against 10 that will clear and
that will score the eighth point for
EES. Well done game two.
>> Let's freaking go. We've got a game on
our hands, ladies and gentlemen. It is
one to one. And honestly, can I just
point out I love how Riftbound Plus is
enjoying this game of Riftbound, man.
still smiling, still having fun. I think
he likes the challenge,
>> having a good time. Also, I just noted I
cuz I didn't realize at first, it was
Fiora that had Trafarian War Camp. Fiora
just beat Victor
>> with a Vanguard's Armory playing their
own Dfarian war camp. That's crazy.
>> It's a great Fiora
um battlefield because as you saw, she m
or Fiora made use of that ganking power
just off of that battlefield. you're
able to pick up those extra points if
you have that on the field.
>> Yeah, you use it to great effect, but
now Rifton Plus playing the void gate.
This will make your bellow's breath hit
harder. It'll make your singularity hit
harder. Um, those are the two big ones.
And we know that uh Riftton Plus was on
just like three of pretty much across
the board. Meanwhile, Fiora is going for
more draw power with the sunken temple.
But with Victor going first, let's see
what they do.
>> And if you notice here y'all, the chosen
champion has been changed. This is now
the Fiora that came out of that
sideboard where when your units become
mighty, you can uh recycle one yellow
rune and you can ready them. So
sometimes first mates aren't needed or
first mates aren't in hand. Instead, we
can use this legend. Now, this is only
available when it's on the field, of
course, but the fact that it's here
means that we're going to see some
awesome plays. And I see a lot of Fioras
pivot to this one when they uh are
assuming they're going second because
you're on the odd number of runes and it
is an odd energy cost. So you can either
play at turn one if you have nothing
else or you can just like do what uh Eve
is doing right now. Unsung hero next
turn maybe play something else turn
after that like few can be played and
then you're back on the even runes which
is kind of the majority of cards outside
of I suppose the set. So but Victor's
doing Victor things. You're just making
your recruits. There's already one out
there on voidgate. play the faithful
manufacturer plus uh the the legend
ability. So, the army is a building.
>> It is building and it builds so quickly.
I feel like things can get out of hand
real quick with Victor, but we do have
our unsung hero. There is an open
battlefield. It just depends on if we
want to move to it. So, we're shuffling
through. We're thinking and it looks
like we're going to play a pit rookie to
buff that unsung hero. Now remember
unsung hero once it becomes mighty you
can draw if it uh dies so
>> we're just making her a little bit
buffer. Uh she's got three might now and
then boom she's mighty.
>> Yeah I I think BF swords is the classic
combo with the uh um unsung hero but
then you can also do this where you buff
it plus the doran's blade still gets you
up to that five might. So, like you're
saying, if it dies, you get value off
it, but it's also a five might unit. So,
we can just go in and start swinging on
stuff and it's kind of hard to deal
with.
>> And as you see, you also get to make use
of your legend there and get more runes
because she is now mighty. So, very
valuable here. And you get to get
Riftbound Plus off of that holding point
with the recruit.
>> Riftbound Plus is taking some time to
think about the next play as
>> I mean, I would too with that five might
unsung hero. Also, I got to ask you
something because I think we have a
little time before the next action. How
do you feel about uh players that have
their runes like Rift on Plus where some
are face up, some are face down?
>> Okay, so I'm very much a yees type of
person where my
runes have to be cute and pretty and in
order. I maybe that's a little OCD of
me, but 100% for me.
>> I'm looking at Rift Plus and I'm like,
"Brother, if you don't turn those rudes
around,
>> I I I did such a good job of not
pointing it out for the first two games
and I can't I can't do it anymore. I had
to point it out."
>> And there's no shame. I mean, like some
people's like they have no issue with
it. I'm like, "Yeah, I can't control
what you do with your runes." But my
roommate knows uh if he's trying to tilt
me, he just like turns once.
I got to put some respect on Riftbound
plus his name cuz a lot of people do
have the blinged out uh overnumbered or
all art runes, but he's rocking the base
runes and I like that. I like that.
>> Baseart Victor base art uh legend. You
know,
>> it's pretty fire because he's out here
speaking with the game play. You know
what I'm saying? Like he doesn't have to
have the flashy cards. He doesn't need
all of that. He out here thinking with
his mind and y'all going to say that the
the shiny promo pack on hero blade. We
got a different philosophy between these
two gamers as Singularity will hit the
board.
>> Singularity is going to target both the
unsung hero and the pit rookie, but uh I
don't think it matters cuz we get to
draw two.
>> Yeah, but I still like it. It's tough.
They're always going to get the two
draws. Victor doesn't have ways to
remove other than just killing. Um and
this is a one of the few moments that
Ease is given with no two runes up for
the repost cuz we saw in that game too.
It was tough. Rift Plus wasn't able to
play through a lot of those turns
because there was always the two runes
up. So, taking the opportunity now to
just have an efficient spell.
>> Absolutely. And I do want to say I do
see a cold the week in Riftbound plus
his hand. So,
>> Yortal, another manufacturer.
>> Well, the Fiora is going to hit the
board here and she is going to become
mighty. So, we might spend a rune to
ready her. And we do. And we're going to
go in and go ahead and try and take care
of this recruit here on Sunken Temple.
We don't want any hold points right now,
so we're just going to go ahead and deal
with that.
>> Get a point and then also trigger the
Sunont Temple. Uh exhausting a rune to
draw a card and another unsung hero.
>> Another unsung hero. Yes. Does enter the
board. Um I do think
>> Did he pay the runes for that second
unsung hero?
>> I do believe so. No, cuz he paid three
for the Fiora
>> and then
>> he recycled
>> tapped one for the sunken temple
>> and then uh recycled for the Dorne's
blade.
>> Tapped the Fiora
>> recycled for the Fiora.
>> Okay, maybe maybe he did because there
were two recycle costs and then Fiora
channel one. Yeah, e either way. Unsung
heroes on the board and that's important
for the cold a week. Okay,
>> it is. So
>> cold a week is now not going to just
kill the Fiora instantly. Yes, I see in
hand we've got the lecturing yortle.
We've got the coal of the week. I do
believe we have an imperial decree and a
thousand tail watcher. I'm just trying
to give y'all a little bit more
information here on what uh Riftbound
Plus has in hand so you can kind of get
behind the logic and the reasoning and
the of the of the decision making. Um I
do believe we're bringing out that
lecturing Yortle here in just a moment.
I don't want to say it until the card
drops down and then boom. Yes. So, with
three runes exhausted, we're bringing in
the lecturing Yortle. So, he's going to
get to draw one off of that play. And
we're going to see what else.
>> Uh there's an Imperial Decree.
>> Uh yes,
>> and we're just going to make more
bodies. Yeah, I don't think we have the
tools right now for Ripton Plus to
actually clear the Fiora again cuz
Unsung hero is kind of protecting that.
Um so, instead, it's just going to be
bodies on the board. No bodies on the
board. And
>> what the bodies?
>> Yep. I was going to say no bodies on the
floor, but uh we are going to go ahead
and ready our units.
>> That should be Victor's theme song.
>> Honestly, yes. Like I could see him
blast.
>> I'm not going to sing it again cuz
again, copyright. I don't know how those
laws work.
>> All right.
>> I was paranoid about it.
>> We're moving the Fiora back to base
trying to keep her safe. There's a lot
of units on the other side as of right
now, but we're shuffling through. Uh it
looks like Oh, he's just lining up the
runes. Yeah,
>> a lot of
>> And that's something that you love to
see as Fiora because Yeah, you can you
you have a lot of choices. You have a
lot of units. I do know that he has a
set in hand. I did see that drawn.
>> Yeah, I was going to say, what do you
what are the big plays that you're
trying to do as Fiora at this point when
you have this many runes to play with?
Like what do you feel the best playing
right now?
>> Um I would be looking for that other
Fiora. That is the Flora that I love to
play with because you get that ganking.
You can score those two points in one uh
in one turn, especially now that you
have this other Fiora on the board. So,
you can with the Fiora's passive. Uh if
she gets mighty, you can then ready her,
gank over to the other battlefield.
That's my favorite play to always.
>> We have both Fioras.
>> The Karma is here. I'm very excited to
see what are we what are we doing with
this unit? What is the play?
>> So, I am realizing technically Karma's
vision ability does recycle. So, you
kind of are forced to, but then it will
trigger Karma to be you recycled one or
more cards. You can buff a friendly
unit.
>> So, maybe that's the idea is you just
you're forced to use the vision to put
the card on the bottom and then you get
a buff. So, it's essentially like a six
might or a seven might.
>> Oh,
>> six energy, one recycle. And then that
one buff can like trigger your your um
legend ability. But I didn't see any
other way to recycle. Uh so I think it
it's just kind of like Karma recycling
for herself and uh it works. I mean now
it's a seven might Karma. That that's a
big body.
>> I I love to see it. I might have to
adapt this take. Uh but I also want to
say we did see a hidden card go under
the void gate from Yees. And I I don't
know any other hidden cards that you can
do in Fiora besides that. uh hidden
blade.
>> Yeah. And I think I I'm pretty sure what
I saw Eve look at with the vision was a
set. So like yes, you get the buff, but
now you don't get to draw that set,
which is also a pretty efficient unit.
So the Karma's kind of got a drawback if
that's the only way to trigger it. I
didn't see any others that I clocked.
May maybe I missed one or maybe the
sideboard also has more options for EES
to to trigger recycle on on the Karma
because it's a cool card. Like if you're
able to trigger it multiple times, you
can get multiple buffs. Um, but uh so
far gotten one and the only Karma in the
entire event. Uh the production did tell
us no one else has blamed this card.
>> I I love to see it and it's so true. The
artwork is out here and pretty, but
we're going to go ahead and flip over
that hidden card. And yes, that was that
hidden blade. We're going to go ahead
and draw the two off of that and let
Riftbound Plus score that conquer point.
Okay, it would have been a crash, but
you don't want to lose a hidden. So,
>> and I don't think we want Riftbound Plus
drawing any more turns, so or any more
cards.
>> Yeah, you're not keeping that unsung
hero alive regardless. So, just get the
advantage. But Riftbound Plus is in a
really good spot. You're within one turn
of winning. You're at six points. You
only need eight to win the game. That's
either hold or conquer. You also have
all of your runes unexhausted. Full turn
to play. I really hope that Eves has
some type of counter spell in hand at
the moment. Oh, I see it. Okay. Period.
So, we've got a death grip. We've got a
set. We've got a challenge. We've got
the repost. Uh we've got a sabotage I
think we have in there. He's splashing
those so quick, y'all. I'm trying my
best. Oh, thank you, bestie. He's just
spreading it out.
>> I feel like you probably repost this
just because
>> Yes.
>> I mean, there's bigger spells to hit,
but you want to keep your units. And I
don't think we didn't see a unit in
hand, right? It was just spells.
>> We saw set.
>> Oh, we saw set. Okay.
>> We saw set,
>> but no way to move him. So, if we're
trying to stay on the board and get
points, reposing here is the way to at
least make sure that we still have two
units for now. Like, we don't know what
else the the Victor has.
>> You can move the set because when he
enters the field, he becomes mighty
because of that Fiora. You can ready him
immediately if you recycle that rune.
I'm a Fiora man, baby. Get it. No, no,
I'm happy you bring that up because
maybe it's it's painful, but maybe you
just let the Karma die. No, E is not
going to do that. We are triggering
something. I'm assuming the power cost
is the repost.
>> Yes. So, we're going to make sure that
that doesn't go off. We're not trying to
kill any units and we're actually going
to make our Fiora a little bit mightier.
We're making her bigger. So, if you
really want to do something to her now,
she has a little bit more might. And
even though Ripton plus has six runes,
like even a singularity doesn't clear
this because the Karma's at seven might
and the Fiora now is at seven as well,
right? Yeah.
>> Yes. So that Victor is going to enter
the board. We are going to channel um a
recruit and we're going to pass turn. We
got to get you off of these
battlefields, but I think we have the
means to do it.
Even more bodies will hit the board as
this uh faithful manufacturer will
presumably die and trigger that Victor
leader to allow you to play a one might
recruit back to your base and a lot of
resources on Rift plus side. Also not
necessarily on the clock, but the
sabotage is huge.
>> I love to see it cuz now we're going to
get that intel. There are 2,000 tailed
watchers. He's thinking Yep. Let's go
ahead and look at the stupify, the
Imperial decree, the Vanguard Armory,
and the 2,000 tailed Watchers.
>> I think it has to be Imperial Decree. If
we don't have a repost, that will just
we'll lose the board because they have
two recruits. They can just Imperial
decree, send the recruits in, then send
two other things in. They don't even
need the Thousand Tale. Um, so in my
mind, it's an easy choice unless Eve's
like drew another rap, in which case
you're like, "Okay, let's bait out the
runes." Uh, and then they can't play the
Thousand Tale with the Imperial Decree.
Um,
but if if you do that, I think if if
you're riff plus, then you probably just
assume, oh, he's got another repos. So,
now we get the mind games.
>> There's a lot of mind games happening in
this game, man. I love it. This is
Riftbound.
>> Yeah, I you know, this is one of those
moments where it's like you can really
try and bluff your opponent. They don't
happen often, but No, this is a safe
route. This is how I usually go. I'm
just like, "No, just get rid of the
thing that's going to lose me the game
if opponent just plays it."
>> Um, so
>> and he did just like that as he I'm
trying to get the intel on the cards,
man. Um, but we're thinking here. So,
we've got the two might up at the void
gate and we got the one might down at
the sunken temple. So, we can move in
and we can conquer these, but can we
hold it? And uh can Euse play more than
just the set? I've seen six five five
only five runes. So it's only the set.
>> It's only the set.
>> If you want to play another body, you
can't play the death grip. You can't
play the uh challenge. So like it's it's
actually really tough the amount of
runes that you find themselves at.
>> I'm not sure what we drew on turn. Uh it
would be great if we got the call to
glory cuz then you could uh for free get
that buff to be spent instead. Um but
I'm really not sure if we have that in
hand. And I know we've got the death
grip, but what can we do to make sure
that when when Riftbound Plus does swing
back cuz we're swinging and he's got to
swing back, will we be able to still be
standing?
>> So, uh, if we can have our card
operator, I believe his name's Will. I'm
going to check and then confirm it for
next game. But if we could get Thousand
Tail Watcher on the bottom right of your
screen, that's the card to highlight
right now because that's on Eve's mind.
You see it on the left of the screen,
but you need to you're assuming that a
seven might unit is going to hit the
board next turn. That's going to make
everything three might less plus all the
bodies that are already there. That's
what 8 10 might on the board for Ripton
plus 7. That is 17. You need to defend
against 17 when every uh unit you have
is going to be minus three might. Like
that's tough. What What do we have right
now? It's 5 + 7 is 12. So we're kind of
close, but then that 12 goes to six.
Yeah.
>> So, you have six currently. You have to
defend against 17.
>> How are we going to do that?
>> This is tough. This is a tough one.
>> That's like Yeah, that's almost
positive. Can Fior do that? I mean,
you've played a lot of Fior. Like, what
are your options?
>> Uh to getting up to 17,
>> getting 11 additional might on your
turn. Would it be like two punch firsts?
>> Yes, you definitely need to be drawing
those punch firsts, but I don't think
that we have those in hand,
unfortunately. And it's also set getting
those buffs to uh rapidly uh keep
increasing the might. But
>> it's never the set. We we know
mathematically playing the set is not
going to get us out of there. I like
this call at least to try and dig. You
know, you can use the sunken temple to
exhaust a rune and draw a card.
>> It's got to be something great.
>> It was punch first. It was punch first.
He does the punch, y'all. It might be
saved.
>> Maybe it might be saved. There's no way.
>> Four runes up. There was a death grip.
There's also a challenge in hand. So
maybe we target one of the units to
maybe go ahead and get some of the other
might off of the board before we get
into re re-swinging territory.
>> I I think what you do here is you pass.
If if I'm Eve, I'm passing because you
hope that griffon plus just starts
swinging in with little stuff and then
like tries to trade and then you can
punch first when the combat heal
>> and then you still have the death grip
to then like swap over to either side
that the thousand tail goes in. Um, and
you hope that Rifton Plus just like kind
of I I don't I I I hesitate to say
misplays, but you give your opponent the
opportunity to not play correct lines.
>> And that's what he did. He is going to
pass. He's got those four runes still up
and we're looking at riftbound plus
readying his units, readying or readying
his awakening his uh runes.
>> We got there. We got there.
>> And the thousand tail watcher does come
out. E does look a little scryy. Yep.
>> Just a little.
>> I mean, we we knew we knew what was
happening. Uh Rift Plus had the rune uh
ramp and so this is all that is going to
happen on Rift Plus this turn. No more
runes to play. We already did the math.
Um that Yeah, it was seven. And oh, I
was I was one off. So it's uh it's
actually 18 18 might cuz there's two
from manufacturer and Yortle that's four
plus the four from Victor is eight plus
the three from the recruits is 11 plus
the seven from thousand tales 18. So 18
might we have to deal with
man this is scary times. But let's see
how Riftbound Plus decides he wants to
divvy this up.
>> And a reminder with Thousand Tail
everything's three might less. So that
Fiora on the Sunken Temple is only two
might. The karma up on the void gate is
only four might.
>> Correct.
>> There's a punch first, there's a death
grip, there's a challenge. I didn't see
any other spells, but I I didn't get a
clear look at his hand. So maybe there's
other surprises, but at least the things
that I'm keeping my eye on are the punch
first and the death grip. If you play
them correctly, I think Eve can actually
get through this depending on how
Riftbound Plus approaches this turn.
>> Yeah, I think the the big the big thing
here is how do we where do we send what
units? Where do we go?
>> If if like Riftman Plus deals with the
if if you send Thousand Tail first to
like guarantee a hit, I think that's the
correct line. But even then, I mean,
like, oh man, it gets so tough. It gets
so tough. Like,
>> they're both like
>> I don't know what Victor's supposed to
do here. I'm not experienced enough as
the Victor or like uh in in these like
wide game states to know like what are
what are you tracking? Like which order
do you attack? My my gut says attack
with the thousand tail first
>> with like a twoight or or maybe like
with the Victor and just like establish
a guaranteed take one.
>> Oh wow. This is tough. I'm happy I'm a
caster and not a player cuz this would
be like one of those moments I'm like I
don't know what to do.
>> Yeah. No. And I mean if you look at
these player cams right now, they're
both lowkey stressing. Like this is this
is tough. And this is like game point.
They're both at six and six. Like this.
It can either end here. We could go one
more turn.
>> So I think that what Ees was deciding
that was a reaction window on the
Thousand Tail trigger. Eve was deciding,
do I death grip now cuz you could
actually death grip like the Karma and
give the full seven might to the Fiora
before the debuff goes through from the
Thousand Tale Watcher. So that that was
what that kind of like thinking process
was from Ees. But I agree. No, let it go
through. I I actually don't think the
correct call is to jump because then the
rift plus can just send everything at
you. And I think mathematically you lose
at that point. Your only way to win this
uh board state mathematically is
allowing the um the victor to kind of
send a couple units in and then tricking
them and winning that combat then
rehealing at the end of the combat.
>> It looks like we're starting to get like
a divvy up of what we're going to send
in first. We've got the thousand tailed
watcher, the lecturing yortle, um, and
one more unit up here at the top, and
the other recruits are sitting down at
the bottom with the Victor. Not sure if
that's going to be the final decision
here.
>> I will say I think the Rift on Plus
theoretically got a lot of information
from E's decision there. You assume it's
either a triumph or a death grip. So,
you know that there's something and
either one of those would give enough
runes for the punch first on top of it.
So, Riftbound Plus, if you if usually
moments like this, you have to assume
worst case scenario. You have to be
like, okay, what's the worst thing that
they could possibly do? Let's play
around that. Can I win? If no, then the
next like decision tree is, okay, well,
what's likely that they have? And you
kind of like start chipping away at that
in the thought process. But we're making
a choice here.
>> We're making the choice here. We're
going in with 72. So, that's 9 and then
10 11 might versus this karma. What is
going to be the response? How do we want
to respond to this 11 mic coming in?
>> So, it's 11 on four. Punch first does
not defend here. I like this math from
Riftbound Plus because it's going to
force both answers from Eaves. But the
problem is both answers from Ees only
crashes. That would be 11 again. So,
Riftbound Plus actually found the line.
Look at that. Really, really smart.
>> Again, I'm so happy I was not in that Z
cuz I probably would have messed that
up.
>> Yes. And as we uh exhaust the runes, the
death grip is going to come out. So,
we're going to give
>> that. This is the line. Yeah, Eve's
actually really heads up play cuz you
know you can't win if you send the death
grip over to the other side. You only
get plus two and the punch versus plus
five. That's seven. That crashes then
you lose.
>> He just drew
>> a repost.
>> Uh it's not going to get much value this
turn. Oh, there's no more spells,
but important for potential future turns
because I think he lives. It's minus
three plus four. So, this is back to a
six might. All the Victor plus the
recruits could clear it. But you see two
runes up. It could be a punch first. It
could be well not another death grip.
So, the interesting thing is Ripon plus
if it was triumph and not death grip
actually loses the math there. If it's
like triumph plus punch first. Um, but
it it worked out at the end of the day.
You score a point. You could just try
and hold here as well. Like Ees is still
in the hot seat, but Ripbound Plus, like
let's see if he if he throws the bodies.
Are the bodies going to hit the
battlefield?
>> Are the bodies going to hit the
battlefield? So, we've got uh four,
five, six, seven on the side of Victor.
And then, yeah, Fiora sitting here with
nine might if I'm correct.
>> So, six. Yeah.
>> So, six.
>> Seven beats six.
>> Yep. So, we will have to swing with that
punch first likely.
Okay, this is the smarter play.
>> Saving the unit.
>> Even the punch first does not clear
this. I think Ees is really hoping that
Riftbound Plus would uh would go for the
other play cuz now not only do you need
to get the Fiora back in action somehow.
You also need to find how to clear. How
much is on that? That's 9 + 7 is 16. 16
on void gate.
>> Lord have mercy. I
>> That's why I saying E isn't out of the
hot seat yet. Like you hold for seven,
that's not enough to win. So you
survived the the crazy turn. That was a
really stressful turn, but you're not
out of the water yet. Like you're out of
the frying pan into the fire here cuz
your situation arguably got worse.
>> Does Eve see the out here? What is the
game plan counting up right now? Uh how
much might did you say that was?
>> Uh I believe it's 16 cuz it was seven
from the Victor and the recruits and
then nine or no it's 11 from the others.
So it's actually um what 18 then
>> yeah 18
>> activate set ability.
>> Yes 18 you are correct. Okay the set
does come out now set can get big and
get ready immediately. Uh let's see if
he's going to be able to make it because
what we're doing is he's played. He gets
the buff. You can spend that buff in the
turn.
>> Did he also tap an
>> I didn't see how many he exhausted for
the set to begin with cuz there's only
four exhausted right
>> because you recycle one. It should have
been five recycle one and then the
legend gets one back.
>> It should have been We're back to five.
But there's only four exhausted. So
maybe he floated one.
>> I don't see a
>> I mean the die would have been spent, I
guess.
>> Odd. Interesting. There
>> we're spending that buff. So it's now an
eight might at the moment.
Let's see what the next course of action
is. We're exhausting two more. We're
going to death grip. So, we're giving
the might to the set. And then we're
going to equip the Dorne's blade onto
the set. So, that's nine additional
might at the moment.
>> We're drawing
this
>> and we're equipping that Doran's Blade.
So, we are making it bigger.
>> 13 plus 15.
>> So, we've got
>> This is enough with punch first.
I'm amazed he had this many runes to
work with.
>> I must I must have missed something,
dude. Yeah, punch first. That's enough.
>> That's enough. Yees takes the win. The
Fiora is going to continue on 8 and1.
What a great game. Honestly,
congratulations to Yees. But Riftbound
Plus, what an insane game.
>> 34% win rate. Pull it off. That is
crazy.
>> Crazy.
>> I can't I I want to look back and see.
Hopefully I I have time to check the
tape to see what happened with the runes
there cuz again like it should have been
the five exhausted for the set. So I I
must have missed something. I I must
admit maybe he like floated one cuz he
he punched first at the end anyway. It's
like you're going to spend uh the power
cost. So I always default to trusting
the judges on on the stage. Um I I don't
trust my own eyes very often. Uh but
like Eve's what a performance surviving
that one turn.
>> Yes.
>> Was already an impressive feat. And then
cuz you have to hold with two bodies and
the four runes up and you only have like
two resources. You're staring down 17
might barely have anything to hold with
and uh he survives that and is able to
make the push for the next play with
that set which was saved because he
reposted and kept the Karma alive. That
was actually crucial too cuz I was like
oh maybe you don't repost the cold a
week because then you can like next turn
send the set in anyway. But he didn't
need the repost. He needed the set to
win that game.
>> Oh my gosh. It was absolutely beautiful.
I'm I'm starruck. I like the decision
making because this man, it felt like he
was like three steps ahead. Like he was
already playing. We were on I don't even
know what turn. Say we're on turn seven.
We were playing on turn 10 on turn
seven, which is crazy to me. So, I
absolutely love to see the just the
skill expression there, the death grip,
>> the um the on the Fiora to bring it over
to the set and swinging, spending the
buffs so that he has so much. Absolutely
gorgeous.
>> Great stuff. But I'm hearing that the
interview's ready. So, that's enough of
us gushing over that win. Let's hear
from the player themselves.
>> Gorgeous. It absolutely was. Such
finesse as the rapier flies across the
stage with Vest here piloting Fiora
immaculately. Ves, I got to say right
off the bat, how are you feeling?
Because that was one of the most
beautiful games of Riftbound I've ever
seen from both of you.
>> I I'm feeling elated. I'm just glad it's
over because he was a really good Victor
player and I was just honestly it's one
of my worst matchups I feel like and I
avoided it all day. So
>> we talked about the matchup. The casters
actually touched on it. Did you know yes
or last week in Liil and currently so
far in the tournament, Victor has a 66
or 67% win rate to beat Fiora? And here
you are.
>> Yeah.
>> Proving those numbers wrong.
>> I built the deck initially just kind of
pat a little bit against the matchup,
but um I was just hoping more likely to
avoid it. But yeah,
>> so let's talk about that. Right. So I
was talking about you a little bit
beforehand and punch first at the end
again. Rewind those last little turns,
right? the repost to keep both the Karma
and the Fiora alive in that game three.
You needed both of those units to make
the math harder. Get some more of these
units off of the board. And then as your
turn comes into it, death grip or sorry,
set brawler, ready it because of the
Fiora victorious.
>> Yes.
>> Death grip. Give it the might. Equip the
sword. Punch first.
>> Yeah.
>> How many punch first did you even have
in that game?
>> I s them out. I keep one in. So I saw it
for turn and not for turn for the turn
before and I was like this might be
exactly what I need to win this game. So
and it came down to when he moved to the
other side. He could have came to my
side and I'd have to punch first there
and I'm not sure I would have been able
to take the other field but he went to
that side and God bless
>> the scare tactics.
>> The scare tactics. Yeah.
>> The puzzle that you had to solve there.
The the body and order combinations. We
saw yesterday
puzzles that you really
might until it comes down to those turns
at the end.
>> I want to talk about your chosen
champion because Fiora victorious was
such a huge part of that victory, but
that was not the chosen champion that
you go into for the majority of the when
you play the deck, right? especially
like going first, but having that three
drop and how important it is to stick on
the board and she stuck around for so
long because then you had the Dorne's
Blade equipped to ready her up, contest
these battlefields early on, it's going
well then obviously with this card.
>> I mean the idea behind Fiora worthy
going into the second. It's not always
going in. Um against like let's say
Ezreal or Kaisawa, I'll still keep the
victorious because the tempo doesn't
matter as much as you think against
those matchups. you want to have the
deflect, but against Victor, they're
just going to call you anyway if you
play the victorious. So, it's too slow
anyway. So, I put in the you are worthy
to keep up with the tempo. And when it
was staying alive for a turn, another
turn, and I was thinking to myself, this
is probably how I'm going to win this
game. I need to keep this card alive as
much as possible. And it was. So,
>> that was exactly what happened. Ves,
congratulations. Now, I hear there's
another Fiora out there that's also X
and one. I don't know the results of
this match for them, of course. So, keep
up the good work. You already got a
great start to day two, but enjoy the
rest of your rounds. We're going to send
it back.
>> Eve.
>> Yeah, he's on one.
>> He's on one. And he's
>> the fact that he drew it. Oh my gosh.
I'm high-fiving you through the camera.
I hope you see this, fam.
>> And he drew that off the death grip that
he used on the unsung hero on the other
turn. Like, he used that just to He's
like, "Well, it's going to die anyway.
Let's just unsung or hit that get the
draw." And he draws the the one of uh
punch first. That That was crazy.
>> The one to win the game. I know. That
he's keeping that in from now on.
>> He's got to frame that punch first.
>> Oh my gosh.
>> Right there. If that wins him cuz
there's another X1 Fior. But if they
lose, that means he wins the the best of
Fiora. He's got to frame that punch
first with the middle card Fiora.
>> Yes, he will. That was amazing. I'm so
glad we got that interview there. Oh my
gosh. I I'm I'm at a loss for words. I
can't lie. Crazy crazy game. And again,
the the win rate is so abysmal for Fiora
into Victor as we saw from Leo. Again,
34% win rate on the Fiora side, 66% win
rate on the Victor side. But I love
hearing him talk about his opponent,
too. It's like, and that's again the
same philosophy that I have coming into
a lot of matchups. Like, you might raid
your opponent has a punch first, but
make them use the punch first. It's
going to dramp them too. They uh don't
have that card anymore for the followup.
And if he had sent in the seven, yeah,
you lose to the punch first, but you
still have 11 holding the other. Then
it's got to be like a set with a triumph
or a set with another punch first or
something like that, right? Or or the
death grip or like all these other
things. Um, so yeah, it's it's
interesting. It's interesting like the
lines that players choose to go down and
then thinking back to be like, oh, like
what what would have been more optimal
there? What would have been the correct
choice?
>> But I do want to highlight the Victor
player because uh even he said like that
that was a really good Victor player. He
knew what he was doing. He I mean at a
certain point you can only play with
what's on the board. You can't talk
about your whatifs. You got to just move
with what you have. And they both played
their best.
>> Yeah. And again I just I love how the
sequencing went from like the sabotage
scene to the Thousand Tales and be like,
"Okay, I know that they're just going to
drop Thousand Tales." It's it was like a
um a stupify and like a maybe Bella's
breath in hand. I don't remember what
the other one was, but like the spells
weren't going to be the impactful thing.
It was just the Thousand Tail you have
to do the math for. So then you got to
solve that puzzle. And it took a long
time. Like those are long turns, but I
those are the type of turns I'm like,
"Yes, take your time." I I'm never going
to complain about somebody taking their
time on a turn like that because I was
like, "Yeah, this is the pivotal moment
not only in the game, but in the match."
That was game three.
>> Um so yeah, you got to take your time
and think through the lines and find the
right angle.
>> Absolutely. And you have to also
remember like they're playing on camera,
so you know, the nerves are getting
getting to them a little bit. like this
might be the first time that they play
on camera, but also what are they
playing for? Like they are still in in
competition to reach the top here. So,
they're making sure that they want to
they want to secure these wins. It might
have looked really good at the beginning
for Riftbound Plus, but uh Yees had to
make sure he stayed in it, not only
mentally, but low key physically with
the cards.
>> And X1 theoretically can still uh bubble
into top eight. So like your tournament
is like you keep rising and again
there's bit bigger prizes for top 32 for
top 16. So like top eight you know it
gets better and better and better as
you're going. So, um, yeah, you got to
stay in it and, uh, never give up. That
game one, if you remember that game one,
he was like, "Nah, f it was like six to
six points or something and he was like,
"Yeah, I can't win from this position.
Let's just go game two." Because it's so
tough in those moments. But I love it
when players are willing to save that
time cuz then it buys you that time
later to take those longer turns when
you actually have an angled.
>> Absolutely. Well, let's go ahead and get
into this postgame recap of what we just
saw.
Monomies. Let's talk about Fiora cuz my
goodness that game was amazing. We have
a lot to get through. So, let's get on
over. So, first things first, let's kind
of show show what happened in game one,
which was the game that refound plus our
Victor player one. Now, as you heard
from Kangas, this matchup is cooked. It
is not good. There is so much removal.
Call of the week, Imperial Decree, a
hidden blade, singularity, wages of pain
for some size of units. There is just
too much going on. And right now, you
can see in game one, this is just I have
two pretty big units. I'm trying to take
Battlefields. I'm already behind in
points because my opponent actually has
pretty good low to the ground drops to
to get aggressive and take points to
early with this. Singularity basically
seals game number one. So, we'll go on
ahead and look at our next thing here
because as we move on to uh to game
number two, we're in kind of the same
situation, but instead the Singularity
once again trying to take out two big
units. This one gets reposted. This is
Fiora's signature spell. You might
think, okay, we've seen set do well, but
in general, these domains haven't looked
all that good. One of the things to
think about in riftbound is why would I
play a legend? And one of the best
reasons to play a legend other than the
fact that you may be like them and main
them in League of Legends is that you
get access to their signature spell.
Only those legends can play that spell.
And repost is an extremely powerful
counter spell. We've seen not so fast,
hard bargain, and defies all weekend
long. This is one of the better ones.
Not only does it counter the spell, but
it also gives the might to the UDA. And
that that part isn't particularly
relevant in this instance. But uh again,
same situation where Singularity is
coming in to threaten two units, but
this time uh it's taken out and we're
able to actually close out game number
two. Moving on to our next thing we have
here cuz again we got a lot to cover in
this.
So now we're in game three 1-1. Uh
Victor and Fior have both split the
first two games. And you might notice
something different. In fact, you might
not have if you might have missed it
down here in the chosen champion zone.
The first two games and the chosen
champion registered for the deck list is
Fiora victorious. It's the the four
energy one. If it gets plus one, it gets
all these different abilities. Really
easy to buff up and make mighty. Makes
triggering your legend easier. Really
powerful unit. Shield ganking deflect.
Seen it in actually a few different
decks over the weekend. This is Fiora
worthy. So, this one is when a unit
becomes mighty, you may recycle and
order power to ready it. And this is
kind of a weird one. I mean, I can't
think of that many situations where it
would come up, but Charmer actually
pointed out to me that going on the on
the going second, just having a reliable
play might actually be a reason to have
this. And it is quite good with the
sunken temple as you can ready in with
your mighty units and try and draw some
extra cards. So, I kind of like that.
So, we'll move on to our next thing
here. But that's something interesting
we might keep in our mind cuz they're
kind of in a similar spot as we've seen
cuz the theme of this game really in
this matchup is you're trying to fight a
lot of removal and protect your units
long enough to go for a win. Victor
eventually is going to overwhelm you,
right? Too many units, easy at getting
points and getting on board. You can't
really contest big battlefields with a
lot of units on them easily and uh once
you start falling behind because of the
removal, you're probably going to stay
behind. So, call the week again, one of
the best spells against these decks
because uh it just kind of kills the
unit, no questions asked. And again, not
a lot of small units for Fiora to
sacrifice. We'll play the clip out here
and see the situation where again with
Singularity, it felt like it was going
to seal the game. This call feels like
it's going to end the game, but
thankfully Fiora has two wins available
and another repost on a much smaller
spell this time. Takes that one out. So,
we'll go to our next clip here because
uh we now see something cuz this is the
other thing Fior can do, right? If you
can't repost the spells, you can maybe
take them away. Sabotage, a very good
card at doing that. If I'm the Fior
player in this spot, I'm going to be
honest with you. I think the game is
over. I have four points. My opponent
has six and I sabotage and I see this
hand. Not only do I see an Imperial
Decree, which feels pretty bad, and I'm
going to have to take you, but I see two
copies of Thousand Tail Watcher, and
Sabotage does not interact with units.
And just looking at the board that's
built out now, the Vanguard Army, oh, by
the way, is also going to make some
extra recruits later. I don't think at
this point deficit, I can win this game
because Thousand Tail Watcher is going
to make it. So, I basically get my units
removed without being a spell that I can
actually take away. But let's go on down
to our last thing because this went all
the way to the end of Regulation. We're
in extra turns and this is where the
magic happens. So you can see our fur
play is deep in thought and I just want
to point something out. So a set has
been played. That unit gets above. Set
at base is a four might unit. Fiora
cares about making units mighty. He
doesn't care about units being mighty
like naturally necessarily. It wants to
make them mighty. And set gets a buff
when you play him or when you conquer.
So going from four to five automatically
when you play a set makes it mighty. Why
does that matter? You can remove the
buff from set to make him bigger. Get
him plus four. That's really good. But
it's even better than that. Fiora
worthy. So the champion we changed for
this final game from our sideboard is
able to ready set because he has now
become mighty. Let's play the clip and
go out cuz this sequence is incredible.
So this unit by the way, which only
lived because of this death grip, there
was another unit over here threatening
to win, but instead the death grip makes
this unit bigger. Saves the fur. We need
to ready our set and makes it so that
Victor cannot win this turn. So we get a
whole point to seven. But now the plan
is how do we conquer 18 might worth the
battlefield. Well, first of all, Fiora
is going to get death grip again. That's
going to add a bunch of might to this
set. That also makes the Doran's blade
fall off of the Fior. So now we can
re-equip it. That's going to move in as
well. And the math just keeps
mouththing. Death Grip draws a card.
What else do we have? Doing the math.
Equipping the blade. 18 might remember
on this battlefield set. I'm not going
to count it for you, but it's a lot. But
it's still a lot more to chai and climb.
In fact, I will count it because now I
just said it and I want to do it. 9 13
plus 2 15 needs a bit more punch first
for 20 might after the set ready, which
was only possible because of Fiora
that's now chilling in the graveyard.
Fiora celebrates away. Incredible play.
And as we heard from the interview, that
punch first that sealed this game, kept
Fior intention for top eight at X and1
was drawn off of the death grip. I need
a bit of a break and I think you all do.
So let's hear interview from Miss Jim
Chim. That game was incredible.
Welcome to the Riftbound Regional
qualifiers here in Atlanta, Georgia. I
am here with T the twotime best of
winner on Garen and you are here back in
Atlanta going for a third possibly. Who
are you playing today?
>> So this weekend I am playing Master Yi.
I I have strayed from my Garen ways, but
not because I dislike Garen, just
because I wanted to try something new.
>> Yeah, you've you've you've laid the
groundwork. You've shown that you can be
victorious on Garen two times. So, we're
playing that Master Yi. What is your
score right now? We haven't wrapped up
day one, but I am curious, how are you
performing today?
>> Sure. Uh, right now I am 6-1. Started
off 6 and0. I just lost round seven to
an Aurelia.
Kind of hard matchup and uh not the best
draws, but one round to go. Try to get
into day two at 7-1.
>> Absolutely. And that will take you over
to day two. Now, I do want to ask you,
was that match against that Ireelia
pretty close or was it a hard stomp?
>> It It was It was a hard stomp. I lost
O2. I missed out on my two drop in game
two on turn one and then game one.
Nothing went right. I drew all the cards
that I want to sideboard out.
>> Absolutely. You know, sometimes that
just happens in the worlds of TCGs. But
I do want to ask you, are there any
legends that you know that you will just
absolutely outperform uh going into day
two? Anybody that you really want to go
up against?
>> I really like playing against Victor. I
think that matchup is good. I haven't
found one yet. Surprisingly, I've played
three Dravens this weekend so far, and
I've beaten all of them, so maybe hand
me another Draven.
>> Absolutely. And you know, uh there's a
lot of Draven hate going around because
there's a lot of Dravens. So, I love to
hear that you have been victorious
against these Dravens. So, we're
obviously gunning for that best of for
day two. And I kind of want to ask, are
you looking to avoid anyone for the next
uh tomorrow?
>> I guess I don't want to play Aurelia
again. Uh there's nothing really in
particular that I don't want to play
against. Ari makes you think a lot, so
I'd like to dodge Ari to save my brain
power. But other than that, just take
whatever comes at me and handle it as we
go.
>> All right. And finally, I want to ask
you your predictions here. Do you think
that you can rise to the top? Where do
you think you'll place?
>> My goal this weekend, the reason that I
kind of abandoned Garen was that I
wanted to top 64 so that I could pick up
my regionals invite. So, I'd be happy
with a top 64, but I'll always be happy
with a top eight and a best of.
>> Absolutely. Well, thank you so much, T.
We are wishing you the bestest of luck
with your Master Y endeavors, and we're
going to send it back to broadcast.
>> So, we've been talking about this deck a
lot, but I actually realized we've never
really looked at it a bit closer. And in
fact, I don't ever explained what the
combo is. And if you want to get
aggressive in rift round while maybe
combo killing your opponents in some of
your games, you should look at this very
explosive deck for a very special
player. So let's swap Lucian on the
screen here. This is not just any old
Lucian list. This is the Lucian list of
the XN1 player after day one. The winner
of RQ Las Vegas. That's right, Sam D.
Sherman away from mid-range Draven,
which he had so much success with in
Vegas. And on to Lucian and still
looking very, very good despite playing
a legend that is maybe not as powerful
as Draven. And given that mid-range
Draven is the most represented deck in
the field. Kind of surprised to see Sam
shift away, but very excited to see his
take on this deck. So, we should start
with the obvious stuff. This is a combo
deck. Well, what's the combo? And the
first thing you look at is Trinity
Force. Now, somewhat innocuous looking
piece of equipment. Master's been using
this as well, but uh this one says when
I hold, score one point. Gives you plus
two might cost four. Seems like a pretty
reasonable thing. So, you know what?
Like, let's say you're Master E. You put
this on a power, you chill on your
battlefield, you get a bit of extra
might thanks to your legend. You know,
that feels good. But in Lucian, I don't
really know what it does until you look
at the other side, which is Skyfall of
Skyfall of Orion. I always mess this one
up. It's fine. Everyone else has their
own way to pronounce it. This one is
also plus two might cost three. Little
more expensive of an equip cost, which
can be somewhat prohibitive. And Lucian
in general, a deck that really chugs
through its runes and recycles them in
order to get maximum value. But this
little bit of text is my hold effects
are also conquer effects. and vice
versa. So that means when you have both
of these pieces of equipment on at the
same time, the Trinity Force and the
Skyfall whenever you conquer, you get
one point for conquering normally and
one point for holding with the Trinity
Force because the Skyfall is also giving
you that hold effect as a conquer
effect. It sees both. That means
whenever Lucian moves in, you get two
points for conquering. That's already
pretty good. If we actually go up a
little bit and look at Lucian himself,
both the chosen champion and a champion
that these decks play the full three
copies of throughout their deck. Three
energy, three might, doesn't cost any
power, has weapon master, so it means
you can equip things like Trinity Force
and Skyfall a little bit easier. The
first time I conquer each turn, ready
me. So, this already feels like we're
getting somewhere nice, right? And in
fact, Windsor Swap Helic, a nice little
bit of tech here that Sam is running in
the battlefield to mean that Lucian can
move in equipped with both pieces of the
combo. go to the helic ready and then go
over again if he wants to try and get a
few more points which is a way to close
out games pretty rapidly because
remember when you assemble the combo
you're not scoring one point at a time
you're scoring two and Rift Burn is a
game where you generally want to score
in increments of two so Lucian is a deck
that can get four points very very
quickly but have a look at some of the
other things that are happening in this
deck cuz it's not just that there's also
some just good quality cards in here as
well in these domains punch first a card
that we've just seen in a ton of
different decks this is just all this
might for a bunch of value plus five
night. Yes, it costs two power, but
again, big orange rune split here. It's
eight orange runes total, eight body
runes there for Sam, only to four fury.
So, clearly caring a lot about the power
cost in this deck. Kaisa survivor, a
card that really helped Sam win in RQ
Vegas in Draven. Still good here in
Fury, even in illusion. Four energy, no
power, four might accelerate when I
conquer, draw one. So, in case scoring
two points with the combo wasn't good
enough and having an accelerated unit
that has a very good rate wasn't good
enough, you can also draw cards when you
move in and dig for your combo pieces,
which is a nice little fun thing,
especially with the candle sanctum for a
bit of extra filtering again in games
where you're really trying to find the
combo pieces. But I think the thing that
really ties the room together for me is
once again the signature spell of this
deck, Relentless Pursuit. And this is
where the combo goes from. I'm doing
cute things and scoring two points a
turn. I am doing really nasty things.
So, we'll read Reliance Pursuit first.
Two energy, one power. It's an action,
so you can do it in showdowns on your
opponent's turn sometimes, which does
genuinely come up in this deck. Move a
friendly unit. Okay, already pretty
good. You may attach an equipment with
the same controller to it. Okay, that's
discounting your equip cost as well.
Notably, a recent somewhat recent rules
change meant that Relentless Pursuit
does not have to attach an equipment in
order to be used. That was one of the
limitations of this card earlier, but
now you can just do all of the pieces
that you can. You don't have to do all
of them in order to actually use the
card. And there's more text on this
card. There's quite a lot. The last bit
is so after you've moved a unit and put
a piece of equipment on it if you want.
Uh the unit also gains when I conquer
you may move move me to my base. So can
get a little confusing sometimes, but if
you go back to Lucian, have a look
again. When I conquer ready me, let's
say you play relentless pursuit on
Lucian, you move it over, you attach
your two combo pieces, you go to a
battlefield, Lucian is going to uh
actually get moved naturally. But even
if Lucian was exhausted, Lucian himself
is going to ready when he conquers. So
let's say Lucian moves to a battlefield,
conquers it, gets two points again
because of the combo. And now says,
"Well, go back." So Lucian's going to go
back. He's ready because he's been
moved. Either awaken or he's going to
reready thanks to his text from when
conquering ready me and go back to base.
And you've already scored two points.
Well, Lucian's going to move over and
score two more points on the other
battlefield assuming it's open. And with
all these ways to win in combats, things
like the punch first that we already
highlighted. Lucian is very good at
getting points quickly. And in
Riftbound, six points is really the
markup you want to look at because when
you get to six, you're kind of
threatening your opponent saying, "You
know what? I can win at any point if I
get a double score, whether it's a hold
and a conquer or if I get a double
conquer." Lucian is, I think, the only
deck in the format that is so
threatening at four points. When you get
to four on Lucian, you have to already
think, okay, if they have the combo,
they finally realize pursuit, I can lose
the game any moment. And there are even
reports of Lucian winning from zero
points. This deck fun, fast, explosive,
so fun. You should definitely give it a
try cuz as far as combo decks go in
Riftbound, this is one that people have
been playing and succeeding with.
We're here live at the RQ Atlanta and I
am joined by I can't believe I found
you, Sam D. Sherman, the champion of the
regional qualifier in Las Vegas just a
few months ago. And not only that,
you're doing pretty well today, but
you're playing Draven, of course, right?
>> Uh, no way. I already have a best of
Draven. I don't need another one. This
time, I'm going for Lucian. Lucian. And
I think I heard through the grapevine
that this round, as we conclude round
seven here, not only are you still
undefeated, but you had to go against
another Lucian, basically knocking out
your best of competition right now.
>> Yeah, I was pretty happy to get that
pairing. No, it's incredible. So, I want
to kind of check base. I want to check
in on you. Okay. You know, we haven't
seen you since Vegas. I mean, of course
we have, but you won on what was
debatably the best deck in the room,
right? Changes were made. You've now
adapted and swapped over to Lucian. Can
you really explain to me why Lucian? Cuz
I don't know about you, but I was
looking at that legend as soon as I saw
the band list because I was like, well,
your worst matchup got hit pretty hard.
>> Uh, yeah. I can't say I knew anything
about Lucian's matchup spread before,
but um, yeah. So, for this tournament, I
was really just looking for a metal card
deck. Um, and I tried a bunch of
different things. Uh, I played a bunch
of Fiora. It felt pretty miserable
playing against Draven with that deck.
And, um, I I thought Draven was one of
the best decks. I didn't want to have
that bad of a matchup. Um, Lucian was
kind of the last metal card deck that
was on my list to try and um, it's not
only is it fun to play and
just yeah, a really cool deck that, you
know, vibes with me, which is kind of
what I was hoping for, but I also think
it's actually just a really good deck.
And um I was telling somebody earlier
that uh I I think somehow if the metal
card thing didn't exist, but I somehow
played all the same decks during
testing, I I I might bring Lucian
anyway. So I'm yeah, I'm really happy to
have landed on a deck like this. I think
the coolest thing about that list is
that you can still play it cuz your
legend like just gives you more might,
you know, the assault on the equipment.
you're still playing a unique game plan,
but just the ability to have in your
pocket in that deck the sort of Skyfall
Trinity Force like combo. It can just
steal wins and I just think it's so
powerful. So, my next question as I
think obviously we're already going to
see you tomorrow and I'm excited to
hopefully have you on a feature match
hopefully at some point, but I want to
see and ask you, what are you kind of
prepping instead for the the Ireelia
matchup? That's obviously like the new
deck that a lot more people are playing
and a lot of people are kind of taking
their own little twist playing different
cards inside of it, but Lucian was
already kind of struggling a little bit
against Draven and you're still playing
against not only now another Chaos deck,
but with Calm on top of it.
>> Yeah. Uh I I think Draven and Ireelia
are the two toughest matchups that I
have identified. I don't think I'm that
behind in those matchups, but I'd rather
not play them. Um with Ireelia, I the
card I'm worried about the most is
Adaptatron. Um, I think most of my plan
is win game one and then hopefully one
of the two sideboard games they won't
screw me over with Adaptatron and uh
yeah. No, that makes a lot of sense.
Well, Sam, you're doing an incredible
job so far in this tournament and of
course we're already going to see you
for day two. So, I hope to maybe also
see you in top eight once again. We're
going to send it back.
I'm going to take offense to that
interview just a little bit.
>> Yeah. You're not letting it go.
>> No. He said that he was looking for
another best of deck because that was
the Vegas winner. So, he won with
Draven.
>> Yeah. And he said specifically Fiora
felt what was it? Awful.
>> Awful. Horrible. I some negative
adjective and it hurt my heart. But he
did say he landed on Lucian and he
thinks that it's a pretty good deck. Uh
and I agree. So I'll give him a little
bit of grace there. Just a little bit of
grace.
>> Lucian is very fun. Uh we were talking
yesterday because we did get to see a
Lucian game yesterday where uh there's a
lot of moving around on the board. You
can do that skyfall, that Trinity Force
combination combo.
>> Yes. And you can uh go in and score
multiple points. But also, we also saw
that the Lucian can bring out an Oxon.
So, if you're going against
>> We highlighted that a lot. Yes.
>> Yes. Oxan was like a star player
yesterday. Loved it.
>> Uh we're getting ready for our next
future match. But before that, let's
catch up on the standings and see what's
going on uh in the race for undefeated
and top eight. We're expecting some X1's
to bubble in. Mathematically, yeah, we
still have a couple more rounds to play.
We we might only get like one or two XOs
in the top eight at this point
>> and that's going to be so much fun. A
good point out here is Prismaticism
>> is still 9 and0 ranking number four
right now. I also want to call out
Frosty delicious. Love those.
>> 9-0 on the Kai'Sa. I actually had to
chat with Kaisa or Frosty a little bit
um before the start of the day and he
was very excited. I'm a Kaisen
enthusiast. Frosty was pretty happy. I'm
excited to see what uh their deck list
looks like, but Boulevard losing a game
or losing a series down to eight and one
now. Again, can still uh bubble into the
top eight, but um we're seeing it's
getting tight at the top there.
>> Absolutely. Another call out here is our
Colin. He has uh fallen to that 8-1. So,
that is our set player who was
undefeated before that first round, but
uh good to see he's still, you know, up
a little bit.
>> We got Staran who was on a feature match
yesterday. uh playing the um Master Ye,
which was really fun. So, a lot of cool
uh returning names here.
>> Hey, ye sitting down there at number 29.
Okay, we're rooting for you. Make Fiora
proud.
>> I imagine again, we we didn't know how
the other Fiora match went, but there's
a chance that Eve even just got the
metal the best of metal card from that
last performance on future match. Pretty
cool.
>> Absolutely. But let's go ahead and get
into our next matchup. The deck list is
going to be first for Kai'Sa. You've
been talking about Kai'Sa so much today.
Break this down for me. What are some
big call outs? What do you see that's
normal? What is different?
>> Well, right off the bat, I'm actually
surprised with the unit spread here.
Plundering Porro is pretty normal.
Watchful Sentry is pretty normal.
Lecturing Yortles uh sometimes contested
with Kais like do you need it, do you
not? Um and then Knox is hopeful has
kind of found its way back into LAX. But
for caster, let's look at Forecaster. I
did not expect this. It's a two energy,
two might. Your mechs have vision. So,
it gets vision and also your Ferris
4runner and then theoretically the mechs
that Ferris forunner would make get it.
Um, but like vision's not really that
powerful of an effect when I think about
it enough to have like another two might
in there. Um, but hey, it's cool. I'm
excited to see what they do with it. Um,
they're also on kind of a more mid-range
deck. No Kai'Sa in sight uh in the main
deck. They they have the one obviously
in the chosen legend spot, but no other
ones in the main deck. Instead, they
have the two Dariuses. Hits a little
harder, helps you control the board a
little more as a defense for slightly
more. Um but then it's still kind of a
fast deck with a 30,000 tales and then
all of the snipe spells, hex tech, ray,
falling star. Um oh, I'm I'm noticing no
singularity. Am I blind? Yeah, no
singularity main deck. Wow. This is a
very low to the ground unit heavy combat
focused Kai'Sa build.
>> Absolutely. Now I will say that yeah
that Darius and that falling star is
something that we usually see especially
paired up with that cleave. But let's
get into the opponent. Y'all are going
to love this. It's Kai'Sa versus Draven.
>> Oh, there's the Kais. We found the
>> You found the Kais.
>> Yep, there it is. Uh Draven playing a
mid-range style. They got the Kises.
They got the Dariuses. These are the two
that people have adapted towards. Um,
you're basically still playing what the
the old mid-range Draven was, just with
the ban list on top of it. Um, instead
you have the Showbo Draven as your
chosen champion. Uh, and you can go to
purple Draven in in certain matchups as
well. Um, but the other adaptation here
is the Rexi three red Rexi. I love this
unit in Draven cuz if you play a unit
from anywhere other than your hand, it
come uh has the ability to come in
accelerated. Notably, your Draven
Showboat from the champion zone is not
being played from your hand. So you can
accelerate your Draven Showbo once
you're at like five or six points.
That's like a nine accelerated unit.
That is terrifying. And the three main
deck rebukes. I've heard a lot of D uh
players talk about this of like, okay,
uh are you on two or you on three?
Nobody's on one. If you're on one,
you're probably a little behind. Um but
the question is like how many do you
need? Three feels pretty good against a
lot of the spread.
>> Absolutely. This looks like a really
good matchup that we're about to witness
with all of the bands. Let's see if
Draven can hold it down in our next game
for the regional qualifier. Let's look
at this win rate down here. Kaisa versus
Draven. 41% 40 at Atlanta. But do not
count it out because we just saw that
Victor versus Fiora and it was highly
Victor favored. But now
>> maybe Kaisa can pull it out.
>> And I will say I think stats like this
can sometimes get inflated. Uh
specifically with Dravens cuz a lot of
Draven players might take offense to
this. I think Draven's an easier deck to
execute.
>> I've heard this
>> across the board. I think that if you
take uh you know, players that are
playing more towards the floor versus
the ceiling, Draven can have a
relatively consistent win rate, whereas
Kai'Sa, I think it's one of the decks.
It's also forgiving. Don't don't get me
wrong. I think Kai'Sa is also a very
forgiving deck, but slightly less so
than the Draven. Uh and I think that the
skill expression scales a little more
towards that ceiling. I think that the
Kai'Sa against the spread right now, if
you have a really good Kai'Sa player, it
can have a lot of success. The concern I
have is this is a unit heavy combat
focused Kaiso list as opposed to a
spellheavy snipe Kaiso list. I didn't
see piercing lights. I didn't see
singularities. So you're going to have
to use your units much more which
Draven's usually happy about.
>> Absolutely. Oh my goodness. But we're
going ahead and we're seeing what cards
do we want to mulligan. Do want to point
out this man's got the signature Kai'Sa.
He's for real with it. I love to see it.
Um, I always love seeing like the uh the
top players. They've always got the cool
cards cuz they know they know they got
it wiz.
>> And you got to have it in the the really
thick plastic case.
>> Oh, you don't want nothing.
>> You're going to be exhausting it a lot.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Hands are sweaty. Uh, so
>> spaghetti.
>> Mom spaghetti. All right, so we've got
Zan Warren for uh Draven and we've got
the Boydgate. Very on theme for Kai'Sa.
We're getting started here. We see a
fallen star. We see a lecturing Yortle
uh in the hands of Frosty, but we're
going to go ahead and uh channel those
three runes and start with the lecturing
Yortle.
>> Ideal for Kai'Sa here. Frosty has a
really solid three energy turn one and
Cara did not play anything turn one. So,
no two drop and a Nox is hopeful. This
is this is where the bandless really is
felt cuz otherwise you'd just play
probably your your Draven uh at this
spot. Maybe not against Kai'Sa actually
cuz you can snipe it. But still like
it's uh this is a really good solid
start for the Kaisa player and the
Dravens falling slightly behind in the
first two turns. Didn't have the ideal
ramp.
>> Absolutely. So the lecturing Yortle on
the side of Frosty is going to go ahead
go in score that point and now we're
bringing in the Kai'Sa with three runes
exhausted and we're going to pass our
turn over.
>> Is there a hex tech ray in Frosty's
hand? That's what Cara needs to be
thinking about here because the void
gate will increase the damage of all
spells by one. So that actually will do
four. So Cara says nope. It's really
tempting to just say no, go for the
yortal cuz you win the combat and draw a
card. Um you get to cycle a card with
zon anyway. Uh discarding rebuke. Um but
it's just scary going into void gate
when there's one rune up on Kaisa's
side.
>> So we're exhausting all of our runes
here and the ferris forerunner. Ferris
>> comes in.
>> Again, I can't do the R thing, but I I I
like it when players
>> It's a tough one. Uh, but yes, it comes
into play here into the base, and we're
going to pass our turn. We're readying
the lecturing Yortle, and we're going to
see what Frosty has in store for us.
>> Now, notably, the um Knoxville can just
stat-wise defend against the Kai'Sa. So,
Frosty will need something in addition
to actually clear that if you want to
get the Kai'Sa to conquer and get the
draw power. I can't quite
>> Is that a Darius that we just drew?
Stupify. If it stupify Darius, that's
pretty good. You won't get the draw off
the Kai'Sa cuz if you try and send her
in with the Noxis hopeful, then the
Noxal is just going to kill her.
Actually,
>> could be a Bellow's breath,
>> I guess. Yeah, if you stupify, then you
could do it.
>> It's a darker card. Uh there's the
stupify with one rune exhausted. And
we're going to draw and we're moving in
that Kai'Sa. Going to trade for the Nox
Hopeful. And yes, Kai'Sa is going to go
ahead and get that conquer point.
Sometimes you just talk yourself in a
circle and you forget the obvious lines
like oh yeah the supify also just lowers
the might by one. I always think of it
as like oh draw a card
>> but it does help you conquer uh and then
you get a additional draft Kaiso. We get
a trigger on warrant so this is a lot of
cards Frosty seen in their deck right
now and they're good cards
>> and we're going to respond with our own
ferris forrunner.
Yeah, there we go. Uh and we're going to
play that straight into the zon warren
as well. So, we've got uh quite a bit of
cards in hand and we're passing our turn
over to Cara. And I did see that we have
a hard bargain in hand. So, whenever we
get into the spell territory that we
don't really like, that can be used to
counter. And it's moments like this that
Kira, unless there's another rebuke in
hand, might be regretting that choice on
the Zon Warren because we we showed
earlier yesterday on the stream, but if
you're if you didn't get a catch it, the
two most played cards or most
represented cards in deck lists are
number one Rebuke, number two Ferris
4runner. And the reason is Ferris
4runner arguably the statu uh wise most
efficient unit in the game. And then
rebuke just deals with a Ferris 4runner
like you just bounce it back to hand
rather than clearing it. You could uh
deny the hold potentially from frosty if
that was available. But now Cara instead
will just go over to the void gate and
establish more.
>> All right, so that Ferris 4ERunner is
going to go into the void gate. Go ahead
and score that point, but we're bringing
out a second one with six runes
exhausted and we're passing our turn
over to Frosty. He's going to ready
those units and uh draw his turn,
channel the two runes, and we're going
to see what he he plans to do here.
Well, so far and it's it's a little too
early to tell cuz we're only at four
points. Frosty's halfway there, but so
far it has not seemed like Frosty's had
that much difficulty in these combat
scenarios. This kind of like unit
heavier Kai'Sa list has been scoring. It
hasn't been given Draven any draws. Like
we haven't seen the Draven Glorious
Executioner draw once. Um, which is kind
of the the always the fear when you're
against this deck. It's like, oh,
they're just going to get resources by
going into combat. And is this a second?
Okay, we have four fairest runners on
the board.
>> Four four runners on the board.
Everybody has two at this current point,
but uh what Frosty has done is he has
played his second one to the battlefield
where the first one is currently
occupied. We're then going to pass turn
here and uh Kira is going to ready those
units, ready those runes, and we're
going to draw for turn. No way we get
another one. I don't remember how many
they were playing in there. Oh,
>> I see. I say it.
>> Okay, so if we have something along the
lines of like Rebuke, I I didn't see if
Draven was playing the cleave. I I
clocked that Kai'Sa had two. I didn't
pay attention if Draven had two. Um but
like Rebuke Cleave could be a really
clean way to clear this. Rebuke plus the
spinning axe, which I don't currently
see in hand.
>> Uh I do believe he has one if I remember
correctly, but we'll we'll see.
>> It's tough to see. They're all shiny
cards at that angle.
>> It's a little tough. I try to give y'all
the info when I see it. I do think he's
got a cara in hand.
>> Yeah. And another fairest 4runner. We
could
>> He does have a third one. That is
>> Do it. Crazy.
>> Is that a ride the wind as well?
>> Ride the wind. Hard bargain. Kai'Sa
Ferris 4Erunner.
>> How funny would it be if we just play
another Ferris 4Runner?
>> I can't wait till we have all the mech
tokens on the board. That's going to be
really fun to keep track of. This is my
toxic trade is I almost always do the
funny play as opposed to the correct
play just cuz I want to see what
happens. But another funny play would be
write the wind the ferris 4runner on
void gate in as you're attacking with
the one in base. So that way four ferris
4runners four fourrunners will die and
then eight mech tokens will spawn at the
same time.
>> That's also funny.
>> That would be a fun one. I think that
would be super fun. It looks like we're
going to go a Oh, JK. Would we have
enough for the No, we wouldn't have
enough for the third Ferris 4Runner on
Carrick cuz you you'd be at five runes
left at that point.
>> We are going to exhaust
>> the six.
>> It's happening.
>> Again, this is also quite funny. I think
all of the outcomes were funny. This is
arguably the funniest.
>> Yes, it
>> hasn't been played yet. There it is.
>> There it is. There it is. So, we're
going to recycle that one just to make
sure we pay that power cost. And it goes
in exhausted. And we're going to see
what we're going to do.
>> Um, yeah. Again, just a reminder, this
is the most represented card at the
event.
>> 500 decks.
>> I see why. Lord have mercy. Uh, so
Frosty's going to go ahead and channel
the runes, ready his units, draw for
turn.
>> Play another one, Frosty. Come on. do it
for the people.
>> Let's put no other units on the board
except for those.
>> We are only allowed to play Ferris
4Runner.
>> Yes.
>> And in fact,
>> send in the Is he really doing that?
There's no way. There's no way. That's
six runners.
>> Six. He recycled one and we're getting
all
>> it ship four runners onto the board.
Cara's like, "What the freaky, bro?"
>> It ain't the League of Draven. It's the
League of Ferris 4Runner. All six are on
the board at one time.
>> I see your 4ERunner. I raise you a
4Runner. Well, I see your 4Erunner
>> and I raise you a 4Runner.
>> This game is so funny, man. I love
Brriftbound. The best part is Cara has
the rebuke. So, we could rebuke one and
force a seventh Ferris 4Runner placement
this game.
>> This is hilarious.
What do you do? We It's a game of
chicken right now.
>> Yes, it is. Um, and we're about to see
we're about to see how do you want to
tackle
>> all of this might on the board cuz like
we said a six might unit. Yes. But it
spawns
another six.
>> We could have what is it 12? Yeah, 12
mech tokens on the field. Do they have
enough in the building?
>> Are there enough mech tokens in the
building?
>> Have we printed enough yet? Yeah.
>> Yeah. No. Like
>> for this one match?
>> This is crazy. Um,
>> and imagine that you get the uh
forecaster out as Frosty and suddenly
you get six vision procs.
>> Oh my goodness. Oh my god.
>> And then you have a Karma. I mean, that
doesn't make sense, but I get a lot of
buffs. I'm still on last game. Okay,
we're going to
>> All right, we're moving in. We're going
to go ahead and start this showdown. I
think we're just sacrificing so we can
get those mech tokens onto the board.
>> Yeah, it's getting a little ridiculous.
Let's simplify the board. And it looks
like Frosty is going to allow that to go
through. He wants his mech tokens as
well. But we're going to go ahead and
bring in the Darius.
>> Yep. Notably mech tokens do not count as
playing a card. So Darius is not ready
yet. You still need to play another one.
And we're going to have the rebuke.
>> There's the rebuke. Back to hand. Kind
of costly. You got to exhaust those
runes. And you got to recycle another
one to get that forerunner on the board.
But it does make the might over here on
ZH a little bit more obtainable as we
move in that Darius.
>> It's seven attacking on Darius cuz he's
a five might, but when you play your
second card in a turn, he readies and
gets plus two might. So that's seven
attacking on six.
>> All right, so we are going to exhaust
one and uh exhaust our legend to play
the hex tech ray.
>> Yep. Of course, the Kai'Sa Daughter of
the Void Legend says you can uh exhaust
the legend to add a power cost that can
only be used on a spell activation. So,
that'll pay for the recycle class of Hex
Ray. Uh everything will just crash.
>> Everything will crash and two of those
mech tokens will be played to Frosty's
base. So, he does have four now because
two Ferris four runners have died. Um
so, we've got the score of five to four
right now. Uh we have two of the
forerunners up on the void gate for
Cara. And uh I'm I'm curious to see like
what do you do now with your uh
>> send the mech in.
>> Yeah, with the
>> send all four mech in.
>> They'll trade.
>> And that's one option. Then you can try
and establish the board. But I think
that Cara
>> Oh, the falling star. Want to take care
of those mech tokens that Cara has.
We've seen a lot of trading here. We've
seen a lot of matching with the you you
spawn a ferris 4runner. I spawn affairs
forerunner. I get the two mech tokens.
You get the two mech token. Let's go
ahead and stop that. Let's get rid of it
and let's move everything, everything we
have, everything we own to the zon.
>> That was awesome.
>> He just says, "Nope. I'm not going to
interact with the Ferris 4unners. I know
that you're going to get all these
tokens. Bet. You got to come into me."
And now that is what 12 16 18 might on
that Zon Warren.
>> Goodness gracious. And we're spreading
them out just for the clarity of it all
to see what might is where.
>> Oh, this this is my favorite match. Oh
yeah, there of course. Yeah, I forgot
about the Rebuke Ferris Runner. This is
the best game by far that we've had uh
so far in Atlanta and we've had some
really good games. I just want it to so
we see all of the mech tokens. I just
want there to be so many mechs off.
>> We we are two away from the maximum
potential because of that uh falling
star.
>> Yes. So, we're going to go ahead and
pass our turn over to Cara. Going to
ready those runes.
And what do we what is what how
>> why I think why is the better question.
>> Yeah. I I I just don't even know how to,
you know, when something gets so
difficult and you look at it and you're
like, "Oh, like how do I even approach
this hill, approach this battle?" Well,
we're going to exhaust five runes,
recycle one, so that we can bring in
this Draven. Like you said, his might is
increased by his points. So, he is
sitting there at eight. And we're also
going to bring in a overzealous fan.
>> Interesting that we put the overzealous
fan, but did not pull back any Ferris
4unners right now. So Cara is still
maintaining the hold but is down on the
clock. So the I I reference the clock
when I talk about Riftbound a lot of
like if you are ahead on points you are
winning the clock. That means whoever is
behind is in the pressure seat. They
need to find a way to come back. A lot
of decks are comfortable being behind.
Aurora decks or decks um even sometimes
Draven decks like they have big
comebacks. But this is a pretty
significant clock cuz Kira can't win on
his next turn. Frosty can. Frosty can
win on this turn if you get the right
combination of cards. He's going to
start with the supery. So, I'm imagining
not, but we'll see.
>> All righty. I'm not sure like can he
accelerate anything so that the
overzealous fan does defend or something
cuz yeah, I'm also curious why he played
that to the battlefield, but we're
exhausting too. And we're going to
stupify twice that Draven that went down
>> went up to that might
>> and there's the falling star.
>> Nice. The Falling Star is going to clear
the board. Is going to be the good game
for Frosty taking the first game.
>> Yeah, I uh Frosty again not having the
singularity in the main deck, but
Falling Star also does the six damage.
So, you double stupify to lower the
Draven from eight to six. Falling Star
and Cara says, "Yeah, I don't have the
gas. I I I cannot retake that
Battlefield Frosty was inevitably going
to hold for the eighth point." So, you
see the top players do this a lot. They
say if I don't have a line to win, let's
just go to the next game. Let's not
waste time. Play the clock as a resource
as well. So that way you have more time
to think on later, more impactful games
that actually have a chance of winning.
But I just want to go back and just say
that we had six Ferris 4unners on the
field
>> in a streamed regional match in Atlanta.
>> That was very hilarious. I'm not I'm not
going to lie to you. I I love to see it.
But we're getting into game two of this
round 10, day two, and we've got the
Candle Lit Sanctum for Frosty and the
Arena's Greatest for Cara. Arena's
Greatest, a really solid card. Um,
Draven's playing this one, it it when
you're going first, you just get to that
win faster, but also just pairs really
well with Draven Showboat because it
gets bigger also earlier in the game. So
by that time you play him, even if you
just play him on ramp, um you're
probably going to be at like a a five
might, six might by that point. Uh and
also has a ideal start with the uh
Pyora.
>> Absolutely. We're exhausting those two
runes, bringing in the Powora for Cara,
but we're going to respond uh from
Kai'Sa with the lecturing the portal.
>> And a reminder that Cara also went first
in game one, but did not have that turn
one play. So, this is already a better
spot to be in as we're going to go into
the candle lit Sanctum. When we conquer,
we can look at the top two cards of our
deck and either put them back in either
order or uh recycle. So, keep the ones
you want, get rid of the ones you don't.
>> I was not able to take a peek to see
what we're looking at here.
>> I saw one with a lot of color on it,
which typically I think is spinning a
Cara's going to keep both. So, happy
with them regardless of what they were.
All right, so we've got two points for
Cara and we're bringing out a Kai'Sa
with all runes exhausted. Now it's turn
for Frosty.
>> Let's see how we respond. We're going to
end up exhausting one, tapping our
legend, and stupifying the Pouty Porro.
>> So, notably, the deflect cost adds
itself to the cost of the spell that's
played. So, you can actually use the
Kai'Sa uh legend to dodge that. Kind of
a cool little mechanic shown there from
frosty. And it lowers the might by one
so yortle can go into the candle lit
sanctum. So we can actually trigger said
candle lit sanctum.
>> And then we're going to exhaust those
two after getting a point for the candle
lit. And we're going to bring in Nox's
hopeful who has a reduced uh cost
because of the card play.
>> Exactly. And still two runes up. Really
good spot for the Kai'Sa player to be
in. Also good spot for the Draven
because like I had mentioned with the uh
Arena's greatest, we actually kind of
have curve here to play the uh the
Draven Showboat and have it be decent
might if we want it. Obviously, there's
better things we could do, but there's
always the option for that. Either way,
Kaisa can go and conquer a third point
and then get a draw.
>> Yes. So, Kai'Sa is going into the uh the
arena's greatest real quick. And I think
they were just checking like, "Oh, what
was that car real quick?" Um but we're
going to go in. We're going to conquer.
Cara's going to get that point. And I
think we just drew a Ferris's 4Runner
and it's coming straight into play with
five exhausted and we're recycling the
six.
>> All right. Conquering or going to hold
here for another point for Frosty.
>> And uh the first of six Ferris four
runners is now on the field.
>> Yeah.
>> Yep. Yes. Are we going to see all six
again? I do not know. But as we're
drawing for turn, we pick up a hex tech
ray on the side of Frosty.
>> Now, do we have like a stupify? Oh, I
see a falling star. So, we could just
hit the ferris 4runner before it gets
onto the battlefield. Sometimes that
feels best, especially if you're not on
singularities cuz often times you're
like, "Oh, singularity deals with the
4Runner and then Falling Stark can deal
with the tokens." But I unless Frosty
sides into the singularities, then you
don't have that same type of like line
that that I typically think of with
Kai'Sa. Um, so you see on the bottom
right, Singularity, really good card,
but Frosty did not have it main decked.
Uh, so if it's going to be here, it's
from the sideboard.
>> I see. Well, in hand, we're going to uh
bring in the Kai'Sa chosen champion and
bring back that Noxis Hopeful and the
lecturing Yortle. Uh, I will say he has
or Cara has two Ferris 4ERunners in
hand. No way.
>> Yes, he does. So, that's going to be all
three there.
>> Um, also has I believe I saw his own hex
tech ray. Was I tripping? I I had the
third card.
>> Sometimes plays it, but very rarely.
>> I saw I think I'm thinking of Frosty's
Hex Tech Ray. I saw another card and I
just wanted to update y'all so y'all can
keep track if you want to.
>> Bargain. I've seen the colors that look
it it's really tough when it's like on
the screen kind of like what's what's
the color on the top one/tenth of the
card
>> kind of looks like two hard bargains
actually in the on the left side but
either way uh Cara is just going to use
the resources already on the field to
just continue to scale points and at
this point your showboat's already at
eight might again that arena's greatest
accelerates it even more.
>> Yes. And we're going to go ahead and
look at those top two cards. We're
thinking what do we want to do with
those? We're gonna
actually I think we Yeah.
>> Yeah. So when you recycle them back uh
you are supposed to shuffle them up. You
you're not allowed to put them if you
put cards uh recycle at the bottom of
the deck at the same time not like
sequentially one after the other like uh
let's say a VI uh you can like choose to
recycle any number from your discard but
you do them one at a time. Something
like this or like a stacked deck if you
put them back at the same time on
resolution you're supposed to shuffle
them up.
>> Got that. Understood. one of those like
little mechanics that I did not realize.
So, I played Ezreal wrong for
>> Well, we're going to move our Kaisa back
to base and the fairest 4Erunner is
coming out to play. So, six uh exhausted
one recycled and we're bringing out our
second one. One more in hand. I think
there the other card was a ride the
witch.
>> I think Frosty's jealous right now. He's
like, "Where's mine?" Yeah,
>> I want to join the Ferris 4runner party.
>> Yeah, we want to do this again. Do we
really? Do we really?
>> I think everybody at home would love to
see if we get six Ferris 4Runners two
duels in a row. Two games in a row.
That's crazy.
>> Look what's happening.
>> How many How
>> That's That's seven.
>> That's five.
>> I think it's a singular one.
>> I'm imagining a singular thousand tail.
>> Oh.
>> Oh,
>> I also was off on the count. You're
right. It was six. So, we're going to
use the Kai'Sa. And the singularity does
come in from the side. a very efficient
use of it because we also had the
falling star in hand. And again, this is
in in this matchup. That's why I think
singularity is such a good card. I was
surprised Frosty was not main decking
it, but it's the type of card that you
you want at some point. You want into
some matchups. So maybe Frosty just
saying it's not good into everything, so
I'm not going to play it main, but it'll
side into these cuz it's so good at the
Ferris 4runner, the Kai'Sa, the the the
Dariuses, like all these kind of
mid-range cards,
>> right? And uh you see why you can see
why uh firsthand as uh that got played
because we were able to take out one
half of the Ferris 4Runner. We do have
to go through these mechs yet again. Uh
but we're going to go ahead and exhaust
one and uh recycle the other to go ahead
and play the smokec screen.
>> Okay, so not the falling star. That
would have been an expensive recycle
cost. We're going to smoke screen the
ferris 4runner instead. Now, there's a
fun little interaction here because the
Kai'Sa is going to go in and we actually
send both.
>> The Nox is hopeful and the Kai'Sa.
>> It's down to two might and there's one
rune up on Draven. I'm wondering what
they're thinking that one rune could
represent to send both. Maybe they just
want to reinforce it. Either way, they
get to trigger the Kai'Sa, but they also
get to um use the candle at Sanctum
first. So, they can actually look at the
top two before they draw with the
Kai'Sa, see what they want. If they
don't want either, put them at the
bottom. Otherwise, you can choose which
one you want and then add that to the
hand essentially cuz Kaiso will draw
afterwards.
>> And that's exactly what is going to
happen. One was recycled, one was put
back on the top, and we're just making a
mental note here as we draw for the
Kai'Sa. Love how Frosty really pointed
that out. The the board state is very
clear here. The lecturing Yortle is
going to move in, go in exhausted, and
we're passing our turn over to Cara. So,
so one of the reasons that Kaisa player
might do this rather than getting the
guaranteed point to catch up, you're
going to give a free draw to Cara
because he has to send a mech token in
to get a point on the um arena's
greatest anyway. So, Frosty's playing a
slower game saying I'm not going to race
for points. I'm instead going to race
for resources. I'm going to try and
trade up. I have spells that will deal
with two threats at once. It's a one for
two trade. Things like Falling Star,
things like Singularity. The The way
that I lose this game is that if I give
my opponent too many resources to play
with. Um, and Cara currently has a lot
to play with in hand. Uh, but Frosty
doesn't want to give more as Cara makes
the first move.
>> The first move does go in and we're
going to respond with the Hex Tech Ray
to get rid of that mech token. He did
only send in two. So, let's see how we
want to play the rest of this showdown.
>> It's awkward. I mean, first off, the
Electra Nortal has tank anyway. It's the
only thing that the Singular Mech token
can kill. Um, you have things like
cleave. You have things like the
spinning axe that can try and get over
because you would ideally like to kill
this Kai'Sa as well.
>> Well, look at that. The cleave is going
to come out. We're going to exhaust that
one rune to cleave and we're going to
end up trading the Kai'Sa and the
lecturing Yortle. Nox's hopeful does
still stand, but look what we have. We
have two more mech tokens that we want
to go in for, and we're going to trade
one for the Noxis Hopeful and collect
that point.
>> Yeah. So Frosty again is in a unit heavy
Kai'Sa list. Maybe some of those came
out in the sideboarding process for the
singularities and and potentially other
spells. Um but a reminder that like a
lot of times you think of saving your
resources as the Kai'Sa. Instead, this
Kai'Sa player saying, "Nope, my units
are the resource to clear out these mech
tokens. The one hexac helps as well."
But now that falling star doesn't get
quite as much value depending on what
Cara plays next. Well, looking at it,
Cara is going to bring in that third and
final Ferris runner.
>> All right, Frosty's uh 0 for three on
the Ferris runners game two.
>> Let's see if uh he's able to get one
established here. Cara will not win in
one turn. You can hold for a point, you
can conquer a point. Actually, no. Now,
now they say that. Yes, he's at six.
Cara can win in a turn. That is pressure
for Frosty. You have to deal with at
least one of these two. Hex Tech Ray
will help. We are going to hex tech ray
get rid of that mech token.
>> All right, that theoretically slows the
clock here is on the Kais and the
Darius's so there's always the ability
to get in there fast. Also even like the
red Rex eye that's another accelerate
unit plus you can accelerate the uh
Draven. So
>> boom and there his own forerunner comes
out the six exhausted recycled one and
we are going forerrunner for 4Runner.
Yeah, and I think we already saw the
Kara in uh Kara had the Kai'Sa in hand.
Again, there's what uh one Darius has
already been played. So, there's eight
with three KISS, three Rex size, and two
Dariuses, depending on what came out in
the sideboard. Um you have to imagine
that there's something here. And there's
a Darius. Now, you just need to play one
more card to ready the Darius, and then
that is GG. Game two to Carol.
>> All right, let's see. We do have
resources available. There's the two.
We're going to do the overzealous fan.
Go in. Boot bop. Beat bop. Eight points.
Sakira taking game two. We're going to
game three.
>> Yeah, Frosty with one rune up. That's
not enough for Kaiser to stop a seven
might unit going in to an open
battlefield. Cara will bring us to game
three. And it's Treasure Horde versus
Arena's greatest on Frosty side. I love
Arena's greatest in Kai'Sa. I wanted to
see I didn't catch it during the uh the
deck um breakdown. Um, but uh I actually
play Marina's greatest on Kai'Sa as well
for when you're going first. And I had
other Kaisa players be like interesting.
Like what's the reason for it? The
reason for your deck's fast like you you
can just get in there control the field
with low cost spells early game control
midame with singularity and as long as
you just have like your little twoight
units, then you're just scoring points
and you can win fast. Uh I actually
really like this.
>> Absolutely. As we go through and see
what we're mulligating, I do see the
spinning axes for Draven. I see the
ride, the win, and oh, I wasn't able to
see that last card, but it looks like
we're ready to get started here. We're
going to go ahead and channel those
runes, and we're going to plop down that
uh
>> Watchful Sentry
card. It's And there I think that's one
of the glossy ones. The glossy ones are
tough. Yeah, because it's just darker in
general. And then also there's the a
tiny bit of glare there. So, watchful
entry really efficient uh two energy
cost unit. It is checked by the powder
pora. So, the danger of this is like
especially in this specific matchup.
Typically, you're like, "Oh, sweet. I
score a point off it and then I draw a
card when it dies." Well, Draven also
draws a card if it conquers or beats you
in combat, sorry, I should say. So,
Patty Porro already checks this. Let's
see if Frosty takes that into
consideration. No, it's just going to be
a Kai'Sa. So, we're just kind of saying,
"Yep, uh I score a point, then you'll
score a point. You'll kill my unit. will
both draw, but I will establish a Kai'Sa
on the field for the next turn.
>> All righty. So, we're going ahead and
drawing, and we're moving the Pouty
Porro in immediately. We're going to
kill that unit. We are going to draw and
uh like you said, Draven's going to draw
as well.
>> Mhm.
>> All right, we exhaust one and we're
playing stack deck. Everyone's favorite
card when going up against Draven. Yes.
Yes. Yes. Do you see what
>> it gives you? So many options.
>> Do you see what's in hand?
>> Uh, also your favorite card.
>> Affairs for
>> it. Sure was.
>> You're so much better at seeing these
than I am. I swear I'm like I just don't
my eyes don't recognize what's
>> I'm just like trying to make sure
everyone at home can see. So, you know
that what's in hand is such valuable
information cuz you can try and get the
logic of what's happening. Noxis hopeful
is going to go ahead and come out. We've
got two runes still up for Cara and
we're passing over to Frosty. Let's see
what happens.
>> Two runes is scary. It can be a uh
spinning axe. It can be a rebuke.
>> Well, speaking of spinning axes. Yep.
>> Why don't we go ahead and exhaust two to
bring out the spinning axe for the pouty
Porro after Frosty brought that uh
Kai'Sa in. Now we're in a little bit of
trouble.
>> This is not ideal for the Kai'Sa. I
mean, you you can really easily set up
crashes. Hard to set up uh clears before
the Kai'Sa goes down cuz like a Stupify
will crash. Uh a Hex Ray will crash. A
cleave will get over it.
>> A cleave does take out that Pouty Porro.
Now, the spinning axes do not go away as
it is some gear that you can re-equip
for next time. So, we're just going to
uh go ahead and exhaust that one rune.
Cleave for the Kai'Sa. And then we're
exhausting two more cuz we're going to
play in a Noxis hopeful at a keeper cost
>> two actually.
>> We're actually playing two.
>> And we still have one up for a
theoretical hexac stupify. There's
things that Kai'Sa can use that for. But
I love this list from frosty. It's very
different than the list I have been
approaching Kai'Sa with, but I think
it's showing the benefits of it. The
things like the the cleave in the main
deck means that your Kai'Sa can do plays
like that. You can always guarantee the
draw or essentially guaranteeing the
draw. There there's decks that will be
able to stop that, but it helps check
things like master y passive. It helps
checks things like directly the uh
spinning ax. It's the same uh might
bonus that you're getting. Really,
really cool.
>> Yes. And we're going to go ahead and
move in that Noxis hopeful to score a
point. And then we're going to exhaust
all of our runes, recycle one. So we're
only down to five here, but our 4Erunner
is going to come onto the board. We'll
then pass turn and uh Frosty is going to
ready those units
>> and hold for a point as well. Frosty is
winning the timer right now. If the game
state just continues and each player
scores one per turn, Frosty wins the
game. So that means again, it's Cara in
the pressure seat. And here we go.
>> It's happening. But we're exhausting
those five of recycling that one for the
4erunner played to the arena's greatest.
>> So there were six played technically
seven cuz one was rebuked and then
replayed. So seven played game one,
three played game two that's 10 and now
two played game three that's 12. There
have been 12 successful plays of a
ferris 4runner to the field.
>> Yes, a lot of four running a lot of
running has been happen.
>> Where are they going? Where are they
running to? Uh apparently to get the
mechs cuz they do normally die. I'm not
going to lie to you. Uh so
>> true.
>> So um here we
>> run to that trash pile where they're
running.
>> Truly.
>> What?
>> Efficiently again. They're efficiently
running to the trash pile. Yeah,
>> they are indeed. What is your course of
action for like when you want to deal
with the might on this top side that
Frosty is holding? How h how do you
overcome that? I think it's as a Kai'Sa
enthusiast, I hate to say it's
relatively easy. Draven's got a lot of
options to remove Battlefield. Things
like Rebuke are going to be at the top
of the list for the Ferris 4runner, but
then we also have accelerated Rexine
that can then allow your Draven Showboat
to accelerate. That's going to come up
probably on later turns. Uh you want the
Draven to be a little bigger and also
you want more rune ramp for that
expensive play, but we got to keep our
eyes on it. Um Darius is another one
that we've seen before. Uh Kira is on
the cleave. So the the OG Origins
Classic Darius plus the cleave. That's a
10 might attacking in with the Ferris
4Runner that would almost clear this
already. So uh I don't think that Cara's
in the immediate pressure to play. Now
when I say like, oh, you're in the
pressure seat because of the timer. It's
an eventual time uh timer like you got a
couple of turns to play with here
because Frosty's not establishing a
board uh at his own base to try and push
onto this Noxis hopeful. you can
probably assume that's going to hold.
Uh, and then you're able to, you know,
just get a bunch of units on the board
and eventually push in to that
battlefield held. But all that to say, I
I think the Draven's one of the best
decks at dealing with this type of game
state.
>> All right. Well, it looks like we're
finally getting into some decision
making. We're going to do the rebuke.
So, we're going to rebuke that Ferris
Forerunner back to hand and bring out
the readied Darius because this is the
second card that we're playing. Oh, it's
really that easy.
>> Yes. And we're moving in with both the
Darius and the Ferris 4Runner. Getting
that additional two might for uh Darius
here. What is going to be the response?
A hex tech ray.
>> Okay. It'll all crash, but it's still
advantage for Cara because you're able
to get the two mech tokens. You're
holding the point. Now you're taking the
timer cuz Frosty I I don't see a lot of
tools for Frosty to get onto the
battlefields fast. You're only on the
one Kai'Sa non main deck. Again, unless
sideboard comes in. We don't know what's
in the sideboard, but I'm going to
assume Cara has now kind of retaken that
timer back onto his side.
>> Yes. So, we get those two mech tokens.
We clear the board. So, we don't let
Frosty get that additional point, and
we're passing over to Frosty. Uh
immediately,
uh we're readying. I thought I thought
those six runes I was like, "Oh, my
brother." Uh
>> technically drew first, but you know
what? Again, good sportsmanship. Yeah,
just just take it. You know, they ready
the runes. Begin your turn.
channel
>> channel. There we go. It's like what's
the ABC? I It's so easy and laid out for
you. It's still somehow my brain just
kind of
>> because like you just do it every turn
of every game. So, you're kind of just
like blah blah blah, you know? Like it
just always comes together.
>> When I'm in competitive environment, I
really try to do it correctly, but when
I'm at home, I do it out of order all
>> every time. Do as I say, not as I do.
I'm expecting a falling star here.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, what do you know? The Falling Star
does take out those mech tokens. So,
it's going to be a little bit harder for
Cara if they want to score on next turn
for uh the arena's greatest. Lecturing
Yortle is also going to come out. And
then we're exhausting three more to play
a second one. And we're drawing a lot
here. So, we're getting a lot more cards
in hand so that we can do something on
our next turn.
>> You know what I'm just realizing? I
think the art on the back of lecturing
Yortle, see that like Yortle behind him
cuz he's he's given the lecture to
somebody,
>> right? Is that the person that's in the
new battlefield? The um
>> arenas.
>> No, the one where you hold and you move
a unit around amateur recital
production. Is that the same? Is there
like a lore about this card? When are we
going to get that card?
>> We Right. I don't think it's the same
person, but you know, I see what you
see. The hair is the same similarities
>> and she did have ears.
>> So I I see what you see,
>> which lecture undetermined if he's has
ears.
We don't know what's under that cap. Th
>> This This is true.
>> Or helmet. Is that a helmet?
>> It does. It It gives Corky.
>> It gives. Yeah. I've just realized he's
in like an orange jumpsuit. I don't know
what qualifications this guy has to give
a lecture.
>> He's I mean, there's a cupcake. Is that
Caitlyn tattoo?
>> Is that
>> This Yortle's lived a life.
>> Is that Caitlyn's trap? Like,
>> it looks like a yort snapp trap. Yeah,
>> maybe he's lecturing her on how to not
get trapped by the Yortle trap.
>> And the Yortle behind is like disarming
a different trap. We're really breaking
down this because nothing's happening
currently in game.
>> Yeah, a lot of decisions are trying to
be made here.
>> Is taking some time to think. So, we're
going to keep talking about the art. So,
the Yortle is clearly like not helping.
The lecturing Yortle is not helping.
He's just lecturing while the other
one's doing all the work and seems
distraught. That's not a happy looking
face. All right, Draven's hit the field.
Draven has hit the field with the uh
five runes exhausted, one recycled with
an additional five might because yes,
when he comes in, the might is increased
by the points. So Cara just wants to
make sure everybody knows he's sitting
pretty at eight.
>> Draven, the hero of the Yortles, going
to make the lecturing Yortle quiet
>> potentially. We'll see what happens
here. The the Yortles on the field of
Frosty right now are going to be
primarily just kind of resource scoring
units. They don't have a lot of might on
their own. Tank is a useful uh keyword
to kind of help dodge some of the
damage, but Draven, as we saw in the
previous turn, can swing for a lot of
damage at a time, especially now that
you have an eight might, soon to be nine
might unit depending on what Frosty
does. I mean, like singularity plus
Falling Star like that can clear this
current might, but the the longer this
goes, the tougher it gets. I guess we
did see the double stupify in the
Singularity on the last game. That's
also an option. But what what's in hand
right now?
>> There's a bellows
for runners. Uh yeah, so he's got some
stuff that he could play, but it looks
like we're not gonna start with the
Fairest Ferrerunner. We're just going to
exhaust two. I Okay, we're starting with
the Fairest Forerunner. Yep. Count them
out. Yep.
>> So that means it's going to be ferris
4runner and base. I was wondering if you
send a yortle in
>> to bring it to a battlefield.
>> Uh oh, no it's not.
>> You know, I love it when they're like,
"Yo, casters, can you let me cook real
quick?" Singularity comes out. This
works, too. Okay. Bellow's breath comes
out
>> very expensive, but it's enough. You
want to deal with the threat of the
Draven while it's at an eight before it
gets to a nine cuz certain numbers are
really really key for certain matchups.
Kai'Sa can hit even numbers much easier
than the odd numbers. Uh I mean you
always have these combinations, but like
getting to that nine is a big break
point where it's hard for Kai'Sa to deal
with. Uh but the Bella's breath plus the
singularity is enough to just go eight
damage, take it out. Once it gets to
nine, you you really need like falling
star plus singularity. Unless if he gets
a 10, it gets even harder cuz then you
have to fall in it twice. Um, yeah,
>> exactly.
>> That was a big swing.
>> It was a big screen. Oh, a big swing,
but also a big score cuz now we've got
two additional points for Frosty. Those
lecturing Yortles are lecturing their
way to victory right now.
>> I thought Draven was going to deal with
them. Uh, they are still lecturing.
>> Yeah, I mean, you can't really like
showboat your way uh from a professor,
man. Sometimes they just got to school
you. That's a good point. He's also a
Showboat.
>> Yes, literally. Uh, Draven Showboat.
>> There's Showboat versus Lecture. Which
is more powerful? I think we got our
answer. As Cara's now in a tough spot,
you have to clear at least one of these.
Has a lot of accelerate units. Can
Frosty check this on the attack? I'm
trying to think. It'd be like a hex tech
ray maybe double stupify.
>> Don't even know if he has that in hand
right now.
>> Stupify plus hex ray. We need a
combination I think with with two runes
as Kaiso right now.
>> And with two runes, we're thinking might
just have to let this lecturing Yortle
go.
>> Trying to remember what was in hand.
>> It's two Ferris.
>> Oh, we see Bell's breath.
>> So, you can Bella's breath. Yeah, you
can repeat Bellow's breath to crash, but
that Damps two, but it denies two draws
from the Draven. It is checked by a um a
cleave or by a uh spinning axe. So, I
think that's what Frosty was kind of
thinking about was like, "Uh, do I do
it?" Cara's got answers. And there's one
of them.
>> And there's the cleave. So, with that,
the lecturing Yortle is going to go
home. The lecture has ended. And we're
going to score a point for Cara.
>> Now, it's it's not ideal, but it's not
dire because Frosty will hold for a
point and still has the Ferris 4Runner
in hand. So, you dramped a bunch, but
you forced out the cleave. So now they
don't have that to play on the next turn
and you can just try and reinforce and
hold kind of reinforce and and hope I
guess is the actual answer. Uh or this
>> GG that works too. The Darius.
>> Wow. Wow. Wow. Frosty is taking that
victory going 10 and 0 baby. Lord have
mercy. What a wonderful wonderful game.
Kai'Sa is doing it.
>> An undefeated Kai'Sa. I was thinking you
try and find a way to hold, but no.
Frosty is playing a very mid-range unit
intense Kaisalist.
>> I actually want to hear
>> second
you don't have watcher. I was like, but
I know you have a fourunner.
>> I love hearing the
>> I was like you have four removal spell.
Uh
and then you remove the Kaiser and
establish. I had like two drops stolen.
>> Yeah.
>> As soon as So like after your last turn,
I was like,
>> "He doesn't have an accelerate unit and
I think I've got it."
>> If I stall
>> and then you and then you showed me the
the Kaiser. I'm like that's the only one
you have.
>> If I stall that Kaiser
>> Yeah.
>> I lose two
of them.
>> Yeah. I have no minions left in my hand.
>> This game is so fun, man. Oh my gosh.
>> That was awesome. That was awesome. I
love taking those little moments to hear
the players talk with each other cuz
especially at the 80, like these are
really good players. Like the way they
approach the game is much more advanced
than the way I approached the game.
>> Yes. And it sounded like Cara may have
misplayed there. He was like, "Dang it."
He didn't say, "Dang it," but he said,
"Dang it." He found maybe maybe that he
had like an out there. He said that he
could have maybe accelerated Kaiser
here.
>> Well, rather than accelerating, he could
just play the Kaiser falling star to
clear the the two Yortles and then like,
you know, play for a longer game, but
feeling confident to go in, get the two
draws. Like, it's so enticing as the
Draven to be like, "Oh, look at the
value of that, but then you don't have
the two runes up cuz you're going to
have to use the um the the cleave. That
means you don't have something else on
your turn." Oh, what a game.
>> What a game. And Frosty said it best
after that victory. He said Riftbound is
so fun, man. Because yes, there's all of
these pieces of the puzzles. You got to
figure out how you want to put them
together because they can be put
together so many different ways. It's
not checkers, baby, it's CZ.
>> He said it himself. Rook's fun. I want
to hear from the man himself. Let's send
it over for an interview.
>> Thanks so much, y'all. I'm joined by the
Kaisa to be talking about right now,
Frosty himself. 10 and 0 now
progressing. Three more rounds to go and
we were kind of talking a little bit
vamping it up. Obviously the energy
winning that match drawing that cheap
spell right at the end to get that
Darius play so you could get to that
last point after baiting out the cleave
from your opponent which means he didn't
have two up to play rebuke that could
have saved him there. How does it feel?
>> I'm shaking. Um I never thought I'd get
this far. Um, and being EXO at this
stage and sitting next to a lot of
friends at the top tables, this is
incredible. It's an awesome experience.
>> That's incredible, man. So, speaking of
that, why why do you think you weren't
going to make that far? Let's Kai'Sa is
a legend that I feel like we keep
talking about, but we haven't seen make
a top eight appearance at all during the
Spirit Forge season and you're this
close. But why do you why did you think
that way?
>> Yeah, so I was on Ezreal for all of set
two. I switched from Kai'Sa in set one
to set two and um I sleeved the deck on
Sunday. I I took a list from a friend um
modified it a little bit, brought it
here on Friday and went 33 on the the
pre- Rift event. Um and then chatting
with Alan ZQ and Randy.
>> Yeah.
>> Um they gave me some recommendations. U
made those changes and a couple
additional changes uh flavored for my
own personal style. Um, and it's it
seems to be doing pretty well.
>> You were telling me your record
yesterday.
>> Yeah.
>> Or not yesterday, sorry. In the pre-
regional.
>> Yeah.
>> Three and three.
>> You're 10 and0, my friend.
>> It's very surreal. I I'm very surprised
to have made it this far. Very, very
appreciative that this has been an
incredible experience in like a ton of
fun the whole time.
>> Absolutely. And you're this close.
You're genuinely this close to maybe
being in the top eight at the Atlanta
regional qualifier to top off the
Spearford season. I I I want to go back
to a more fun question.
>> Were you counting Were you both counting
how many Ferris 4Runners hit the board
across that entire match? The fact that
all the full play sets came out in that
first game was crazy. Mechs were
literally flying around.
>> Yeah. So, there's an edge in the matchup
after you have foreigner first typically
with some exception. Like there was an
opportunity for me to play one and it
was just higher Eevee I think to play
something different. But we were like as
soon as he played another and I played
it like we were laughing about it like
quite a bit. Um so I'm looking forward
to playing it later and like seeing
seeing how our records go after we
continue to play each other. Absolutely.
You said matchups. I wanted to let you
know ahead of time Kai'Sa matchup
percentage win percentage going against
Ravens is actually only about 43 44% of
comparatively to Liil and so far in this
tournament. And once again this is now
two rounds in a row where the underdog
has taken the victory. I'm surprised
I've defeated all three Dravens I've
paired into. Um, day one I was I faced a
unique deck every day, every uh every
game. Um, and then I somehow have bested
all three Dravens that I've played into.
Today I've only played Draven. Um, the
first game I think is favored for
Draven. Um, as I have too many two drops
in my deck.
>> Yeah. And then as I board in more um a
little bit more removal, it it evens out
the matchup a bit. But also, I have more
combat tricks in my deck than most Kais
in the room.
>> That's good.
>> There's some friends of mine that are
trying to convince me I have the best
deck in the room. And the the further
the like well the sorry the the best
Kaisen list in the room.
>> We'll try we'll find out. See if you're
holding a best of at the end of the day.
>> I'll be so excited.
>> Well, congratulations for your victory.
You're doing an incredible job, Frosty,
but we're going to send it back for more
action,
>> y'all. Oh my gosh. Like, I was lean
forward the whole time. I wanted to make
sure I heard every word. Oh my gosh.
That it's just so exciting hearing these
players. Uh dude said he went three and
three
>> on Friday
>> and still stuck with the deck.
>> And still stuck with the deck. Sleaved
his deck on Sunday. Yeah. came here
Friday 33 talking to Allan make some
changes and now here we are 10 and up
>> and also similar arc to myself I didn't
play Kai'Sa in Origins but I started
with Ezreal and Spirit Forge post ban
list I was like ah I don't like the play
style of Ezreal as much I was more on
the miracle build so then I found Kai'Sa
and that was the first deck that really
called to me I was like oh this is fun
this is that high action high you know
tempo gameplay that I I really look for
I know that's ironic that I just said I
played Miracle and then Kais is very
different. But either way, um it's it's
awesome to hear a fellow, you know,
player have a similar journey, a similar
arc, but in a very different way, cuz
his list is unique. And he touched on
that a little bit. He's like, "Yeah, I'm
playing more of those two uh two might
units, which is bad into Draven." And
Draven, I I don't have a screen here,
but I'm gesturing to the general
audience is everywhere. Like Draven is
the most popular deck at this tournament
right now, uh based on like the the
stats that we were looking at. So, it's
a tough matchup, and he's probably going
to play more Dravens today. Okay. So,
let's see if he can keep the undefeated
streak.
>> Yeah, he's probably going to play more
Dravens, but if we think back to what he
said, he's played a lot of Dravens
>> and he's beaten all of us. Oh my gosh.
>> And and again, I even said that uh going
at the percentages, I was like, I feel
like Draven is uh it's easier. It's more
friendly than Kai'Sa for the low end for
for the people that are coming to an
event for fun and are, you know, going
X3, X4 and still playing and having like
a good time. Whereas Kai'Sa, it's also
again it's it's still a pretty forgiving
deck. like you're not dramping for your
spell costs. Like it's I don't want to
say that Kai'Sa is not forgiving, but I
think Draven's more forgiving. So
whenever you look at stuff like that,
I'm like matchups can be skewed because
it's not just the top tables that these
matchups are happening. A top Kai'Sa
expert can have a good matchup against
these decks. Even if statistically the
field would say that it's a bad matchup.
>> Yes. And honestly, I I I think he just
displayed the skill. Now, he said that
his friend said that he might have the
best uh deck, the best
>> best deck list,
>> but it's he's still in the running for
that best deck list. I also loved how he
did take some outside uh
>> like outside knowledge,
inspiration to increase his deck, but he
stayed true to what he was his own play
style. And I love to hear that because
it sounds like he knows his play style
and he's using that to his advantage.
>> Whenever I hear players mention stuff
like that, like, oh, I got like some
tips from this like really good player
like Allen's EQ, but uh I still made
some of my own modifications for my play
style. I'm like, what were the
modifications? Like I want to know like
what the play style for him was. I I
assume it was forecaster. Forecaster is
a really interesting card. We didn't see
it hit the field, but like I've never
seen that in a Kaiso list. And I'd love
to go over that because they said that
they were kikiing and cocking about all
the forecasters that were 4Runners that
were hitting the field. But we're gonna
do a postgame analysis real quick for
y'all.
>> Hello everybody, Charmer here and we are
going to do a postgame analysis that
will absolutely talk about those Ferris
4ERunners. Uh, we need to change the
name of this card because it's not
fourer runners cuz I count one, two,
three, four,
five
ferris 4runners. And there's a reason
that this is the second most card played
in the field at this event. It's because
it is incredibly hard to deal with.
There was this arms race that we saw and
if you remember correctly or if you're
just joining us maybe you don't know. Uh
we're going to let the tape roll here
but you're going to actually see a sixth
one hit the board. Uh there were in the
double digits throughout this series
Ferris 4Runners played. And the reason
for that is quite simple. It's a lot of
might that's also very hard to deal
with. And it's one of the things that I
wanted to highlight because ultimately I
think the reason Kai'Sa performed well
in this matchup and the reason I think
Frosty is doing well throughout the
event in general is that there is a plan
to deal with what the Ferris 4Runner
brings to the table. Of course, there's
that sixth one that I was just talking
about. And we're going to go ahead and
move on to the next clip which is going
to showcase one of the ways that we deal
with Ferris 4runner as a Kai'Sa player.
That is of course singularity. So,
singularity is, of course, a premier
removal.
It does deal six damage to a unit. Six
is a magic number because of the six
might on the Ferris 4Runner. In this
particular instance, it's also taking
care of a Kai'Sa as well. Another
premier card in Draven lists as well as
the Kai'Sa. We can go ahead and let this
roll because it's not the only answer.
One of the reasons that I think Kai'Sa
is performing well into Draven is you do
also have access to cards like smokec
screen so that you can make favorable
trades. We're going to see one of those
pop up here in just a moment. And on the
other side of the table when you're
thinking about what's in the Draven
arsenal for how to deal with things.
Draven of course has rebuke. There was a
moment in this matchup where Cara did
play a rebuke on a 4Runner, but because
Cara at that point in the matchup was
behind on points and because rebuke is
only a temporary answer, it simply
slowed Frosty down. Uh, in game one in
particular, I think the real story as
well was the fact that Cara missed that
turn one play that allowed Frosty to get
the point tempo. That point lead is very
important in these kind of Fairest
4Runner dominated mirrors because if
you're the first one on site, it's then
up to your opponent to find ways to deal
with those Fairest 4Runners and they
kind of have to break through your
bunker first. Now, once you break a
Fairest 4Runner, uh we're going to go
ahead and move to the next clip. You
still have to have a way to deal with
the mechs. And both lists have the
ability to run this card. Of course, I'm
going to be highlighting falling star
naturally. Uh, in this situation here,
you can see we've got the standard two
mech tokens that are made after a ferris
4runner. So, if we go ahead and roll the
footage, we're going to see a falling
star come in immediately deal with those
tokens. And again, yes, Draven does have
the ability to run a crawling star. We
do see it in those lists, but it is a
staple in Kai'Sa because of the Kai'Sa
legend ability. Being able to utilize
her to pay that power cost, not have to
recycle, that allows her to continue to
scale her runes until she can get up to
singularity to also again deal with the
continued onslaught of these larger
threats. And uh I think Frosty navigated
this incredibly well. Uh, one last thing
that I want to note. Uh, in game one,
Frosty did have the point lead. Utilized
that beautifully. In game three, part of
the reason that Frosty was able to close
things out successfully was that Frosty
was on the even point totals. I know
that myself, Pastry, Kangas, etc., Miss
Chimchin, we've talked about how the
even point totals are very important in
Riftbound, and this was another
showcase. Frosty being at six was then
of course able to get that hold point.
And even though there was only those
fury runes did have the hexte ray plus
the Darius to close things out. Hexte
ray of course another great way to deal
with those mech tokens if they are on
the battlefield. But uh I think that
this particular matchup just comes down
to does the Kaisa player have the right
answers for the opposing Ferris 4runners
that you expect to see all day long.
again, second most played card in the
room at this Atlanta regional qualifier.
And uh with that, I'm going to be
sending it back to the broadcast. Take
it away.
Very, very cool breakdown from Charmer
right there. And I want to highlight one
of the things he touched on was like the
the intricacies of the Ferris 4runner
mirror because any red deck can run into
these situations where you got the
Ferris four runners versus each other.
But um the singularity I actually kind
of favor a little more with the red blue
combination cuz it is slightly more
efficient than the rebuke. The rebuke on
the purple red and and this is a taste
thing. Some people might disagree with
me and say that no bouncing the fairs
for runner is more efficient because you
don't make the mech tokens. But then
they can play it again. It slows them
down but you haven't really fully dealt
with the threat. You've just delayed the
threat. Whereas singularity accepts that
the uh tokens are going to come out.
takes a Ferris 4Runner and something
else with it like the Kai'Sa in that
last play or two Ferris 4Runners or or
like a Darius or like it's just such an
efficient way to deal with the the
Ferris 4runner along with something else
which is part of why I think that Kai'Sa
uh or really any of like the the red
blue matches like you can make the same
argument for Rumble too. Um I I don't
think we've seen like many many Rumbles
going around. We had one on day one
feature match but I don't think that
they've excelled since then. Um, but
like theoretically the the red blue
combination can deal with Ferris for
4Runner in a very smooth efficient
manner. All you need is eight runes and
a lot of recycle cost and you can just
get rid of the Ferris 4Runner with
something else.
>> Yeah, and I mean we saw it firsthand
here and I'm I'm surprised that Kai'Sa
was so underfed
uh in that matchup with
>> skill issue.
Not 60% of the Kais have a skill issue,
but it looks like
>> Call it as I see it, Reagan.
>> It looks like the Frosty here is one of
the best now 10 and 0. Y'all, I checked
the stats here and it looks like Frosty
is one of two people left who have an
unblenmished record. It is Frosty and an
Annie player.
>> Yeah, that's what we're seeing over
there. But we also have a meta breakdown
from Productions. Let's take a look at
the meta breakdown and then we can talk
more about who is still at the 10 and 0.
Um, Draven had a 211 representatives.
Kai'Sa was still in the top three.
Kai'Sa is not like a slept on pick. It's
like one of the most popular picks, but
a lot of people were disrespecting her.
They were like, nah, she's been around
since Origins. Everyone's been hyping up
Kaisa since Origins. She hasn't won
anything. She's not going to win
anything. Uh especially when you think
about all the green uh you know counter
spells for Aurelia, the way for Draven
to deal with the ferris 4runners with
rebuke and even like hard bargain and
such. Um but no, I think if you get the
right Kaisop pilot, it is still strong.
>> Look at these percentages here though.
Like we have a very dominant Ireelia and
Draven metag game right now, right? Um I
think it's so interesting to see that
they are still so dominant. The bands of
course came through, but there is still
so much trust in those legends. Uh, as
we go down looking at the Leonas, the
sets.
>> So, interesting to note the only three
best doubves that had been secured
already were Garen, Ranata, and Leona.
Correct.
>> Who's at the top of this list? So, I
don't know. It's probably been updated
since then. That that was at the
beginning of the day. We've had two
rounds. So, I'm imagining that there's
been more, but that's I I didn't like
clock that right away that uh there was
a lot large field of uh stuff under
Leona in representation that there were
still multiple people in the running
for.
>> Yeah. No, that's really interesting. I
mean, 34.
>> Jax in particular is tight cuz there was
one towards the end of the day yesterday
that was undefeated um that I think they
were like 6 and0. I
>> It was actually No, it was the last
match. It was the last match of the day
cuz it was the Jacks that stole had two
and stole it. Oh my gosh.
>> And the Skyfall.
>> It was It was Jax versus Mastery.
>> I'm pretty sure that was crazy.
>> You're so correct. Oh my gosh. Wow.
>> Or versus Lucian versus the Lucian cuz
it was the Skyfall with it. Yeah.
>> Oh, it was illusion.
>> Yeah. But that that Jax player uh still
in it in a in a really good spot, I
imagine, depending on how the the rounds
went uh today, but still uh fun to see
just the the spread of the decks
overall.
>> Well, I think we should look at day two
real quick uh for a little review as
well.
Here we are. the the numbers did go
down, but the percentages stayed about
the same.
>> So, this is all the decks that made it
to day two. And Kai'Sa did uh a little
more poor compared to the field. Master
Yi did a little better compared to the
field, but Draven and Aurelia still in
that top two.
>> Yeah, still in that top two around the
same percentage that we have like
actually representing the legend.
>> Actually, we're seven Rex eyes. That's
something that I was chatting with uh
with Pastry Time about was like, "Yeah,
Rexi had some hype going into Leo and
then did not do well at Le and then at
this event we didn't get a single one on
feature match. It's not going to there
were no undefeateds there or no X1's for
it going into today. So no shot at the
top eight you have to imagine. Um at
least that we spotted like maybe we
missed one but uh only seven that made
day two to begin with.
>> I want to talk kind of about this uh
Darius. I feel like Darius is kind of
just popping up out of nowhere here.
Wow, the numbers really dwindled.
>> Okay. A lot of twos.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, I guess a couple a lot of threes
and fours. So, still respectable
showings. Four rumbles. Hey, there we
go. That's the other red blue.
>> And the bottom three are our best of
winners.
>> One of those sets was undefeated.
>> Yeah, one of those sets was undefeated.
Very unfortunate. But I I think two uh
that we're getting representation for is
the Volibear and the Yasuo and the Lux.
>> I I'm hearing that the set was actually
a three. I thought I saw a set that was
undefeated. Does that mean we had three
undefeateds?
>> I'm just making sure I heard that from
production correctly.
>> Okay. It sound like they're going to
double check that. Uh but yeah, I know
one of the sets was undefeated, which
was crazy. It was it was an eight and
zero set at the start of the day. Uh
yeah, Colin. Yeah, he had a great show
and we got him on feature match
yesterday, too.
>> Um and wait, where's Jinx? Oh, three.
Three jinxes. I wonder if any of them
were still in the running.
>> A cute little
>> there. There was I think two X and one
Jinxes.
>> At least one. There was at least one.
>> I'll have to check my stats on.
>> I got to see their deck list cuz I have
not been able to make Jinx work on this
format. I'm so far from a playable Jinx
deck.
>> You got to take that and like adapt it
because they're they're obviously
cooking in the stew with something.
>> Again, mine's my party deck. Everyone
should have a party deck. You know, you
got your like competitive deck that you
try and win with and then you got your
party deck that you're like, I'm just
going to play with friends. That's
that's jinx for me right now. Do you
think Unleashed is going to make her
better?
>> Oh, 100%. Yes. Yes. Uh I'm I always
blank on the name, but the the three
energy, three might that can play itself
from your discard. It's a red unit. You
can uh spend three energy and recycle a
red to play it from your discard. I
think the red Jinx is back. Red aggro
Jinx. It's coming for you.
>> It's coming.
>> Now we get Phoenix. We get that guy. We
can still have our um our uh the the
three might from Origins. I haven't
played them in a while, but when you
discard them, you can recycle a red to
play him from your from your discard.
>> You got so many things. Your graveyard
just another hand. It's just another
hand.
>> It sounds like a lot of parts.
>> Get your red seal. That's what I'm
getting. I'm I'm That's not advice.
That's not market, but I'm just saying
if you want to have fun, if you want a
party deck like me, if you want to party
like Angus, get red seal.
>> I think there's going to be a lot of uh
Origins uh legends that might make their
comeback. Uh I've heard that Volibear
might make a return. a dragon build's
going to be crazy. Reagan, have you seen
it? The eight drop dragon. You play it.
You ready two runes for every dragon you
got. So just base, it's already good.
Like an orange deck can just play that.
I legit think that we might just see
that in orange decks cuz it's an eight
might that just readies two runes. So
it's essentially like a six uh six
energy. Oh my goodness, that card's stat
efficient. And then when you add the
other dragons on top of it with the
Volibear passive, like I I already got
my um my Kadrians. I picked up Kadrians
this weekend. I was like, "Yep, I'm
going to be playing some dragon Voli
Bear."
>> I think I've also heard that Fiora will
just get stronger in the next set as
well. No,
>> I think I think I'm a little biased.
>> It's the Fiona man.
>> The Fiona mane. I love her so much.
>> So, what's the story behind calling her
Fiona, by the way?
>> I I really don't know. I like to say
words differently. I really do. So, um I
I like I'll call an ambulance a fire
lance.
stuff of that sort.
>> So, just like pet names.
>> Yeah, I like that.
>> It's just what I like to do. Uh Fiona is
also from a uh IP that I don't want to
mention because I don't want us to get
copyrighted or anything. Yeah. Oh, okay.
Trick. I'll see.
>> I don't know the rules. So,
>> hey, now you're an all-star. Speaking of
all, let's throw it over for a deck
breakdown of Leona and Unleashed.
>> Hello everybody. Welcome. I'm at Charmer
joined with pastry and we're in for a
treat because I was dragged over here
and told that you have something cooked
up that you want to show off to
everybody at home. So, uh, Unleash is
coming is, uh, is out very soon, if not
already, depending on when you're
watching this, I suppose. And, uh, you
know, lots of things are fun. So, Leon
has been a little down in the dump,
shall we say. Uh, Frank Kasanova, big
fan of this Legend in Origins. I've been
a big fan of it with Baited Hook. So,
I've been thinking, you know, what could
we do with this show? So, this is kind
of my first attempt at building what
Leona might look like in Unleash. So,
the things I want to tell you, Chararma,
cuz I'm curious what your deck building
philosophy is as well when you're
approaching new sets and new formats.
So, the way I looked at this was like,
okay, the cards I am really excited that
I think are good, I want to play three
of, right? Cuz I want to see them a lot
when I'm playing games. I want to like I
think they're also good, so I want to
have them a bunch of times, but I also
have a bunch of different one-offs in
here that I'm like, you know what? I
think this might be good. Let me try it.
And this is kind of the my first process
in terms of how I build decks when I'm
trying to figure out like what do I
actually want this list to look like. So
still building from like first
principles on deck building. I've tried
to have enough six drops. I have like
you know a bunch of stun stuff. For me
the big unleash is that there actually
just good stun cards and we could start
with I actually back off.
>> This card is real good.
>> Yeah. When this was revealed I was a big
fan of it because I like hidden stuff.
No surprise. I'm a Teemo enjoyer. but
also because it is a versatile stun,
right? This is something that uh if you
play it from your hand, you get to draw
a card. We like that kind of recycle
mechanic with your hand, but you can
also hide it, catch people off guard. It
is cost effective. I
I All right, I got to ask you though. I
see
>> I see
>> he has not seen this list, by the way.
>> I have not seen this list. Uh tell me
about the mouser inclusion.
>> Oh, okay. So, I was looking at different
true drops to this deck. So, the obvious
one I have is honest broker. I think in
general Leonard is very power hungry.
So, you want a way to generate gold.
I've used this as a bunch of baited hook
decks. I just like this unit a lot. I
think it's good in this deck. I think
calm in general very power hungry. And
it was kind of like this or honey fruit.
And I kind of want an actual unit. Uh
but Mouser, this is like a I think this
might be good as a two drop generally as
a two drop in these colors.
>> Okay.
>> I want to try and see how this work cuz
statwise it's got everything you need.
Leon is the deck that wants to hold.
This is a one in like the top right,
which doesn't feel all that good, but
shield two and tank. Tank actually
pretty valuable in decks that want to
hold because you're maybe trying to
protect more fragile units. But, you
know, as a as a two as a one drop or an
early drop that costs two that is
effectively three might. That is kind of
sounded good enough.
>> Fair enough. I was just asking because
th this is my take. Okay.
>> Uh there is a porro that has two might
with shield one.
>> So, just kind of statistically better
minus the tank.
>> Yep. So, I didn't know if you were
specifically trying to protect another
unit here or if you were just unleash
pilled. I also know that you've been
brewing a lot of Ivor and it has the cat
on it. So,
>> uh I mean I do like cats. I am a little
unleash build as kind of like wanting to
test what does the new unit feel like.
That's kind of one of the other things
that's important whenever new cards come
out is like I think this is good. I want
to hit it a bunch of games and just see
there is a very good chance this would
just be stol. You're right. But uh it is
definitely more in the unleash pills/ I
like cats category than anything else.
>> I'm never going to argue with I like
cats. Uh one of the things that I also
like about this list of course is the
three of of the new Vex. There's a lot
of talk about uh all the versions of
Vex, but uh this one I think is maybe
the most underrated because there's a
lot of emphasis on the uh existing one
from Spirit Forged as well as the new
purple one. Uh tell me what you like
about this one.
>> So I've been thinking about this card a
lot. Uh, I started obviously with Beta
Hook Leona. That was kind of my my
blueprint for looking at Unleashed in
general. That's the deck I've been
playing the most in Spirit Forge. Uh,
and I had this as like a one-off. I'm
like, "Oh, it's kind of cute. It's a
good unit to hook into as you're lading
up. Uh, if you stun, it can like move to
a battlefield." Like, it seems pretty
versatile. And then when I was building
this deck, which is kind of a more
regular stun the owner list. The more I
looked at this card, the more I was
like, I actually think this might be the
best card in the deck. This card does so
many things. So, it's a five in the top.
It is basically a six cuz when you have
you want a stun to use this that's going
to buff it thanks to Leona. So it's a
six on offense. It's a seven on defense
because it has shield. It also has tank
which again when you're trying to hold
feels like a pretty valuable thing for
me. The mobility on this is what really
puts it over the top. The obvious combo
is using your chosen champion Leona
determined. When you attack you stun the
unit Vex charges in. But especially with
stuff like back off when you're hiding
cards this card can like move around
battlefields at light speed. Like even
if it's just Vex on her own, if you stun
a unit, she just goes over there.
>> So, I wanted to highlight this card as
well because even though it says Vex on
it, it feels very Leona because you and
I have both said uh we play a lot of
Leona in League of Legends, right? I
love being an initiator. Hopping on the
enemy is my favorite thing to do. This
again, even though it's Vex, is that
personified? You're going to stun a
unit, hop onto them. I love the idea of
utilizing this with cards like Thonk,
for example, where they might be going
to an open battlefield, but if you flunk
or do something like that over there,
she can hop over and suddenly become a
defender and then still score on your
opponent's turret.
>> Yeah, you can do it on offense as well
with like Zena Blade. This is already
like one of the reasons to play Leona,
right? Zena Blade's a very powerful
signature spell even though it power is
a little bit expensive. And in general,
the origin signature spells have not
been as well represented as the spirit
forge ones. But on offense, you're
already moving a unit to a battlefield
and stunning it. That's already good in
this deck. Now Vex can come along for
the ride no matter where she is. Whether
she's in your base exhausted if you just
played her, whether she's on another
battlefield that maybe she was holding
or helping hold before. Like the more I
looked at this unit, the more busted it
felt in this deck. And I don't know how
good it actually is, but I wanted to do
play three because I thought this was
maybe the best card in the deck. And if
that is true, not only do I want to draw
it as much as I can, but I also want to
find out, right? Cuz it's a new set. So,
I was like, I think this is good. I'm
just going to go for it.
>> Yeah. I
I'm going to be honest.
>> I was going to be more judgmental.
>> You should do it.
>> This uh this doesn't look that bad. At
least as a first draft. I wanted to come
on and kind of, you know, make fun of
you, but no, this honestly this looks
pretty solid as a first draft just for
trying things out. Uh the other thing as
a person who's looking forward to
playing VI when unleash comes out. Tell
me about your one inclusion of the Vi
with Ambush.
>> So this is definitely like if the if the
three of Unleash are the cards where I'm
like I think these are good. I want to
at least try them and see how they feel.
This is like I'm not sure but I think it
might it's it's at least fun but uh I I
want to find out if it's good but I
don't think it's so good that I want to
see it a lot. So just having one to see
how it feels in my hand. My worry is
that there's quite a few fives in this
list already. So that slot's kind of
clogged up and you're not that excited
to cast this. Uh it is also very similar
to your chosen champion in Leona
determined. So I didn't want a lot of
this effect. But the ambush is new. It's
a little bit bigger than Leona, right?
It's a six when you buff it as a stun
comes in. It doesn't come with a stun.
Like actually it does come with a stun
when you attack. And it's a little bit
different in terms of like when you can
use this card. I think it might be good,
but I don't know. And it was kind of
like a fun of one of. It's like
something I wanted to try, but don't
think it's so good that I'm actually
going to play a lot of this effect. I
was just thinking about the potential
blowout turns where if you've developed
Vex and then on the following turn after
you're ready once again, if they go into
a location and you vi there and then Vex
hops, that's suddenly a lot of might in
a location that just was not there
before. So, I really dig it. Now, one of
the other things when I'm deck building
that I like to think about is, okay, if
this is what I'm trying to accomplish,
right? What am I worried about? Are
there any decks when you're, you know,
playing this that you're saying, "Hey, I
think I might struggle against this."
>> I think any decks that are very good at
consistently playing threats in the
early game. So, I think things like
Azir, some builds of Master Year running
around, like anything that's basically
going to play a uh a two drop on on the
first turn in any other game cuz my big
worry about this is it's really slow.
Like, a lot of these units feel clunky.
Like, it curves pretty nicely. I have
kind of my 62s to try and hit them
pretty consistently. Uh Leona being my
chosen champion actually is great
because it's always a drop you want to
play even though I have some other
options as well. Mostly Stellorn because
>> I'm covering it by the way. Let's show
her off.
>> She is uh obviously I have Stellorn just
cuz it's Stellorn. It's probably the
best card draw unit in Karm and Leona
certainly needs the help as far as card
draw goes. But other than that like Vex
I think very powerful. Salari Chief
really fun if he can combo with another
stun. Leona Radiant is a one of
something I've done quite a lot of but
all these units are like really really
clunky. So, I think it can protect them,
which is I'm not worried about removal,
but I'm definitely worried about getting
behind and not being able to get back
on.
>> And so, that leads me to the followup,
right? You were talking about the clunky
worried about the early game. Uh, if you
do find yourself struggling with the
early game, would you consider cutting
something like Solari Chief that does
more situational and just put in more
two drops or how would you adjust it uh
if you do find that you're struggling in
those games?
>> I think depending on the texture of
those decks. So, is it like go wide
decks that are doing it? Is it decks
that are just trying to protect like a
single unit but they can play it early?
Is it I don't know is Rengar like
ambushing me in every other game? So
like the answer might be more removal.
This deck actually pretty removal light.
One of the things about Leona that's fun
is that you care so much about kind of
removing units in combat, right?
Stunning them bringing them towards you
with cards like charm moving into their
battlefield with Zenus blade. But you're
not all that good despite being in order
at like removing a unit turn. I have a
couple of hidden blades, but I have no
coderinks, for example, cuz coder week
felt a little weird in this deck that
didn't have that many small units.
>> Yeah, you actually said something that
just clicked for me, which why I was
chuckling, which is in order as a
domain, you very often are playing this
kind of hard removal. It's cards like
Call of the Week, but you can't stun
units if they're dead.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. And the whole point of Leona, the
whole fun is stunning units. So, that
makes sense.
>> Yeah. So, I think uh if it was like
those, I'd maybe have more removable. If
it was like go wide decks, not that many
sweepers in these domains if uh from
memory, but so I probably would just
want to play more units and try and have
a smoother early game to have combat
earlier cuz I think when this deck gets
set up and that is one of the other fun
things and also weaknesses of Leona, she
kind of needs a good amount of setup to
get going. But if you like have a Vex
parked with another unit and like a
counter spell and like a stun spell
ready, your opponent just like cannot go
to Battlefield. So you're just going to
pretty much on offense or defense,
you're going to blow them out. All
right, final question before we throw it
back to the cast.
>> Uh, as somebody who plays a lot of Teemo
or other lists that have been
holdentric, obviously I love Ari.
>> What is your retake strategy if they do
push you off of a site?
>> So, I think the obvious one is like
Zenith Blade and then Vex plus Zenith
Blade. That's like the that's the bread
and butter. Uh, Leona radiant not bad in
the late game as a unit that can enter
ready. I think these domains can
sometimes struggle for ways to actually
have accelerate already. There's not
that much in these domains, but uh my
retake strategy, if it's not that, it's
like charm them off, move in, and then
just like cross my fingers.
>> All right. Well, I actually am very
happy that you dragged me in here and
over this because I am inspired. I might
be taking a look at Leona myself, but
>> start cooking some more next.
>> Unfortunately, we're out of time, so
we're going to be throwing back to the
cast. Take it away, Kangas and Miss Chim
Chim.
>> Hello everybody. Steve Kangas here in
Atlanta for the Riftbound Regional to
give you a meta report. I'm going to
break down one of my favorite decks to
play in Riftbound right now and that is
Kaisa, Daughter of the Void. I've been
playing a lot of this and this is the
top finishing deck list, 22nd in Le uh
and we're going to break down some of
the cool choices they had and also what
makes Kaisa tick as a deck. Obviously,
the legend. A lot of people will know
this already, but if you're newer to
Riftbound, you can uh exhaust this to
give yourself a power to spend on one of
your spells. A lot of spells, a lot of
the best spells have a power cost.
Kai'Sa doesn't mind that because you're
not going to dramp while you're casting
your spells, specifically ones that
snipe the board. I'm thinking of the
falling star, the singularity, the
piercing light. This is kind of the
bread and butter of Kaiso when I think
of the deck. It's your ability to
control not only units at battlefield
and doing damage to them, but also units
on their own field, their own boards.
So, uh it doesn't matter where they are,
they're not safe if they're against
Kai'Sa, which of course means that green
is going to be your natural enemy as the
Kai'Sa player. But you don't always mind
that because you have other tools at
your disposal, too. Specifically, very
powerful units. Not only is it about the
sniping spells, Ferris Borrunner, one of
the strongest red units in my opinion in
the game, and thousand tail watcher, one
of the strongest blue units in my
opinion in the game. Both of these help
you kind of control the matchups when
your snipe spells aren't going to be
enough, especially if they have things
like not so fast on the green matchup,
even hard bargain and the purple
matchups. But it's your ability to still
push through with your bigger units
regardless of if your snipe spells go
off. That type of flexibility makes the
deck very satisfying to play. And always
having access to your Kaiisa chosen
legend Kaisa survivor means that you
draw a card when you conquer with her.
You have progress day to draw four
cards. Uh you have things like lecturing
your adult to draw cards as well. You're
always going to be able to dig into your
deck and find the cards that you need to
win a specific matchup. So not only is
it flexible on the type of cards you can
add to the deck, but also it has a
consistency to find those cards more
often than not. And if that's not
enough, you also have access to two of
the strongest spells in the game, time
warp and unchecked power. I love that
they win unchecked power in the main
deck here because nobody expects that
game one. Then you can also side it out
depending on the matchup for game two.
Um but time warp, we all know one of the
strongest spells in the game that can
just win you a game on its own. You get
a second turn in a row and uh if you're
holding a point that means you just
basically get a free point right there.
So these two are the big kind of game
enders. You have the strong units to
make pushes. You have the sniping spells
to control the board. I just describe
this deck as kind of feel like a race
car. Like that's I it's like a luxury
vehicle. You're just going fast. Uh and
you're you're out running the
competition. Uh there were a couple
changes with the ban list that happened
specifically in the battlefield
department. So you don't have things
like Dreaming Tree anymore. That was a
big hit cuz that means you don't have
like the stupify play on your own unit
to draw two. Um but the adaptations I
still think are are pretty good. Raven
Bloom Conservatory. You see we're on a
lot of spells in this deck. So, if
you're defending, high chance that you
get a free draw essentially by revealing
a spell. And if you're in combat in a
showdown, hex tech ray, some of these
are action spells that you can still use
during that combat to try and flip the
script on your opponent. So, even like
smokec screen, stupify, you get the idea
there. And then via always fun,
especially against all the Aurelia going
around. That's sometimes annoying. Void
gate is a classic. Your spells that
already did a lot do even more. The
sideboard's also one of the strongest in
the game specifically because of thermmo
beam. You don't see it right here, but
it's one of the best spells in the
format because of how many gear decks
are out there. The Lucian, the master
yees, the Aurelia. You got one spell
that doesn't even pay the full power
cost because of your Kai'Sa legend uh
that can just deal with all of that. So,
I love this deck. I think it's really
strong uh and it just it plays so
smooth. So, this is one I'm going to
have my eye on. I really hope I get a
cast one during one of our future
matches. But that's it for my meta
report on Kaisa. Hope you enjoy the rest
of the event.
Hello and welcome back to the Riftbound
Regionals qualifiers here in Atlanta,
Georgia. I'm Miss Chimchum and I've gra
I've grabbed three special participants
cuz I want to play a game. I want to
spice it up a little bit. We're going to
play a little bit of telephone. So,
we're going to start with a over here. I
want you to name a card that starts with
a. When uh he names a card, we're going
to pass it on to the next person. He
must name a card that starts with the
ending letter that the first person said
and so on and so forth. We are going to
eliminate somebody if they cannot come
up with a card within five seconds. The
last man standing wins three packs of
spirit forge. So, are you ready? All
right, we're going to start with A. And
what is the card?
>> Arena's greatest.
>> Arena's greatest. T
>> Targon's Peak.
>> Is okay. I'm out. Oh my god, the FF. The
immediate FF. Okay, this is totally
fine. We're going to start back up. So,
uh, it was K. So, you're going to have
to come up with a card name that starts
with K.
>> Oh, no. I just killed myself.
You win.
>> All right. It looks like you are the
last man standing and you win three
cards.
>> Sorry, that was a lot harder than I
thought it was.
>> No, that's totally fine. So, let's go
ahead and get into it. We're going to
start with a
>> Ari.
>> I think I'm out.
>> It's tough. It's tough, honestly. Okay,
so we got two people. Here we go. I'm
going to still go with I
>> I'm going to start with I.
>> Aurelia.
>> Oh, Aelia. Perfect.
>> Aspirin's climb.
>> Bellow's breath.
eight.
>> And we have our winner. Three packs of
Spirit Forge here. I would like to see
you open them, but we're going to send
it to the broadcast.
Hello and welcome back to coverage of
regional qualifier Atlanta. We're
getting to the business end of the
Swiss, as they say. Shama, welcome back.
>> I am very happy that you have welcomed
me back. Very happy to be here.
>> Imagine if I was like, you're unwelcome.
I guess you're here.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Do that to you,
>> I guess. So, uh, we are nearing the end
of Swiss as you pointed out, right? Two
rounds left.
>> Yep. 13 rounds total. Two rounds left.
>> We have only a couple of undefeateds
left as well.
>> Also true. Do you know how many?
>> I I said a couple.
>> Oh, literally two.
>> Literally two.
>> Literally two. That's right.
>> And I I know I'm about to jinx it. It's
the caster curse and so I'm sorry, but
uh earlier this weekend a lot of folks
have been asking who do you think is
going to win? What legend do you think
is going to win? Uh my answer has pretty
consistently been I think it will be uh
Ireelia if I'm just picking the legend
without the player.
>> But if I'm taking the player into
consideration, I think that prismaticism
on his Annie is looking to make that
final step. Prismaticism has been in so
many top eights, performed incredibly
well, uh, continuing to perform well
again today. And so I'm I'm thinking
that this might be it. I think he could
go all the way,
>> which is wild to think that he's
playing. I mean, not exactly the same
list, but a very similar list. Uh, cuz
you only have a week between Lil and
Atlanta to figure things out. Obviously
still on Adding for anyone that didn't
know. Uh, looked very good on that deck.
The main innovation being Rengar, which
was a pretty sweet one. And uh whatever
changes made clearly working out in a
Draven heavier field is going to take a
look at the standings and now Chara
spoilers can finally be unleashed. There
are three undefeated technically
prismaticism ism at the top at 10 and
zero. Frosty who we just saw on stream
on Kaiser at 10 and zero and then Koko
Lopez 90 and one still technically
undefeated but a lot of killers still in
this first page of the standings as well
at X and one. Yeah, and as we're looking
at the legends here, uh again, we'd kind
of said we expected Draven to be the
most represented. There is a plethora of
Dravens in those top spots, but uh the
undefeateds, we have an Annie, we have a
Kai'Sa, but we also have a lot of other
legends as well. We see the Master Yi,
we see the Ireelia down there in Nine,
Azir, Set Jinx, all still live as well.
Uh the Jinx, Ryan on that Jinx is one
that I think is incredibly surprising
because going into this uh I think
people expected the domain combination
of Fury and Chaos to do well, but I
don't think that many folks have
respected Jinx as an actual contender.
>> I had a I know a recent game in the
standings in the tournament as well.
It's a very good Draven player in IicO
and uh Rift Mount T you may know as the
best of Garen the Garen guy as it were
has taken off the trading weights per
his own admission and is doing very well
on master yet X and one looking to
qualify uh get in the top 64 something
he hasn't been able to do yet and turns
out good KO players pretty good so when
Garen goes away the results still stay
in fact they get even better because uh
now you're potentially live for top
eight still at X and one
>> yeah but you do kind of lose a little
bit of that loa that's true
>> yeah the the spin to win, as I like to
say. I love playing some Garen. But what
do you think is going to be our top
eight? We just saw all of the the, you
know, players that are in that
contention, right? Do you think that it
will play out and we'll see uh all of
those Dravens hang out or do you think
that we're going to still see that
diversity?
>> I think the Dravens are going to like
eat each other basically. Like there's
so many Dravens at the top of the field
that at some point you're going to
parent another Draven and those Dravens
are going to get knocked out of
contention. So, I think just naturally
based on how like it get how it works.
The pairing is more likely to hit you
into another Draven with the same
record. Therefore, all those Dravens
can't make it. Therefore, some of the
Dravens are going to there's only one
undefeated Draven player. They don't
even have the best records of the
undefeated. They have the third third
best record only so far in the field,
which is still pretty good. So, I think
there will be some Draven. I don't think
it will be more than two is maybe my
take.
>> Interesting.
>> Uh I think in general, we're going to
get a decent amount of diversity. I'm
actually a bit worried about Aurelia's
representation. She was very good in
liil. Aelia seems to always sneak
through into the top eight, but at least
in North America, if you go cast your
mind back to Vegas, there was only one
and it did not make it out of the first
round. So, uh it's funny that you
mentioned that you think prismaticism
might win as a player, but might win as
a legend. I think as a legend may be in
a bit of danger, but prismaticism as a
player certainly not. And with that, we
are going to take a look at our deck
list. Starting with Aurelia. We got her
back on stream. It is Arya at XN1. And
this list is looking okay. There's a
back alley bar. We already have to start
chat. Yeah. Bing.
>> Yeah. So, this is a version of Aurelia.
I had the pleasure of talking to some uh
players while I was on break. Uh I
believe this is somebody that is part of
the team that is here. They are all on
Aurelia. Many of them are doing well.
Made day two. Uh they are running this
sneaky deck hand and this one main deck
adapteratron as well as tech
specifically for the field. Uh the
person I talked to also said that the
sneaky deckhand tech is specifically for
when they are on uh the draw as they say
when you are going second and you have
the three runes. uh you want to get the
deck hand onto Taran's peak because that
will allow you to also immediately ready
the runes, have those backup energy uh
available for the pumps like on guard
like discipline. So the Decan not only
gets that initial point but likely the
hold point that keeps them on even
points. They specifically called that
out the importance of staying on even
points and then they kind of like ride
that momentum forward. Uh the adaptatron
obviously tech for potentially the Azir
and some of the unknown things. Uh so
this is something where I think that
they properly identified what they
needed to do to have uh a good game one
and then still go into that sideboard
and and adjust accordingly.
>> All right. Well, our next player is
playing Azir, another deck we expect to
be pretty hot as far as contention goes
and uh having a quick peek. This is
looking like a very good but standard
Azir list.
>> Yeah, I'm not seeing anything that
really jumps out to me as uh out of the
ordinary. Uh, again, one main deck
salvage, kind of a staple at this point,
but very similar in thought to what the
adapter does. You kind of want some sort
of gear answer or gear removal in the
main deck. It's particularly good in
Azir because even in a pinch if you need
to uh if you really have to dig, you can
get rid of one of your own pieces of
gear. But, uh, as Spirit Forged has
shown us, there are just so many targets
that you need an answer for. I'm pretty
confident that is an exact main deck of
the best of deck for
>> It does look It does look
>> I've looked at that list quite a few
times. It's looking very familiar, but
uh with good reason. That's a very very
good list. Was good enough to take down
the RQ in Liil. So uh we can get
ourselves in the game in a moment when
we're ready. Char. This matchup is this
matchup's interesting. Yeah, I think
it's going to be very interesting
because there's
not a lot of new tech that you can
really throw into these matchups, I
would say, from a theoretical
standpoint. But again, the fact that uh
these Ireelia players took this
particular build with the main deck
adaptron and with the main deck sneakys
to try to get some additional early
tempo. I think that might be a
difference maker here.
>> Yeah, we'll have to find our game is
ready. Let's head on down to the feature
match area. We are getting to the pointy
end of the Swiss as it were. Ooh, little
win rate action. Aelia versus Z match up
at Lil 54% for Aurelia. Have to assume
that is Z though in Atlanta 39%. So that
is a big drop.
>> Yeah. And I think that might speak in
part to the fact that the Azir that
performed well in Le has now kind of
publicly laid the groundwork for how to
pilot and how to build this deck. And I
think players took that built on the
shoulders of giants as they say and they
are now pushing that forward and seeing
those results.
>> We'll have to see here. It's Arya on the
left on Aurelia and Warro on the right
playing Azia Emperor of Sans looks it
looks like it is going to be peak to
kick things off here for first
Battlefield and Hall of Legends. I would
say the most powerful battlefield in
Azia's arsenal. In fact, I'd say for
both these decks, these are the
battlefields that they are quote unquote
best on or at least best set up to
utilize.
Yeah. And again, we're going to be
paying close attention to uh the opening
turns here because Azir wants to be fast
out of the gate. Ideally, uh one of
those one energy gear openers into the
sand soldier on the other side. There is
an early unit. So, Arya does have the
lonely porro.
>> Yeah, not that many in the system. I
think it is just porro on two as a two
drop. I have to refer.
>> I believe there were deserts call which
is a pseudo
>> desert score tricking me. It's funny
I've talked about this card so many
times over course speaking about this is
so good all the comics are playing it.
It's a two drop and a four drop.
Everyone loves it and yeah kind of
remember when it is relevant here as
sand solders will be made on either side
but lonely power going to take the first
point as a collects the tigan's peak.
That's going to mean going to mean two
runes get ready at the end of the turn
as uh Azir opens with a classic eye of
the Herald into activate Sanchel for a
uh two might unit that also has a little
bit of bonus and Stellorn Herder being
the followup. Feels like Aurelia is off
to a real good start here.
>> Yeah, this is almost ideal starts for
both players. Porro into Stellicorn is a
phenomenal beginner uh excuse me
beginning start for Arya. Arya is far
from a beginner. Uh, but on the other
side, I in the Aurelia matchup in
particular is great because all of the
additional recruit tokens that get
generated throughout the course of the
game are good in this matchup with no
Bellow's breath to worry about. Uh, none
of those multi-target removal options.
So, you kind of have to defeat all of
those recruit tokens over time. And
because Azir plays so many pieces of
gear, the recruit tokens can also equip
things in a pinch and it becomes uh kind
of hard to get over top of them if the
game drags on.
>> Yeah, I have kind of a fun one. Doesn't
give you any might naturally, but does
make a recruit uh sorry when I move
plays a recruit token there. So actually
that token is going to follow. It's kind
of like having plus one might. But if
you keep moving and I can maintain those
tokens or maintain that eye, you can
generate quite a pretty big pretty wide
board in short order as discipline
thanks to Targon's peak going to be the
answer here to try and win this combat
on the Aelia side. And the card draw
does go through. War is considering the
rest of his options and loses the
combat. That feels real bad for Azir.
>> Yeah, and that's exactly why these
Aurelia players are running targets peak
as I pointed out. You want to get on it
early, hold up those additional runes to
have the energy to pay for those buff
spells. Uh, discipline perfect because
it also replaces itself with that draw
effect and wins the combat. So, not only
does the lonely porro stick around, the
hidden card is also still there. Uh,
again, great start for Arya right now.
Aurreelia can sometimes struggle with
the early points, but uh, it's not
updated yet, but should be going to two
here after the hold.
>> Yep. And three after this conquer. Hold
of legends going to be the play. You
could get a could get an extra ready on
this Aurelia if you really wanted to,
but uh not necessary as Aelia has not
been as legend at least has not been
exhausted yet. But her very fearsome
ability as Zas is going to be the play
that moves over just chucks it in the
base, moves the parro back to protect
the Stellon Herder. I was going to have
to talk about sequencing, but I just
making it not matter. Basically moving
the hourglass back at three points to
protect her most precious unit, which is
of course that Stellorn Herder.
Yeah, that's a very heads up play. You
don't want to leave that porro on an
island and have somebody go in there and
force trigger the zas. Also, the porro
is something that you actively want to
leave the battlefield most of the time.
Uh unless you're ready for it to die and
get that draw, but with the zonas, it's
a a Oh, we're going to tide turner as
well. So perhaps we might see Warro try
to take advantage of that and force
break that ZAS on the tide turner.
>> Oh, we have another one. We have a G.
All right.
>> So I guess in order to move the pearl
off, you obviously have to flip over
your hourglass or lose it and having it
in play feels better than not having it
in play. But uh using the titer there
basically is a a two might unit that
draws you a card thinking getting
another move. So I don't mind. I think
protecting this teleorn does make sense
here. Position feels pretty good. you're
up three points to zero. So going to
have to force War to get a little bit
more work done. And mercifully that BF
sword thanks to going second was
actually on curve to make a sand soldier
as well. So it's been exactly what Azir
wants so far this game. Apart from maybe
winning more combats, playing in
equipment and making a sand soldier
every single turn using all of the
resources. It's sacred shear is going to
come into play.
>> Yeah. And another reason I think I
really like that tie turner play. The
more I think about it, the hand as she
tipped it forward, Arya has uh some more
equipment. I think it's a little light
on the kind of interactivity that you
prefer with Ireelia. So getting the
additional move just to dig further and
get out of this kind of clunky spot
makes an awful lot of sense.
>> You see catching the zonies there knew
exactly what was going to happen. Moves
in, gets the conquer and breaks the
hourglass.
>> So it doesn't mean tide turner sticks
around but that's a two might unit
>> getting resed back to life or at least
getting protected in that stasis as yet
another bit of kit. As we already
noticed, the sacred cheers came in.
Means Azia can activate. And uh Hall of
Legends did not get you less this turn
if I recall correctly. Going to hold up
two runes instead. And
>> yeah, and that's the sort of thing that
you kind of want to keep an eye on if
you're Arya because that means you are
signaling
that two energy is being saved for
something. Is it a discipline? Is it a
pair of defies? Uh is it an ong guard
and a defy? Uh I don't believe on guard
is traditionally ran in Azir. So uh if
you're basing it off the best of list in
your area, you're not really thinking
that. But
>> there are two in this list at least.
>> I was just going to say there are Celon
going to move back over to the peak.
Notably the target streak also requires
you to conquer the battlefield in order
to actually get its effect. So the hold
was nice cuz you got some extra points,
but you don't actually get the effect
again until you reconquer it. So moving
the poro off of that battlefield has a
little bit of bonus uh incentive there
as well as I going to go up to four
points one on Azia's side which isn't
too bad as boots of swiftness usually a
signal that Aelia is about to do
something very silly but I think in this
case just a uh a bit of pre-planning for
the future. Nope, never mind. Someone's
getting suited up. It's the Stellorn.
Yeah, I was going to say boots with
Stellorn is typically the play for
Aurelia because it's allowing you to
continue to draw cards. Uh the other
thing I want to note is that Arya still
has Aurelia in the champion zone. Uh
this Stellicorn right now is now the
unit for Raro to deal with. And after
everything is expended on the Azir side
to maybe ultimately get it off the board
in one way or another, which will be
difficult because of the guardians, uh
the additional might because of the
boots. Uh but then you'll likely have to
turn around and deal with the Aurelia.
So, uh we're going to see a death grasp.
>> Yeah, death grip. But which unit is
getting felt here? Are we trying to win
the combat or are we trying to just get
a little bit of value?
I assume we're trying to win the combat,
>> but there's not that much might. I think
she is plus one, so three is the most
might you can add. I guess now checking
for it to fight.
>> I actually think they're discussing when
choices have to get made for death.
>> I think you just have to pick the
friendly unit you're taking out. I don't
think you have to pick the target, but I
could be wrong.
Yeah, that's
I believe something where you actually
do have to pick the targets both, but I
do think that that's what they are
verifying.
>> Well, there's a defy. I did spot it in
the hand. So, it seems to be a pretty
good spot to commit it. Bar test for the
spell. Permission is not granted and
Santor is going to lose the combat.
It'll be yet another point there for
Aurelia. And Stellin's not as big as
Aurelia. We can say that's that's pretty
obvious. But uh it is maybe more
threatening in a way as as it moves
around it just draws so many cards. If
you can make it big enough, right, by
using your pump spells, protecting it,
using your equipment, um it's again not
as fearsome in combat, but very very
annoying.
>> It is, I would argue, perhaps more
important. It is the engine of these
Aurelia lists. Obviously, Aurelia is
incredible and you have access to it
every game because it comes from the
champ zone. Uh, if anything, I would say
that Stellicorn Herder was designed in
part as a bit of a nerf by not being a
champion so that you can't champ Zona or
else it would be absolutely absurd. It
does so much for calm because otherwise
the only access to card draw that this
list really has uh would be cards like
stack deck or anything that is uh
considered a replacement effect like
discipline. But Stellicorn Herder gives
you additional cards for doing things
you were already doing with this list.
>> Yeah, it makes your moves that much
better. And you can see why a bunch of
resources got invested into moving this
Silicon around to get up to five points.
Draw a bunch of cards. Silicon does have
a G also attached as one of the pieces
of equipment. So unless that one of
salvage in the main is lurking around
even if teleon loses the next combat
which seems like seems likely given how
much might these sand soldiers are
wielding. Uh still going to be a threat
that has to be dealt with later as we
moving with the sand soldier. It's big
enough to break the G and everyone's
going to be happy enough with that
exchange as the units trade off.
>> A recall is not right.
>> Yeah and I you just picked that up on
the microphone but I was going to
clarify that as well for home. Uh the
recall when your unit is saved from a
guardian angel is not a move effect. So
there will not be a draw triggered on
the Stellaricorn from that interaction.
>> Yeah, the funny thing is on a bunch of
the cards that do recall, it actually
says that. But uh didn't have enough
room in the text box of GA cuz it's
right down the bottom to be able to say
that. But yeah, uh it is not a move as
is explicitly stated on many cards. I
think sets legend is probably the best
example of this where it explains the
whole thing in very great detail. But uh
Doran shield going to be the play. Sand
soldier going to get made and Waro
trying to fight back from a very big
points deficit this game. There is still
uh that Eye of the Herald equipped Sand
Soldier can go to the peak which will
mean some runes can get readyed but
perhaps Hall of Legends looking to maybe
make another sand soldier decides
against it. We'll take the points
instead, make a recruit and uh you know
claw their way back into this game. But
Aelia in a pretty commanding position
despite being a little low on runes.
That's kind of been the trade-off of all
this card draw.
>> Yeah. And I think that's a sacrifice
that are willing to make every day of
the week.
>> Uh just in a normal game, but
specifically in this Azir game because
we know that Azir can pile on the points
if it's left unchecked. Again, there's
still a lot of might available on
Warro's side. Yes, War is behind on
points, but that's mostly because Arya
has had the right cards to win combat at
the right time. Warro still has this
army of sand soldiers and they all have
the best outfits they can buy. They are
stacked with equipment and so I think
Arya kind of understands that uh she
needs to get one more point and then
likely look to go from six to eight on a
double conquer turn because of those
boots of sweat.
>> Yeah, I was actually just going to make
say the same thing. Unfortunately with
Hall of Legends being left open uh no
real no other units to to ready in
there. Azir obviously playing the sand
sword was exhausted. Does not get to
ready them unless you do something like
Arise which is good fun. But yeah uh six
getting two points feels uh not trivial
but quite straightforward for Aurelia
specifically. So my guess given the
point leaders I is going to move
probably lonely poro into this whole of
legends cuz at least if it goes down you
get a card draw you are going to force
your opponent to do something about it.
Instead decides the stellicorn is the
move because drawing cards is everyone's
favorite thing to do mine included. But
at six points now, I think you can look
to develop this Aurelia, take a turn,
maybe even two off given the point lead
you have. And at some point, Aurelia
with boots of swiftness is just
unstoppable on most board states.
>> Yeah, I was just going to say there
might not be an Aurelia here because the
hand when I was taking a look at it from
Arya. There is finally some interaction
picked up, but I did notice there was
this second boots of swiftness.
You've got the two lonely porros. There
is still the ability for Arya to cascade
the equipment around if she wants to.
Again, we're used to seeing that from
the Azir side of the table, but perhaps
Arya says that I've got the best kicks
in the place and I'm going to use them
to walk from battlefield to battlefield.
>> Yes. So, if you're wondering about how
that specifically works, uh equipment
obviously can't be moved unless uh well,
unless you're weapon master, unless
something intervenes, right? Weapon
master. Generally, once you attach it to
a unit, it stays attached until the unit
goes away. But it does give might and
it's kind of might that stays on the
board you know semi-permanently we can
say. So if lonely parro gets one pair of
boots gets another pair of boots which
only costs power not energy to equip at
least then that power is going to get
big up to six that power can run in
trade off with a bunch of units fall to
the ground draw you a card but then you
have another power that can be suited up
and run in. So I do like that play just
kind of leaving these innocuous ready
units at the ready to maybe try and run
in for the double conquer here.
And it is also potentially baiting WO to
go in to try to get rid of the
Stellicorn. We know that's a premier
target. Uh War is starting that action
right now. But if Arya still has some
interaction available and can reduce
some of the might on the other side of
the board through this combat, it'll
make the uh potential retake stuff next
turn. Or there's just flash.
>> Yeah, there you know the one on Flash is
probably the best answer in that
situation. saving up to two friendly
units from base at least moving them uh
moving them to base. Very very nice.
Draws a card of course in the process as
well thanks to Stilicorn's text and uh
protecting the the prince we didn't
necessarily expect in this deck. Aurelia
perhaps not necessary as a card gets
hidden that is almost assuredly hidden
blade although I guess it could be a
guards is the other option Aziz have
access to at least in the main typically
but Ari just saying I kind of got my
lead. I'm feeling good about my card
draw engine. I'm feeling good about
this. Celicorn being big enough to get
the job done. The question is we can if
we can conquer twice, we can win here.
Does Ya have the tricks to take game one
here? Well, I know in hand earlier I saw
not so fast. I believe the draw for this
turn was also a Defia. And if it wasn't
the draw, I know it's there. It was at
the top part of the hand. So, the
counter spells are there. You have to
assume if you see a faceown card against
an order opponent, it's probably hidden
blade. So Arya does rightfully have a
couple of different answers for that. Uh
the other piece of the puzzle here is of
course just the might check, right? As I
said before, yes, Warro was down on
points, but there was still surprisingly
a large number of might on the other
side because the tokens plus the weapons
just add up over time.
>> So it's six on the bottom battlefield
with the BF sword soldier and the
recruit. And it is 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 I
believe on the top. So Stellon going to
get suited up one more time. At least
finally finally has a shoe for each
foot. Very important
>> and uh does have a rebuke in hand as
well as a card I spied. So move on in
here first and uh tempt that hidden
blade. And at seven that's three plus
the four thanks to the two boots that
Silicon is now wearing. Card draw is
going to happen for moving in and uh
seven is greater than six. So discipline
going to try and change the math on that
one. And defy is immediately played from
hand. Yeah. And this is also the right
call here because even though the defy
could also target a potential hidden
blade, you do also still have the not so
fast for the targeted. This face breaker
though coming from Warro will also
demand an answer. And so if that is also
still a hidden blade underneath, that
could be enough. I only remember two
counter spells available.
>> Defy defy not so fast still available.
also actually had two defies here to I
think deal with all of the interaction
that's going to come through. So that
face breaker is going to get defied. War
we assume has no answer in hand and now
going to have to use the hidden blade.
It is hidden blade. It could have been
face breaker. I realized that's another
card that does have hidden on it but uh
lets it go. Oh, no more power. That's
why couldn't afford the not so fast.
There's no calm runes left.
>> Yeah. So there was, as you had pointed
out, the third counter spell. I'd missed
the second defy. But uh only two calm
runes. So doesn't matter if you have 10,
you can only pay for two. Something that
calm definitely can suffer from at
times. A very powerhungry domain. Uses a
lot of power for their, you know,
understandably pretty good effects.
Things like their defies and they're not
so fast. So Stellacorn does not break
that battlefield. There's still uh some
options to move in with the rest of the
units as well. Although discipline worth
remembering is still oh no got counted
never mind. So the might is actually
still as it's still six on that bottom
battlefield but certainly means that I
don't think anything's happening in the
top side anytime soon.
>> No I don't think that you can break
through the top side unless you decide
to commit absolutely everything
>> and number the method they're checking
out right now I guess. Oh I see. Put
both boots on. put both boots on one
unit and send all three units.
>> That would be 10 total. There's a
basically five twos on the board right
now.
>> Yeah. Right. The problem with that is if
your opponent continues to have even
more answers. There is still two energy
available for Warro, you could just lose
the game on the spot by getting blown
out twice in one turn. So, this might be
the situation where Arya says, you know,
I had that early point lead for a
reason. Let's reset, find some
additional answers with the stack deck,
get myself in a position to take another
shot next turn. Uh, or we could just
rebuke the sand soldier that has the BF
sword.
>> Yep. And move in with the two. So, it's
only recruit down on that bottom side.
This won't win, by the way. Just as a
reminder, it is uh only the seventh
point, but it will retake the peak,
which I guess has a little bit of extra
value.
>> It retakes the peak. Uh the thing with
rebuke that you have to remember is that
normally it is a tempo play. It is kind
of a a temporary answer, but with
tokens, it does just permanently get rid
of them. They do not go to your hand.
They just dissolve into thin air.
>> The BF sword does stick around, which is
the BF sword does. news. Uh, bad news I
suppose for Aya cuz that sand soldier is
looking to get suited up and run back
into the battlefield and Lonely Porro
might need some buddies cuz it seems
like with only two runes left cuz again
the the big thing that happened here is
Arya had to recycle a lot of her
resources to get to this point kind of
going not all necessarily on the Stella
corn but committing a lot to try and
keep it alive and and conquer this
bottom battlefield. But I think that
means that breaking the top side not
happening anytime soon. And even though
the points are are still pretty far
apart, three points ahead feels like a
good buffer. I don't know if it's enough
to to rebuild and develop for enough
turns to try and conquer twice. So, are
we playing for hold here potentially?
>> Uh, that could be an option, but I just
spied. And yeah, she's going to go for
it. I think I was about to say I spy a
defiant dance.
>> Does the math check out? This is
basically plus four plus two for me,
minus two for you. So, for uh for one
energy and one power, that's pretty
good.
>> Well, it's going to only end up, I
think, being a
>> uh minus one. Yeah, because of the sand
soldier.
>> Sand soldier not big enough. Although,
is it the one holding the Doran shield?
Cuz I think that gives plus one as well.
>> No, the shield is just tank and
>> Oh, so it's actually only eight might
then. I did the math wrong.
>> Yeah. So, Aparo is a four
>> versus what should be now seven
>> if I recall correctly.
>> Yeah,
>> I was just about to say this actually
should be a minus two because uh this is
a card that doesn't say to a minimum of
one.
>> It can go to zero. And so I think Warro
properly let her know that that should
be the case. But I was also about to
call out, I like the heads up play from
RA here by putting the minus two on the
tank knowing you have to go over that
anyway. You might as well allow yourself
to get that out of the equation and then
assign the rest of the damage however
you need.
>> I think scuttle crab has done
irreparable damage to my understanding
of riftbound because now that you now
that I realize oh zero might does not
mean you are uh unal alived still there
until you take damage. Zero might is
still good enough to hang out. So Divine
Dance is one of the effects that does
not say as you mentioned to a minimum of
one. One of the reasons it's a even
better card. One of the one of the
reasons to play Aurelia, if not the
reason is how powerful the signature
spell is. This is not quite enough to
get the job done, but it does clear
quite a lot of the way. And I think if
Tide Turner suits up the boots, we might
be running in for a W. Unless War has
something to say about
>> I was just about to say that attacker
wouldn't be enough. But if we see the
allin here from Arya saying I don't need
runes, it's today or it's never. This
tide turner could be swiftly approaching
that battlefield.
>> D shield does say plus one by the way.
>> Oh, it does.
>> Yep.
>> Production pull up D shield.
>> Yeah,
>> it is still tank though. That much I
remember.
>> Yeah, it is definitely tank. And here
comes Titaning with the boots. What do
we have left? We have nothing. We have
game number two. That is a very sweet
victory there. Ara recycles all of her
runes and that is enough to win the
game. No Aurelia necessary. And I did
the math as I go and I went in like,
"Oh, wait."
>> That was very impressive for Arya. I
really appreciated the way that she
navigated the early game to get a big
points lead. And then again, properly
identified, I need to get to six so I
can set up the double conquer. Knew what
the macro game plan was, executed it
beautifully, and really took advantage
of that targets peak in the early
stages. Like we had talked about ahead
of time, the goal is to get there, have
those runes up for some of those buff
options. And now we see back alley bar,
which when you're doing as much movement
as we saw in that first game, could be
very relevant in game two.
>> Yeah, looks real good here. So does
seated power honestly for both players.
I think a little bit better for Azir
because of how wide this deck can go.
And it is Dor and Shield into sand
soldier. A classic opening for Azerius.
Basically any one cost equipment into a
sand soldier for this in this case a
three might unit on the very first turn
of the game. Stack deck though is going
to be uh filtering a couple cards. Put
one extra in the hand. And what is the
two drop of choice? There's a couple
here to play with. It is going to be
Tide Turner.
Tide Turner again just trying to get
that early presence on the board for
Arya. very clearly
these are Ireelia players that have the
emphasis on making sure that you're not
having to come from behind. Now, we have
seen that and we know that that is
definitely a viable strategy for Ireelia
players to maybe kind of give up the
early tempo and then utilize the
incredibly large Ireelia to get back
into the game and lock your opponent
out. However, it feels like this version
of the list is instead trying to
capitalize on the mobility, score those
early points and then get wherever you
can. However, that charm is going to
slow things down.
>> Very aggressive use of that card, but I
think relatively warranted again. Azir,
especially going first is a deck that
wants to get ahead and stay ahead. Aelia
going to be to play this time. Did not
see her at all in the last game. Finally
making appearance here. Uh going second,
getting the extra rune channel means it
is a viable turn to play. Not only is it
a viable turn two play, but again, I
think that this is Arya recognizing,
okay, I was trying to keep pace on
points. Worked very well game one. Warro
had the charm and is going to jump to
two before me. So now you have to
transition into what we were just
talking about, which is that play from
behind strategy with a turbo Aurelia. So
the faster you can get it out, the
better. I think the nice thing is here
like players have been quite scared of
doing this in some matchups but Azir
specifically what does Azir have that
deals with the backline Aurelia like
>> do they play that many calls
>> it could come in from the boards we
don't know the side boards are and it is
an Aurelia right so
>> that would have been my only concern
>> that's true no that's true there is cult
but I think a calculated gamble we can
say we already saw a charm that is
another way to do it but not enough
presence at a battlefield to be able to
get that done so uh I don't mind the
risk and I think it is going to pay off
here as Aurelia does make it through.
Stack deck now going to get used and
Aurelia already getting plus one might
thanks to readying this turn. And uh we
don't see it too often, but if there's
one unit that's going to make very good
use of the back alley bar, it is
Aurelia.
>> Yeah, Aurelia is going to hopefully get
a bunch of might from obviously being
chosen from readying, but then also from
that back alley bar with the moving as
well. And we get this first point. I
like that.
>> Yeah, I was going to say
>> is this boots reinforce ready move draw
a card.
>> That would be hype
>> cuz you can leave a unit at the seed of
power and then move over.
>> Uh I was going to say I don't think that
we'll see the reinforce simply because
uh if reinforce was the option you would
likely start at back alley and then go
to seat because then you would draw a
card having presence at both. But
because you're not reinforcing
>> and you're likely to go home anyway, uh
going in this direction, I think makes
more sense.
>> No, you're right. Sorry, I in my head I
was like, "Oh, I want to draw a card
here." So, I was trying to find a way
and there was a way. Uh had to do the
reverse of what I said and do what
Chararma said, which is pretty good
advice for anyone listening at home.
Generally, listen to what Chararma says.
And I don't know, enjoy what I'm saying,
I suppose, as Aurelia does get two
points on the board. This is kind of the
uh the plan. and get the Aurelia out
early and try and catch back up on
points as things have been evened up two
to two. There is still the question of
uh quite a formidable bit of might. It's
five on the top side there that uh that
first centur with the BF sword and three
for a total of eight. And Aurelia again
a unit that can get awfully big awfully
quick. Only a six right now. Although a
single pump spell is going to change the
difference. I think the thing about
Aurelia, I mean already on guard
discipline, divine dances are already
great cards as we saw in the last game,
but Aurelia can basically treat all the
spells like they have plus one extra
might to give her thanks to her ability.
>> Absolutely. And on top of that, you
could potentially worry about something
where if you send too much in that
direction, perhaps it's a surprise ride
the win back in the other direction and
then she scores an additional point on
your turn and kind of recaptures the
pace. So, uh, I think Warro is realizing
I would like to avoid that Ireelia and
still score some points and heads over
to the sea. Yeah, I think generally when
you're looking to pick a fight with
Aurelia, you have to do it carefully.
>> Oh, I like this though. Accelerate the
Azir, bring the sand soldiers over. You
do get to move them in and the emperor
has summoned up his soldiers and is
rampaging into backlo. This would be a
great time to have that flash by the
way.
>> Yes, a flash, a ride the wind, anything
like that to save it would be
incredible. I think I see a rebuke here.
>> See rebuke and defiant dance. And if uh
there's one thing you don't want to see
when you're tussling with Nella, it is
Defiant Dance. That card is so good.
>> That's the looks like the D just
representing the uh might increases that
the equipment give. I asking them to
remove them cuz I mean it's printed on
the card as well even though currently
the sand soldiers are covering them.
Yeah, I think that the judge was trying
to make sure that the the bonuses were
represented, but I think Arya would
prefer that that only be for temporary
effects as the reminder. Uh, and
rightfully so. I think that it's fair
and clear to just as you pointed out,
have the printed value be there. Uh,
Defiant Dance, as you had pointed out,
is going to be the play basically plus
five as far as the might trade goes.
Minus two for you, plus three for me.
Defy going to be the play here on the
other side. Does I have an answer?
tapping a rune, that usually means
something's up. War does have another
rune available. So, if it is Defy on
Defy, it's going to be the player with
the uh the most number of those is going
to come out on top. So, here's the
second one. Defy back and that's it. War
does not have the uh
presumably does not have the answer
here. So, there's more that could be had
here. But, is Aurelia winning the fight
currently? I'm trying to figure it out.
Well, I think that might have been what
the hesitation was because now Arya
doesn't have that rebuke as a a backup.
>> So, I think the hope is
>> I was going to say that it survives, but
>> it's nine on the earlier side right now.
And uh 2 3 4 5
>> and there's the on guard.
>> Ong guard gets it over.
>> Yeah, it was it was 10. Sorry, my brain
was like really focusing on doing some
math. It was 10. So, going to nine
wasn't quite enough. on guard certainly
is. That's plus three just for one when
uh you're when you're alone. So that is
certainly enough there. 3 + 9 is 12. So
now 12 plays 10 after all is said and
done. And again putting it back over
there, seeing if you have to defy and
the answer is no. So all of a units go
crashing down. A is going to get the
whole point when the turn passes back.
And that is a pivotal moment in this
game. That is that is a huge exchange
and Arya had exactly the tools needed to
get through it because uh again I think
the game plan involved the rebuke just
cuz it's a little bit safer. It only
gets stopped by not so fast. It can't be
defied. But the moment that Warro had
the defy for the defiant dance, she had
to commit hers which means ong guard had
to be committed. If it was not all of
those pieces on her side, I think that
Warro ends up winning that exchange. And
then things start to get dire because
not only does he have the point lead at
that position, but she would have no
presence on the board as well.
>> Certainly rough stuff here as uh two
runes are exhausted. Guardian Angel is
the play. Recycle the final calm rune
and put it on Aurelia. And is she going
to stay there at that battlefield? Looks
like she is
going to pass it on back. But Az with no
soldiers, unless you have something like
Arise, it can be tough to make a play
proactively. Certainly with your chosen
champion also in your trash. Not a lot
of accelerated or readied options
available for
>> Azir. I think I do see the Arise there.
So now the math becomes uh if I play
Arise and I send both units in, can I
pick off the Ireelia?
>> I don't think that that is necessarily
wise. There is three energy up on the
side of Arya. Perhaps you say, "Hey, I
just saw a bunch of cool tools used.
Maybe she's starting to run out." But
you still have to worry about things
like discipline. Uh the other concern
with taking that route is that the
guardian angel means that you might win
the combat, but ultimately you're just
moving her back. Uh you're going to have
to go ahead and do it again anyway. So
uh I think that this is the right call.
War instead plays guards.
>> Yeah, it would have been two Sanders
that could also be readied and equipped.
That would have been eight knight
playing seven, but as you mentioned,
Aurelia's numbers often lie on their
face value. uh cuz whenever she has a
pump they just get that much better.
Guards also does bring a readyed sand
soldier. That is another way for Azir to
get a unit active early without having
to wait a turn. The discipline for plus
two that's four plus to three is seven.
So currently we're trading with Aurelia
if nothing else happens.
>> Yeah. And there is still that Doran
shield that uh I learned today has plus
one.
Uh I was confusing it with Warmogs in my
head. That was the problem. the one that
adds a buff on uh the conqueror. But
>> moving on in,
>> we do see the shield attached and it is
headed in. 8 plus 7 rebuke. Oh,
discipline. That's even better.
>> Like I said, it's the uh discipline that
I'd called out before is likely what
you're worried about. Uh this could be a
situation where did top deck a defy.
Obviously didn't have two Defies last
turn, but if there was a top deck here
could be an issue.
Plus one for Aurelia. That's being
represented by that die. Plus two
overall ready as well for an extra plus
one. Cute little trick that Aurelia can
do from time to time. Wanted to make
sure she maximizes her might because
you're getting face broken which means
uh nothing's going to happen except
Santor is going to have to go home.
>> Yeah. But it does save the unit.
>> Mhm.
>> Pretty uh valuable one as well. Fairly
big seven at base.
>> It's a big seven, but it's also another
unit that will be readied next turn. uh
as you had pointed out not a lot of
sources of accelerate in Azir once the
chosen champion is gone outside of Arise
uh or guards and you just used a guards
your chosen champion is gone
I have a hard bargain cuz I'm looking at
four runes I'm looking at two about to
be turned I'm looking at an Aellia
player about to win two zero if she can
hold this battlefield and go score the
other one and if I'm flipping over to
six and I'm a zero I'm just looking to
play a rise and the only thing that
stops me in this spot is hard bargain
cuz I cannot pay
>> I I mean, we are in game two. Perhaps
there was a dip into like a one of wind
wall in the the sideboard.
>> Okay, that's true.
>> I don't think that's the case, but that
would be another thing. I I do see a
defy and I think it's actually an
adapted Tron that's there.
>> Could not see what the third card was.
>> Wonder if it's what what I was thinking.
It's just like if I play this rise, I
mean, if plays the rising gets
countered, the game's over. We've
already kind of Well, that's is that
actually true? Sans could still try and
do the thing it wanted to do last turn
and try and trade again.
Does feel bad because it kind of feels
like you're playing not to lose rather
than trying to play to win because
you're just so far behind cuz Aelia has
lived for so many turns.
>> I see Arise.
>> And all right,
>> here we go. What do you got?
>> Arise, tell the people what you have
seen today. I've seen Aurelia versus
Azir and I' seen a lot of great matches
of roofbound.
So, it's been a good day. It's been a
good day for you, boy. There's two more
Santos. They are ready. And joining the
one that was uh in the little face
breaker
situation in at the seat of power means
that we have enough might to try and
challenge us. So, what's left as far as
pump spells go? We've seen quite a few
on side. Is it enough to win this combat
as well? And we're going to move them
all in. There we go. There we go. Move
them all in there.
I think there was a consideration of
hedging the bet, leaving one back for
cascading the equipment. GG Rebuke's
going to be enough to make it all
happen. Arya had the answer at every
single turn and hidden blades were
available, but afraid of a potential
counter and honestly removing the
Aurelia doesn't necessarily solve the
problem. And also there's a guardian
angel. So a tough spot for Waro to
navigate and 200 for Aurelia now X and
one still after round 11 of Swiss.
They're going to make top eight and
maybe prove to right that Aurelia could
be the legend that wins this regional
qualifier. Yeah, that was incredibly
well played by Arya. I think it
showcased well in game one what you can
do if you have the aggressive start and
in game two how you can pivot if you do
not have the opening that you desire.
What uh I think Warro actually did a
really good job in that second game of
trying to get back in it. You saw the
hidden blades. Not only does Ireelia
have the guardians, but then you'd also
give her more card draw as well. That's
a bad trade-off. Likely wanted to use
those on his own sand soldier tokens to
continue to draw, but because of the way
the combats were going, Arya was able to
keep Warro with very few units in that
second game. The first game, flood of
units, a wealth of units. Uh second one
uh quite the opposite story and
ultimately Arya used that to her
advantage and got a victory.
>> I think a really good example of how the
temptation when playing Aurelia is to
just build up the biggest hand, biggest
backlog, biggest arsenal that you can to
go in. But you don't need like all of
your pumps and all your counter spells
and 10 runes to win. You just need the
exact right amount. Figuring out what
the exact right amount should be, that's
the challenge of playing the deck. And a
clearly understanding all the different
lines, understanding how to push to the
limit to make sure she could eek out
just enough because you don't have to
win by 10, you just have to win by one.
And at and especially in the first game
when ran out of runes to win that first
game. Clearly understands the limits of
this deck.
>> Absolutely. You cannot take those runes
runes with you to game two. So you might
as well spend them all in every way,
shape, and form in that first game.
>> An impressive showcase of one of the
most represented legends in our RQ. Here
we're going to go down with an interview
with our winner.
>> Thanks so much for the pass. I'm joined
here with the winner of that incredible
match. One of the most decisive 20's
we've actually seen on the broadcast
across the entire weekend. Arya piloting
that incredible Ireelia list. And I've
got to ask you right at the back, your X
and one still moving in. Two rounds to
go. Why Ireelia? Because I think you
might currently be the highest seated
one right now. Yeah, it's it's really
funny. Coming into this event, I really
wanted to try and play a lesser played
le legend, maybe like go for a best
offguard, but me and my friends, I've
testing with a bunch of friends from
work. We just tried so many different
decks trying to find like a new best off
spin. We just could not find anything to
beat Aurelia. So, if you can't beat him,
join him.
>> Well, that kind of answers my question
then. I mean, uh X and one, which means
you've lost one match so far across the
two days. So, if you said nothing could
be Ireelia, you're not really afraid of
any matchups then, right?
>> Well, we weren't afraid of any matchups
before the tournament started. I think
now there's like a matchup or two we're
a little afraid of. I think Lucian is
the big one that we find kind of scary.
Uh they're just really good at like
Aurelia's really good at holding one of
the battlefields every turn, but you
can't really hold other battlefield hold
a second battlefield. And normally that
like shuts your opponent out of winning
the game if you can just rely really
reliably hold the battlefield in the
late game. But Lucian has a way of
scoring a eight point that's not
conquering both battlefields. And it's
really hard for Aelia to hold both
battlefields at the same time. So kind
of a problematic match up for Aelia.
Everything else I'm still pretty happy
with.
>> That makes a lot of sense. You better
look out cuz I know Sam D. Sherman, the
winner of Las Vegas, is still running
around with that Lucian deck that we got
to see on stream yesterday. So watch
out. But of course still doing
incredibly well. Only two rounds to go.
So trying to avoid those Lucian of
course already doing incredibly well.
And you've got other teammates I know,
working along as well, playing kind of a
similar deck as well.
>> Yeah, four of us are like on the exact
same list.
>> That's awesome. Well, I hope the success
is going to keep going well for you. Two
rounds left. X and ones currently. You
really are on your way to hopefully
taking home that best of Ireelia and
maybe even a top eight appearance. Arya,
thank you so much. Congratulations on
your win and we're going to pass it
back.
>> Thank you, Barrett. Always great to hear
from players much smarter than me and I
are certainly qualifying for that. I
mean to be fair, pretty much everyone we
had in the feature match can uh can hold
that uh flag high and wave it. But uh
really curious to hear her take on some
of the matchups I was thinking about.
Yeah, I in particular was not surprised
to be honest that she said Lucian is a
difficult matchup for Ireelia,
especially the way that team has the
list built because it's going to bank a
lot on Rebuke outside of Rebuke and
maybe the one main deck adaptatron. If
Lucian gets things going, the the
biggest issue is Ireelia has leaned
heavily on charm as their premier
removal because usually your Ireelia is
just bigger than other units. you charm
into it, you kind of get that free uh
pull from the backline, win in combat.
Against Lucian, it just makes their
stuff bigger. You charm them in and all
of that assault triggers from their
equipment. So, it ends up becoming a
problem. So, I'm not surprised that she
said Lucian uh is potentially a bad
matchup. The good news for her, however,
is that there's not many Lucian in the
field.
>> Yeah, Lucian uh having an okay day,
although we'll have to see at the end of
it how day two is really shaking out. I
think there's a couple last time we
checked that are live for a top eight at
least. But
>> yeah, Sam
>> Sam's still live. Yeah, makes sense.
Perhaps only there's the one loss we saw
the other day. We do have another
matchup on the way for you also. We'll
get to that as soon as we go. We had a
backup feature match. We have a game
three to bring you. And uh you like
doing math, Chararma been
>> historically uh I say in card games,
math is for blockers. I like to just
send it all and let them figure it out
if I got enough. That's uh how's it
going for you in your rebound comments?
>> Uh not very well of course. Uh it's also
in part because uh the the kind of work
that I do traditionally involves a lot
of math and by the time I get to my fun
time, which is playing Riftbound, uh I
don't want to do math anymore.
>> Yeah, that's very fair. Well, uh we
don't we have that coming up. But before
we get there, we are going to get some
extra postgame analysis from the desk.
>> It's okay, Charmer. I'm not a big fan of
math either, but we're going to learn
some basic math here today. And that's
just counting numbers cuz as the replay
we're going to look at is to show the
strength of Aurelia and what happens
when resources get out of control. So
everybody in chat, make sure to count
along ones, twos, whatever you can
because you might notice currently on
the field, we have the boss of Aurelia.
People will tell you Aurelia is the
actual main unit in this deck. Nah, that
ain't true. It is actually all about the
Stella corn. So, let's actually play
this out and we're just going to fast
forward and I want everyone to count
along with me to see how many resources
Stellacorn gets. So, let's start the
fast forward here because we're going to
count them out. Number one move is going
to happen, I believe, up to this
battlefield here. Let's just fast
forward it up. Oh, it went to the other
way, but that's fine. So, there's one
move. Keep it going. Keep it going.
There's two moves. Keep it going. Keep
it going. What's going to happen next?
Ready's goes in for a third. Over here
for a fourth. That's four draws so far.
And we're going to add up together.
Count with me, everybody. That's five.
And how many we're going to get by the
end? It readies up. It goes in for
another six. And it just keeps going
back for a seventh. And then it'll go
in. And finally, it will die at this
battlefield. But that is eight moves on
one stellar corn. That means eight draws
on one stellar corn. This unit, it gets
out of control real fast if you don't
have the ability to clear it. And Azir
uniquely doesn't have that many options
to deal with the silicorn outside of
maybe like a hidden blade which is in a
lot of Azir decks. Also then the uh
Aurelia has a lot of the green spells to
counter that. So that's our basic
arithmetic. Charmer, how'd I do? Was
that enough math for you?
>> Yes.
All right. Well, the answer to that is I
can't count to eight, but I can count to
two. When I I heard that Stellacicorn
ended up getting two extra starting
hands worth of cards.
>> That's what I can count to.
>> That's pretty good.
>> No, that seems like a ton of value. And
again, I kind of said earlier that as
much as Ireelia is a force to be
reckoned with, the real I think backbone
of the deck is Stellicorn Herder. Uh if
it could be a champion, I think every
Aurelia would play it in the champion
zone over the Ferven if they could.
>> I think the word you used uh in that in
that series actually was engine. I think
it's the best way to describe yourself.
It drives the deck forward. It keeps
your cards replenished. Make sure you
have interaction spells. Make sure you
have counter spells. Make sure you can
>> uh keep on pushing forward and uh making
things happen on combat cuz again,
Aurelia sometime sometimes the
battlefields get real big, real messy.
There's lots of it on there and you
would be maybe shocked or maybe not
depending on how much you've played with
or against at the kind of battlefields
you can crack open with just enough
spells. Speaking of big Battlefields
trauma, I did tease that we have a bit
more feature match to come and uh game
three is coming up shortly between uh I
don't know how people feel about this
deck. I'm I'm softening on it a little
bit, but we have a mirror match which I
think is our first mirror match on
stream. It is Chikas on the left versus
Ominous Milk who've seen on the stream
before. And do not let your eyes deceive
you. It is the master ye showdown. Yeah,
this is going to be two players on the
Wu Bladesman, of course, famously in
that proving grounds.
It is amazing how often that plus two on
defense comes into play. Uh players have
been abusing it since the game was
released because uh anytime you can find
additional, but not just additional,
consistent value, you want to take
advantage of it. And you don't have to
pay resources for it. you just have to
do the thing you already want to do. Uh
there is a bit of a deck building cost
as they say because you are focused on
just one unit at a time. You can't get
around some of those uh you know swarm
mechanics at times. But we see a lonely
porro to start things off
and lonely feels good. Really any two uh
two drop unit you can play feels pretty
good in Mi and going first feels pretty
significant in this game. And uh we're
going to go off to Star Tipped Peak,
which we're going to have to bring up to
have a little read cuz we do not see
this battlefield very often. If memory
serves, when I hold this channel one
rune exhausted, that is correct. And if
you're playing Master Y, you're already
planning on holding so you can get some
additional value there. Of course, we
see the biom layer on the other side.
And I like that Chica said, "Look, I
want you to either send your unit over
to the layer where it could potentially
be stuck for a while or come into my
lonely porro and spend extra cards to go
over the top and let me draw a card from
the death nail trigger." So, ominous
milk of course avoids that. Just
develops a second clockwork keeper.
>> Yeah, couple more units, but again, it's
kind of one at a time with Ye as the
game goes. So, both players happy.
deploying their early threats. But
again, kind of being the first to get
ahead on points has to feel pretty good
here in a very hold ccentric matchup. If
we're going to split the battlefields,
then uh if I get my hold point first,
I'm feeling pretty good. And Jas is
like, "Yep, I'm happy. Your turn again.
I'm already ahead." So the other reason
that Chica is happy is not only was it
the hold point, but because of the
battlefield, the additional rune channel
means that Chica could play the champion
unit as early as next turn and still
have additional resources to back it up
should that be the play. Uh on the other
side, we're going to see Ominous go with
a Trinity Force, put it on that
Clockwork Keeper over in the layer and
say, "Okay, I know you wanted to strand
me over here, but now I'm going to win
the race on the back of my equipment."
Now I'm going to have to remind myself
now cuz Master does enter ready and also
has ganking which is pretty sweet as J
champions go. Can you gank from Vile
Wars lair?
>> Yes.
>> Ah okay.
>> You cannot go back to base.
>> Okay. So Miy will break the layer which
feels pretty good. Also makes sense why
smoke might want to play it cuz it's
pretty annoying for a bunch of other
decks especially Aurelia who's uh as
we've seen showing up a lot. But there's
a charm moving one on over. No, I don't
think so. Defy into Defy into
>> Are we going to see a third? Oh, so the
charm is successful.
>> So, where are we charming? I guess we're
going over.
>> Yeah, it's got to be going over. I think
that the the play here because the
discipline was played first and you're
now the defender because of charm. Uh
should currently be a six versus a four,
but the ong guard is going to make it
six versus six currently.
>> You know what's really funny? Uh if uh
Chica started this whole thing, if he
doesn't have another buff, he does have
triple thonk I believe was what I saw in
hand. So it might just be like you know
what I don't like how this ended. I'm
just going to thunk you kick you back
out to base I believe would be how it
worked. But I also see a punch first to
get made here.
>> I also see that punch first which I
would imagine if you really wanted to
win this combat would get the job done.
>> So it's six to six just going to take
the trade. Trendy Force falls off, but
uh take the draw off the lonely porro.
Play stalwart porro and redeploy some
units.
>> Yeah, that stalwart porro is
unfortunately not a cat as we were
talking about earlier, but it is still a
very effective unit in Master Yi. Uh two
base might, but with the shield and the
Yei ability can just sit casually on a
location for five defending. Uh I think
Chicus was okay with that trade because
you get the draw off of the lonely
porro. You're denying the hold point
that Ominous Milk was trying to use to
go ahead and on top of that was able to
develop on the backline as well.
And with Ominous Milk scoring this point
will even things up, but again will not
allow Ominous Milk to go ahead uh in
this kind of hold versus hold matchup.
whoever is the point lead is driving the
pace of the game essentially because
they're making the other person have to
uh break through that defensive wall.
>> Yeah, as you pointed out though, Trinity
Force is the kind of card that lets you
play catchup. It's actually really nice
in these decks. If you're ahead, it can
get you further ahead and if you're
planning it can help you catch up and
Ominous Milk kind of using that second
option that Trinity Force gives you if
you're able to successfully hold. So,
the points aren't even for now. But I
think the question becomes that stop hit
peak has meant a pretty significant rune
advantage for the mouse player on the
left. And you have to remind me what
this does because I do not remember what
primal barrage does.
>> I can tell you uh this gives plus seven
>> plus seven.
>> Uh we need to get Kangas back on this
broadcast because I can't count that
high. That is a lot of might. It's
actually going to be nine total coming
in which is more than the static six
that was sitting on Ominous Milkside. Uh
the thonk plus defy. So again, just
flurry of reactive options from both
players.
>> No extra thunk just yet. Pretty good in
this matchup as you have to expect cuz
you are trying to hold and defend in a
lot of situations which means uh
attackers are often moving into you if
they're trying to get anything done.
Makes sense as a card kind of similar to
white flame protector which we see but a
little bit cheaper. Only a spell not a
unit but discipline going to be the
answer here to try and make it happen.
But that's only 8 to 9 and that is not
enough right now.
and did not find the answer from the
discipline. So, Chica will successfully
win that combat on the back of that huge
strength play
and go up in points again deny the
Trinity Force extra points that are
trying to give Ominous Milk a bit of a
springboard back ahead in the race.
And as the runes dwindle down, as the
spells are traded back and forth,
Mastery uh in some ways I wouldn't say
not a nutrition deck, right? cuz you're
not you can't go super late, but
definitely a deck where you're kind of
grinding your opponent out of resource
and just trying to have enough at the
end of it to keep ahead. So, you know,
as you kind of said, setting the pace,
starting the race, and then uh
>> hoping to get all the way to the end at
point number eight. Make it five now for
Chikas as started peak once again keeps
the runes very healthy as far as
available resources. Now, Ominous Milk
did develop this Ruin Runner, which
could be a problem for Chica because
it's not something that can be thwked.
You can't charm it. If it gets the
Trinity Force and lands successfully on
a location, it's going to be incredibly
difficult to deal with. Chica
recognizing that goes in for the double
conquer, goes all the way up to six. So
even if this Ruin Runner successfully
captures a spot, Chica will go to seven
on the hold and Milk will have to answer
for that other location on top of
stacking someplace with the Ruin Runner.
Uh there could be something like a charm
to pull off on the other side. We'll
have to wait and see how Ominous Milk
navigates it, but that's kind of the the
macro game plan for both. Chica wants to
hold the seven and then force Milk to
have an answer uh for the other
location.
>> Yeah, threatening to win technically. It
just seems quite unlikely that both
these porros are going to hold down the
fort. But punch first is going to make a
very big stall. Porro remember with the
shield that is five naturally. So that
is a 10 might poro just punching the
ruin runner back into the trash. And now
I think it's desperation master from the
chosen champ zone and th is going to
thwart this play immediately which I
believe means is going to be the one
winning this game number three. There's
the handshake. Yep. Check the hand and
that's it. Chica's 10 and one on Mi.
>> That was an absolutely massive punch
first there. And the reason that that
card was so impactful there at the end
is because it goes around all of the
interactivity in terms of like counter
spells that these Yeists run. It cannot
be defied because it has the two power
cost. Does not target the other unit.
So, it cannot be hit with a not so fast.
The only way that you can deal with a
punch first is to just go bigger. And
ultimately, Chica won that on the back
of having spells that go bigger. We saw
the huge primal plus seven to take the
location and then the big punch first to
seal it.
>> Yeah, primal looked like a really cool
bit of tech. I don't know if that's in
the main or for the mirror, but I I
really like that addition in these
decks. I think again it is kind of the
battle of mid-range, but when that
happens, typically it means you're just
trying to go a bit bigger than the other
decks. So, there's kind of this arms
race of like what pumps you're playing.
Uh I will say wind wall as you mentioned
in our previous series can also get the
job done against punch first but very
few players are playing windw wall and
if they are playing wind wall it is
typically not to deal with punch first
cuz just on rate exchange one and your
two power for my three and my two power
feels pretty bad. It does feel bad. And
uh I do also like the inclusion of
Primal, even if it is coming from the
board uh for certain matchups because uh
one of the things we've talked about a
lot this weekend is if you're a
defensive deck or if you're a more hold
centered deck and Master Yi is that I
mean it is it is it is a you know still
a mid-range list at heart. It wants to
play big numbers, but it gets its value
from holding. You have to have a plan
for retakes. So for some of the control
decks, that's something like Watcher. In
this case, it's something like primal or
punch first where you can go back in
with your buff and then retake a
battlefield.
>> Yeah, we see white flame kind of in that
slot as well that can do the job.
Sometimes your chosen champion, which is
kind of a neat thing about mastery just
kind of naturally how the deck shakes
out is that you get a lot of things you
don't get in your deck in your chosen
champion zone, which is like that's
pretty wild as far as design shook out.
It's one of the reasons the deck has
been so successful for quite a while.
But top eight's looking interesting
based on the number of different legends
we've seen at X and one. There will
almost surely be a Draven, but I don't
think there'll be that many. The record
to beat in North America at least is
less than four. I already said I think
there's going to be two and not more
than that. So, I think we're at least
going to get under four.
>> I'll believe it when I see it. I still
think North America is the League of
Draven, but I hope I'm wrong. This is
one of those instances where I would
like to be wrong.
>> We don't dislike Draven. We just like
seeing lots of different decks. And I
think which strategy is going to, you
know, kind of prevail in this RQ. I
mean, even in this this end of this
spirit for season for regional
qualifiers in general, that kind of
seems to be the story, right? Azia
surprisingly won in Lil just a week ago.
Will we have another surprise legend?
Will it really finally do it in the
west? or I don't know how well they're
performing, but I know there was a lot
of very good day one performances by
Darius. So, we saw a zir rise to
popularity in Le by being aggressive and
just kind of getting as much money on
the board as possible and we're seeing
these mid-range Darius lists follow
suit.
>> All right, with that we are going to
pass it on over to Kangas who's standing
by with an Azir deck profile.
Hello everybody, Steve Kangas here at
the Riftbound Regional in Atlanta. And
it is my privilege and honor to give
Pedro's number one Leil winning deck
list for Azir and the meta breakdown for
it. How he was able to take Leil shocked
a lot of us. And now we get to talk
about what the deck does, the strengths
of it, and how he piloted it to
perfection to get that flawless win. Not
dropping a single series is very
impressive. So up first, it's Zir
Emperor of the Sands. your legend
abilities. Whenever you play an
equipment, you're able to play a sand
soldier with weapon master. Obviously,
you're going to have a lot of equipments
in your deck. The BF sword, the sacred
shears, the guardian angel, the
brutalizer, eye of the herald, door and
shield, all of these. Your goal every
single turn, just keep playing them. So,
you keep getting your sand soldiers out.
This is where the deck ramps. A lot of
decks will ramp through runes. They'll
ramp through, you know, big either seals
or like big units. Now Azir just wants
as many equipments on the field as
possible because it all accumulates to
the signature spell Arise. Arise is one
of the strongest signature spells in the
game for a couple of key parts. Number
one, you can't defy it. You can't not so
fast it. You maybe can hard bargain it,
but still it's a six. So if you prepare
for that, you can still on a 10 rune
ramp uh still play the arise and get a
big push. But you play a two white sand
soldier token for every gear on your
field. If you have six gears, you get
six sand soldiers. If you have 10 gears,
you get 10 sand soldiers. All of which
with weapon master, two of which will
enter ready. Now, that gives you massive
tempo pushes, massive tempo swings, cuz
not only do you get the advantage from
the equipment, you also get advantage
from just bodies to utilize the
equipment. And what better way to
utilize the bodies than the Azir
sovereign as well. Whenever he moves,
which by the way, he can enter
accelerated. Whenever he moves, he can
move any number of tokens with him. So
all of your sand soldiers will follow
that Azir, whatever battlefield he
chooses to go to. So not only can you go
in with the Arise play to push in with
multiple sand soldiers on their own, you
can then use Azir to push the entire
army with him. The Emperor of the Sands
really living up to the name. Uh, other
key combo, and this is what Pedro played
perfectly, is the death grip card. This
is one that I overlooked, and I think a
lot of others overlooked at the
beginning of Spirit Forge, just how
strong this card is. Two energy, no
power cost, reaction speed. Already,
you're like, okay, there's a lot of
stuff going on there. What does it do?
You kill a friendly unit and then give
its might to another friendly unit and
then you draw a card. So, it replaces
itself. That draw one's actually pretty
big for the deck, but most importantly,
it makes your relatively small army,
each individual sand soldier is pretty
small, but you can send one in conquer
death grip to kill it, give the might to
something else and go swing at a bigger
target. Or if your opponents try to
snipe or attack in on something, you
kill one back in base to buff up the one
that's out at the battlefield. The
reaction speed is the key part here
because you can really react to anything
your opponent is trying to do. You combo
it with brutalizer, which is an
incredible equipment that anytime you
equip it to a unit that turn, it gains
an additional plus two might in addition
to the one, that's three total might.
You can equip that, send it in, kill
that sand soldier, give the five might
to something else. Re-equip the
brutalizer for a total of eight might
bonus. That math is crazy. And Pedro
showed us just how powerful it was and
how much he was able to dominate a lot
of even like Draven matchups. Master Yi
match ups holding points and it all
accumulates into some of the coolest
like suite of um tech spell cards,
things like face breaker and especially
the salvage. Salvage we we've seen here
in Atlanta this weekend how important uh
gear hate is and having the access to
this main deck plus more in the
sideboard means that you're always
prepared for things like baited hook,
Aurora, even like Aurelia with guardian
angel and such. So the whole package is
really fun. I overlooked Azir and Pedro.
I am sorry. Thank you for teaching us
how strong this deck can be and I'm sure
you inspired a lot of people to play it
this weekend in Atlanta. But again,
congratulations to Pedro for his
placement in Leo. That's a breakdown of
the Azir deck. Hopefully, it's inspired
some of you to play it as well. Now,
let's get back to the event.
Hello and welcome back to the regional
qualifiers here in Atlanta, Georgia. My
name is Miss Chumcham and I've got a lot
of friends here with me today. Okay,
we're going to be playing a quick game
of telephone. So, I'm going to start
with you and we're going to start with
the letter A. You can say any card name,
but the next person has to say a card
name ending with the or starting with
the letter of the ending letter of your
card. Okay? And so, we're going to go on
to each person. They only have five
seconds to come up with a card name and
the last person standing will win three
packs of Spirit Forge. So, a lot on the
line. We're going to go ahead and get
started with you. Let's start with A.
>> Okay.
>> I just ate here. Ari.
>> Uh, Imperial Decree.
>> Imperial Decree. E.
>> Oh my god.
>> And you're out. All right. Imperial
Decree. E.
>> Why is this hard? Ezreal. Ezreal.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> L.
>> LeBlanc. Can I
>> LeBlanc? Yeah, I'll take it.
>> C.
>> Uh. Uh. Oh my god. I can't think.
>> And you're out. C.
>> Wait, guys. What card starts with C?
>> LeBlanc doesn't start with C.
>> All right. Card sharp. Card sharp.
>> P.
>> Uh, loyal pup. No. No.
>> Oh, God. It's over.
>> GG, congratulations. You are our winner.
Absolutely love it. Thank you so much
for watching and we're going to send it
back your way.
Hello everybody, Charmer here coming to
you from the Atlanta regional qualifier
for Riftbound and I'm excited to talk to
you about some new mechanics coming to
Unleashed, specifically all things
experience. This is a new mechanic that
will be featured and there are three
legends that are going to be taking
advantage of it. We're going to start by
taking a look at Kaix. This is the void
reaver. As you can see on the legend
text here, when you win a combat, you
gain one XP. There's also a way to
expend the XP to give buffs, do some
movement. This is not the only legend
that cares about experience. We do also
have Keeper of the Hammer, none other
than Poppy herself. She's going to
gather that experience from holding. And
then once again, you can spend XP to
draw a card. Finally, we have the Wu
master. Master Yi, that is going to care
about experience. But you'll notice this
just says level. Your level is equal to
the number of experience you have. So,
Yei wants to collect it, wants to hoard
it, and then utilize it all for himself.
That's right. He is scaling to the late
game. Now, the legends have ways to gain
XP with the exception of Master Yi. So,
there's obviously other ways to get it.
There's going to be cards like Herold of
Spring. This is a card that's again
going to be coming in unleashed and it's
very simple. When you play me, you get
to experience. Seems pretty
straightforward. That's a great way to
get some of that. We do also have other
cards that will grant you experience
like Alpha Strike. This is going to be
Master Yi's signature spell. Obviously,
it does some amazing things for farming
that XP in the jungle, but it has this
nice gain one XP. on the bottom. There
are other ways to gain XP as well, such
as the scuttle crab. It wouldn't be
jungling if it didn't involve getting
our scuttle crab friend here. This, of
course, has the death now of this cool
effect where you get to look at your
opponent's hand, but also gain one XP.
So, as you can see, there's already a
lot of ways that we can collect it. But
wait, there's more. After this, of
course, we have our good friend, Master
Ye Unstoppable. This doesn't collect XP.
This showcases yet another way that you
can utilize hoarding it. So, much like
the Master Yi Legend, here you have
these different level thresholds. First,
it becomes cheaper, then it becomes even
cheaper, then
even cheaper. But when you get to level
16, that's right, cannot be chosen by
enemy spells and abilities. And that's
on top of the already static bonuses
that you're going to get from the Wu
Master Legend. So when you're playing
this with Master Yi, you're going to get
all those big bonuses. We also have
other really cool payoffs when it comes
to experience like Poppy, Defender of
the Meek. So, this is a card, not a
legend, but just a card, a unit that
allows you to spend XP as well. In this
case, it will allow you to play this
Poppy for a cheaper cost. It does also
have ambush. This is another mechanic
that's going to be utilized heavily in
Unleashed. And it makes sense if you're
a jungler, you're coming out, you want
to gank your opponent, but you want to
do it with some surprise, with some
flare, with some gravitas. Ambush allows
you to do that at the reaction speed so
you can catch your opponents offguard.
Now there are some other ways to gain
experience as well through the hunt
mechanic. So we have another keyword on
Kha'Zix evolving hunter. This was also
if you were paying attention on the
Herald of spring earlier. Hunt says when
I conquer or hold gain one XP and this
is again in addition to any of the other
effects that are gaining experience. So
in the case of Kha'Zix, the legend would
get you the experience for winning a
combat. And then if you also conquer as
a result of that combat, well, you gain
an XP with evolving hunter as well.
There is another Kha'Zix unit. So this
is of course uh the body version, but we
have the chaos version none other than
mutating horror, which again showcases
ambush, but when you attack or defend,
if it's alone, you get the bonus XP as
well. So this is really trying to single
out those opponents. If you're trying to
relive your favorite League of Legends
moments where you were jungling on
Kha'Zix, you catch somebody one-on-one
with that isolated target, you get the
kill, you get the bonus, this is what
this card is going to be doing for you.
And so overall, the experience mechanic,
I think, is going to be a welcome
addition to the game. I think it's a
flavor win when it comes to making the
card game feel like League of Legends.
And it's also a very interesting new
mechanic and in many ways a new resource
to manage on top of energy and power
already. I'm looking forward to seeing
how these cards synergize, how players
navigate around it, and hopefully you
are excited to build with these cards as
well. So, if you've made it this far, we
appreciate you. Stay tuned. We've got
more Riftbound action coming your way
throughout the day.
Welcome back here to the Riftbound
Regional Qualifiers here in Atlanta,
Georgia. I am here with Colin and you
are running what deck right now?
>> Uh currently running Seth the boss, my
old classic.
>> Okay, so tell me a little bit about set.
Why are we gravitating towards him?
>> Uh I played him a lot in set one and he
was my favorite legend kind of
throughout the entirety of that set 2
came out. I started playing a few
different things and I just wanted to
mix it up again, give it one last ride
and uh so far it's working extremely
well for me.
>> Absolutely. So we're here on day one.
What is your uh score right now?
>> Uh currently 7-0 undefeated.
>> Oh my gosh. So, you're going into day
two feeling really strong. Now, day one
hasn't wrapped up here. Uh who did you
just play against and was it an easy
stomp or was it kind of back and forth?
>> I actually played against my friend Rob
who's a very good player. Uh he was
playing Victor which I think is a pretty
fortunate matchup for me as well, but
one I was uh happy to sit across from.
Obviously, it always sucks playing
against a friend, but um at least being
able to take it and walk my day two at
at least seven wins is quite nice.
>> Absolutely. And so, obviously, you're
you're 7-0 right now. You're gunning for
that best of. Do you know how far above
your opponents in this category you are?
>> Yeah, currently I'm two wins above
everybody else. So, we're looking pretty
good for that. And uh on a very unique
version of set as well. Everyone else
who's playing set today has walked up
and told me about their list and like,
"Man, your deck's so different compared
to ours." And I'm like, "Yeah, I know. I
It feels really good to be able to play
something unique, you know, that uh is
in the game of Riftbound. Obviously,
you're stuck with a certain chosen
champion and legend and being able to
play my own version using the different
set using uh the yellow one instead of
orange has been uh quite nice."
>> Absolutely. And those standouts honestly
are probably what is propelling you to
these victories hitting that 7-0.
Obviously, you're going for the best of
in this set category, but I kind of want
to ask your prediction on what you feel
like tomorrow will entail. Do you feel
like you can place that top eight or
maybe even take the whole entire thing?
>> Honestly, I played against uh a lot of
the meta decks. I beat a Draven. I beat
Aurelia. Uh beat even multiples from
yesterday as well. So, so long as my
draws keep going well and my deck keeps
performing for me, then anything is
possible.
>> We're rooting for you. You've obviously
got it all mapped out. You've got this
very unique deck and we're rooting for
you to be maybe on that stage at the end
of the day. Thank you so much for this
interview and we're going to send it
back to the broadcast.
Hello and welcome back to Regal Club
Atlanta. We're in round number 12. My
name's Py Time. That's still Charmer.
Still in day two. He made it. He
qualified. Well done.
>> This is my first time day twoing at a
riftbound event, so I'm very happy about
that.
>> Very nice. Uh I don't want to spoil too
much, but I we have some bangers lined
up for this round. That's all I can say.
It kind of makes sense, right? We're
getting to the uh very near the end of
Swiss. This is the penultimate round of
the 13 rounds. This is our 12th and then
we'll have a top eight after that. So,
eight rounds a day, but uh three of them
are a little bit different on day number
two. But before we get there, we have to
figure out who's in the top eight. And
this is what uh continuing to win does
for you. We don't know yet how things
shake out, what the records need to be,
but we do know we're getting awfully
close. And we'll have a check at the
standings cuz after round 11, Frosty is
still undefeated and so is Coco Lopez.
That draw not getting too much in the
way, but there are some absolute demons
still at 10 and one. Colin still alive,
Boliv. the wall prismaticism haraza we
saw on stream we saw of course winning
in the last round Allen's EQ still 91
and one only a single loss so presumably
still live as well and Jinx also still
there ran also at 10 and one
>> yeah this is a very competitive top 16
at the moment I see some names that we
have seen several times on the broadcast
I've seen some names we've seen several
times at previous regional qualifiers
there are a lot of legends represented.
I am excited.
>> Me too. And I even see someone that has
been believe peeking in on our 2v2 games
in the hotel lobby. I believe Zayn at
16. I believe that is the player that
we've been chatting to. I know he is on
Draven for this weekend. Seems to be
still in the running as well. If I have
my players correct, that is a very
exciting looking top 16. A lot of Draven
as expected, but like I said, I believe
the Dravens are going to eat themselves.
And even if there are more than two
Dravens, which is the thing I I didn't
promise you anything, just as a
reminder, but I did say I believe there
would only be two in top eight. Uh the
fact that Set and Jinx might make top
eight is pretty awesome. Yeah, I love
when these events have at least one like
surprise standout. You know, I think
back to Vegas where we had Jax make the
top eight and it was an incredible run.
Uh the player was very entertaining. Uh
great. Uh we just had Le where Azir uh
you know Azir had performed well over in
China but it was kind of the coming out
party in the west ended up winning the
entire thing. Did not drop a a match the
entire event and I think we're seeing
some potential for you know again that
run here. Is it going to be the Jinx? Is
it going to be the set? Uh if there's
somebody who's going to do it on set,
Colin certainly does make an awful lot
of sense. All right, let's have a look
at our deck list cuz again like I said
this feature match is an absolute
banger. Kicking things off with a deck
and a player we love know and love.
Prismaticism and Annie are still here
after toping in Lil looking to do the
same again a week later here in Atlanta.
Yeah, this is obviously a deck and a
player that I am very much impressed by.
A big believer. Prismaticism has a
background from Legends of Run Terra as
well. just a very decorated card game
player no matter what game they pick up
in Riftbound in particular has had a
number of top eight I believe it was top
four in Leo and I think that this is
going to be the event where they finally
go the distance and get the win. Yeah, I
know there weren't too many changes to
the list but I believe if my uh memory
serves one of the changes I have noticed
between his version of the deck in Lil
where he won best of and this is that I
believe he added one more Rexar breacher
going from two to three. Clearly liking
that card and you know who else likes
that card? everyone else. In fact, the
littlest had three cuz everyone else
likes you. You know why? It's sold out
in the hall. Chararma, there are none. I
talked to at least two deals yesterday
that were sold out. Turns out the hall
is just done. There are no more Rex eye
breaches left to buy. Yeah, I think when
this card was originally revealed,
everyone focused on just the Rex eye
package and the number of ways where you
get to look at cards, maybe banish one,
play it, etc., and then this would give
accelerate to those. But the reality is
it works on your chosen champions. It
works on the mechs created from Ferris
4runner. There's a lot of potential
value to be gained from this and it just
has accelerate on its own.
>> Very, very good all things around. Let's
have a look at the other deck list now
because his opponent is another very
good player. A champion of a previous
regional qualifier. Dwali is back in the
same domains that won him Houston but on
a different legend. Draven his choice
for this event.
>> Yeah, Draven obviously still considered
the top of the mountain even after the
bands, right? uh most represented deck
here, second most represented deck in Le
has incredible conversion rates. Again,
we've seen a lot of players on Draven in
that top 16 graphic we were looking at
earlier. I know that earlier though when
we were talking about these two players,
you had brought something to light,
which is uh the fun fact that Dewali won
in Houston on who?
>> Annie.
>> Okay. And prismaticism was on who?
>> Draven won best over there in Vegas.
>> And they have swapped spots.
you know, just I mean, turns out they
both like these domains. I think that we
can we can figure that out as much. Both
pretty good decks, but it is funny to
see them swap their legends. Only two
Rexi bridge are here for D. Clearly
couldn't find a third one in the hall.
Sold out a little too swiftly, but
triple gem jammer kind of a fun one. I
think we're seeing quite a bit more of
this card is just a very solid play you
can have on the early turns being only
two energy. But giving units ganking
turns out that's pretty powerful. Yeah,
I think that when you're deck building
and you want to include two costed
units, you want ones that are hopefully
versatile into the late game. Obviously,
Overzella's fan is a staple, but cards
like Tide Turner have also been around.
And then, of course, we have now Gem
Jammer entering the frey because if you
draw it later in the game, you can still
find use from the when play trigger. And
I think that that is what has really
made it rise in the ranks as far as
considering uh during your deck
building.
>> All right, let's head on down to the
feature area because it is two titans of
the game about to play each other for
what could be a spot in the top eight.
Again, I have not done the math yet. I
will not be doing it. That will be
someone else's job. I don't know what
the stakes are on this match, but I do
know if you want to make top eight, the
best thing you can do is just keep on
winning. And one of these players, one
of these very good players is about to
pick up their second loss in this
regional qualifier. Now, this is
actually a very interesting statistic
that I'm seeing on the screen right now,
which is that Annie versus Draven was
pretty close to 50% in Leo. Uh, a little
favored toward Draven with 47% win rate
on the Annies, but has dropped
significantly here at Atlanta. And the
only thing that I can think of is that
some of the tech that players were
including to potentially battle Azir and
that deck coming out faster is also
impacting this Annie matchup almost uh
catching strays if you will because of
Azir sins. Yeah, I also wonder how many
Annies potentially entered the field
after prismaticism made top eight in uh
in Liil and we'll have a look at this
game one battlefield here. It is seed of
power versus Zorn Warren prismaticism on
Annie Duali on Draven swapping things
over. But uh I do have a little fun fact
for the battlefield that I did note. Uh
one of them has arena's greatest and the
other one has aspirin climb. So I wonder
when do you decide to take that one out?
because uh I think the Aspirin's clim
player probably wants to find the
arena's grades and the arena's grades
probably wants to dodge the climb if
that makes sense.
>> No, I think it's actually the reverse.
So, uh Boulevard, who we also know is
performing well in this event, had said
that specifically they were trying to
play uh greatest when they were going
first because if their opponent is going
second, that's usually when they want to
deploy climb and they're just trying to
deny the value that climb gives them,
>> right? All right, so I Okay, so it's
reverse. So Draven wants to have the
climb be uncontested and Prismaticism
wants to find the climb and the arena's
greatest in the same game. That makes
sense. Over Fang going to kick things
off. Looks like it is Annie on the on
the play. I'm going to have to be very
careful about which legend is which
because they are very similar looking
sometimes obviously in the same domains
and often play quite a lot of the same
cards, but Gem Jammer going to be the
early drop of choice here for Dwali as
things get passed back and first player
on the board is going to be
prismaticism. And uh turns out that
Annie legend ability is that the is that
the best of Annie just chilling by the
way?
>> Uh it it certainly does look like that
is the case. Likely the one that was
being from Le.
>> I don't know why that didn't strike me
but yeah I mean it's probably been a
week. He got given the card when he was
in Le bring it on over. Yeah. That in
the legend zone.
>> I I think it just stands out because
none of the other cards we've seen so
far are featuring the bling. That was
actually something I was going to point
out. Uh, traditionally with League, you
always say skins get wins. And we see a
lot of those incredibly beautiful foiled
out full art runes, but uh, these are
two very decorated players just rocking
the base runes here. And so far, base
versions of each card. Uh, again, just
wanting to focus on the game play, but
there is that best of Annie out there,
so it really stands out.
>> They just give you the card. I guess you
use it. You know, stack deck going to be
resolved here by prismaticism. Having a
look at the rest of the hand. I see a
flash. just here Nox's hopeful which has
already had its legion effect online
thanks to stack deck being the first
spell of this turn ride the wind one of
the other cards in hand I couldn't quite
catch the fourth one
yeah I couldn't see it either I was
trying to see if I could get a gleam
which Battlefield
>> yeah this is interesting if you don't
like your hand warren might make sense
just to get the filter
I will say is definitely a uh very
deliberate player, one very thoughtful.
>> Also, it's a consideration where if you
think for whatever reason you're going
to be forced into combat, you might want
to force your opponent away from Zon
Warren. So, that could have been a
consideration. Uh instead, opting just
to pass. Doesn't want to go to either
battlefield. Uh I also like this. you
face your opponent to make the decision
first and then on the next turn when you
go for your own double conquer
potentially you'll be able to get both
the Warren's trigger and the seed of
power. So just kind of maximizing your
value without putting anything in
danger.
>> I can tell you that uh my little read
from that situation I do really like the
patience here. I think often players
just rush onto the battlefield without
giving it too much thought and that is I
would say more often than not the
correct play but not always the correct
play and I think that's something that's
important to know in Riftbound. Just
because the points are there for you to
grab doesn't mean you need to take them
yet. Sometimes you want to do a little
bit more setup. I think especially
against the deck like Draven where when
you are wrong about the combat outcome
you get punished as Kaiser Survivor
going to be the play. No accelerate
though. I I was just about to say I
would not be surprised if Dewali
develops and also passes because these
are two players that understand that
even numbers are the important numbers
when it comes to points. Getting that
one point is kind of inconsequential
compared to getting two and it's
exacerbated by the presence of seed of
power because you also want that card
draw. Uh neither of these players wanted
to give up a unit from early exchanges
unnecessarily and prismaticism strikes
first not just with the double conquer
but with a big reinforce with that
ferris 4runner on the warren which is of
course trying to deny that trigger
>> I have a rules question for you then uh
I don't know what the answer is I'm not
sure if you do but I trust you for many
things if overzealous fan gets
sacrificed and pushes a unit out does
that mean Draven has won a combat
Uh, I don't believe so because that unit
isn't present to win the combat at the
battlefield any longer. You win a combat
by having units at the battlefield at
the end of every
>> All right. So, I like the thing that
that makes sense. And the reason I like
this maneuver actually is that you're
reinforcing the battlefield that uh you
want to hold down the most. Ferris
foruna is I would say at its best when
you reinforce it somewhere else. And
obviously again, you do not want to lose
combat to Draven and give those bonus
cards away. away. And yes, prismaticism
thanks to Annie's legend ability is
holding up two runes as well, which
could be a number of different tricks at
his disposal. But the fan just sitting
there is not going to it will likely
give Kaisa a card draw if Diwali wants
to go over the top there and get the
conquer and the point, but it will not
be giving an extra card thanks to Draven
winning a combat.
>> Well, that is that is also assuming that
the fan doesn't just ship it back.
>> So, I think we're actually going to see
Dewali go in the other direction. Maybe
this is signaling something like a a
cleave
>> or a rebuke maybe.
>> Yeah, it certainly doesn't seem fun to
go up there. So, do you want to contest
but Dwali doing the thing that decks
usually don't like to do which is run
into the fullerrunner which could mean
one of two things. You just have to do
it and the grimace on the face that I
can kind of clean maybe is that or
there's a rebuke.
>> Yeah, that's what I was saying. It might
be the rebuke for the 4Runner. I think
that makes the most sense. You want to
do this now while you have all of these
runes available so that you can play
around hard bargain because we've seen
that have some very effective blowout
options. Instead, prismaticism goes with
the flash and that gets hit with the
hard bargain from the side of Dewali.
So, as I was just talking about playing
around hard bargain for the blowouts,
it's actually Dewali using it to make
sure the rebuke goes off and that's
really going to slow down the pace that
prismaticism had set. Yeah, a lot of
players have actually been taking the
hard bargain specifically against Draven
in these domains. There's a lot of
spells that could be tough to hit.
Rebuk's the obvious one, right? Can be
tough to hit with something like a defy,
but a little bit easier to hit with
something like hard bargain. And I
believe in the main Dali only has one
and prismaticism has two. So a uh a very
big win there in that combat. Kaiser
does go down thanks to the hopeful
having four might. So no extra card draw
from the conquer from Kai'Sa but the
card draw from Draven nonetheless and
the card draw and a bit of filtering
from Zorn Warren.
>> Yeah, that's the thing of one of in
lists that can sometimes be tilting as a
player because it's very hard to always
play around it. You have to assume
mathematically they're less likely to
have it this early in the game. But when
they do find it, it's such a blowout
because of that exact reason, right?
You're kind of not expecting them to
have it. And uh as you pointed out,
prismaticism is running two. That's just
because Annie is always essentially
guaranteed to have those two energy
available for it. It makes sense to kind
of increase your copies. But Dewali
getting the initial benefit of that hard
bargain exchange. And I think now the
question for Dewali is is this going to
be a reinforced hopeful to try to, you
know, defend on that Warrens against
something like uh an accelerated Kai'Sa
or is it going to go in base? And I I
like this play. I think that uh jamming
it on the top just leaves you open to
too many uh counterplay options.
And that flashy sold that did get hit
with a hard bargain. That is one of the
centerpieces of this deck as Ferris Fora
comes back on down the other side this
time. You know what? didn't have so much
fun. Obviously can't reinforce a
battlefield you don't occupy. So the
same play but just in the top side this
time as Ferris for joins overall fan and
if there is a board state you don't want
to look at when thinking about going to
a battlefield that is probably the one I
like the least.
>> Yeah and as you had pointed out Ferris
4runner significantly more effective
when it's used from a reinforcement
standpoint. uh playing it into base.
Obviously, it's still a great unit, not
the end of the world. But in this
particular matchup where uh you are
trying to race in points and in this
particular instance, while normally the
even points matters more often, you've
kind of entered this weird stalemate of
both players sitting on one spot, you
want to hunker down, ensure that you can
hold this location off and continue to
score points so that you maintain that
point lead until you can get back on
track. This makes an awful lot of sense.
certainly
does and uh 3 to2 now is the point score
here getting the hold point thanks to
the overall fan being ignored in the
earlier exchange. So as you said the
points race is currently favoring Annie
which uh does make sense for the play
that went first but still plenty of play
left in these games or ride the wins in
these decks there plenty of accelerate
units. We talked about Rexai Breacher a
lot already lots of ways to kind of get
back on the board and try and get a
conquer. The tricky thing is that Paris
4 on it tends to make that quite
troublesome. And uh two runs is good,
but for this any deck in particular,
three is even better when you're
thinking about tricks that prismaticism
could have.
>> Yeah, it is something to keep an eye on
as the game drags out because uh
breacher as far as activations on your
chosen champion is going to be far more
impactful on the Dewali side. that
Draven giving it accelerate when it
enters play in that like eight might
range is big enough to go over top of
even the 4Runners. Uh we're not quite
there yet, but you know what else is
pretty good? Darius.
>> Darius pretty good. Just develops the
Darius and says go. Wanting to build up
a little bit more might Draven often
happy to store up some might and then
crash in with big numbers to try and win
those combats, keep the card draw
flowing and retake control of the game.
Annie kind of getting under a lot of
that again. always readying Trins,
always having a trick available. We've
seen flash, we know about Rook, we've
talked about hard bargain, but the one I
was alluding to earlier with Truins is
of course Rengar. One of the very
exciting additions to this list, a very
unique combat trick as Ride the Wind
over to the other side. Not going to
draw a card from the Cedar Power, but is
going to get to discard and draw thanks
to Zornwar and maybe more critically
gets an extra point out of the deal as
well. And the base we go.
>> And I was about to say, and I think the
reason that Ride the Wind was the choice
here is because it moves ready. you can
safely go back to base. You see Dewali
setting up. Uh if you're watching at
home and you're trying to figure out how
you navigate around uh what your
opponent is doing, Dewali played that
Darius the previous turn and simply
passed. What that signals to
Prismaticism is that Dewali is trying to
develop enough might where he feels
comfortable and confident to go in and
win these combats. And if that is their
game plan, score the points you can and
then safely bring your units back and
now put Dewali in the position that you
were just in. So now if Dewali wants to
keep pace on points, has to put some of
these units on the battlefield, but then
will be facing the wrath of a
prismaticism counterattack the following
turn.
>> You know what the fun part is? It might
even be bigger than it looks because I
talked about Rengar, which is usually
something you play when battlefields are
getting assaulted, but you get an action
window uh in a lot of different cases.
You could just chuck Rengar in your base
if you need a little bit more might on
the following turn.
>> Absolutely.
>> All right,
>> this is going to be a very critical
exchange here.
>> See pretty good cards in Dwar's hand. I
will say Falling Star Ferris forun are
the first two cards at the top of that
hand. We've already talked at length of
how good Ferrron is. So Gem Jam is going
to get the party started and
Prismaticism just says you got it. Three
points now for the Draven player. still
trailing by two, but not in range just
yet for either player. Not at that
critical six that we've seen in so many
different games. And this is not a climb
game. So, we are playing to regulation
as Rexai Breacher hits the discard
thanks to Zorn Warren draws an extra
card and Darius might as well take the
draw. But again, can't spread yourself
too thin. There is a lot of might at
home and Prismaticism clearly resigned
to letting this turn happen.
>> So, sequencing obviously really
important here with the Darius though.
you can go in, get the draw, and there
has Yeah, I was going to say not had the
activation played quite yet. So, there
is the option to uh play your second
card, ready the Darius, and bring it
back if that's what you're fearing.
I think it's a nice little thing about
Darius we sometimes forget is that uh
it's so often just played basically as a
unit that has accelerate rather, a form
of accelerate. You play it as a second
card or you play it and then a second
card and you wake it up and charge on in
the reverse, as you noted, does also
work. Tie Turner actually going to make
that uh well I guess it's a bit
unnecessary to do it the this way but
you could flip the tie turner back if
you wanted to press 400 coming down as
well. Don't miss your Darius trigger. I
guess we haven't played two cards.
>> Yeah, this would be the psychic card.
Yeah,
>> miss it. He's good.
>> There we go. Yep. Flips it on back.
Ferris 4Runner coming down. And now once
again the same decision. Where is Ferris
4runner going? To base or to the
battlefield? And as we've said, the
battlefield is often the place it wants
to be at. And Dewali is not quite sure
to base he goes.
>> And again, this is that situation
previously where uh prismaticism had
identified Dwali was building in base.
So pulled back and now Dwali recognizing
prismaticism has all of this might and
is trying to uh establish, you know, a
reconquer to uh potentially take
advantage of any units that are left uh
on an island by Dewali. So, Dwali says,
"I don't want to lose to anything that I
don't have to, and I don't know what you
have. So, I'm just going to play my best
unit back in the base and set up for
a a retake, if you will, because uh
prismaticism was only on five points.
Uh, you know, we've talked about it,
adnauseium, but five is just not as good
as six. Those even numbers are more
important. Uh, Prismaticism does end up
sending the fan up top. So, we'll go to
seven.
>> Curious what the endame setup here is
for Prismaticism cuz we're in range now,
right? Can't win this turn, but can win
on the following turn, either by double
conquering or by holding. Holding
typically, especially in these domains,
little less likely. And uh, as we can
see, Dual has plenty of might available
for combats.
So, end of this turn, what I would
expect is one of two things. Uh, the
first is either a lot of might on both
locations with runes up so that you can
just have combat tricks and say, "Okay,
come at me." Because you have to take
both locations. I'm at seven. Uh or it
could be a situation where uh it was a
lot of might on one side and uh and
looks like this is going to be the case
and an overzealous fan on the other
because that essentially means you
either have to have removal for the fan
or you have to send two units there
because you can ship one back. So that
is the case. We have all of the runes
available for prismaticism. Uh almost
all of the might on warren and then the
one fan on the top side on that seat of
power.
>> Yeah, I really like the setup here. I
think just threatening and again even if
you know the the exchange happens Dwi
manages to get there and everything's
all good can still have a unit to roll
into on Battlefield only need one more
to try and conquer. So a very tough
situation and Dwali on the other side
cannot win this turn. Four points is uh
well out of range for a double conquer
to win you this game.
>> And the real pickle that Dwali's in is
let's just say hypothetically Dwali has
what it takes to get through both
locations. It's not going to happen
without a pretty great expenditure of
resources both in terms of cards from
hand and energy but also units on the
board if that's the case because of the
forerunner that's on the warrants.
Prismaticism is still going to have a
healthy number of units to attempt a
retake the following turn. But Dewali
having a very timely Brin here thunders
song here is going to put prismaticism
in a bit of a pickle because now any
reactions that you want to play have to
be done in this window.
>> Yeah. And it can only be reactions. So
flashing back on Noctisal and Ferris for
the fan is going to stay there. I like
this. It kind of puts him in the same
situation. And uh Brin here clearly a
card that Diwali thought was quite good
in this metag game. Has two copies in
his main deck. So liking this effect a
lot given how much how many different uh
decks with good cards we've seen that
you want to try and stop Aurelia kind of
being one of the premier ones but very
good in the mirror very good in this
matchup as well. So the flash is there
to save the units but Pris is back on
the I must double conquer plan which I
think is totally fine and again as you
mentioned these overells fans they might
be small but they are going to force
additional units to be committed over
which is just really annoying. Yeah,
absolutely. Dwali will now likely
successfully take both locations, but
because Prismaticism had the exact
answer in Flash to save the two units
when the Brin here came down. Uh before
I was talking about if it's other
things, you might have the mech tokens
left over for a retake. But here, if
Brin here is coming down, you just pull
everything back and say, "All right,
you're going to have to get me off of
these locations, but that's going to
strand your units." And then in doing
so, I will likely be able to retake the
next turn as well.
Uh, and this is a very critical falling
star to get rid of that second
overzealous fan so that it's not going
to push something back.
>> Yeah, first fan push back the tie
turner. Would have traded but decided
that, you know, might as well just push.
I think denies an action window
potentially is a reason to do that.
Although not sure there's much to would
want to cast there. I don't think it
mostly matters at the end of the day.
4Runner though they're rumbling on in
and again nothing to do here because
even if Prince had other spells he maybe
wanted to play Brinier's effect is still
alive. So two more points now at six now
threatening to win on the other side. It
also here's the interesting thing uh it
also was a bit of a check for whether or
not
>> oh rebuke is going to be game doesn't
even bother doing anything else. Already
knows that the game is over. The second
rebuke very timely there out of
prismaticism and that is game number one
going to Annie in the battle for which
uh legend is better in these very
dominant domains.
>> Yeah, I was about to say it was going to
be a check for uh whether or not
prismaticism felt comfortable with the
exchange, but Brin here is making it so
that there's no interaction available
anyway. Um, I was going to say it was
potentially a check for hard bargain,
but even at the reaction speed, uh, it
turns out you can't play counter spells
through Brin here.
>> Nope.
>> That makes sense. You don't want to like
lose to a spinning axe and like actually
have the Titan on the battlefield. So,
just pushing it away, making sure it
can't get there. That was its job to
begin with. As we move on over to game
number two, it is Zorn Warren again, but
this time on Pris's side and Taragon's
Peak for Diwali's Draven, which means
the final game is going to be Climb
verse Arena's greatest if we get there
with Pris going first because winning
the first game, it gives you the luxury
of choosing whether you want to go first
or second in the final game.
>> Yeah. And uh again, I feel like the
arena's greatest inclusions are really
just trying to deny the aspirin's climb
slowing things down. So recognizing uh
you've won game one, Dewali is going to
likely be on the play. So you roll out
your other battlefield and then on the
following one, if there is a game three,
you've got the greatest that will
counter the climb. And uh this is a
great turn one play from prismaticism
stacked deck into a hopeful and then
because you're Annie, you get to have
two runes ready to go. Uh that's about
as good as you can start when you are
going second.
>> Yeah, we talked about uh Darius getting
stuff done with Seal Captain on the play
which is a very fast start. This is
pretty close to one of the fastest ones
you can get especially going second. So
form might already but form might
answered on the other side. Gem Jammer
and Noctis hopeful hanging out on the
Targon's Peak together.
>> And if you're watching at home, just a
little bit of shortcutting there. Dewali
paid full for the hope because of peak.
>> Uh this is beautiful from Prismaticism
coming in.
>> There's the cat. Ringa pouncing into
play. Uh is attacking. So assault two
for so it's a five might unit rumb. And
there is only six might here. So, do you
want to kill the five or the four? I
have to think the bigger number is the
better answer, but four static might is
also pretty annoying.
>> Yeah, the interesting choice here is
whether or not you think you're going to
have like a falling star that could
clean up the Rengar later. There's that
breakpoint difference of three versus
four for those effects. Uh Rengar
offensively, as you pointed out,
represents more might. So, Dwali decided
to go with that. But it was not
necessarily, I think, an easy decision.
I think your hand state is going to
dictate a lot of that choice.
>> Also takes the peak and gets double any
legend activation basically readying all
the runes after recycling the fifth for
that Rengar. And it is a setup turn once
again. Darius go. Diwali going to have
to play patient. And as we saw when
Annie gets ahead on tempo feels like
actor can keep it quite consistently
>> and it's even better for the Annie
player when these early takes still
result in the hold point after. So, as
the merchant moves in on the other side,
we're going to get a lot of filtering
triggered for prismaticism, but also go
up to three points, and that's going to
allow the hopeful to go back. And then a
4runner. We've seen him all day long. I
this I'm getting ded. It's exactly the
setup that Pris had basically in game
one. And he's going second in this one.
But seems to be the plan is you know
what, play my early units, try and get
uh some things happening, take it to the
battlefield, then move one of my smaller
units on and then plop a 4unner next to
it and see what your opponent has to
deal with it. Darius, a pretty
formidable unit in combat. But forunner
is just so annoying whether it is
beating you in combat or if you're
taking it out or trading with it. So
much might, so much value generated with
this sneaky little spirit forge rare.
Yeah, the thing about this as well is
that this is the second game in a row
that Prismaticism was the first person
to develop a 4Runner on a battlefield.
And that is so important, I think, in
this matchup. You get not just the point
lead because you're obviously on the
battlefield, but you create this
additional hurdle that your opponent has
to go over, spend a bunch of resources
to do so. Uh, in this case, it's going
to be a rebuke. Again, a little bit of
deja vu, but you know, it's just coming
back next turn. There's still the
hopeful. And uh we saw we saw this
again. Is there the hard bargain? Yes.
>> All right. I promise you folks, this is
a different game. This is game two. All
right. The battlefields are different.
Check the tapes. Uh even though a lot of
the exchanges that we've seen already
have happened, this is a different game.
Darius will successfully conquer the
battlefield. Fell the merchant with his
big old axe and push Dwali up to two
points. Still again a little bit behind,
but Prismaticism losing that big 4Runner
that he developed. Now Dwali can't do
the same and reinforce this Darius
Battlefield with that unit cuz only
three wins left after the exchange. But
have to feel pretty good about snagging
a flash two games in a row that was
protecting a 4Runner.
>> Yeah, I think it speaks volumes when you
consider these are two very decorated
players that have navigated almost the
exact same game back to back. That tells
me that they both have a game plan. They
know what works. They're 10 in one for a
reason and they're sticking to their
script. It just so happens that that
script replays almost verbatim in two
different games, but uh it works, right?
We saw a very uh effective game from
Prismaticism in game one. Dewali was
doing everything uh available to try to
overcome it. Uh it's the same thing game
two. Prismaticism gets the early start.
Dewali tries to overcome it. We get the
rebuke. We have the back toart bargain.
Uh the real question now is does it
continue to play out like game one or
with this tide turner
we see uh Darius come back to base. It's
the second card played because of that
Darius readies from base and then goes
to the other side and now Dwali has
closed the points gap.
>> Yeah, I really like that. Very cute
little play. Titan is so tricky
sometimes, but you can kind of see it as
a way to ready your units as long as you
do some extra steps. have to do some
thinking, have to think about what
different uh abilities it's maybe
comboing with, but in effect here.
Rereied the Darius for the base and then
got Darus to move on over. So, Ar
Hopeful is going to move on in. Three
runes open and available, but
Prismaticism going to start at the
easier of the two battlefields to take.
Look to try and win this fight with four
might to two and go up to four points.
The points are even, but again, back on
tempo for Pris here. Able to take the
next two points potentially before
Diwali can do so. So, what does Draven
have to stop this assault? And even if
he does have something, does he want to
commit it now? Cuz resources are running
a little bit low here. And there's still
quite a bit of game left to play. Yeah,
this worked out a little bit in
Prismaticism's favor just because uh if
this combat is successful, the Z warns
would allow some additional filtering to
find some answers. But we do have the
spinning axe answered by the long sword,
a card that I love in Annie.
>> Very nicely done. Plus three for the
axe. That makes it uh lost my brain.
That makes it 5 to four and then plus
long sword makes it 6 to 5. So Pris wins
that combat. By the way, I believe one
of the only changes made according to
production who were in my ear just
before when we over deck list, it was
minus one mindsplitter plus one long
sword. So I don't know which long sword
that was, but that one came in clutch to
win that combat. Get the zone warrants
trigger happening and get the game
moving in the right direction for the
Annie player. Annie herself going to
make an appearance. And there's the
flash. I'll take that right on back.
Yeah, prismaticism I think hoping that
Dwali didn't have additional hard
bargains in the sideboard says okay
you've got it twice I'm still going to
utilize this flash which was honestly in
my opinion I think the gamewinner for
prismaticism in game one being able to
save all that might when the brin here
came down that allowed for the retakes
on the following turn it's a powerful
card for a reason it's in the Annie deck
in proving grounds for a reason. It's
kind of the goto answer. Uh cuz right
now what you're saying to Dewali is I
have units on this other side. If you
don't come over here, I'll take the hold
point. And if you do and I can't win the
combat, then I will just run away and
you spent all those resources to get the
job done. Yeah, I think uh it's funny
with how much DNA these two decks share
and they do have a lot of overlap as far
as cards they are playing. Uh really the
the backbone of manism any deck to me is
flash. This is a flash deck. This is a
deck that wants to utilize Ferris for
like many of the fury decks in the
field, but also just the power of flash
and how it combines with Annie's legend
ability. So, four points to four, but
again, Dwal is still just a little bit
behind, like a step behind on the point
tempo, which is sometimes enough in a
game like Riftbound. It's been scrappy
as both players are kind of going back
and forth trying to get, you know, just
a single point. We're not even getting
increments of two cleanly here because
there's so much interaction that happens
in these combats. But Dwali going to
move Darius on back and perhaps it's
another development turn here. Six
wounds available. That could be a
4Runner, but don't think we're getting
through the topside battlefield this
turn at least.
>> Well, I think Dwi's taken their time
trying to figure this out simply because
there was a scenario where you could
bring the Darius back, play two cards,
Darius readies, and then maybe uh if you
also had a cleave or something like
that, you could try to contest. The
problem with that is uh even if you're
expecting prismaticism to flash back,
that could have been bait and then you
could have answered with a rebuke on the
Darius instead. So Dwali, I think
rightfully says this is just a
development turn. Prismaticism uh is
only going to hold up to five, which is
not six. So I can get something in play
and then kind of regroup.
>> And five points is good, but Ferris 4
back on the battlefield where he
belongs. That little yodle in the giant
mech being pretty fearsome even with
Darius and Kaiser. Two very powerful
cards from Origins sitting in base ready
for combat with Dwali. And again, this
is a very tough fork to try and navigate
because like you mentioned, there is
flash. Everybody knows there's a flash
in hand, but is it bait? Could be. How
much how much worse can it get for you?
Even if it isn't, what do you actually
do if you move in and they flash a unit?
Which units do they flash? Are you
trading something away? like
>> you're forcing Diwali to to ask you
questions and you have answers ready to
go and this is uh I feel like prismatic
is in the is in the point where most
players in this kind of matchup want to
be they are the one dictating the pace
of the game and Dwali is still trying to
play catchup even though it's a point
between these two players feels like the
tempo is still in Pris's favor and I
appreciate how dynamic prismaticism is
with his units moving any back doesn't
do anything really on that battlefield
being a bit of extra might so might as
well leave it open to threaten a
potential conquer as Dwali going to
bottom here to the Targon speak and try
and pick up a point and prismaticism
says that's fine. That point doesn't win
the game. I'll give that one over.
>> One of the I think most frustrating
things when you're trying to play
against Annie is really just figuring
out exactly
what card they're holding up for. In
this case, obviously we know there's a
flash in hand from the Annie, but just
in general, because so much of the deck
is built around these really powerful
combat oriented two energy cards, when
you're going into any location, you have
to say, is it a flash? Is it a rebuke?
Uh, do they have a hard bargain for
whatever my trick is? Uh, is it a ride
the wind so that they can hop over to
the other location and then score on my
turn? Because as we pointed out, yes,
prismaticism is at five, which is not
six, but you can very quickly jump to
six on your opponent's turn with a ride
the win. So,
>> we're going in cuz without that spinning
axe, the might uh the might battle just
was in favor of Bri and it could just be
the flash. Could also just be a Ringar
and I did spot a rebuke in hand.
>> Darius uh I believe should have two more
might so has been ready. Yep, we're
going to represent her with the die.
>> So, that is was base. Uh 7 + 5 is 11.
No, that's not right. Z plus four is the
man. Z plus four is 11 plus 14. So it's
14 playing 12 right now and we'll see
how it works out because I did see that
rebuke in Prismaticism's hand. So what
do you think Di has? What do I want to
commit here? Flash feels like the safest
play, but it doesn't necessarily feel
like the play that advances the game to
the point you wanted to. Yeah, this is
uh do I take the safe play or do I say I
don't think you have another hard
bargain? You've got me twice with it.
I'm going to go with the rebuke. but uh
instead just doesn't commit anything is
fine with losing the battle but getting
might off the board for Dewali
because of the mech tokens coming in.
Again, this is the power of Ferris
4Runner. Dewali commits resources to get
that location. But as far as net might
goes, Prismaticism only loses four to
effectively get rid of uh Kai'Sa on the
other side, which is a very big trade,
>> I believe. Yep. Dwali is at six points.
That was the thing I was looking for.
So, Prismatic cannot win on this turn
and Dwalli is now in kind of the endgame
spot where he can try and navigate his
way to scoring twice and getting those
last few points to to take us to game
number three. But I was going to mention
as you kind of alluded to that 4Runner
is also just fine with trading. So,
taking a unit out there, making that
spinning ax have to be reattached if
Dwali wants to keep it, which if you
attach to either of these units is going
to be a massive blowout with Rebuke,
which doesn't feel all that good. And
again, your units are still under
threat. They are not particularly safe
at the battlefields. And the axe is
going to be committed here. Recycling
Aroon making that Darius even bigger.
And what else is left here? Looking at
those mechs, it's nine might at home,
plus the two from the long sword. So 11
total available. Titan are not looking
all that hot as far as defending, but
Darius looking relatively imposing at
the Zorn Warren.
So now the decision-making
puzzle is put on prismaticism because
you cannot allow both locations to go.
You have to conquer at least one to just
not lose the game. But it goes beyond
that as well because if you leave one
location up, then they only have to
conquer the other. And we've already
seen Darius move around a lot with these
tide turner tricks. And there is
obviously accelerate units or more
Dariuses potentially in the hand of
Dewali. So uh you're really only safe if
you go for in my opinion some sort of
double conquer or uh double answer. So
even if
Chris Massim goes in. Yeah, I was going
to say uh we might see something like an
offensive rebuke here. Even though that
doesn't feel great because the Darius
goes to hand and then can ready when it
comes back down. You just still have to
force Dewali into a position where they
have to commit the resources to do so.
You want to limit their options on the
crack back turn.
>> Yeah, this is eight on eight. Uh so I
think prismaticism has passed and like I
said, I know there's a rebuke in his
hand. So I think he's just saying, you
know what, I'm going to bait you to try
and play something here. I mean, unless
you have a hard bargain that I can't pay
for. If uh Di commits something to try
and save this Darius, whether that's a
pump, whether that's two spells, if you
can do that here to pump a Darius,
that's the dream. That would be
disastrous given what we know about
prismatic systems hand. So we are going
to commit something. Oh, it's a rebuke
of his own
>> onto that long sorted mech. That's going
to get bounced back.
I assume we bounce to Darius here, but
not necessarily the only line, but to
the top of the hand it goes.
>> I think I was going to say I think this
should be safe now just because there's
enough runes up where even if Dwali
repeated hard bargain, prismaticism
could pay for it.
>> Yep. I like this play. So uh turning ax
is going to go away. Darius goes back to
hand. It's a very expensive unit to
replay. And Prismaticism threatening to
win once more. Discards a flash.
>> There is another story to be told here.
>> Uh because Dewali played his own rebuke
and then Prismaticism bounces the Darius
back. The rebuke obviously forced Dewali
to recycle two runes. Darius has a power
cost as well. And when I was saying that
you really just want to limit options,
uh, even after channeling and going to
six, Dewali needs to be able to double
conquer because Prismaticism is holding
both spots and it's looking to hold to
win. And I don't think on six runes, the
options are going to be available. So I
think that prismaticism
the recycle. Yes,
>> the hand prismaticism 11 and one Dali.
Oh, that hand is awfully clunky. Falling
star cannot get it done. The long sword
equip actually helping out. There is a
mindset. I guess it's coming in from the
sideboard these days. I was wondering
what that was. I thought it was a bonus
to be flash cleave and that is enough.
It's because Maticism masterfully guides
through not a mirror match, but at least
a uh a matching domain matchup and looks
awfully prepared for the most
represented deck here in Atlanta. Yeah,
that was just kind of a a master class
in my opinion from Prismaticism because
this is playing against the deck that is
the most represented. Playing against
the deck that many feel is still
potentially the most powerful in the
format and playing against a former
regional qualifier winner and
Prismaticism of course made it look easy
in many ways knew exactly what to do and
uh Dwali no slouch. So, uh, this is
somebody who has a plan, has been
executing it. And like I said before,
the fact that game one and game two were
almost identical starts, says that these
players know exactly what it takes to
win, and they're just going to follow
their script until something breaks.
>> I mean, Pris also arguably the player
has played the most Draven like has has
a best of Draven card had did top eight
anarch in Bolognia on actually in Vegas
as well on Draven. So, knows that very
well. still a deck he could have piloted
here in the same domains, a style he
clearly likes. Even though it's not the
miracle version, would have been more
than comfortable on a more mid-range
deck. Decides that actually, you know
what, I like these domains, but I don't
like this legend as much. I'd rather
play Annie. I think that's what will
make me more successful in this field.
And given the how much Draven is in the
meta, given his results in not just this
week, but last week, hard to argue with
Prismaticism right now, who is your
player to watch moving into the top
eight and at this point, very likely to
make it there again. Yeah, I'm just
happy that we finally got Prismaticism
on the broadcast because made me look
smart. Thank you, Prismaticism. Thank
you. Cuz I've been singing the praises
all weekend long and now you got to see
exactly why.
>> Yep. Uh we're never breaches never
coming back if anyone wants to know.
It's just never making it back in.
There's there's none left.
>> I mean again X2 again I'm I'm not good
at standings math. So do not look to me
for any of that. Uh that is something I
will leave to the professional.
>> We should ask Kangas. We are getting We
should
>> I hear Kangas is great at math.
>> What if he's lowkey really good at
standings math? That's like his one
thing. I'd love it. Honestly, Kangas, if
you're out there, you let us know. Uh we
are getting close though. That is round
12 in the books, more or less. Some
matches perhaps still finishing, but uh
we only have one run left of Swiss
before our top eight. We're getting uh
awfully close to having only eight
players left in this 1,500 or so player
tournament.
>> It is hard to believe that we're already
there. I honestly feel like the event
just started. It has flown by. Uh the
games have been great. The community has
been awesome when we've talked to people
out here on the floor. Everything has
just been a wonderful time. And so, uh
it really is hard to think that we are
one round away from our top eight.
>> And again, a lot of exciting things to
look at. I don't the updated standings
yet. No, I'm so curious who whoever uh
whoever gets to check the standings next
is going to be in for a treat cuz the
number of potential X1 players, the
number of different legends they could
be playing. I mean, I have to say for
all the story lines we've track,
Prismatic is an excellent one. Can't
wait to hear from him in a moment in a
winners interview, I'm sure. But
>> I really want to know if Set's going to
make it. I I have to imagine at this
point Colin is already locked for the
best of, but it's got to be a little bit
better than that. I feel like
>> I think that's a fair assessment. It
would be difficult for me to think that
>> there's a better set player in the room.
>> There's a better set player at the
moment. Uh that being said, we know
after day one that there were only three
decided best of. So there was at least a
player in play.
>> Yeah, 25 other legends still up in the
air as the tournament is going as the
rest of them battle for the best of here
on day number two. I also just realized,
by the way, uh there is a Jinx also
floating around X1. Again, don't know
what the result was, but we could have
the same domains represented in top
eight by three different legends, which
I'm very confident in saying I don't
think that has ever happened before in
original qualifier.
>> And I'm sure that the community would
take that in stride. There would be no
problems with that whatsoever. Uh the
sky would not be falling. Uh it very
well could happen. I think that it still
would not necessarily be an indictment
on the meta because at the end of the
day, the thing I think folks need to
remember is uh we've seen a lot of
legends perform very well. It is
difficult to make the top eight. Yes,
you have to be an incredibly skilled
player and what I'm about to say is not
meant to take anything away from them,
but any good player will also tell you
you kind of need a little luck to go
your way from time to time. And so
sometimes the chips just fall in a
direction where you'll get six fury
chaos. There is a famous phrase in card
games and I'm sure many other avenues of
life. It is better to be lucky than
good. And if you're trying to win a card
game tournament, you best be both.
That's basically the conventional
wisdom.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. With that, we do have an
interview ready with our winner of our
last round. Let's hear from the man
himself, Prismaticism.
>> Thanks so much for the pass. I cannot
believe we got two heavy hitters in this
second to last round here of Swiss. the
Houston regional champion versus a three
time top cutting player in yourself,
Prismat. You now also have two best of
and if you get this one, it's your third
one, correct?
>> Yeah, it will be my third one,
>> which as far as I'm keeping track so
far, that will be the highest amount
that people have in
>> I'll be tied with Allan. Yeah, I'm still
playing for his. So, I'm still catching
up to that guy. He's pretty good.
>> No, absolutely. So, I here's the big
thing. I just saw you last weekend, Lil,
you had an amazing performance.
Obviously not the win that you wanted to
lock in, but you are now on your way to
now your fourth top cut. Please, please,
please gush about Annie. We've already
seen her win a regional qualifier back
in Origins and now you've not only shown
that she still can compete and even post
bands with a lot of hits to these two
domains. How and why?
>> Well, after the bands, I was looking for
a deck. I had a lot of ideas. Uh Annie
was one of them. I tested her out. Uh
Allan's my main testing partner, so I
test a lot against Ezreal. And it's sort
of the idea where if the deck's good
enough to beat Allen or at least go
50/50 with him, it's probably a pretty
good deck. But I think it was the first
week after the bands, I was actually
having some trouble beating him with
Annie, but that was with an older build.
Was not as refined. Uh I switched to
Aurelia. I was trying that out for a
week. I found that the mirror match was
just not very not very skill intensive.
I really just wanted to avoid that as
much as possible. and it felt like it
was still a pretty and it would still
have an advantage in other matchups but
still pretty draw dependent deck overall
pretty reliant on the Celicorn Herders.
So on the Sunday weekend before Le I
switched back to Annie. There was an
event in Toronto that I played at and
then went through that did really well
there. I was like okay I'm locking in
this deck. Um it's has a lot of unfair
turns. It's the best forerunner deck in
the game where I get to play the 4Runner
immediately protect it with flash.
That's a lot of value there. We we saw
it literally in that match really quick.
>> Well, it got it got hard bargained
twice, but that's the thing is even if
that happens, you're so far ahead on
tempo from the early game that you have
the time to just play it again and your
opponent, they're not going to have the
second rebuke, second harden. Well, they
could, but very very unlikely.
>> Well, it it's just like you said, I
mean, you know that how good in that
pushing that is and Dewali 100% respects
that. He knows that you need to hard
bargain. You have to exchange these
resources in the correct way. And I
thought it was an impeccable match
regardless of the actual end result of
the 2. You two every single game and
every single movement y'all made is
inches on each other. Like you said, I
mean just it really shows. And what I
want to kind of really pitch, you
brought about your play test partner
with Allan.
>> Yeah.
>> How many hours have you spent playing
Riftbound right now and how much time it
has taken to be as prolific as you are?
>> I mean, I have no idea. Like back back
in set one, early set two, me and Allan
were doing like 10-hour days together.
Uh after the bands, we were not doing
quite as much testing, but still doing a
decent amount, like three or four hours
a day, figuring stuff out and then also
playing at locals as well to get a
little more a little bit more variety of
the practice. Um but total number of
hours, I mean, easily four digits. I if
you count like the time thinking about
the game and outside of just playing at
maybe five, I don't know.
>> Wow. All right, my last question, but
it's not going to be just for you. Um, I
actually have a special guest here that
I want to ask this question to. Um, you
first, Prismat. How does it feel to now
have swapped legends and having success
with them as our Annie winner in Dewali
Draven best of now having changed
places? How do you feel about having now
this kind of dual rivalry identity?
>> I mean, it's pretty cool. Dewali's
amazing player. I still got to get the
win to match up with him. Uh, but yeah,
Red Purple is really good.
>> That's true. Thoughts, Dewali?
>> Yeah. Um, so in Origins, everyone's
like, "Kais's best deck. We brought
Annie and crushed." And then this time
everyone's like, "Oh, Draven's busted.
Areli's busted. He brings Annie in
crushes." I'm sitting there wishing it
was me. Like, but you know what? It's
It's I had a good time. It's fun. He's a
He's a really p you know, you're a
powerful opponent. Like, it's I sit down
across from him like, "What the you
know, I'm" and it was it was a rough
match for me and I think your deck is
busted and I I hope you win the
tournament. So, yeah. two incredible
players, an incredible match for both of
you. I look forward to seeing more of
your faces, not just later today, but
the rest of future regional qualifiers.
Thanks for the great insight. We're
going to send it back.
>> Thank you very much, Brad. Always lovely
to hear from our winner, but even nice
to hear from our loser as well, while
he's stepping up to have a little
chitchat about them swapping best of.
>> Yeah, and not just stepping up, but also
gushing about the opponent. Again,
that's what I love about the community.
We were seeing a lot of uh jovial banter
post matches. At least I have on the
floor where people, you know, you lose a
tight game, but then they talk about
what happened. I've seen a lot of uh
situations like that where you're just
like, you're a powerful opponent.
>> That's true.
>> Uh I would print that on something and
hang it on my refrigerator if I was
prismatic.
>> That's a shirt prismat.
I am a powerful opponent. It's very
true. again the uh the most powerful
opponent really that we have been
watching all not I would say all weekend
long but it's actually been like all
Brickbound organized play lifetime long
certainly in recent RQ seasons. Uh
really cool to see Annie still doing
well. Dwan thinks it might be the best
tech in the tournament. That is
>> honestly I heard it and my immediate
thing was a little bit of whiplash but
it's marinating a bit more now in my
mind and I think that might be kind of
true cuz we talked about 4Runner being
maybe the best card in the format and I
agree with Prisman. is the best for a
deck.
>> So, I think it's also
it's a very astute assessment from
Dewali because if there's anybody who
can judge an Annie deck, it's the person
who won the first ever regional
qualifier in Houston with Annie. But
also, I just keep thinking back to, you
know, we've talked about how the meta
might slow down because of the postbans.
And in several instances leading up to
this event when I would talk to other
players, talk to you especially uh I
have said I really feel like Annie's
well positioned to go underneath and if
it can get that done uh it can be a very
powerful deck and that's exactly what
we've seen.
>> Yeah, that's what we certainly saw in
that match as well. We're going to move
on back over to the desk cuz you have a
little bit more postmatch analysis.
>> Thank you very much Pry. Here we're
going to take a look at game number one
and a critical end to the game and some
of the intricacies of the matchup and
potentially a different route that
Dewali could have taken. So let's pull
it up on screen because this was of
course game one where prismaticism is
already ahead a significant amount of
points. Also has a lot of units on the
field and this is actually a little uh
past where I would like it to be. If we
could go back to around 40 uh 350 I'm
going to guess. Uh maybe even 45. Let's
let's try 45 cuz what I want to
highlight is when the brin here first
hits the field. So we're going to rewind
until the brin here just enters. Now we
can go forward to when the brin here
enters play. Thank you very much to the
operator. So Brin here comes in and
immediately prismaticism is going to be
a little worried about this. So let's
see the brin here hit the field cuz once
Brin here is in play, you cannot play
cards for the rest of the turn. You have
to use any reactions that you have right
away. So you're going to see Dewali's
doing some math. He's seen that you want
to deal with the Rex eye cuz that's
going to allow anything to come in
accelerated not from the hand
specifically things like the mech tokens
the Annie potentially you have two
overzealous fans you got to get through
and even the affair's 4Runner tough unit
to deal with so let's see how Dwali does
it actually let's just fast forward okay
no no we got it we got there we go
perfect hit the field now we're feeling
a little concerned now luckily you have
a reaction window because Briner
thundersong is a trigger so that means
you can react what does prismaticism
have in hand? Annie does not have that
many reactions, but one key one which
will be nice is that we get the flash
off.
Actually, looks like I'm a little early
on that, but eventually Prismaticism
will feel good about having that flash
say, "Okay, I at least get to save some
of my units." Now, I want to fast
forward a little bit past this because
basically what's going to happen is
we're going to send a bunch of units in
and we're going to try and clear these
off and we're going to use the falling
star to clear try and reinforce and then
rebuke comes down on Prismaticism's turn
and Dewali is going to scoop. But
because of the route that we went, I
actually want to analyze a potential
different line Dewali could have done.
Let's go back uh about a minute here to
see the first time that the tide turner
tries to go in and contest this
battlefield. So we flash away two of the
units. We have these two here and Dewali
chooses to send Ty Turner in. And since
these are two of the best players in the
world, it's easy to think like, oh yeah,
this has to be the correct call. Often
I'll just default to that. But looking
back on it, there's some potential other
lines because we have a lot of other
units that could go, specifically
something like the Darius. If we imagine
we send the Darius in, if you count up,
we've played one card so far. So there's
one Brin here played in base. We could
send the Darius in instead of the side
turner. That will move back. And if
we're going to play the falling star
anyway, the falling star can deal with
the Rex eye and the overzealous fan
readying the Darius and then send the
Darius back in with the two might of the
tie turner and the Noxus or the Ferris
4Runner and then potentially we're able
to have more points holding cuz the idea
behind the rebuke is oh we don't have
enough to deal with what's already on
the board. Like just what's visible will
clear that but if we have the extra two
might maybe we're able to hold a little
bit better. Obviously, we don't know
what else prismaticism had in terms of
resources, so maybe that's all mute. But
it's just one of those things to think
that there's so many different decision
trees and all the branching paths lead
to different results. This one led to
prismaticisms when that's our breakdown.
Back to the casters.
Thank you, Kang. It's always fun to
analyze different lines. A tough one
there again without knowing all the hand
information. It's hard to say. I could
see the appeal, but I understand why
Dwight did what he did because he's
going with the huristic that's kind of
becoming a standard of Rift Band. That's
uh win in twos if you can.
>> Yeah, I think that the win by twos is uh
become kind of the prevalent gameplay
preference because it's not even just
these decks where you are trying to be
the aggressor whether you're Annie or
Draven. Uh but again, we saw Arya
earlier in the broadcast on Ireelia and
when I spoke to her teammates because
they're all on that same Ireelia list.
They said specifically that that opener
with the sneaky deck hands is to get
them on twos. Going to two to four to
six to eight is incredibly important or
at a minimum you want to position
yourself to where you can get to that
magic number six so that you can start
threatening the double conquer. That's
going to change the way that your
opponent approaches the board and
interacts with your pieces. Yeah, I mean
you could see again even in the even
that game where there's a lot of back
and forth and kind of the battlefields
are split because there's so much
powerful might on either side of the
table. Uh players were navigating
themselves like from five to six and
then just kind of going from there,
right? You want to make sure you get to
those different break points. So again,
you can set up a situation where you set
up to take those final two points and
grab the winning one. We do have another
game though for you though and uh we
heard actually this player mentioned
already on a broadcast just a just a
moment ago. Do you remember the name
that prismaticism said
>> it? I think it rhymed with like balance.
Balance. Uh,
>> it's a big deal. It's Alan's EQ. He's
back on Ezreal as always. Looking to win
his third best off on the legend. Didn't
quite get there in Liil, but has been
looking very good. So, that's going to
be our match up. Ezreal versus Draven. A
Draven play we've actually seen on
stream already as well. In Liil, it was
51%. In Atlanta, it is 48%. That is
absurdly good. I have to feel like
>> it's interesting because it both are
very close to 50%. It's probably overall
what the matchup is in general, but what
this statistic doesn't take into account
is Alen. I know that Alen is far greater
than 50% in matchups.
>> Uh certainly at this game in general, it
feels like so Allen's Q still in the
running. Uh has one loss and a draw. So
still alive for top eight, I have to
imagine. And uh Kyra Kra of Kaira, a
player we saw on Draven earlier, just uh
not quite get over the line against
Kaiser, who was at least coming into
this round, our only undefeated Oh, our
one of two undefeated players, a play
with a draw with no losses. It keeps
getting me, but our our first place
player on Kaiser did defeat this Draven
on stream. So, we'll see who's going to
end up with only a single loss in their
column after this round. It is 911
versus 101 the records. It is Climb
versus Arena's greatest and Draven is
going first. Draven. Got to feel good
about that.
>> Yeah. And of course, this was the player
that uh was part of that exchange where
we saw all six Ferris 4unners on the
battlefield. Uh again,
>> that will not happen.
>> Our uh Kai'Sa player did take that home
and you are correct, it will not happen
in this game. But uh we do have, as you
pointed out, the greatest going into the
climb. So, it's going to be a standard
still eight points to win. You need nine
total to win, but because you're both
starting at one, you just have to
somehow score eight. So, kind of
negating the benefit of the climb with
the arena's greatest.
>> Yep. Don't get tricked, chat. Uh, there
are ones on screen from the arena's
greatest, but we're still looking for
nine, even though it's the same number
of total points as a regulation game.
Powro going to rock on in and take a
point off the arena's greatest. And
Pyro, the second, is going to join Nox's
hopeful the first as they look to maybe
assault the aspirants climb in the
following turns. And this is the thing
we know about Allen's deck. It is uh a
little slower, a little more
controlling, very Trixy, very powerful
when you can amass resources and keep
the card flow going, which is something
Ezreal's legend ability is awfully good
at doing.
>> Yeah. And right now, I was going to say
I think we're just going to see some
development of some might. There's not
really many options that are going to
deal with these porros effectively that
you want to use at this state. Uh this
is in my opinion kind of a nightmare
start for Alen simply because those
porros while they're just two might they
do have deflect. That deflect is
sometimes relevant and against a deck
like a Ezreal, excuse me, where you want
to do a bunch of targeting. Uh paying
for that and dramping down those runes
is going to be potentially relevant. Uh
hopeful as well with that form might is
sometimes a little bit harder to take
out. There's a lot of things uh that
only deal three. Uh we are in game three
so we don't know if maybe rocket barrage
has come in. Uh but that would have to
have uh targeted in the base. I feel
like hopeful is going to be making its
way to a battlefield soon. I think the
other thing to think about is like uh
macro matchup wise. Draven obviously
wants to be the aggressor in this game.
Uh can be you know go a bit bigger but
Allenz isn't really concerned about the
size or the the width of your units at
all. Allen I think is one of the few
decks in Riftbound that could win uh
when your opponent is at, you know,
seven or eight points. One point away
from winning. Ezreal can hold down the
fort long enough to win from zero. I'm
not saying it's going to be easy and
certainly this start looks very good for
Draven over Zal's fan joining Patty Para
on the top side and one unit going back
as it's four points now for our Draven
player. But this is the kind of thing
Allen is used to maybe doesn't like
exactly how it's going in terms of the
tempo of the game. But Ezreal is a deck
that can grind you out.
This might be the sort of game where
Allen falls incredibly far behind but
gets back into it off of the back of
like a watcher bellows combo. That is
something that has really risen in
popularity but we haven't seen a lot on
broadcast this weekend.
However, when your opponent goes so
wide, there's not many other tools to
catch back up. Uh Alen, I don't believe
is running unchecked power. That's just
not his style. Has not been in any of
his previous lists. So
wages, buying some time, card sharp,
getting some points is okay.
Unless Alen can come up with a big
answer for all of this might though, I I
don't know how you get back into this.
>> There is something somewhere. It's just
kind of a matter of when. So holding up
some runes, but uh feels logical at
least to go away from the card shop
that's occupying the ice as climb. And
again, to remind you all, we've talked a
lot about uh winning in twos. And six is
usually the point we want to look for
because that is where you can
potentially look to score twice and win.
Uh six in this game is going to be seven
thanks to Asper's climb. Yep. Thanks, J.
We didn't catch that on the broadcast,
but you can all imagine in your mind's
eye what just happened. Gust, Gust,
Wages of Pain. I can see those three
cards at least in Alexander. Pouty Porro
going to move on in. and even Augusti,
which isn't a bad answer, trying to
maybe uh move something off the board.
Boy, oh boy, is it annoying to Gustoa
Powro thanks to that deflect. Yeah,
again, the deflect is very meaningful
and annoying. I think that's why this is
the go-to uh additional two drop, right?
You've got the tie turners, they have
that utility. You've got the overzealous
fans, they have that utility. Earlier we
were talking about just two drops that
you're okay with also drawing in the
late game and porro because of that
deflect can sometimes come up big and
especially as a Draven play if you're
expecting mirrors and you get to a
situation where your opponent is playing
falling stars and or rebukes and now
they're also paying deflect costs it can
be a very big deal. How much is bellows
plus uh so repeat bellows plus watcher
>> repeat bellows? Uh that would be 11
>> 11
>> uh likely 10. Uh it is worth noting that
uh Ezreal does reduce the additional
costs and Alen will likely play that
ahead of time if that's going to be the
case. But uh we are going to see a
mindspplitter get rid of that ride the
wind from Kra.
>> Well, this is interesting cuz that is
the last card in Draven's hand. Minds
that it does actually reinforce the
aspirants climb. Gets a point for Allen.
Goes up to three. Doesn't leave too many
options available, but again, Allen
happy to grind out the game. Draven's
come out of the gates very quickly.
Racking up points now. Going to go to
six off this hold, but currently cannot
top of the mind spplitter with the six
might in base. I just have to feel like
Allan is very patiently building up to a
turn where he can turn the corner. But
Kaiser such a good top deck,
accelerating in, going to get a card
draw, going to get two if he win the
combat. And Stupify going to try and
trink the units here. And I did find
Allen yet another answer. And there's
the gust. Pumps the hopeful up. It's now
small enough to get moved back to hand.
And Midsman is going to win the day
effortlessly.
>> Yeah, that was such a beautiful exchange
there for Allen. The defy into the gust
and specifically on the hopeful because
you don't want the Kai'Sa to go back to
hand. You want to get rid of that.
>> Uh you maintain the point hold. You slow
down your opponent. They just answers
with playing a huge Draven because of
Klein. Yeah, that one does not lose to
watches repeated bellows. It's a little
too big even for that little
combination, but uh rebuke's deck. Smoke
screen I can see in hand. Allen has so
many cards and Draven is out. This is a
very classic kind of aggro versus
control matchup. Not necessarily what
these decks always want to do, but I
think in this particular matchup, that
is how it is going to present itself.
So, Ezreal out of the chosen champ soon
going to discard a card and draw two
more. Allen has a huge bit of card
advantage. Is that enough to overcome
the points disadvantage?
I think you've misspoken because you
just said Draven is out of cards. And
I've been assured that that doesn't
happen.
>> Are you sure?
>> Uh but it does happen when you just
continue to vomit out these cheap units
again. You had all these two drops. You
had the hopefuls which are uh
essentially two drops.
>> HP.
>> We are
going to see the bellows. We were
talking about that coming down. uh the
damage being done and then the card
chart going in is just gonna kind of
recreate a miniature watcher bellows
combo.
>> Now it's just the Draven who I I will
remind is nine might right now and gets
even a little bit of bonus might thanks
to Aspirin's climb being the battlefield
in this game cuz you get more points
than you typically would in a normal
game of Riftbound. But that is big
enough to the mind splitter. But Allan
just has so many cards in hand. And I
mean, I did say this is a game where
Allan could potentially win from zero.
And it's not zero right now, but it's
starting to feel like Allan has
completely turned the corner. He has
cleared the board. All but one unit and
the top of Draven's deck.
We'll see what this top deck is. If it's
another Kai'Sa, this would have been a
beautiful opportunity to uh go up in
some points and draw some additional
cards. That's going to be the big story
here.
You want to try to get to at least seven
because again aspirin's climb seven is
the new six and then you can go from 7
to9 in a double conquer but does not
want to leave the Draven alone on a
battlefield. So just passes and this is
Alen's window of opportunity to close
the point gap. I see a Fizz in hand as
well. I see a huge trash stocked full of
spells that Fizz can try and go for
again. Might move in onto Arena's
greatest go to point number five again.
not really concerned with the speed of
his getting his points. He'll get them
eventually, but Kop going to come down
reinforce. That's 10 mine now. Enough to
best the Draven face up as it is only a
nine with those six points like Kyra
has. Gold going to be generated. No gold
given back again. Kop does give your
opponent the option to make a gold and
if they do, you get an extra one. And I
don't think I want to give Alan ZQ any
extra resources in just about any game
of Riftbound I might find myself
against. And Ezreal is going to join the
party as well. Just say that's good
enough. I've got again about eight cards
in my hand. What do you have? Cuz you
did not play the one you drew.
>> And it also makes sense that you would
always want to deny the gold generation
to Alen. Because if you're already
playing units with deflect, you're
trying to make sure that your opponent
has to spend more resources on your
stuff. You don't want to give them free
ways to get around cards like Pouty
Porro. Uh Draven does go up to seven
here. And then we have a fan to back it
up. I can tell you that the fan is not
going to do very much because there are
so many ways for Alan Tech to kill over
fan.
>> Yeah, I was going to say I respect the
fan, but you've already seen gusts and
things like that. Wages of painen wages
of pain.
>> Uh there's a bunch of those in hand.
>> This is going to be massive because the
six damage while not killing the Draven
will put it in danger of being
destroyed. And earlier I was saying, you
know, you might need something like a
watcher's bellow's breath to clean
everything up. is so clean.
>> It turns out a mini Bellow's breath
combo followed by a singularity to clean
things up gets the job done as well.
>> As soon as you see that singularity,
your heart sinks because you know Allan
is not playing this card targeting your
10 might unit if there is not a followup
and that I think is going to be the
straw that breaks this Draven's back.
Mindsitter are going to chill there at
the arena's greatest going to retreat
his other units
and again the point lead is in the favor
of the player you'd expect. It is up to
Draven, but I think this game is out of
reach.
I'm also pretty confident that one of
the cards heard you drew is a cleave,
and that does not do anything if you
don't have any units. And you can see D
players laughing in the player cam.
Yeah, I'd be curious to know what the
other card is, but uh this is a
situation where if one thing just would
have went the other way, right, when
that top decked Kai'Sa went in expecting
to go over that battlefield, get an
additional point, but also get the draw,
game would have been completely
different. However, now uh as a Draven
player, you're in a position where you
have no cards in hand almost. You've
been struggling to draw. Apparently no
units to develop either.
>> Oh, it's happening again. What do you
got? Mind spplitter. Scoop of shame.
Nope. Show him off. It's Darius and a
tie turner. I think Darius is probably
the first one cuz he couldn't do
anything with the Darius and the Titan
is not going to do much of anything.
Allan one point away from winning.
Cardrop goes in. All we do is have to
hold. And there's one draw off the top
of the deck to see if it's it. Flips
over the X. Flips over the TI turner and
shakes the hand. Allen ZQ still live for
top eight 101 Anguang with a masterclass
in Ezreal versus Draven.
>> So the thing that I really like about
that particular matchup is that uh Alen
was patient, knew how to resource manage
against Draven, avoided the combats, got
them to run out of cards, but also very
effectively played around the way that
Kyra could have got back into the game.
Specifically, when we saw that Darius, I
was starting to wonder if maybe what the
game plan was was waiting for something
like a Darius plus Kai'Sa combo where
you just double accelerate, catch Allen
off guard if he somehow pulls back or
leaves not enough might on a spot. Yes,
there was the mindsplitter for most of
that, but there was still, I think, a
path. Allen just did a great job of
shutting any opportunity down and locked
in the win.
>> That's why he loves this deck. He he he
believes that this is a deck where you
have enough time, have enough space, you
you do enough practice, you can answer
just about any problem someone can throw
at you in Riftbound and you have to do a
lot of reps to get to that level of
mastery and Allen clearly has on Ezreal.
I do want to think though, I'm going to
have to scroll back to footage cuz I I
just thought of something that might
have been a mistake. I can't remember if
he ever activated his legend.
>> He must have. He must have. What do you
mean why do you hand size limited rift
bound? That's That's so Alen. If he
actually never activated it, but he had
the opportunity like with the Bell was
at least the only one I could think of.
I was like, "Oh, there wasn't any other
opportunities."
>> That's the most alien thing that you
could possibly do. This card doesn't
need text. I just want to play the
Azreel in the champion.
>> We'll check the tapes, but uh if if that
is true, uh that is all. We are going to
go down to the desk cuz Barrett is
standing by with someone you you may all
know and love. Uh yeah, let's check out
Barrett and Kasanova.
>> Welcome over here. I am joined by the
wonderful Kasanova, who I've had the
pleasure to even sit backstage with, of
course, in the Houston regional
qualifier. Kasanova, let me just ask, as
we're here in Atlanta, how are you
doing?
>> I'm great. I think every single time I
get to come to one of these, it is a
treat, a pleasure. Uh, meeting all the
people who are excited about Riftbound.
People like to come up to me and talk
about content or talk about Riftbound or
talk about casting or anything is an
absolute blast. And, uh, I just love
playing the game. I I got to pick up a
new deck uh just before Lil uh had a day
two there and uh I've just still been
playing it. Look, results weren't what I
wanted this time, but I've still had a
blast playing. So, yeah.
>> I mean, it was a good enough legend that
people like Sandy D Sherman also picked
up Lucian, right?
>> I was surprised by some crushers
bringing the uh the event here. The guy
who like top two tune in Event New
Zealand on uh Lucian showed up to this
event. Blame Lucian again. Yeah.
>> Well, speaking of people that top cut,
that's kind of what I want to pick your
brain about. you know, you know, you
make the content, you know, you watch
every event, including the Chinese
streams. Uh, let's talk about the
standings that we have right now. So,
these are from our post round 11
standings. And why you're here and why I
wanted to ask you is you're an expert on
a lot of these names. There are so many
people here that are not only, you know,
actual regional qualifier champions with
Allen's EQ, Dewali right here, but other
people in the scene that we know are
already having success. We have
Prismaticism here in the fifth seed.
Frosty being the only real undefeated
after that round, spoiler alert, having
beaten prismaticism in that round. And
then people even like Boulevard who have
come from all over the place.
>> Yeah, I mean Bullard is a literal world
champion. Uh Boulevard very good friend
of mine. He used to cast Legends of Rune
Terra with myself and Charmer and Bry
Time who have been on the desk all
weekend. So we we absolutely love this
guy and uh he's got a very spicy Draven
list that's got arena's greatest and
aspirates climb in it. some very cool
stuff. Uh very proud of him. I think
he's doing a great job. But on top of
that, I mean, prismaticism, right? You
mentioned the the past success.
>> Three top eights. No one has been able
to do remotely what he can do, but he
wants that win. It it matters so much to
him. He doesn't think about the three
top eights. He's hungry for the win. And
of course, you know, players who have
gotten it, as you said, Dwali, Allen's
EQ. I know there's a win and in for
Dewali and Prismat happening either now
or happened earlier, but it's it is it
is that is a game that I'm so excited to
watch myself. And I even heard that
Frosty being on Kai'Sa, this is a deck
that we thought might be a little bit
dunzo nowadays with the Aurelas after
the performance we saw in Liil. Frosty
showing us that's not true. No, I mean
third most represented deck in the
tournament, but like you said, we
haven't seen Kaisa top cut a single
Spirit Forge real regional qualifier and
today might finally be the day right
before we end it going into Unleashed.
But again, more names. Colin Kaiser
here, known set player, took a break
from it and now is back on it as we got
to highlight him at the end of day one.
>> Crazy that he's at 10 and one on set. I
do think that this deck kind of got a
lot from the bands. it, you know, it
struggled with Reaver's Row, it
struggled with uh Fighter Flight, and
now having those out of there, it's
really, really good for Colin to kind of
come in and play his favorite. A couple
of the challenger guys did, I actually
want to He's not on the screen, but I
want to shout out Villionaire brought
his favorite deck, Volibear, and he'd
been worried about bringing it for so
long. He's like,
>> I'm going to do it. And I think he may
he he's getting close to locking that
best of, which is really really awesome.
And I I also I mean, we're talking about
these like weird decks.
>> I got to talk about this. I don't know
who this player is, but they are 10-1 on
Jinx, so I want to know who this player
is.
>> Uh, we had them actually as a backup
match. And, you know, spoiler alert,
obviously you guys didn't get to see
that match. It was amazing.
>> I got to see it at some point.
>> He's playing out of his mind. And not
only that, you talk about things that
got hit by the bandless. A lot of people
thought a character like Jinx was dead
in the water.
>> I mean, I did.
>> And then here we go sitting right next
to exactly that same situation with
Colin Kaiser. Of course, we only have
eight slots going into top eight. So my
final question for you, Kasanova, is
this. Out of all these names right here,
if you had to pick eight people on this
list alone,
>> so I got to pick eight out of 16.
>> You got to pick eight of them.
>> And I can't pick both Pris and Dewali
cuz I know for a fact they both won't
make it
>> cuz they're playing.
>> Cuz they're playing.
>> Easy lock up here. I think you can take
a question if Coco loses too, right?
>> Yeah, we'll we'll take Frosty and Coco.
That's that's how that feel that feels
good. Um I'm going to take one of the
two from this matchup. I'm gonna take
Prismaticism. I think the Annie deck is
the best deck in the room. I think Pris
deck and I think he's the best pilot in
the room. So, you know, we got we got
two for two on that. So, I'll take Pris
even though Sean's a crusher and he's
going to be
>> very difficult to beat.
>> And I think I'm going to take Boulevard.
I think we should really really count
him in here because I mean I think this
is really the chance to shine. So, it's
very much one of those ideas. So, real
quick, I got to make you pick a couple
more, right? 1 2 3 four.
>> I would also take Boulevard. So then uh
then let's go Colin. I think Colin is
too big of a crusher. He's going to make
it happen. Uh I can't bet against Allen.
I think that would be ridiculous.
>> I played against Arya in the uh
pre-regional and I think she was a very
strong player. I would not be surprised
for her to pick up uh that spot. And
then what do I do I have one more?
>> Yeah,
>> I don't know how to count, but I think
one more is probably fine. Let's throw
the Jinx in there. I don't think I don't
believe with my head, but I believe with
my heart. So we'll see if the Jinx can
make
>> You heard it here. Official prediction
of your top eight from Kasanova. Thanks
so much for joining me. We're t tossing
it back.
>> Hello everybody. Charmer here at the
regional qualifier in Atlanta and we're
doing a deck spotlight to talk about a
deck that I am very passionate about and
one that I think has the potential to
perform well at this event. It's none
other than Annie. Uh this is a list that
has been piloted by Prismaticism to
great success. This is a list that I
think has a good opportunity to go
underneath some of these decks and kind
of compete with Azir as being one of the
premier aggressive decks in the format.
And because of that, I want to talk
about why Annie works so well with that
game plan. Starting with, of course, the
legend ability. If you're not familiar,
at the end of your turn, you get to
ready two runes. And what that does is
it allows you to develop your board,
develop units, and then still have
energy up for you to be able to play
some of these key spells that Annie
likes to feature, such as Rebuke, such
as Flash, Switcheroo, and even Long
Sword. Uh, Flash is the one that I
really want to highlight here at the
beginning though because uh, one, it
comes with her in proving ground. So,
obviously it was kind of designed or
meant to be played with her, but also
Flash in particular does something
important because Annie is playing these
cost effective cheap units to get the
early scoring. It usually means that you
don't have a lot of large units to go
over the top. It does run some, and
we'll get to those in a moment. But
these early units, you do want to keep
them alive. if you want to protect them
and flash is a very effective way to do
so. And because it costs exactly two
energy, your legend ability means you
will always have that available. Another
card that I want to highlight is of
course rebuke. Rebuke is a premier uh
kind of answer to problems that are
posed by your opponent in the meta right
now. There's a lot of decks that are
trying to focus on maybe one or two
large units, whether that's the offmeta
decks like Orin or Illusian, but also
with decks like Aurelia, and you're
going to need to have an answer for
those really large Aurelia, and
particularly an answer that goes around
cards like Guardians Angel or even
potentially the Za's Hourglass. So, if
you're going to be playing this Rebuke,
you have to expect your opponent to have
counter spells, specifically not so
fast. So, how do you answer it? Counter
spells of your own. Another great card
in Annie is of course hard bargain. Once
again, exactly two energy. So, it pairs
very well with her legend ability, but
also if you just naturally leave two up
and then ready to more, now you can play
both rebuke and hard bargain on their
turn if you catch them overextending
with their rune expenditure. So, I
mentioned the top end of the list. Of
course, we have the uh Ferris 4runner.
This is kind of the staple in fury decks
right now. It is very sticky. What that
means is it's hard to remove in a lot of
situations because when it dies, that
Death Nell ability means you get two
more mechs. So, you get six might
followed by six might. It also pairs
incredibly well with the new tech that
many of these fury lists are including,
which is, of course, the fury version of
Rexai. So this is uh a Rex eye that
allows you to give accelerate to units
that are not played from hand. So that
means units from the champion zone like
your anti- champion unit, but also it
does mean from the mechs that are
created from Fairest 4Runner as well.
Sometimes that allows you to kind of get
back into combat if you have to
sacrifice the 4Runner on an offensive
trade, but you'll get the mechs. You can
pay the accelerate cost to then go back
into combat with them. It's a very cool
trick, a very cool interaction. The
other bits of the top end that I want to
highlight is mindsplitter. Uh sometimes
this is a one of this particular list
showcases one. Sometimes it's two or you
might see more in the sideboard. But
this is a card that is a lot of might,
but also because you get to look at your
opponent's hand. Sometimes you can get
rid of those key cards that they might
be using to counter your strategies and
again kind of seal the deal because your
goal is to be very aggressive out of the
gate and then capitalize at the end with
something like this to deny or you could
use something like ride the wind. Uh
ride the wind is in this list as well.
Both to save your units much like with
flash, but also it can be used to get
additional points even on your
opponent's turn if they do not respect
it. Ride the wind of course also costs
two energy. You might be sensing a theme
with these Annie lists. Two energy is
kind of that marquee cost for your
effects.
One other thing to note, battlefield
selection. Annie wants to be aggressive.
So, we're going to see battlefields like
arena's greatest and that's going to
accelerate the points that you gain
because you're going to get the free one
from the battlefield. Uh, but
specifically, we're seeing more and more
decks, especially these mid-range Draven
lists that are running Aspirants Climb,
trying to slow the game down. If you can
kind of predict when your opponent
planes to play that, specifically when
they are going second, you can then
deploy your arena's greatest to offset
that or if you want to play it when
you're going first to really accelerate
the race. That is also an option as
well. Uh, again, this is, I think, just
a very flexible list. It's very low to
the ground. It's very cost effective. It
allows you to play a lot of might early
and then kind of protect those units. It
has some pretty decent card draw baked
in as well with of course cards like the
Kaisa Survivor. Uh some of the other
battlefields help with the card draw
andor filtering in the form of Zan
Warren or uh the new seed of power which
seed of power is actually fantastic in
Annie because you get to draw a card
based on the other battlefields you
control. This is a list that very often
wants to double conquer and so you're
going to be pulling that off, getting
that additional draw, refilling your
hand. The last card that I want to end
with because it's it's one that I'm so
happy is making uh its presence felt in
the meta is Rengar. This Rengar uh is
not two energy, which is I think why it
was not included in many of the earlier
Annie lists. But for one more energy and
a power, if you go up to three energy
and one power, you can offensively get
five might because this can be played
offensively with uh essentially ambush.
Again, this was printed before unleash,
so it has that reaction, but it does say
that you can play it where you are
attacking. And then because it has
assault 2, it has that three might plus
the two from assault. So this is you pay
three, you get plus five, and you get
the unit that sticks around. So again,
longterm, you get to utilize that might
for reconquering, etc. Uh this is a card
that I think has been uh performing very
well. In fact, yesterday when I was
listening to players playing in the
Friday event, I heard two people mention
that they were blown out by this card.
So, I would expect to see this kind of
become a staple in the Annie lists going
forward. Uh, again, this is Annie. I
think that it's well positioned to go
underneath some of these slower decks.
Expect it to perform well at minimum in
the hands of some of our star players
like Prismaticism. But again, in North
America, we've seen it do very well in
previous events. Uh, it's had a pretty
strong showing so far in day one. And
hopefully this inspires you to maybe
pick up Annie and give her a try if you
have not done so already. So, uh, thank
you. Uh, hopefully you enjoy the
coverage and we have more action coming
your way.
Welcome back, ladies and gentlemen, to
the Rifound qualifiers here in Atlanta,
Georgia. Man, the games today have been
something to watch. Yeah, we got one
more round ahead of us before top eight.
Also, I just want to acknowledge Charmer
there saying everyone pick up your
Annies if you want to try it out. I did
pick up my Annie this week.
>> Did you?
>> And I picked up a mastery. Yeah, I was
inspired.
>> Okay. And how have you been performing?
>> Well, I haven't built it yet. It's
sitting right over there. I wish I knew
I wish I knew he was going to throw it
that way cuz I would have had the legend
with me.
>> Right.
>> Yeah. To to prove it. But now you just
have to take my word for it. I'm a
trustworthy guy. Right.
>> Right. I feel like I've earned trust,
but still like some doubt with my
accuracy of some of the calls.
>> I think you've been doing a great job,
honestly, especially in terms of your
explanations of what's going on into the
game. So, I think you might be able to
pilot Annie and Master.
>> Okay. Okay. I'll take a might.
>> I'll give you 51%.
>> 51%. All right. All right. Well, we got
one round ahead of us, um, Reagan, but
that that means that there's a lot of
players that are kind of waiting to see
are they going to be able to get into
that top eight. They still have one
round ahead of them to prove if they
can. It doesn't guarantee it for a lot
of these, but let's take a look at the
standings to see who's kind of favored
to actually make that run. Um, cuz we
have updated standings right now.
There's only one player still not to
pick up a single round loss. Only one
tie in Coco Lopez.
>> Coco Lopez. And that's that Draven. But
I really want to point out here Frosty
>> that Kai'Sa still up at the top with the
11 and one. We also see Prismaticism
Sism uh 11 and one and another Draven
Colin also set represent
>> Allen ZQ Stardust a lot of names that
are competing here and four members of
the team CTCG. I like highlighting
teammates um especially early on in
games like this because suddenly that
group that team is getting a lot of
notoriety. I I say suddenly they they've
already had the notoriety in the last
couple events, but still like they're
just building a legacy of like they are
the team to beat when you consider that
these guys all test together and play
together.
>> Yeah. But I think we also need to point
out this Jinx, but I also
>> Yes, let's do it.
>> Yeah, the Jinx is still sitting here in
the top 10. You know, we still got a
couple more rounds. 10 one in one. I was
so sad because I saw that I was like
there's a good chance we get to do that
on a feature match. It's not going to be
the feature match unfortunately.
Um because of what we know the feature
match will be. Uh you know I don't want
to spoil too much. I know who Rian's
going to be going against and it's
actually kind of crazy. But let's keep
going down to 10 and twos because 10 and
two uh is the bubble to try and make it
into the top eight.
>> Okay. And what do you what do you notice
here? There's a lot of
>> a lot of Aurelas.
>> A lot of Aurelia and a lot of Master Ye
as well. Like I feel like
>> the one Teemo. Yes. Um but yeah, I feel
like we're starting to see like the the
top contenders here. We're really seeing
the Master Yees. We're really seeing the
Ireelas. Of course, the Dravens are
there. Um racking up almost 50% of the
top what was it 16. So it's it's fun.
>> I'm mostly admiring these names right
now.
>> Um
>> I'm I'm cheering for Fat Poe.
>> Fat Poe. That's That's my That's my
gamer right there. Carmen Carmen H
Diego.
>> Or is it H Diego?
>> Is it Is it Lil A or Little
>> I would say Angel?
>> Oh, Lilac Angel.
>> Although I I did almost go lila.
>> No,
>> this is why I don't do this. I'm not
looking at the name.
>> But here's the rest of the 10 twos. I
fishy lube. I'm going to say that one.
That's the last one I'm going to say. 10
and two. That's a bubble to make it in.
It got a lot of nine two and ones. 193
making it on the graphic. Look at that.
>> Okay, look at that. You still got the
represent representation from Zapo. We
see you, Zapo. 9 and3 with the Draven,
of course.
>> Yep. Uh so again, the anybody that has
that 10 and two record, they're going to
be sweating here cuz you need to win in
order to try and make that bubble in. I
believe looking at the math there that
yeah, two there's at least going to be
like one, maybe two that make it in.
Again, none of this is official. we have
to wait for the actual standings to come
in. But this is where you start looking
at the numbers. There are a number of
people at this event thinking, "Okay,
it's actually possible to still like
make it." So, uh, stay in the tournament
if you're X and 2. Don't FF your match.
You know, keep trying cuz there's a good
shot that you can make it high up. Time
to let go of the deck list though uh to
reveal who will be we will be watching.
>> I think I know who we'll be watching.
And yes, it is. We're going to be seeing
a Draven. There's a lot of Dravens in
these top uh positions here. So, do you
have any standouts here from what you
would normally see in a Draven deck?
>> First one is Realm. That's a very
surprising one to see. Just the one of
in there. Uh this is more of the gear
heavy lists with um the three spinning
blades. Although, now that I say that,
we actually don't have other gears in
the main deck. When I see rei, I
immediately just kind of assume we're
going to have like um uh the swifty
boots or something. But nope, just going
to be that for the spinning axe. That is
a little surprising for me.
>> I'm I'm curious because isn't it only
the spinning axe that can be attached to
her for no cost. It's
>> the only equipment that she can interact
with currently and it already has quick
draw. So that's why I was a little
surprised to see that. But we'll see. I
mean obviously the second a lot of
one-offs as well. Things like Blood
Rush, Gem Jammer, and uh Ride the Wind
and the one of Cleave as well. Also one
of Rexite. Wow. A lot of one-ups in this
list. But uh let's take a look at the
other list because the Dravens a lot of
cards are interchangeable. And we got a
mirror match here. Oh,
>> we get a look at a different build of
Draven. And this is a a drastically
different build of Draven.
>> I see we still have that Brin here. Uh,
and we've got the Kaiso. We've got the
Rex side. We have more like multiples of
it, but I'm looking at the Vi and we
know that that VI ride the wind combo is
more strong. So, uh, any other standouts
for you?
>> A lot of people kind of wrote off the VI
ride the wind combo after Spear forge
came out saying, "Ah, it's not as
powerful." But then the ban list
happened and now things like the fighter
flight or reavers row that are big
defenses against it are gone. So you
actually have the ability to punch a
little harder with this. Things I'm
going to note though is only two Ferris
4runners. Uh only two rebukes and one
acceptable losses in the main deck. I
think these are key things to highlight.
Also also the bin here thundersong. But
let's talk about acceptable losses
first. It's an action speed spell. Each
player kills one of their gears. So you
can either play this before you play
your spinning axe or just, you know,
play it and your spinning axe dies
usually if it unequips and then your
turn starts anyway. So acceptable losses
in the main board. I've heard a lot of
people talking about this kind of the
boogeyman for the Aurora decks, the um
the Aurelia decks, even the Lucian
decks. Uh there's a lot of gear hate
right now. And uh even in the mirror,
this does have some uses with those
spinning axes all over.
>> Absolutely. Yeah, this is acceptable
losses is one that I haven't seen
necessarily. But also want to point out
that we've got the one flash there.
Ready to if we need to if we need to
recall some uh friendly units to base,
it is there, but only one copy.
>> All right. Well, we're ready to hop into
game. So, let's do it. A Draven mirror
match for the final round. The winner
here, so the these uh duels are both 101
and one. You see on the right there, the
backup feature match is actually Allen
ZQ playing Ezreal versus that Jinx. I I
I teased it. I highlighted it. I would
love to get that on stream at some
point, but we we'll see some of that if
it's um uh if it's a 20 here, like if
this first uh feature match is fast and
that one goes a little longer. I just
want to know what that Jinx player is
playing.
>> Absolutely.
>> We could have top eight.
>> I want to point out here, we've got the
Draven versus Draven matchup win rate.
It's about a 50% chance that Draven is
going to win. to be 100
>> I think technically yes it is a 100%
chance that Draven wins this
>> versus Draven
>> Draven match up
>> 100% of the time Draven wins but I guess
also 100% of the time Draven loses so
that's probably where the 50/50 comes
from
>> it it's really like is the glass half
full or half empty
>> which one are you are you a
>> always half full
>> optimist half full nice
>> and you know what half if you round up
it's five plus it's really all the way
full
>> that's a good point
>> five rounds up to one.
>> Exactly.
>> All right. But again, we highlighted
some of the key individual cards in this
matchup. And I know maybe some people
are like, "Uh, Draven, mirror match."
Really, these are different builds of
Draven, different looks at Draven.
They're both still what you would kind
of consider mid-range Draven, but even
like initial battlefields are looking
different. We have Aspirants Climb going
first for Stardust. So, accepting, no,
we're going to extend the game for that
game one. And maybe the sideboard is
going to dictate which battlefields come
in for games two and three or at least
just give you information. But that game
one you get more to work with and we're
just going fast.
>> Yeah, we're going fast. I feel like they
know their decks pretty well and you
kind of know kind of what the other
person has in their deck. So the powdery
porro comes out on the side of Oz Mister
and then we get the stack deck. Stardust
has already played his Rexside to base
and we're waiting to see what the
decision is going to be from the stack
deck.
>> I wonder if Mr. Oz was taken potentially
swap him around. You know, still gets
the point across. Uh didn't see what
they took with the stacked deck. It's
face down, but uh you still have three
runes to work with and we're just going
to develop our own Rex eye and not send
the pouty porro in to die.
>> All right, so we're kind of leaving our
units in our base at the moment and
we've got that mirror Rex side matchup
right now in this Draven matchup and uh
we've readied our runes on the side of
Stardust as we try to see.
>> See a Brin here. I see a re. I think
there was a
>> gen jammer in the side of Osmister
>> and also a uh spinning axe. So that's
full hand.
>> Okay, cool.
>> Absolutely
>> interesting hand. So we have some units
to develop. We have ways to play through
stardust,
>> ways to stop spells or cards being
played.
>> Exactly. Like early Brin here typically
is something you wait for later to play.
Okay. And I think that this is an
instance where we will because we're
playing chicken right now. Both of these
Rex eyes punch harder than they defend.
So unless you have a way to defend them
like a spinning ax, you don't really
want to send them in. But we know
Osmister has access to one of those. And
what did they draw for turn? Is that a
starfall? Starfall is a big one. You can
actually deal with the Rex eye before it
goes out there. But it's only going to
kill one thing cuz we don't have enough
to kill the Nox's hopeful with it.
>> All righty.
>> Maybe we go for a Zon Warren Conquer
here. Try and dig a little deeper.
things like uh the Brin here aren't that
I mean they're good in the matchup but
like actually probably the re I I would
imagine like if you go zon you discard
the re means that you don't have
something to develop but you're hoping
to draw into something else or maybe we
just play it. All righty. I think we're
about to Yes, the real is going to come
out with the four exhausted and then
another gem jammer.
>> Yeah, start has to familiarize himself
with this real card.
>> Real is one that I tried out in like
Lucian early spirit forge. Didn't like
it and then just kind of moved on. I
haven't seen many top decks playing
this. Actually, I haven't seen any top
decks play this. I haven't seen many
decks period play this. It's a four
energy, four might with tank. And then
when it attacks, this is kind of the fun
of the card. When it attacks, you may
play an equipment uh with energy cost no
more than two, ignoring its cost, and
attach it to me. So, it basically gets
you a free quick draw. Uh, and it says
ignoring its cost, not its energy cost.
Uh, it says energy cost no more than
two, but then you're just ignoring its
total cost. So, that means that you can
equip even things like um like long
sword to it without paying the energy
cost. So, it's kind of like a cheating
quick draw, but only on the attack.
>> Gotcha.
>> But the key one is the the the spinning
axe because that's a two energy, one
power cost. Um that you don't have to
pay the power cost to equip it,
>> right? And uh we're kind of shuffling
through here, not really knowing what we
want to do on Stardust's turn. Love the
name though. There it is. The Ferris
4Erunner has come out with the Yeah, I'm
tired of saying that name today. No, I'm
well I'm laughing a little bit of that,
but mostly I just neither one of these
players wants to go onto the field.
They're like, "Nope, I got M board and
I'm going to keep it that way and you're
going to go on the battlefield first and
we got a long game of chicken."
>> Absolutely. Cuz uh once the crash does
happen officially, then we've got we've
got a game on our hands.
>> But the important thing is Oz Mister
with that development turn has the gem
jammer and we're just going to go for
our own ferris 4runner. I'm wondering
like if you
>> they passed. We're just refusing to
score points.
>> This is so silly. I absolutely love it
though. So, here we are with so many
>> This is how the mirror normally goes. I
feel like I haven't seen this before.
>> So many runes on the board, so many
units on the board, but not a singular
battlefield has been touched yet. So,
let's see what Stardust does. Is he
going to finally go in?
>> Someone's got to touch battle.
>> Yeah, somebody's got to
>> got to go in. poke at a point. At least
at least tap it.
>> All right, let's see if Stardust is the
first one to go in. I expected Osmister
to go in with like the Gem Jammer cuz
it's a smaller unit. You don't really
care. Maybe the Patty Porro. Uh actually
just the Yeah, gem jammer's already like
it doesn't have anything to accomplish
anymore other than be two might. Then
you can play the 4Runner on it and you
have the spinning ax in hand,
>> right?
>> But no, I it's just a long drawn out
game of chicken here. I mean, somebody
has to to buckle first. And it looks
like Stardust might be ready.
>> Yeah, it looks like he wants to send in
something not Rexai here. Uh, he keeps
picking it up, putting it down. The Nox
is hopeful. The Rexai. Yep, he's
counting it up. Which one do I want to
sacrifice?
>> Another big reason why this can happen
in the Draven Mirror. Again, it's funny
it's happened for this long, but if you
lose combat, you're giving your opponent
the draw. Both of these players realize
that. The Draven Legend is so strong.
Whenever you win that combat, you get
that extra advantage. And that's part of
the reason why, you know, neither of
these players want to go in right now
and be the first one to do it. Uh, okay.
So, we're going to take those ones and
discard the cleave to draw another card.
So, Stardust is um that was an
opportunity. That's a good tool to hit
in. So, like, but I guess if Osmister is
refusing to go in, he's just going to
refuse to go in. But, this is a way to
dodge it. So, we actually have uh Ride
the Wind, which can move Nox's hopeful
over to Aspirin's Climb and then move
back to base. We might not even commit
to holding a battlefield,
>> right? No,
>> that's so funny.
>> I actually super duper love that because
you're getting your points, you go in
and you go out. It's kind of that Lucian
play style, but not Lucian.
>> Yeah. And we get another Noxious
Hopeful. Continue to develop the board.
Sarda said, "Okay, I'll dramp a little.
I'll use some of my resources, but I'm
going to uh score some points as the
trade. You basically traded your ride
the wind for two points.
>> It's going to be a nine-point game cuz
that aspirin's climb though. Everybody
remember that that um it's we're in for
the long haul here.
>> And we're and we're going to I feel like
we're going to be here for for a while
with the way that uh we're not wanting
to officially commit to that combat yet.
You can tell that they're both just a
little bit a little bit scared to start
uh actually going head-to-head here.
>> And we saw this a few rounds back, the
last round that we were casting with all
the different Fairest 4Runners. I've
been talking to a lot more of the
players at the top tables and the
opinion I'm getting generally from the
the player base is like it is a meta of
Ferris 4Runner. Who gets their Ferris
4Runner first? Who establishes it first?
And now that we're in this type of game
state where everything's back in the
battlefields, I think it's like who gets
more I maybe would would be the next
step. We're finally going onto the field
though.
>> Yes. So with the uh five runes and one
recycled, we're going to get that
accelerated Kai'Sa to automatically go
into the Z warrants for Oz Mister. Now
is this bait is this like dangling a
little a little bait in front of uh
Rexai to uh get her to finally come out
to then respond with own Rexai? Like
what what are we thinking? Well, I think
that Osmister has two spinning axes in
hand. I saw at least one. I'm pretty
sure that they drew one off the Kaisa
Conqueror. I think I saw that correctly.
So, at least one. I think it's two.
Yeah, there's two. Blood Rush means that
we can hit hard. Double spinning axe
means we can hit hard or defend hard. We
have enough runes up for it on
Osmister's side. So, Stardust is now
going to be doing the calculations.
Never mind, it's still Osmister's turn.
Has not passed. Falling Star will clear
up some of the clutter.
>> Yes. So, we're going to go ahead and uh
exhaust two runes, recycle the two
runes, and we're going to play Falling
Star. Stardust now has the opportunity
to respond. You could try and hard
bargain if it's in hand. It would force
Osmister to spend two more, or you can
spending a targets were selected. It's
Rexi, which will be defended by spinning
ax and just the tide turner. Yeah, I I
think it I understand the thought
process from Osmister because the extra
two points were scored on Stardust's
turn. If they go in, they can have
Draven Showboat come out accelerated and
he's gonna be a little bigger than what
Osmister would be able to put out right
now. But nice spinning axe will defend
the play and Osmister will just send a
Ferris 4unner up to further defend. I
think at this point, so it's a fun start
cuz it's so goofy looking, but now it
gets really like complex because since
you're behind as Osmister on points, you
have to eventually go out there and it's
like what do you use? What do you save?
What do you commit to the field? Looks
like we're just going to defend with a
total of 12
>> and
>> on the point which will check the
Ferris. Actually, it doesn't check the
Ferris four on a Rex side cuz Rexai gets
assault one.
>> So, so those two alone will be able to
clear this.
>> So, again, I wonder if it's like
dangling a little bait to like get
Stardust to finally swing in so then
Osmister can respond by finally swinging
in with the last laugh. So far, I'm
happier with Stardust's play in the
mirror. I feel like the ride the wind
play gets you more points, put some
pressure. Um, you're able to
>> evil like very easily answer. Okay,
that's a rebuke. That's really big, too.
But easily answering the falling star
like Osmister just kind of dramped
himself and didn't get much value for
it. Meanwhile, Stardust has gotten a lot
of value for the cards. And that that's
even more like rebuke on the Ferris
4Runner is huge.
>> Yes. Listen, we're finally moving in
with this Rex eye with the spinning axes
onto the Zon Warren from Stardust. And
we're going to see what Osmister has to
respond. And we're going to respond with
our own spinning axe, exhausting two
runes, recycling one, and attaching that
to the Kai'Sa.
>> This is still pretty tough cuz like all
Stardust needs is a blood rush, uh,
cleave. Actually, I think it was only
Osmister that had the blood rush. I
don't think Stardust did. Stacked deck
in combat. Yeah, dig a little for it. If
you get a cleave, if you get a quick uh
spinning axe,
>> you're still able to do this.
>> Spinning axe in there, but I'm not sure.
>> So, so Osmister is basically just trying
Oh, yep. There's Yep. There. Yeah, this
is disastrous for Osmister. You lose the
ferris 4runner. You're going to lose
this battlefield. Stardust is still
ahead in points and he wins the combat
to draw the extra card. Like, it's gone
completely pear-shaped for Osmister at
this point.
>> Oh no. So, both units are going to die
here and the spinning axe is out.
>> Yeah, technically it should still be on
the field and die at the beginning
phase, but uh I mean we know it's going
to end up in the the trash pile anyway.
Again, Stardust is so far ahead at this
position. You can send like the Ferris
4Runner out probably to aspirin's climb.
We're going to trigger the Z warzo and
we still have more decisions to play
here still for Stardust.
>> Yes, we do. And we're going to flash
back to base.
>> Are we just not going to send anything
>> for Rexi
and then we are going to end our turn
here.
>> Oh, not passing just yet, actually.
>> I heard verbatim from Stardust.
>> I I would take that back. If I'm
Stardust, go.
It's tough. I like you can just score
Aspirin's climb and then flash them both
back anyway.
If your goal is to score the points and
then get out of there and not give more
combat opportunities for Oz Mister, I
think that that was an inefficient way
to do it at Sardis might now be
realizing that. But we'll see what the
next decision is because potentially you
wanted to leave the Ferris 4Runner out
there anyway just to kind of block that.
That's a pass. I'm going to call that
what I what it is. I think that was a
misplay. You had an opportunity to score
a free extra point. Yeah, cuz that three
should have been able to get to four.
Flashback both.
>> I I
>> That's a tough moment. That's tough
right there. the the pressure I think is
mounting for both of them. And again,
that that's what can happen when the
game states get gets that uh funky. It
gets it's a little goofy when everyone's
just kind of playing passing, playing
passing, playing passing, no one's going
out to the battlefield, you kind of lose
track of like, okay, what's the optimal
playal
>> cuz the more decision tree branches
there are, the harder it is to do the
right thing.
>> Absolutely. But we're going to see the
six runes exhausted and one recycled for
that Ferris runner to reenter the board
state and then immediately pass back to
Stardust trying to get back to where we
were on Osmister's side. Yeah.
>> Um I think the bright side for Stardust
is you're still on aspirin's climb. You
need nine points anyway. So
theoretically you can still score two
per turn and it's essentially the same
clock. So like I don't know how much
that's actually going to affect the end
of the game and I think you're still in
a commanding position regardless. So
Stardust, if if you're out there rooting
for Stardust, I think you can still be
pretty happy with the state. Although
see seeing him do that uh that type of
thinking, that's tough.
>> Yeah, it looked a little stressful,
especially with both people playing so
respectively, I guess. Um but here we
go. We're We're about to make a decision
here. I see I see we've kind of thought
it through. We're exhausting
>> five for the Darius.
Oh, and the VI. Oh. Oh, we're exhausting
everything, baby. So, the Darius Darius
have come onto the board. So, we've got
a lot of might here. And we do have some
readyied units. So, it looks like we
might move the Noxis hopeful. Oh, let me
not speak too fast.
>> I think Stardust is figuring out what he
wants to do. It looks like a judge gave
a quick note right there. I don't know
if this is a judge ruling call
happening. Looks like the table judge is
wip judge call. So technically Alaria
should be ready. Yeah. And there we go.
Cool. Sorry I just noticed it. So uh I I
want to commentate on a or comment on a
few key things here is the information
gathering. These are is a mirror
matchup,
>> but both players are realizing that
they're not on the exact same build. I
mean it would be rare to be on the exact
same uh either way, but uh the the VI is
known now cuz not everyone's on the VI
and also the re's known now. But I just
got some news. Reagan.
>> Yes. I think we hear that y'all are
asking for the Jinx match in chat. So,
why don't we give that to you during
this little judge call? Let's Let's
pause.
>> We got to pause anyway. Let's take a
look at the Jinx versus Ezra. And I
think it's Jinx versus Ezra. Yeah, it
was it was Allen at the table.
>> Yes, it was.
>> And they they were both a 10- one and
one. So, I feel like that's what has to
happen here as There we go.
>> You're getting your Jinx game.
>> Oh, I must have been I must got some
good karma to to earn this one. This is
fantastic. I am a huge Jinx enthusiast.
I've been playing Jinx since Origin. I
stand that I had the best Jinx list in
Origin.
>> Okay. I I
>> And then it was completely invalidated
in Spear forge. It got really bad. It
was not the same. I was on red aggro
Jinx. Doesn't work in Spirit Forge in my
opinion. But maybe Rianne has a
different opinion. Is on the red Jinx.
So Jinx Demolitionist. Um I I've moved
on. I'm now on on purple Jinx and
playing more of like a ramp like jump
around the board style. But what Jinx
Demolitionist does well is it punches
hard, punches fast, and it discards two
cards mandatory from your hand when you
play it. Now, you might be thinking
that's pretty bad. That's a hefty cost.
But Jinx uh loose cannon legend ability
says that if at the start of your
beginning phase, if you have one or
fewer cards in your hand, you draw a
card. So that means essentially you're
drawing two for your turn. One at the
start of the beginning phase, one at
your normal draw phase. And you can use
your trash pile as a second hand. things
like um Immortal Phoenix, things like uh
Super Mega Death Rocket that will uh
still be playable from the discard pile
and even things like Fizz can, you know,
pull back your spells that you're
discarding with your Jinx. So, it's a
really low hand size to optimize the
deck, especially with red Jinx. But
there's other ways to play. You can
still play more ramp and just use Jinx
demolitionist like punch in really hard
and fast having an accelerated unit. So,
I'm very excited to see how Rian pilots
this. with that minefield. I'm assuming
it's the graveyard or the trash pile
build of Jinx.
>> It looks like it. So, we're we're going.
We're bringing out the Rex Eye and we've
got the Tide Turner already going into
>> I'm so excited,
>> y'all. Kangas is jumping out of his
chair right now. So again, Rexi uh you
already have acceleration on your chosen
uh champion here with Jinx. So it
doesn't give you value there, but what
it gives you value on is the immortal
Phoenix, which is like one of the best
cards that Jinx can play um when it
comes back from the trash pile cuz if
you kill something with a spell, it can
come back from the trash pile. You can
play it accelerated. So I'm talking a
lot about the Jinx side. Reagan, how
about you catch us up on what's going on
with the Ezreal side because that is
Allen's EQ. He's a rock star in the
scene. Uh and he's known for his Ezreal.
So, uh, Allan and his Ezreal have gone
ahead and sent in a card shop to deal
with that tie turner on the side of
Rian. And then we played a, uh, stack
deck to, to take a peeky at some cards
here. And now, uh, with our turn, we're
going to pass it. And Jinx is going to
go back in, ready those runes, ready
those uh, that Rex eye. And it looks
like we're going in with the Rexai
immediately after. Allen is then going
to tap one and stupify.
>> So gave you a draw and then the Rex side
would crash, but Cleave is available for
Jinx. And there's the gust reaction.
>> Gust and it's so quick. He knew exactly
what he wanted to do. So he's going to
be able to keep that little uh point
there
>> for the time being though.
>> For the time being cuz we can if you're
Rian, you can just replay the Rex eye.
>> Okay. Five recycle should be in hand.
Okay. No, he he is just going for it.
So, he's just going to play the Rex eye
cuz you tapped the or exhausted the one
for the cleave. And then we're
exhausting more for the Rex eye
accelerator.
>> Oh my gosh. Is that another
double stupify? Is that what just
happened there?
>> I believe it is. So, that card shop is
going to is going to stay there and get
that hold point. He really wanted to
protect that hold point and that card
sharp.
>> Well, yeah. You never expect the third
stupify. That is crazy what uh Allan was
just able to pull off there. And and
also Stupify is getting you cards drawn
every time you play it. So typically
Jinx, when I think about this build of
Jinx, it's like if you're drawing two
every turn, normally you feel good with
kind of one to one trades, but the
problem is Ezreal is one of those
legends that also can draw and Allen got
the extra draw off of that cuz he
targeted so many times. Now the uh
Ezreal Prodigy is going to come out and
draw even more. So Allen's actually one
of I I would argue I imagine the worst
matchups for Jinx just because it's
going to match you pound-for-pound on
draw power.
>> Absolutely. So we're uh we actually
brought out the Ezreal to that minefield
uh with the card sharp now. So yes, when
you play him, you can discard one, then
draw the two, and you can uh even pay
your uh optional additional costs you
pay cost one or eight or less.
>> Yeah. So if you're trying to like repeat
something, the classic one was called
shot, but that's been banned. The next
ones are like hard bargain, uh frigid
touch. Those are two that now Ezreal's
kind of moved on to as like the premier
ones. You get value off of this, but you
don't even need the value off it. You
still just like it for the draw power on
its own. Now, let's see what Rian does.
Cuz the field is held by Allen.
Currently, it's one to two points. And
Rian, the goal is usually to get your
hand size a little lower than what it is
currently. I think I see two VI.
>> I think you see correct because one is
coming out. Uh we have exhausted the two
and recycled one to bring a VI out into
the base. Exhausted, of course. Again,
another reason to have a battlefield
like Minefield to to run this type of
deck with all these tide turners that
they're just going to be discarding a
bunch. You load up your graveyard, make
the VI really big. The classic combo is
Ride the Wind does reinhabit. Yeah,
recycling the entire graveyard. That
means that we are sending this VI in.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> How many was that? Was that eight? I I
can't quite tell.
>> I think it was five.
>> Oh, it was only five. I was I was way
too excited. Eight total might on the V.
I think I heard somebody say eight, but
yep. There's the ride the wind. There's
the ride the wind. So, we're going in.
Of course, we're getting that uh point
over here on the void gate.
>> Yep. And this is the classic combo. Ride
the wind moves a unit and readies it.
And Vi has ganking. So, you go to one
battlefield, conquer it, gank over to
the other battlefield. And we're doing
it in this order so we guarantee the
point here, but h it's not guaranteed.
There is a rebuke.
>> Oof. Oof. And the rebuke comes out from
Allen ZQ.
>> Expensive turn. re-engages recycled the
entire graveyard for that push. And now
has no more trash pile to actually
utilize. And I think we're just going to
replay the the VI.
And yes, we are. The Vi is going to come
back out with uh a couple more runes
exhausted and one recycled. And we're
going to pass over to Allen. Very
unfortunate, but Allen is playing
defense like crazy.
>> And Allen knows the ins and outs of this
Ezreal
uh deck. one of the best pilots in the
world. I mean, already able to win a
regional with the deck.
Allen in a really good spot now with
another card sharp and Rian not opting
to take their own. And I would even say
Jinx is one of the decks that maybe
would because again, you want to get
your hand size low and I see a lot of
recycle cost in Rian's hand. So, you
we're not utilizing the Jinx passive
yet. Uh we have not gotten any extra
draws on Rian's side. But
>> oh my gosh, Allan, let the man play
Riftbound, bro. Let let him let him let
him get one, man. Come on now.
>> I don't think Allan's interested in that
trade proposition.
>> Oh my god.
>> I don't think he's taking a trade deal.
>> This man is not letting this man score.
>> Yeah. Allen controlling the battlefields
exquisitly. Can throw out the plundering
porro to get a extra gold gear. Can
throw out a card sharp to to the other
one and even just hold more resources
back in base while continuing to
develop. Like this is a suffocating lead
that Allen's EQ is about to establish.
>> Absolutely. And the plundering Porro is
going to go in and score a point, but
even more fruitfully a gold gear. So,
you've kind of got more resources to
play with here. And then Lard Sharp is
going to go over to the void gate and
score another point. Allen is sitting on
five points while Rian can't even get to
two.
>> That is the nightmare scenario when
Ezreal just says, "Pass all runes
available. I'm not going to spend any."
And you're like, "Oh no." Uh,
>> oh my gosh, the smoke screen with two
runes exhausted uh after the Ferris
4Erunner was played by Rian to try and
do something about this minefield
battlefield with the plundering porro
from Allen ZQ on it.
>> Also, Rienne um you know flipping over
more Chaos runes means that you only
have one fury rune to work with. So
maybe like one VI if you want to play
another Ferris 4runner that'd be one
Ferrris 4Runner. Um so I believe we're
still in the reaction window right now.
I'm trying to think of reactions. I
guess it would be hard bargain, but
there's so many runes available for
Allen ZQ. So,
>> and there it is.
>> That's the third Gust from Allen ZQ. But
we're actually going to exhaust two to
flash
>> the Ferris 4Runner.
>> That's big. Back to
>> you have to cuz like if you fall that
far behind on tempo, it's just
disastrous. We're not playing the VI
though. We're just holding our runes
available on our side for Rian. But
Allen doesn't have to do anything. Yeah.
Allen can literally just like
>> Oh. Oh, no. No. It is still Rian's turn.
My apologies. I thought I think the buy
is going to come out here. Yes. And a
boot of swiftness with three more
exhausted. And then we're passing to
Allen Q. And honestly, this still isn't
favorable. Allan just went up two points
for holding and we're readying all the
50 million runes that he has on his
board right now. and and and we get to
play more riff. Allan gets to play more
riffbound. Rian doesn't get to play any
riffbound.
>> If you're if you're a fan of Allen,
you're eating good right now.
>> Yes.
>> Um if you're a fan of Jinx Loose Cannon,
>> so you
>> you're crying internally. I'm a
professional externally though. So I
would never admit it.
>> Oh, I see. Well, unfortunately, it just
it I I'd say we see it through till the
end.
>> The game isn't normal. The game isn't
over until the nexus explodes. So, we're
just going to play a card shop uh card.
>> That's actually a Raven Bloom student
that was just played and then we moved
back to card sharpen the uh Plundering
Porro. So, uh Allan's EQ is just saying
you can have the battlefields. You can
you can go out there and do your thing.
It'll be cute. Uh I'm I'm
Yep. And he'll just swing in on the next
turn. But we're going to see what can
Rian pull off.
>> I think I see a rebuke in hand. So,
Rienne actually does have
probably some things to do. Um, it's
just ideally by this point you would
already have something like a Phoenix
and um, Super Mega Death Rocket setup.
Now, I say that not knowing Rian's list.
That's how I played the uh, the Jinx
deck and I think it's a really strong
combo. When I see the Rex Eye, I assume
that's what they're on. Um,
>> oh, dude. Wait, y'all. Okay, Tad. Come
on, bro. like what?
Okay, so
>> okay, I'm a professional. Well played,
Allan. That was awesome.
>> Is going to be played. Return a unit at
a battlefield to its owner's hand. So
just bouncing back that Ferris runner.
And I think
>> we're going to go into game.
>> Yeah. No, that's that's tough. And I I
honestly think that's why I dislike
going against Ezreal so much cuz you
don't get to interact. They get to
interact with you, but you don't get to
interact with them at all. They say,
"Uh-uh, you're not touching me."
>> I would argue, I don't know exactly what
Rian's list is. Maybe we can take a look
at at some point, but I would argue that
this is like one of the best possible
matchups for Ezreal cuz what Ezreal
loves to do is like match up against
these decks that have a bunch of three
might units that are going in so you can
gust them and then a bunch of like, you
know, three to six might total. So that
way your smoke screens hit them and then
you can trade with your, you know, your
uh card sharps or even like your um your
uh plundering porros at that point. Like
uh the Jinx operates within the range
within the might range that Ezreal is
specialized to deal with. So this is
just a inherently tough matchup I think
for the Jinx.
>> Absolutely. We're getting straight into
the second game here of this best of
three. And an overzealous fan is coming
out on the side of Rian for Jinx. And
then a card shop is card sharp is coming
out for Allen ZQ with a gold gear.
>> Still not taking it. Again, I think that
there's arguments sometimes cuz we saw
how few runes Ren got, but I guess it
wasn't a rune issue. It was more so
access to cards issue.
>> Yeah, it looks like we're going to
exhaust all four runes and we're going
to go ahead and play a Kai'Sa. M.
>> Okay, so we're passing our turn over to
Allen ZQ.
Let's see what this man does.
>> Not sending in the overzealous fan
either because we don't want to just
waste the resource. Card sharp would
just be able to deal with that. We'd
rather use this to try and defend the
Kai'Sa if there's a swing. But with that
arena's greatest does mean that this
game is going to go pretty fast. That's
now two points that Alan EQ has picked
up on his second turn and still has a
lot of runes to play with on Rian's
turn.
>> Yes. Yes, he does. And then we're also
going to get uh the pass over to Rian
with the overzealous fan going in for
Aspire's climb and we're going to get
that point. So, we're sitting at
>> Ooh, that's big. That's really big.
Falling star is huge. Uh it'll clear
both or yeah, both of the units EQ is
going to save his own unit and get an
extra draw. So trying to utilize as many
of the runes as possible, but this means
that at least there's a clear avenue for
Kai'Sa to go in and conquer and draw a
card.
>> Absolutely. So with that,
we're going to recycle a rune.
>> Oh, was that for
>> that was for Yeah, I think Allan even
reminded him. And
>> yeah,
>> Allan's such a professional up there,
man. He's just like, "Yeah, yeah,
>> he knows what he's doing."
>> So calm and collected, too.
>> Here we go. We're exhausting the one.
We're playing the stack deck. Let's take
a peek see at what is on the top.
>> So, sending Kai'Sa in feels like an
obvious uh choice here. You get the
draw, you get the point. It does mean
that the Kai'Sa is more vulnerable. I
think Rian just wants to see a little
more of the deck and what the options
are for the followup before committing
the Kai'Sa. And is this just going to be
Yep, there's another stack deck. Okay,
>> another stack deck. This time Allen
doesn't get to play Riftbound quite yet.
We're kind of trading through the play
times here.
>> Reminder that there's a lot on the line
here. If you win, I from my math, again,
this is not official, but from my math.
Okay, there's
>> And there it is. Kaisa tries to go in
for the arena's greatest and immediately
gusted back to hand. And so Rian
responds by playing a uh Noxis hopeful.
>> So Allen's Q had uh stupified double
gust in hand. That's a very Allen ZQ
coded hand. Um, Q is going to send it on
the over. So, this is tough cuz Rian has
to trigger defend abilities before an
action step. So, you have to decide now
if you're going to use it. If you pass,
then Alq now has an opportunity to play
a spell. And it's a very efficient one.
I think Rian in that type of position,
you're hoping that maybe it's like a
stupify or or like a I don't know, it
probably won't be a smoke. You you hope
it's something that then you have more
information of what Allenz no longer has
access to. But instead, it was a stacks
deck. So very clean uh clear for Allen's
EQ and Rien doesn't know any more
information as to you know what Allen's
EQ doesn't have access to cuz if it's
Stupify you're like okay that's two now
he only has one left in the deck you
know but we didn't get that type of
information from Rion. No but with the
stack deck we're also stacking units
over on Aspire's Climb and we're
stacking gold as well uh as another gold
uh gear was played to base for Allen. So
yeah,
>> we're trying to see is there any other
plays that we want to do or do we want
to leave those runes up? And we do. So
>> if you're Ezreal, you always want to
leave the runes up. It's almost never
will will you see Allen um completely
exhausted down. Very rare with Ezreal
cuz you have so many spells that are
action and reaction speed. So yeah,
Ren's doing the right thing. He's
saying, "Hey, can I look at your your
trash pile?" I believe it's two gusts
and a stupify and that stacked deck. And
then and then the units um the the one I
think it was a Raven Bloom that was shot
with the Falling Star.
>> Yes. And that Noxis Hopeful is going to
go in for Rian and score a point. So
we've got a tied game here. The Ferris
runner is coming out recycling the one
rune of course. And we're passing turn
back to Allen. So he is going to hold
for that fourth point. And let's see if
he's going to make any movements.
>> Oh,
>> okay. mine later.
>> Well, actually, you know what? Jinx
doesn't necessarily mind this. It's
double Kaiser, double ride the wind
because Kai'Sa uh or sorry, Jinx the
Loose Cannon Legend says when you start
your turn and you have one or fewer
cards, you draw an extra card. So, like
Mindsplitter, it's annoying cuz they get
information, but you sometimes are happy
to have a low hand size depending on how
the uh the the board has progressed.
But, I would argue that this is a tough
time. Interesting. Allen's actually
backing off. So basically giving the
draw for the Kai'Sa. Also there's the
4Runner there.
>> We're fully exhausted here on the side
of Allen though. So just remember that
even though we got that plundering Horo
to be uh played out now that it's Rean's
turn, he kind of has free reign here.
>> See, I'm of the opinion some people
disagree. If you're in this high
pressure of a match, don't keep your
hands shown. I mean, it's kind of like
the sportsmanship thing because the
mindsplitter, it's known information. So
you're just saying, "Yeah, this is what
I got." But when when your top eight is
on the line, I say nah, make him
remember it's it's going to be a long
day. Make him use the mind the the
mental power to remember what's in your
hand because
>> you never know.
>> Maybe that caused them to slip up.
Exactly. You know, this there's a lot on
the line here. And you know, right as I
say Allan almost never completely
exhaust. Look at us.
>> He exhausted in the last rune. You know,
I think they hear you and they're like,
you know what? Let's make him eat his
words.
>> I'm telling you, every time I like make
statements like that, they're always
like, nah, you're wrong. There's no way
a Jinx wins this Jinx Ezreal match.
>> I have to say it.
>> Oh, say it.
>> I don't want to say it. I can't do my
girl like that.
>> That's like I That's like a lose lose
situation right there, Reagan.
>> We are going to go ahead and play the
Kaisa into base. But we're going to
accelerate her and move her in to get
that score for the fifth point on the
Aspire.
>> It wasn't accelerate, it was ride the
wind. Notably that moves the Kaisen and
readies her and then we can move it back
to base. So, we scored the point, we get
the draw, and we back off, and we're
still showing that ride the win. Man,
Rian is a homie. That is That is a That
is a good sportsman right there.
>> They're just so skilled, man. And you
can like I I don't know. It It comes
down to how a player places their card
like they've got that little cascade.
Plundering Porro is going to be played
uh by Allen to the Arena's greatest so
that he can score another point here.
And then Card Shot is gonna take over
Aspire's Climb for that six point.
>> We're racking them up.
>> Technically Ran is ahead of point ahead
of the clock because Allen's turn he's
at six. Rian's turn could get to seven.
But the problem is Rian can't win on his
turn. Allen could win on the crack back.
You just need to score two and then you
go up to that eight and that is game. So
Allen's in a really good spot here. But
Rian's still playing the game. I mean
Ferris for run. Okay, well that'll
change it.
That'll do it.
>> I think you probably hit the Noxis Hope.
Yeah, I I like this from Allan. You hit
the Noxis Hopeful and the Kai'Sa, not
the Ferris 4runner cuz that would just
give more tokens and then he can play
with them. Make him play with one guy,
just one dude.
>> Yep. And we're stacking up the Spirance
Climb. Uh, and still trying to see if we
can maybe do something with the
Plundering Porro as we pass over to
Rian.
>> I I think this is a heads up play from
Allen. was at first wondering
interesting that you would stack up one
and rather than trying to push for the
win on your next turn, but remember that
Jinx demolitionist is always the threat
in the uh chosen champion zone that can
come in accelerated and punches with
assault two, meaning it's a six. So that
would be 12 might represented and Ron
could take both battlefields. As of
right now, Rian will just go for the one
battlefield
and Allen still has two runes
nonexhausted that are available to play
with. And we're looking through the
graveyard here of the Jinx uh just to
see what could possibly maybe be in
hand. Always gives a lot of information
of what is played, what cards can't be
there.
>> Three unknowns. A ride the wind that is
known.
>> What if we accidentally just like flip
it upside like what if you like forget?
I don't know, man. I'd be scared.
>> Right.
Um, five exhausted right now. I'm trying
to think what that would be in this
deck.
Uh, I can't spot it.
>> Is it super mega? No, another Ferris.
>> Oh, there's already one exhaust, I
suppose. Maybe.
>> I'm going to imagine that's what it was
as Ferris 4Runner comes out
>> and an overzealous fan
>> and two more. So, no exhaust. A hidden
card with Ride the Wind in hand. So Rian
is going to try and uh hold this point
and then pressure to maybe go in and
fight. Now I'm thinking what the hidden
cards could be. Jinx would probably play
things like Tide Turner, maybe
Switcheroo.
>> Those are kind of like the the two prime
ones that I'm thinking of. It used to be
Fighter or Flight, but of course, you
know, ban list and all. It's not that.
So those are the top two on my mind, but
we didn't see the deck list ahead of
this. So unsure. There's another mind
spplitter, so goodbye ride the wind.
And we're going to go ahead and exhaust
those runes for that uh mind spplitter.
And then we're going to play a Raven.
And we're going to move all the units
back.
>> And we're
>> we're seven to seven.
>> We're passing.
>> And passing to Rian.
>> Okay. We're readying units. We're We're
channeling our runes. We're drawing for
turn.
>> I'm very confused what's happening right
now.
Rienne can just move to Oh, it's
Aspirin's climb, but it's Oh, yeah. So,
we're going to nine. I just completely
missed that. My apologies, everybody. We
are playing to nine. It doesn't just
cancel out the arena's greatest. It
means that Arena's greatest gives you
the point, but Astron Glim still says
you're going to nine. So, Allen is
actually able to win in two turns. Ren
will not win here with the hold and then
the conquer. I'm all caught up.
Everybody already probably noticed that
in chat.
>> It happens. It happens. I feel like even
when you're at nexus nights, sometimes
you forget and you think you've won at
eight and then the uh opponent is like,
uh, actually we're going to nine, buddy.
So, it happens to everybody. We're all
human.
>> So, Rian's got the classic uh thinking
look right now of how do I hold this?
You do two per turn with Jinx because
again, loose cannon says that when you
start beginning phase, you draw one if
you have one or fewer cards in hand.
There should be two in hand for Rien
>> and we're exhausting three recycling one
and we're going to equip a boots of
swiftness for the Ferris 4runner. So if
we need to gank,
>> we can get a little more might
>> because we can
>> and then another hidden
>> another hidden card. Who knows?
>> Who knows what if it's a switcheroo on
both sides? So you switch and then you
switch it again. I think that's actually
worst case scenario because if it's a
switcher on both sides that means Allen
Oh, okay. So, we're just Yeah, I think
realizing I just have to hold this is a
little is it better? I'm trying to think
cuz switcheroo
it's good if you have small units on the
battlefield.
>> But if that switcheroo on the aspirin's
climb, it's a six might and a four
might.
>> So like Allen could attack in with the
Ezreal card sharp and you can't switch
route to dodge that like that's going to
make it worse. So that'll just clear the
uh Ferris Forerunner. The Jinx makes it
a little nicer. What's nice on that top
battlefield, the um arena's greatest, is
that we do have uh the Overzel's fan
that we can switch R with. And this
actually maybe makes the switcher better
cuz smokec screen just made the ferris
4runner small.
>> All right, so we're moving in with the
mind spplitter just one at first. So,
will we trade or will we?
>> Ah, it's not switch. It is a tie turner.
And again, we don't know. We We didn't
see the deck list, so we're unsure what
hidden cards Rian has. I'm just taking
guesses as like what the options are.
And react gust. Oh.
>> Oh, it's starting to feel bad. It's
starting to feel real bad. Uh these uh
purple cards go crazy.
>> Yeah.
>> So, Ty Turner can move back to the
Ferris 4Runner and swap there if you
want. I'm trying to do the math here at
six of eight. It's eight defending on
mine spplitter currently. So, you don't
have to swap with Ferris 4Runner. I
think at this point Rian's like, "Yeah,
I got to hold it the other."
And I don't think you can. Like I even
if that's a it's like a tide turner,
that's going to be what, eight 10
defending and there's already so much
attacking in here.
>> Yeah, that's a little it's a little
stressful. Sounds like we're just trying
to confirm what can be done with the
judge. But
>> yeah, I'm not sure whose um action
window it is currently or who who has
priority or focus, but I think it's
Allen with focus and priority. He's just
choosing where the damage is going to
go.
>> So, the mind splitter will die, tie will
stay, two mech tokens will come out, but
I mean like
>> all Alen needs to do now is send Yeah.
one three might in and everything else
can go to the other battlefield. O. And
so he conquers there with the Ezreal
after everything resolves and Aspirant
climbs now belongs to Allen for the
additional point. Then we're going to
Arcane Shift. So we can uh
blink something out, play it back to the
field. It's going to be the Ezreal. That
means that we get to discard and draw
two. And most importantly, it'll deal
three damage to that Ferris 4runner.
Three damage is now on him. And that
means it like uh just send two little
guys in or we just we might just have
enough snipes.
>> Oh my gosh. Is Is this BM?
>> Might not even give him a chance. No,
not at all. This is Allen playing it
correctly. This Allen playing it smart.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> Oh, what a play.
>> The six damage stays. You kill the gear
and that means a tide turner will swap
with a mech. But that is it.
>> Oh my goodness. What a display of skill
there. Allen's EQ with an 111 and1
record looks to be making top eight.
>> I mean I I I see why he won with Ezreal.
That was absolutely phenomenal. Oh my
goodness.
>> Ran can hold their head high. I believe
that should be enough to get the best of
Jinx. I can't imagine how the Jinx was
able to make it that far. But a tough
matchup. Allen's EQ showed a master
class right there. Not even going in and
giving the opportunity. I was like
switcheroo is like a crazy option. Maybe
it's that. But like Guy Turner is the
more realistic one. It's the more common
one in decks. Um and so reading that
he's like, "Yeah, I'm just going to just
snipe out that uh Ferris 4Runner, not
even send my units in." And like Alan ZQ
had so much more than he needed to win
that game.
>> Yes, he did. And there was I mean, he
was playing it so perfectly, just making
sure that all of his ducks were in a row
there to secure that win. I thought it
was BM because he was he had all this
all these units, but no, it was just the
accurate way to play smart and safe.
>> And I I also got to say uh uh it's tough
when like you set up all the excitement
of what Jinx can do and we didn't
actually get to see the Jinx really get
off the ground. I really do think that's
got to be a tough match up. There's not
going to be a lot of data on it, but I
would have to imagine you let those two
play 10 games and it's going to be like
nine for Ezreal just because everything
Jinx is doing is again within the bounds
of what Ezreal wants to interact with.
three might and below Jinx has a lot of
units there and even like only up to six
at the top end. It's like that's pretty
easy for Ezreal to deal with too,
>> right? Exactly. And I mean the Ezreal
also just did not let Jinx interact with
those Gus with those
>> three stupify. Three stupify was
awesome. I mean it what what a way to
like start game one right there. Just
getting all the draws. But I'm hearing
that the interview is ready. So I'm sure
that Allan's going to have a lot of
thoughts on that one and we can hear
about him as he's approaching top eight.
I am pleased to be joined by the
prestigious Allan ZQ because you have
just locked in your fourth top cut at a
regional qualifier. You've already won
one of them Allan. This is going to be
your fourth best of third time on Ezreal
once with Kaisa. Allan, how are you
feeling right now?
>> Oh, an absolutely relief. Uh there was
an imposter syndrome coming at me. I'm
like, am I not going to make it really?
And like in the little like there was a
bit downfall of the deck was not greedy
enough. But this time it just served me
right. I was pretty much proud to hold
the tournament. Uh a metal slayer. I had
a lot of legends that are more chasing
for the best of not necessarily uh for
the top cut. And surprisingly for the
top eight, I was fighting for Jinx.
>> Yeah, exactly. And that Jinx deck was a
ton of fun. I actually had the pleasure
of seeing some of it in action. But you
had a very dominating per performance
there. The aspirin's climb in game two
was the make or break I think and I've
talked to a lot of people about how just
having that ability to turn or slow the
game down by one extra turn and it
worked exactly exactly the way that it
planned out I think in your head. Is
that the kind of game plan always going
second? You kind of want to have that
extra little time to get on the board.
>> Yeah. So basically the battlefields you
have to adjust to the whole deck
building and because of the deck got a
lot greedier uh you have to make up with
battlefield. So I just put a negative
battlefields so I have more time and I'm
not forced to conquer where there are
battlefields such as a Mar or Targon
where you want to go in more
aggressively which my previous list was
doing was more temporiented and then I
ended up being on the top decks and I
was running out of cards because less of
the real trigger as well uh because it
had more general tempo cards that are
not targeting. Uh however here the
aspirant is to counter the all the arena
greatest uh basically all the aggro
plants and that works uh wonderfully.
The only really
back side of this is just that D red
draven in the they get to grow it a lot
bigger so have to deal with that.
>> Well that is incredible. It's it's so
insightful hearing such powerful
strategic knowledge because I think
Battlefields is such a unique part of
the game plan. Like you said, if your
main deck and your deck, your sideboard
is already there to help what's going on
in the game plan going into the
tournament. The Battlefields and the
adjustment game to game is really where
you can shine and show that skill. But
speaking of skill, you've got other
people in this bracket in top eight
you've got to play against. There's a
set, a Kaisa, an Ireelia, an Annie, two
Dravens so far locked. What are you
looking to maybe avoid since you will be
coming in kind of on the bottom side of
this bracket?
>> I mean, I absolutely want to avoid
Prismat. He has a better match up into
me and he knows exactly how I play. He
knows my whole deck because we practice
so much. So, he probably can get best of
me uh if we face. And generally, I
really post the B is not so hot, but I
would say it's uh fairly okay. Uh and
the rest I feel confident going into.
However, I want to shout out the Prismat
and Frosty Quark, both from our study
group and like the newly made one and we
all made the top cut and we had one more
person going for the top eight. However,
I knocked him out two runs ago uh out of
the contention unfortunately.
>> Hey, but the team doing well the it
really is showcasing the amount of time
and knowledge it takes to showcase and
be good at this game and you're doing it
multiple times after another. So, Alan,
congratulations once again. I mean,
Prismat told me that you all kind of
think that he might be playing the best
deck in the room, but are you gonna
maybe prove that it's still Ezreal?
>> I mean, it's just my pet deck. I I set
myself a challenge and I am the up there
to try to make the best out of it. And I
got the challenge up to three four. Not
quite the 44, but hey, you can't
complain.
>> That's right. What a great way to top
off the Spirit Ford season, Alan. You've
had an absolute tear of these first five
CH regional qualifiers, and I wish you
luck in top eight. Thanks so much,
>> man. He's doing it. Yep.
>> He's doing it
>> on the pet deck. He's like, "Nah, it's
not the best deck. It's just my pet
deck, and I'm just that good,
>> and I'm just that skilled, you know? I'm
I'm I'm just
>> I need that confidence. I I need I need
to take some lessons from him." Yeah.
>> I'm sure he's putting in tons of hours,
tons of work, studying these cars,
learning the matchups, learning what to
do in what situations that, you know,
it's just paying off. is paying off. And
uh again, I got to talk with Ri about
his Jinx list. I'm gonna find you.
>> Yeah, we we need that Jinx list for
>> I need that Jinx list. I need to figure
out what the magic was and what the good
matchups were. I don't think they were
Ezreal matchups. I'm going to say also
probably not uh many matches against uh
players of Allen ZQ's caliber. That is
his fourth top.
>> Yeah,
>> that is crazy. Like, do you understand
how variant card games can be? You
shuffle your deck, you don't know what
you're going to draw. You get a
mulligan, too. But like then you have to
make all these decisions. Incredible
decision trees across long days. Eight
rounds day one, five rounds already now
and then a top eight as well.
>> And to be that consistent and that good.
>> Yeah,
>> that is insane.
>> There's a lot of variables when it comes
to it. Just even down to the mental
fortitude of Yeah. even just the mental
fortitude of getting through the day
because sometimes you get tired and you
start making different types of
decisions and
>> it it kind of it kind of makes a mess of
everything. But I think we should get a
postgame recap real quick to sum
everything up.
>> Thank you so much, Miss Chimch and Kas.
That was an incredible game and it does
seem like Allen's EQ kind of has the
number of the Chaos and Fury domains.
That's not the first time I've seen
Allen never get a match up pretty well,
but he might be playing his teammate at
some point in the top eight. That's
going to be very fun to watch. So, let's
have a look actually at the closing
moments of this game because I think if
there's one thing that's just so fun
about watching Allen on Ezreal, just
clearly a master of understanding how to
get out of very a bunch of different
problems. So the thing about Ezreal is
especially the way Allan plays this
list, it's not particularly like
intuitive at all times. It's also not
particularly splashy as Kangas I heard
mention on the cast at one point. Not
unchuck power in this list. Not playing
big powerful cards. Playing a lot of
really efficient spells, things you can
buy back with Fizz out of the trash.
Just a lot of different ways to kind of
nickel and dime your opponents with all
these incremental spells that build up
into an even bigger advantage,
especially when Ezra's legend is drawing
you cards. So let's set the stage real
quick. Game is close. We're climbing
with Aspirin's climb. So, eight points
here for Rian, our Jinx player, seven
points for Allan, which is basically six
in a normal game, right? So, if Allan
can conquer both these battlefields,
which do have some relatively fearsome
units on them, then he'll be able to win
this game. So, as you can see, there's a
full runner here and a full runner here
on the battlefields. And overall stand
at this battlefield and one hidden card.
And we actually play the clip out. You
can kind of see Rian, there's no cards
left for our Jinx player. So, we'll roll
it through and you can see that it's
going to basically say, you know what, I
got nothing left. I'm going to hide my
final card and see what happens from
there. So, we play the clip and I'm just
going to walk you through this kind of
as we go. So, last hidden card here
comes through. What is it? We'll have to
find out in a moment with our little
puzzling borrow. But, uh, someone that's
pretty good at puzzles is Allen's EQ.
So, kind of just considering again, I
think there's a there is a jinx also
still available from the champion zone.
Ran's basically like I got nothing. What
do you got? cuz it's this I'm either
going to win the game or lose the game
at this point which is this is the spot
we're at. So Allan awakens, draws a card
and starts to think now already you can
see Allan is a lot of might 14 here with
the mind spplitters four more for the
Raven Bloom students although they can
get a bit bigger quite quickly. That is
18 plus six for 24 and you can see 12 10
you know there's not that much might
left on these battlefields but Allan
doesn't know what the hidden cards are.
So he doesn't want to take too many
chances. Verrunner especially can be so
annoying and if somehow the game doesn't
end this turn, we don't really want to
give the mex away. So smoke screen first
to clear things out and then
Mindsplitter rolls on into the
battlefield
and as you can see currently
Mindsplitter is a seven. I'm sorry I'm
not going to drawing numbers and it is
Tide Turner which is actually doing
something really cool here. So we didn't
actually see this interaction all that
much but Tide Turner is actually trying
to go with this overzealous man because
there is a attack trigger still
happening. You can actually swap the
tide turner and the overzale span and
you'll get an option to get an overzeal
span trigger, sacrifice the fan and push
it back which would have been
backbreaking in this situation. As it
turns out though, Allan has the gust.
Very nice. Manages to push the tide
turner away. So, push the overall span
away before the tie turner can finish
resolving its action on the chain. And
that basically says okay again Allan is
sitting down here on this battlefield
currently looking decent on might. It is
two 4 5 6 7 8 Might to the Mindslitter
is seven. So Alan needs a little bit
more, but of course it's Edel with a
handful of cards. So doesn't feel too
bad to to figure it out. But Allan is
still thinking, puzzling through,
figuring out what to do. And you'll
notice that right now Allan has what,
seven, eight runes awakened, ready to
go. Allan is going to use most of those
this turn. Also, you can see over here,
the Raven Bloom students slowly getting
bigger as well, which is always nice to
build up a little bit of extra might.
That's why he's kept them in the base.
So, we're puzzling. We're thinking, we
know by the numbers things work out. All
just decides, you know what? I'm going
to assign some damage. I'm going to let
Ferris Ferrunner go to go to the trash.
Get the two mechs. This doesn't really
matter at this point. Again, this is the
last turn of the game. These mechs being
in base
>> sometimes often very scary. Not very
scary in this instance.
But there's still this battle to deal
with. So Ezreal's conquered this. That's
a point. We need one more. Arcane Shift
the choice here. Doing three damage to
the ferris 4runner. Getting back to
Ezreal to draw even more cards. So this
Ezreal is going to shift on out and
we'll see him over here. this way. Oh,
we had one Ezreal here and now Ezreal's
over here drawing Allan two cards. You
can see the forerunner still has three
marked on it. Wages of pain. That's
exactly three damage. Four run is going
to get cleared. And of course, the final
thing, one accelerated losses at the end
because the boots are still attached.
Don't forget there's a pair of shoes
right over there. But it's all good for
Allen who's going to take the two
battlefields and take the game. I will
say for Allen's level, not the most
intricate sequence you've ever seen him
go through, but despite having the might
advantage, really cool to see Allan
basically navigate through every
possible hidden card his opponent is
likely to have, use basically all of his
resources and ensure a guaranteed
victory. And for me, this is the thing
that Allan just does so well. He is so
good at figuring out what can my
opponent have and how can I play around
it? And when he has enough time, when he
has enough resources, when he has the
knowledge and the practice that he has,
it doesn't feel like very many dicks can
really do this. We're actually going to
take a look at the jigs. So, I know
Kangas said that he wanted to have a
look. So, let's have a look at the jinx
deck list cuz we've seen Allan take a
few times. This, by the way, this is our
best of jigs. Ren may not have made top
eight. Was one win away. Allan and
Rianne were playing for that final spot,
one of the final spots in top eight. But
this is officially our best of jigs. And
it is so wild to me that we could have
had
one domain combination have three
different legends. All three of its
legends actually currently which is wild
cuz there's an extra proven grounds
legend as well or represent in our top
eight. Instead it is just Draven and
Annie. So let's have a look at this list
here. Uh Rex Abrio Ferris 41 noxious
hopeful. These have become the staples
of Fury I feel like. Uh Kaiser Survivor
also kind of in that row. This deck is
actually very very streamlined. There's
a lot of Draven DNA in this list. Three
Overdas stand, three Tide Turner. These
are all cards that a lot of these decks
want to play, which I think is kind of
fun to see. Uh, one note for me that I
think definitely stands out. First of
all, Minefield in the battlefields. And
I did see Rien in uh, this series at
least against Allen actually led on
Minefield. So, clearly a battlefield
that uh, he pretty consistently wants to
go to, which is kind of cool to see.
Again, when you conquer here, you put
the top two cards of your mandic into
your trash and, you know, have some ways
to maybe move through your deck, which
is kind of fun to see. Uh stack deck
though I think is kind of standing out
to me. Not because this isn't a good
card. Everybody knows stack deck is a
very good card. The thing about stack
deck is that some decks you know they're
playing one maybe two. I think all might
be playing three just cuz he really
values your filtering and Ezreal.
I don't think a lot of the if memory
serves I don't think a lot of the uh you
know the Annie and the Dravens are
necessarily playing three of this card
because I think they maybe value having
maybe higher impact cards maybe more
expensive cards but clearly valuing the
filtering and in general if you just
look at this list it is threes basically
across the board two fair cuz that's a
little bit too expensive which is a bit
surprising given how much of a presence
that card has had in this metag game but
other than that it's you know one bit of
swiftness for the ganking which makes
sense three cle the wind uh one hard
bargain this kind of a thing. How many
flash? Actually, we'll have a quick look
at uh that card as well. This card's
been stellar all weekend long. Most
decks are actually running one. So, if
we have a look at this boots of
swiftness just real quick, I can have a
peek at how many flashes are in this
deck list. No, I can't cuz that covers
it. No, it's one flash. One for both and
one for falling star. I think it's
probably two or three if I had to guess.
Really? Oh, only one falling star.
Excuse me. And again, makes sense when
you have all these threes. And honestly,
if you look at this, not unreasonable to
say, you know what, this kind of just
looks like a good Draven list, but using
a different legend, which is kind of
been Jinx's thing since Spirit Forge.
But I think the thing that sticks out to
me and the thing that Duke are
definitely not playing anymore and one
of the reasons to play Minefield, in
fact, in this list, at least in the
main, the reason to be playing
Minefield, Vi, which is a a champion
that has been tearing people up, coming
to unleash, super excited for this. Uh,
it does have ganking, which is pretty
important. And again, ganking is a very
nice uh keyword to get, especially in
when you're a deck that's trying to
conquer battlefields pretty
aggressively. But this is recycle one
from your trash. Give me plus one this
turn. And playing minefield as one of
your battlefields. Having three of this
to me says that this is a very valuable
unit in this deck. This is not like the
other decks where you were just running
it for the recycle. Maybe running one,
maybe two if you wanted to care about
just uh having it as a a drop you could
play that could get really big in the
late game. This is an early drop that
you can deploy even though there are
plenty of other twos. In fact, there's
nine two drops not including the VI in
this deck. So again, Rian clearly caring
a lot about getting uh in play early and
getting onto battlefields and conquering
them. But especially when Jinx is
discarding cards, VI is just the card
that can get massive and when you're
trying to break through things like
Forrunner, these big battlefields, even
Aurelius that these decks can generate.
This to me is one of the compelling
reasons to play this cuz Jinx from your
champion zone able to discard cards, a
really fun accelerate unit draws you up
as well. Again, a lot of the DNA of the
Draven decks we've seen, even some of
the stuff we've seen in Addy from
Prismaticism, but Vice sticking out to
me is a really fun one. And this just
looks like an extremely aggressive,
really nicely streamlined list. And
obviously, obviously good enough to win
the best off here, which is very
impressive despite Rien just barely
missing on top eight. Well, that's what
I think. What do you all think back
there?
>> I think that Kangas has a lot of
thoughts.
>> I have a lot of opinions. Thank you
first off, Pastry, for showing that deck
list. That was fantastic. I was very
curious. Um, but I think he actually
summarized it great. That was just a
Draven list in in Jinx. And I like it
when you lean into the strength of the
legends. So when I lab Jinx, I'm trying
to play with the death rocket. I'm
trying to play like to get that low hand
size and get the extra draws of the
Jinx. But this was a much more
streamlined like no, we're just going to
play the good red and purple cards. Uh,
and then the vibe was kind of like the
fun spice. like they were having some
chefery going on in there with their
their cooking, but uh for the most part
it was like a just kind of standard
Draven list, which has gotten Jinx's uh
tops. I think pretty much all the best
of Jinxes have just been kind of like
taking a Draven list, right?
>> And being like, "Hey, I'm the best
Jinx." Um but hey, still almost top
eight getting to play Allen on feature
match. I think that's a really cool run
regardless.
>> Absolutely. And it was just tough
opponent, tough matchup all in all. So,
I think that uh there's a reason that
the Jinx made it this far. Obviously,
there was skill expression in knowing
that list.
>> Yeah. You're not going to go 101 and one
if you're not good at the deck. Like,
very clearly uh knew what they were
doing.
>> Absolutely. And I do want to say hey to
the friend who is in the back of pastry
time with the walks. That was
>> we were I hope they would come a third
time. I was really ruined for the third
appearance.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> I'm hearing speaking of threes that we
have our uh previous feature match that
we took a break from. game three that
we're going to hop back into and take a
look at the Draven Mirror match. We took
a break for a judge call that was
resolved. Uh and it looks like it was
one to one between game one and two. So
we are going to game three aspirin climb
versus Targon's Peak. They got the same
three battlefields just playing them at
different times.
>> Perfect. And to update y'all on that
judge uh whole situation, they were just
figuring out the board state, I do
believe. Yeah, it there was a um uh I
believe all we were told was an error
and then talked to both players,
everything was above board. They added 9
minutes to the timer total. Um so it
looks like that's fine. But then we do
have another update. Um there was an
appealed slowplay warning. Um but it was
upheld. So uh that means that whatever
time we see on screen, we're expecting
to be correct. Um but I'll let you know
if if there's any update on our end. But
that's not a lot of time to get into a
game three. You can feel the pressure
and we already saw that game one how
slow things were going. Neither one
wanted to go to
>> No one wanted to play the game, but uh
let's hope that we don't get that again.
We've got the Rexai already on the board
uh on the side of Ozister, but we've got
a tie turner uh on the board for
Stardust. So, let's see uh if we're
actually going to get some movement here
uh before things settle. It's now
Stardust's turn. And it looks like we
might go in to conquer.
>> Yeah, I mean, when you don't have this
much time, I think you have to actually
go for the game. Especially with
Aspirin's Clam, you got to go to nine
again, just like game one did. Uh, so
we're going to go for the merchant and
send into Targon's Peak. Get a conquer
that will ready two runes at the end of
the turn.
>> Absolutely. So, we've got those two
units on the board for Stardust. And now
we have passed over to Oz Mister
like always. We get our runes. We get
our draw for the turn. Looking in hand,
we've got a ride the win. I do believe
not a ride the win, a rebuke. I believe
that is a falling star, Ferris Runner,
Forerunner, and I can't see two of those
other cards, but I just wanted to make a
mental note. Is
>> Yeah, Falling Star, Ferris 4runner,
Rebuke, Hard Bargain, I believe.
hardgain.
>> Is that a Rex eye? I can't tell. Uh
might be another Rex eye, but we we'll
see. I imagine if it's a Rex eye, they
would probably play it here.
>> Actually, I think it's Is that Der
Merchant? I can't tell. I I'm going to
stop pretending like I can uh tell what
that card is. Could be a lot of
different things. Maybe even a gem
jammer. It looks like there's a power
cost though. I
>> um
>> we are going to exhaust three here
though. It looks like Oh, JK. We're just
getting them all together.
>> Four and a half minutes on the clock.
Really stressful for both of these
players here. And a reminder for the uh
Tai for for the time rules, it's 60
minutes plus three turns. So once we hit
that 60 minutes, the three turns uh
total here. And um you have to lead by
two points to be cleared the winner of
the match.
>> Yes. And Stardust is currently up those
two uh two runes exhausted for that gem
jammer that you did spot in the hand of
Osmister. So now it's Stardust's turn
after the pass. We're gonna hold.
>> So Gem Jammer as opposed to the Falling
Star to deal with the threats. I feel
like Falling Star was the more optimal
play, but I I suppose hard bargain
repeated is the punish. So Osmister was
playing around that.
>> Yes, we're going in with the traveling
merchant to get a third point. And we've
got all of our runes up. So there's a
little bit more that we can do here.
The problem is like if you're Oh, yeah.
It's not the 4Runner turn because
Stardust like I think the hope for
Osmister is like, "Okay, play the
4Runner then I can falling star after
and then clear out the board." But the
double hard bargain is still a threat
and you have not gotten through that. So
tight game here. Okay, we did add time
to the clock. I imagine that's the um
the the slow play warming warning time
extension.
>> Currently there's 5 minutes on there
now.
>> Yep. Got a little bit got a little bit
more as we might be starting a showdown
with this gem jammer.
>> Would be interesting to send that in
first as opposed to the Rex side cuz
that means you have to use something
proactively unless you just I guess
sacrifice it.
Uh let's see what they do. Osmus are
taking a lot of time like you don't have
a lot of time.
>> Nope. With that
>> and you're behind on points here. So
Stardust if we go to overtime and then
there's the three turn. Sardis is
leading by three right now.
>> All right, so we're trying to get some
of these units off of the board here
with this falling star from Oz Mister.
We're traveling both or we're we're
targeting both traveling merchants. Yep.
But we're going to respond with a
spinning axe and just uh give up one of
those traveling merchants here.
>> Saving the one in the base, meaning that
we can go in the next turn and try and
conquer and get a draw. Osmister can try
and take some points on the board here,
but Sardus is setting himself up to have
a really good start. And now that's a
reaction flash as well. I suppose that's
the the chain is being added to the um
spinning axe, but there's a hard bargain
and Sardis is completely exhausted.
>> Yep, hard bargain on that flash. Unless
he wanted to pay to he's giving up that
tie turner
>> and Stardust was trying to do that so
that there wasn't a draw from Osmister.
trying to save another unit and not give
the plus one to Osmister on the uh the
winning combat. Um but yeah, Osmister
with the hard bargain. That's a a decent
time to use it. Uh and you got to get on
the board. I don't think that it's going
to get that much easier for Osmister.
Yeah, he's going to reinforce. So, he's
still going to be behind in points. 3
and 1/2 minutes on the clock.
>> Yes, three and a half minutes. But you
also have those three turns in overtime
to try and get something.
Yeah, but you you need to be again lead
by two. So Stardust currently already
>> leading by two. New Yorker.
>> Oh, did they miss sequenced their ABCDs?
I think they awakened and or they
channeled and then awakened. Is is is
that what I'm hearing there?
>> There was something about channeling of
runes there.
>> I can't tell. Are we just continuing? I
think we're just
>> we're starting the turn. Yeah, cuz that
counter has gone away.
>> Might have been a a warning. I'm not
sure. But Judge mentioned something to
Stardust. That's got to be stressful.
The time is the time. Judge standing
right behind you.
>> Judge is making sure. Well, we also have
to make sure that we're doing everything
that we are supposed to do for this game
state.
>> This is one of those moments I just like
to remind everybody. This is a very
human experience witnessing right now.
The stress of the moment. Top eight on
the line in a mirror match that is very
complex. You don't want to mess up.
>> No. And there's a timer on your
forehead. So, it makes it that much more
stressful. Nobody likes being rushed, of
course. So, we're going to go ahead and
bring in that Draven Showboat uh with
the traveling merchant on the aspirants
climb.
>> Okay, I'll play it. Uh
>> okay,
>> we're going to try and hold. If you're
Stardust, I think that your way to play
the clock can just be to to hold. Um
because Osmister is the one that's in
the the pressure seat right now. you're
behind a lot of points
>> and Osmister was saying like, "All
right, let's let's get this rolling cuz
he's got to play that catch up right
now."
>> I mean, but Osmister is the one that
arguably taken longer on the turns. I
know Star's last turn was a little
longer, but Osmister on every turn has
taken at least like 25 to 45 seconds.
>> Here we go. We're exhausted
>> now. Like taking some time. Like you
don't have a lot of time.
>> Wondering what we're going to do. Howdy.
Is it going to hit?
>> It's excruciating. And it's got to be
even worse in their seats.
>> Yeah. Oh, I think we're taking that
back. We don't want to let that card hit
quite yet, but
>> And then he goes back to it. Okay.
>> Howdy porro. Then we're exhausting the
four. We're going to get the Kaiser.
We're going to move the gem jammer back
>> and the overzealous fan. Was that is
that an overzealous fan? I
>> uh gem jammer, Rexai, pouty porroa.
That's what we got there. Yeah,
>> that card is so dark. It is right now.
I'm not really
>> Looks great in person if you actually um
in in in the like get the sparkle on it,
but Stardust just gonna score the point,
pull everything back. Osmister can
actually catch up a little bit in points
here.
>> And then we are going to stack deck
>> Okay, there's a chance Stardust actually
bleeds out the clock on this turn and
that would put us in a really good spot
for overtime.
>> Oh, Mister a little stressed here.
Darius.
>> And we're going to play a Darius real
quick with the exhausted and one
recycled.
>> And it it it readies. It's the second
card played. Yep. Keep it there.
Stardust.
>> Do you want to go in and conquer and get
the point and ready two runes for
Targons? You have your option.
>> Rest.
>> And again, Osmister is really pressuring
him. Again, Osmus is also taking time.
you know,
>> feel for both of them, but you got to
you got to understand the tough
position.
>> Absolutely.
>> So, he gets in and he scores. Time has
hit zero
>> and he'll go for another one. So, I
believe that this is now turn zero here
and Stardust will start on turn one.
>> So, we moved that Kai'Sa in. We moved
that Pouty Porro in and we scored those
points. And now we're starting to stack.
The rail comes out. The gem jammer goes
to protect the Kai'Sa. Rexai is ready.
We're tapping. We're exhausting
and we're hiding a card on the uh
Targon's Peak. We're passing over to
Stardust for turn one
in this overtime match. Everything's
ready on the side of Stardust and we're
going to start moving in.
>> So in the overtime, yeah, in the
overtime period, if a player leads by
two points, they can be declared the
winner. Osmister is in a really, really
tough spot right now. So, we're
recycling the rune. We're equipping that
spinning axe on the Darius.
>> And we're moving into the Aspirants
Climb.
>> So, that is representing I don't think
he got the plus two from his own
ability. So, this is just eight, I
believe. I I I don't think that uh
enough cards were played
>> unless Sardis has something here in a in
an action step. players in turn zero.
>> It sounds like the overtime is starting
right now. The judges are speaking to
them about turn zero starting now for
Stardust. So I think I restart my timer
here.
>> So uh players are taking a moment. I at
this point you don't have to play crazy
fast because now it's about playing
optimally. Stardust has the opportunity
to make a big push here and just take
the series. Osmister is going to have to
play one heck of a game of riftbound in
order to make this comeback happen.
>> And remember that this is one to one,
but Ozmister is bringing out his own
spinning axe, equipping that to the re.
>> Yeah. Also, um, we're hearing from
production, they're just confirming when
overtime happened because there was a
additional 50-second delay from the
clock on stage versus what we were
potentially seeing because of the slow
plays. So, we're we're going to confirm.
I'm I'm going to stop saying which like
turn in overtime it is right now until
we have confirmation. But what we do
know on the field right now is uh what's
happening currently.
>> Yes.
>> Where's my
>> still I think if Stardust is able to
make a big push that is huge.
>> We can slow down.
>> So I believe that was rebuke on the
Darius. I was looking at the the
information.
>> Yes.
>> On overtime there. Yep. Okay. So the
Darius is gone. We re-equipped the
spinning axe. That's going to be five
might on the traveling merchant and
still six runes available for Stardust.
>> Yes. And we're counting up here and
we're going to recycle a rune
and we're going to equip that spinning
axe again to that uh merchant.
>> Another one. Okay.
>> Yes. So, we've got a grand total of six
might on that merchant with the
additional two that it originally has.
We're going to go ahead and send this
JK. Yep.
>> Oh, taking it back. Taking it back. No,
no additional information was gained.
So, you're allowed to rewind the clock.
>> I rewind the clock.
>> I'm working on it.
>> Okay. Okay. I like the sound of this.
How was it?
>> That was I'll give it a three out of 10.
>> That's That's quite low. I'll give it a
three. It it it kind of sounded chicken
like
>> uh so I could I could have committed
more is what
>> you could have definitely committed
more.
>> Was that better?
>> Okay. Yeah, I heard I heard how it could
be a rewind but it looks like we are
going to re-equip that spinning axe here
and we're sending it in to the Targon's
Peak into that Kai'Sa and the Gem
Jammer. Now there is a hidden card
there, but we're passing priority
>> and it's switcheroo.
>> All right.
>> Massive right there. So that will swap
the two might with the eight might and
kill the merchant. If it goes through,
if all this happens, no hard bargain.
>> Wow.
>> Oof. Oof. That is a toughy, my brother.
- 6 plus 6 for the mites here.
And for the response, Stardust
is thinking through is this where we get
a turn of events from Ozmister.
Now, this is I if the um that the timer
was correct on our end and if it
actually was Osmister's turn when
overtime was reached, that would make
essentially turn zero of overtime. You
finish the turn. Stardust is on turn
one. So that means that we get Osmister
for a turn and then Stardust for a third
turn in overtime.
>> Let's see what else Stardust has in the
tank.
>> You just got to get a point above or two
points above. So Stardust just needs to
get one here.
>> All right. So we we are equipping those
spinning axes onto this ready Draven
here who has the might increased by the
amount of points which is five. So we're
essentially swinging in with 5 33 3 11
>> 14 by my math and the re's 7 plus porro
is two so that's nine. So I I feel like
that's the obvious choice here. Just
attack in on the real porro.
Otherwise it would be eight and four.
Actually the 12 also works like you win
either side of that.
>> All right we're moving in and we do take
this battlefield. So Draven is going to
get that additional point. We're in that
two-point threshold as of right now. Is
there anything that we can do
about this next one? Oh, and we ride the
wind over to the next battlefield. The
Draven does go up an additional might
because of the point going up and we
clear that battlefield as well. So now
we're going to get an additional
conquer. Draven is ready. What are we
going to do?
>> I don't think it's possible. So Osmister
gets one turn, you can score two points.
That puts you to six versus seven of
Stardust. Move the Draven back, send it
into Conquer. You got to lead by two. So
as long as Stardust is able to get
guarantee a point. Stardust did a really
good job of just putting himself in a
like excellent position to win. Asper
target speak should ready that rune, but
I I don't know if Stardust has anything
to use. We'll see. Okay, there we go.
They are correcting it. So
>> the judges are on it. I love to see it.
So I'm moving back. I just passed.
>> What do you think?
>> So technically at the end of the turn,
you have to ready it. New information
was gained as Osmister drew a card. You
could argue. We'll see what the judges
rule.
>> Osmister is really playing that line of
like what's acceptable, what's not. I
mean, Stardust also I don't even know if
that rune will matter too much. I I
won't I won't I won't.
>> No, I know. But
>> it would be a double hard bargain would
be like the most impactful thing, but
since Stardust didn't hard bargain
earlier in the turn, maybe they don't
have it.
>> There's a lot of technicalities here
that are like you just got to make sure
you get you get the official way that
you're supposed to play it in
>> during your turn.
>> Yeah. So Osminister's goal, I suppose,
at this point is to
just, you know, get get these two points
and then make sure Stardust can't get
one more. You have one unit now. What
What else does he have in hand? Let's
start thinking of the the potential
while they're talking about this call.
Is there anything accelerated? No.
There's a stack deck. You have to draw
something off that stack deck or
Osmister just loses.
>> Cuz if you score one, it's five to
seven. Stardust starts turn, ends turn,
that's game.
>> Yeah.
I mean, they're probably going to rule
it the same way.
>> We're going to see if there is a
different ruling here.
>> I mean, Stardust has already said it's
fine. The runes like I from what I could
uh tell interpreted from my end, it
seems like Stardust is fine with the
current state. And right,
>> we're still talking about something. I
don't know what we're talking about.
>> I think we're talking about the slow
play here, but we're looking for the
stack deck on Ozmister here as
>> slow play in overtime's crazy. uh going
through. Yeah, I think it's just a lot
of uh technicalities.
>> I think it's a lot of emotion.
>> A lot of emotion. And here at the end,
we're we're borderline at the finish.
The most important match. It's been a
long weekend.
>> There's a lot on the line.
>> A lot of rift.
>> I empathize with everybody that's in
this type of situation. Regardless of,
you know, how you're handling the
pressure, it's so much pressure to be in
this seat. And I just got to remind
everybody, this is a human experience.
>> Absolutely.
>> It's tough. It's really really tough out
there.
>> 100%.
>> Now I don't see a way to accelerate. I
don't think that Osmister had it. You
took I think that's a rebuke. Yeah,
that's a rebuke.
>> Yeah, there's a rebuke in hand.
>> It's a Ferris 4runner, a tide turner,
and I don't know if there's anything
else.
>> It looks like Rexi is being being sent
into Targon's pink uh to score an
additional point. Is Stardust going to
let this go through?
>> Let me tell you, I don't envy those
judges right now. Also,
>> no. Yeah. Everybody's got to be on their
Q's and P's, y'all.
>> That's a tense tense table.
>> You better sit the freak up. We're
playing Riftbound right now.
>> Yeah.
>> In a moment of brevity. I do like these
poro sleeves. Yes. Want to point that
out while we're
>> They're very They They bring a little
bit of light and a little bit of
happiness to this very tense.
>> Feel like we need to take a Everybody
take a deep breath. Everybody at home in
and out.
>> Spinning axe. That's the other card in
hand. Yeah, I don't think Osmister can
do it.
>> I know it's tough. I know it's
heartbreaking. It's the worst feeling in
the world. You've played so many rounds
this weekend.
>> A tight mirror match to close it out,
but if you don't have it, you don't have
it.
>> We are exhausting five. We're bringing
in the Draven. We're recycling one.
We're
>> ready and two to pass for the Targon's
Peak. But there we go. Stardust is two
up.
>> All right, we've got the might in. We go
in for the point.
>> I mean, the rebuke comes down, but
>> the rebuke comes down.
>> Stardust is leading by two. Again, in
overtime period, a player must lead by
two points to be declared the winner of
the match.
>> All right.
>> If the player's lead is less than or
equal to one point, the match will be
declared a draw. I'm looking at the
numbers. That's two in favor of
Stardust.
>> What can be done here?
Rise coming in. It looks like
>> and we also have ride the win. So like
Stardust even just wins clean. Like it
doesn't matter. The overtime point rules
like this is the third turn unless the
only other thing is unless the timer was
wrong and it was actually Stardust's
turn. I suppose that would be a much
bigger indicator here. So there's a
potential cuz again there was multiple
time extensions and uh solo play
warnings that were issued by judges. So
there is a chance that you know
Osmister's turn was not turn zero and it
was actually Stardust turn which would
completely flip the script. But
regardless of that
>> I think it's ending right here.
>> The additional 12 might here and we
might even what are we going to do with
those spinning axes as we play the ride
the wind. We're recycling
>> and that's going to conquer. That's
going to gank over both battlefields.
That's going to be a victory. Oh,
>> for Stardust. The Draven versus Draven.
>> Goodness gracious. Draven did win 100%
win rate, but also Draven did lose. So,
also 100% loss rate.
>> The curse of the mirror match. Curse of
the mirror match. And I would love to
know because that completely actually
changes kind of the interpretation of
the table state and the tension
happening on the table depending on
which turn zero it was, whether it was
on the the left or the right side.
Because if it actually was on the right
side, then again, that would have been
turn two. And there would have been
another turn for a Draven on the left um
to actually try and play and go for the
tie, which maybe a tie can get you
bubbled into top eight. I don't know
what that would look like cuz there's a
lot of X2s that are going to be waiting
patiently to see if they can get in.
Suddenly, uh 2x12 twos show up. It's
like, oh
>> yeah,
>> that can make things really chaotic.
>> It's it's just a lot of intense moments
all at once. just making sure that you
you you play Riftbound in the order that
it's supposed to be played, the ABCs.
>> Uh but yeah.
>> Yeah, we we commentate with the
information that we have on screen, but
also wanted to highlight that with all
the time extensions, you never I'm I'm
not fully confident with what exactly
the game say was. All we know is one
clean win happened. The VI ride, the
wind came up. We were talking about in
the Jinx. It showed up in the Draven.
And let's hear from the player
themselves about the deck and how that
experience was.
Thanks so much for the great cast. And
not only the great cast, but great game
play. I'm joined. Stardust. I've got to
tell you, you were the person we were
waiting for. You are our last lockedin
top eight contender. How does it feel?
>> Oh my god, it feels surreal. I I I don't
even know if I'm dreaming, but it feels
so real. Like uh I I I'm I'm honestly
speechless, but yeah. Seriously.
>> Could you say that the room is spinning?
like those spinning axes that were
coming out.
>> Everything was everything. The cards
were spinning, the runes were spinning.
Everything's spinning. I don't I don't
know what's going on. I'm dizzy.
>> That's okay. Well, take a minute,
compose yourself cuz you've got a little
bit more tournament to play. You're
actually you and seven other players are
the only ones left with a tournament
left to play. Now, you're not alone on
Draven going into Top Cut. So, I want to
pick your brain just a little bit. There
are two others in Top Cuts for Draven.
And you've got five different legends
that you might be going against. You've
got Ireelia, Set, Ezreal, Annie, and
Kai'Sa. Just real quick vibe check. Who
do you not want to go against
legendwise? Because I then want to pick
your brain about that mirror match you
just played.
>> Yeah. So, actually, I feel very
comfortable with the mirror matches. I
built my deck specifically to play that
mirror match. Um, Ireelia, it's it's
kind of the same thing. I built the deck
for the Ireelia. So, now these rogue
decks coming in with, you know, Yeah.
like with a set and stuff and honestly I
want to say Kai'Sa is not really scary
but he's been cooking every Draven so
now I'm kind of scared. Um and so I I
wouldn't want to play probably the
Kai'Sa set. Just give me more Dravens.
Give me the Dravens and I'll come your
champ.
>> I mean it I mean it's such a hard na
like battlefield to navigate. Pun
intended. Uh speaking of battlefields as
I seem to always be talking about them
all the time. You picked Aspirin's Climb
for game one and I think that's such a
unique choice. Obviously, I feel like we
all know that a lot of Dravens are
playing as Aspirin's Climb right now.
Literally, it came out when, you know,
going second. That's typically the play
that we've heard about most of the time.
But you picked it going first. Can you
like elaborate a little bit on that or
>> Well, the primary reason is cuz I'm
horrible at dice rolls. Like, I lose
every dice roll. Like, it's actually
genuinely awful. Um, and I play ZH.
Well, people usually play ZH like uh
first, but I like ZH last because if I'm
siding in cards, I get to see them
faster, right?
>> True.
>> Um, and yeah. Uh, so, you know, if I if
I know I'm losing uh the dice roll, I'm
I'm going going second. So, yeah, that's
why I play it.
>> Well, like I said, you've already locked
in that top eight position here,
Stardust. Not only that, you still have
to fight for your best of prize as well.
But regardless, at the end of the day,
you're going to go home with some of
that prize pool that's going in there.
So take, you know, take that moment. You
have some time before your matches that
are coming up, but you know, any other
shout outs or anything you want to say?
I mean, you obviously had to work
incredibly hard to get here.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'm I genuinely like my team
uh back in Clarksville and the people
who came to support me, like it's not
very many of them, but like they
believed in me and they were talking
about manifesting it the whole time and
quite like I don't know how like I just
I'm here now standing here in front of
you talking to you like it just feels
surreal. So yeah, thank you guys. in um
Clarksville and uh hope hope to make it
higher than top eight.
>> Higher are the stars just like Stardust
here. Incredible game to conclude the
Swiss rounds here in Atlanta. Don't go
anywhere though because of course we're
going to send it back to the casters
before we start our top eight.
>> Thank you so much Barrett. What a
wonderful interview. What amazing
insight from Stardust himself. I think
it's so interesting that he said he went
into this building his deck, crafting
his deck specifically for that mirror
matchup because he knows that there's
going to be a bunch of Dravens here. And
also the Ireelia, he kept that in mind
because again,
>> those are the top two.
>> Those are the top two. There's so many.
Now, speaking of top two, there will be
two other Dravens in this top cut,
>> but uh do we think that Stardust is
going to be able to
>> if he built it to beat other Dravens
theoretically? Like that that's good
statistical odds of getting a good match
up, especially if there's anellia up
there as well. Uh I also just want to
point out you don't have to win die
rolls, just got to win games.
>> You just got to win. And it looks like
that's what he's doing. He said he was
manifesting this win. And look at him
now sitting pretty in the top eight.
Also, the shout out to the team back
home. Super
>> all the homies cheering him on.
>> Um, but I also want to notate. He said,
"You know, I'm kind of fine going up
against these other people in this in
this talk." But that Kaiso who said that
she's specifically coming for the
Dravens. Uh-uh. I don't want to go over
there. So, I think it would be really
interesting. Low key. I know he said he
don't want it, but I kind of want to see
the Kais trying to curse him trying to
start us right now. That's crazy. We're
just cheering him on.
>> I think it would be fun to see Kaisa
Draven. How about we send the Kai'Sa
against the other two Dravens. How about
that?
>> Okay, you know what? We can count
Stardust. We're going to manifest that
you you get to breathe for a second. You
get to breathe. I will manifest that you
win the next dice roll, though.
>> Oh, that'd be good. That'd be good. All
right. We do want that for you.
>> Well, that's it for our Swiss round,
though, Reagan. All we have left is top
eight. It's getting tight here in
Atlanta.
>> It's getting very close. I'm so excited.
Okay, I want your prediction right now.
Who do you think is going to win?
>> I still have Kai'Sa. I'm going to stick
with that all weekend. I said Kai'Sa was
the deck and a Frosty the pilot. I think
Kai'Sa can take it.
>> All right. I'm I'm going to rock with
that. I I'm going to say I do think the
Kai'Sa will probably take it, but I'm
rooting for Set.
>> Oh, true. Yeah, Colin's your boy.
>> Yep.
>> Colin's your boy.
>> We stand Colin in this household.
>> At least you're consistent. I like that.
That's good. You've been cheering for
him the entire weekend.
>> I have. Yeah. Well,
>> yeah.
>> After the Fiors got eliminated.
>> After I met him, that's when I started
cheering for him. So, yes. Uh whole
weekend.
But yeah. No, it's I I'm I'm so excited.
I'm glad we're getting down to the
nitty-gritty cuz we're really going to
start seeing
>> the like gameplay get really intense
here.
>> Noah's ears also. So Leo will not have a
repeat
>> champion, but there's still the option
for something new. We got Aurelia, we
got Kai'Sa. So we got set a lot on the
table. But with that being said, that's
it for the Swiss round. It's time to
throw it to a break before we are back
with our top eight right after this.
Heat.